foreign
welcome to this video on AWS full course
we will begin this full course video
with what AWS is and how AWS Services
work and we will be looking into a bunch
of AWS services like ec2 Lambda S3 IAM
cloud formation ECS Route 53 elastic
bean stock VPC Sage maker cloudfront
Auto scaling and redshift after this we
will do a comparison of popular Cloud
providers like AWS Azure and gcp moving
further we will also see how to become a
solution architect we will also guide
you through AWS certification exams and
in which we have explained how to choose
the right certification for your career
we will then conclude this interview by
discussing the essential interview
questions and answers to help every
individual crack an interview by the end
of this video I can assure you that all
your AWS career related queries would
have been answered for this training
with me I have her experience AWS
specialist Sam and Rahul together we
will take you through the various topics
of AWS so let's start with an exciting
video on AWS Phil course before we begin
make sure to subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit that Bell icon to never
miss an update from Simply learn meet
Rob he runs an online shopping portal
the portal started with a modest number
of users but has recently been seeing a
surge in the number of visitors on Black
Friday and other holidays the portal saw
so many visitors that the servers were
unable to handle the traffic and crashed
is there a way to improve performance
without having to invest in a new server
wondered Rob
a way to upscale or downscale capacity
depending on the number of users
visiting the website at any given point
well there is Amazon web services one of
the leaders in the cloud computing
Market before we see how AWS can solve
Rob's problem let's have a look at how
AWS reached the position it is at now
AWS was first introduced in 2002 as a
means to provide tools and services to
developers to incorporate features of
amazon.com to their website in 2006 its
first Cloud Services offering was
introduced in 2016 AWS surpassed its 10
billion Revenue Target
and now AWS offers more than 100 cloud
services that span a wide range of
domains thanks to this the AWS cloud
service platform is now used by more
than 45 of the global market now let's
talk about what is AWS AWS or Amazon web
service is a secure cloud computing
platform that provides computing power
database networking content storage and
much more
the platform also works with a PSU go
pricing model which means you only pay
for how much of the service is offered
by AWS you use
some of the other advantages of AWS are
security AWS provides a secure and
durable platform that offers end-to-end
privacy and security
experience you can benefit from the
infrastructure management practices born
from Amazon's years of experience
flexible it allows users to select the
OS language database and other services
easy to use users can host applications
quickly and securely scalable depending
on user requirements applications can be
scaled up or down AWS provides a wide
range of services across various domains
what if Rob wanted to create an
application for his online portal AWS
provides compute services that can
support the app development process from
start to finish from developing
deploying running to scaling the
application up or down based on the
requirements the popular Services
include ec2 AWS Lambda Amazon light cell
and elastic Beanstalk for storing
website data Rob could use AWS storage
services that would enable him to store
access govern and analyze data to ensure
that costs are reduced agility is
improved an innovation accelerated
popular services within this domain
include Amazon S3 EBS S3 Glacier and
elastic file storage
Rob can also store the user data in a
database with aw Services which he can
then optimize and manage popular
services in this domain include Amazon
RDS dynamodb and redshift if Rob's
businesses took off and he wanted to
separate his Cloud infrastructure or
scale up his work requests and much more
he would be able to do so with the
networking Services provided by AWS some
of the popular networking Services
include Amazon VPC Amazon Route 53 and
elastic load balancing other domains
that AWS provides services in are
analytics blockchain containers machine
learning internet of things and so on
and there you go that's AWS for you in a
nutshell now before we're done let's
have a look at a quiz which of these
services are incorrectly matched one
two
three
four
we'll be pinning the question in the
comments section comment below with your
answer and stand a chance to win an
Amazon voucher
several companies around the world have
found great success with AWS companies
like Netflix twitch LinkedIn Facebook
and BBC have taken advantage of the
services offered by AWS to improve their
business efficiency and thanks to their
widespread usage AWS professionals are
in high demand they're highly paid and
earn up to more than 127 thousand
dollars per annum once your AWS
certified you could be one of them too
let me start the session with this
scenario let's imagine how life would
have been without Spotify for those who
are hearing about Spotify for the first
time a Spotify is an online music
service offering and it offers instant
access to over 16 million licensed songs
Spotify now uses AWS Cloud to store the
data and share it with their customers
but prior to AWS they had some issues
imagine using spotify before AWS let's
talk about that back then users were
often getting errors because Spotify
could not keep up with the ink increased
demand for storage every new day and
that led to users getting upset and
users canceling the subscription the
problem Spotify was facing at that time
was their users were present globally
and were accessing it from everywhere
and they had different latency in their
applications and Spotify had a demanding
situation where they need to frequently
catalog the songs released yesterday
today and in the future and this was
changing every new day and the songs
coming in rate was about 20 000 a day
and back then they could not keep up
with this requirement and needless to
say they were badly looking for way to
solve this problem and that's when they
got introduced to AWS and it was a
perfect fit and match for their problem
AWS offered a dynamically increasing
storage and that's what they needed AWS
also offered tools and techniques like
storage life cycle management and
trusted advisor to properly utilize the
resource so we always get the best out
of the result those used AWS addressed
their concerns about easily being able
to scale yes you can scale the AWS
environment very easily how easily one
might ask it's just a few button clicks
and AWS sold spotify's problem let's
talk about how it can help you with your
organization's problem let's talk about
what is AWS first and then let's bleed
into how AWS became so successful and
the different types of services that AWS
provides and what's the future of cloud
and AWS in specific let's talk about
that and finally we'll talk about a use
case where you will see how easy it is
to create a web application with AWS all
right let's talk about what is AWS AWS
or Amazon web services is a secure cloud
service platform it is also pay as you
go type billing model where there is no
upfront or Capital cost we'll talk about
how soon the service will be available
well the service will be available in a
matter of seconds with AWS you can also
do identity and access management that
is authenticating and authorizing a user
or a program on the Fly and almost all
the services are available on demand and
most of them are available
instantaneously and as we speak Amazon
offers 100 plus services and this list
is growing every new week now that would
make you wonder how AWS became so
successful of course it's their
customers let's talk about the list of
well-known companies that has their ID
environment in AWS Adobe Adobe uses AWS
to provide multi-terabyte operating
environments for its customers by
integrating its system with AWS Cloud
Adobe can focus on deploying and
operating its own software instead of
trying to you know deploy and manage the
infrastructure Airbnb is another company
it's an Community Marketplace that
allows property owners and travelers to
connect each other for the purpose of
renting unique vacation spaces around
the world and the Airbnb community into
users activities are conducted on the
website and through iPhones and Android
applications Airbnb has a huge
infrastructure in AWS and they're almost
using all the services in AWS and are
getting benefited from it another
example would be Autodesk Autodesk
develops software for engineering
designing and entertainment Industries
using services like Amazon ideas or
rational database service and Amazon S3
or Amazon simple storage service
Autodesk can focus on deploying or
developing its machine learning tools
instead of spending that time on
managing the infrastructure AOL or
American online uses AWS and using AWS
they have been able to close data
centers and decommission about 14 000
in-house and co-located servers and move
Mission critical workload to the cloud
and extend its Global reach and save
millions of dollars on energy resources
bitdefender is an Internet Security soft
software firm and their portfolio of
softwares include antivirus and
anti-spyware products bitdefender uses
ec2 and they're currently running few
hundred instances that handle about 5
terabytes of data and they also use
elastic load balancer to load balance
the connection coming in to those
instances across availability zones and
they provide seamless Global delivery of
service because of that the BMW group it
uses AWS for its new connected Car
application that collects sensor data
from BMW 7 Series cars to give drivers
dynamically updated map information
Canon's offers Imaging products division
benefits from faster deployment times
lower cost and Global reach by using AWS
to deliver cloud-based services such as
mobile print the office Imaging products
division uses AWS such as Amazon S3 and
Amazon Route 53 Amazon cloudfront and
Amazon IM for their testing development
and Production service sources Comcast
it's the world's largest cable company
and the leading provider of internet
service in the United States Comcast
uses AWS in a hybrid environment out of
all the other Cloud providers Comcast
chores AWS for its flexibility and
scalable hybrid infrastructure Docker is
a company that's helping redefine the
way developers build ship and run
applications this company focuses on
making use of containers for this
purpose and in AWS the service called
the Amazon ec2 container service is
helping them achieve it the esa or
European Space Agency although much of
esa's work is done by satellites some of
the programs data storage and Computing
infrastructure is built on Amazon web
services Esa shows AWS because of its
economical pay as you go system as well
as its quick startup time the Guardian
newspaper uses AWS and it uses a wide
range of AWS services including Amazon
Kinesis Amazon redshift that power and
analytic dashboard which editors used to
see how stories are trending in real
time Financial Times FD is one of the
world's largest leading business news
organization and they used Amazon
redshift to perform their analysis A
Funny Thing Happened Amazon Redshirt
performs so quickly that some analysis
thought it was malfunctioning they were
used to running queries overnight and
they found that the results were indeed
correct just as much faster by using
Amazon redshift FD is supporting the
same business functions with costs that
are 80 percentage lower than what was
before general electric GE is at the
moment as we speak migrating more than
9000 workloads including 300 desperate
Erp systems to AWS while reducing its
data center footprint from 34 to 4 over
the next three years similarly Howard
Medical School HTC IMDb McDonald's NASA
Kellogg's and lot more are using the
services Amazon provides and are getting
benefited from it and this huge success
and customer portfolio is just the tip
of the iceberg and if we think why so
many adapt AWS and if we let AWS answer
that question this is what AWS would say
people are adapting AWS because of the
security and durability of the data and
end-to-end privacy and encryption of the
data and storage experience we can also
rely on AWS way of doing things by using
the AWS tools and techniques and
suggested best practices built upon the
years of experience it has gained
flexibility there is a greater
flexibility in AWS that allows us to
select the OS language and database easy
to use swiftness in deploying we can
host our applications quickly in AWS be
it a new application or migrating an
existing application into AWS
scalability the application can be
easily scaled up or scaled down
depending on the user requirement cost
saving we only pay for the compute power
storage page and other resources you use
and that too without any long-term
commitments now let's talk about the
different types of services that AWS
provides the services that we talk about
fall in any of the following categories
you see like you know compute storage
database Security customer engagement
desktop and streaming machine learning
developers tools stuff like that and if
you do not see the service that you're
looking for it's probably is because AWS
is creating it as we speak now let's
look at some of them that are very
commonly used within compute Services we
have Amazon ec2 Amazon elastic Beanstalk
Amazon light sale and Amazon Lambda
Amazon ec2 provides compute capacity in
the cloud now this capacity is secure
and it is resizable based on the user's
requirement now look at this the
requirement for the web traffic keeps
changing and behind the scenes in the
cloud ec2 can expand its environment to
three instances and during no load it
can shrink its environment to just one
resource elastic Beanstalk it helps us
to scale and deploy web applications and
it's made with a number of programming
languages elastic Beanstalk is also an
easy to use service for deploying and
scaling web applications and services
deployed a beat in java.net PHP node.js
python Ruby Docker and lot other
familiar services such as Apache
passenger and IIs we can simply upload
our code an elastic Beanstalk
automatically handles the deployment
from capacity provisioning to load
balancing to Auto scaling to application
Health monitoring and Amazon light cell
is a virtual private server which is
easy to launch and easy to manage Amazon
light cell is the easiest way to get
started with AWS for developers who just
need a virtual private server light sail
includes everything you need to launch
your project quickly on a virtual
machine like SSD based storage a virtual
machine tools for data transfer DNS
management and a static IP and that too
for a very low and predictable price AWS
Lambda has taken Cloud Computing
Services to a whole new level it allows
us to pay only for the compute time no
need for provisioning and managing
servers an AWS Lambda is a compute
service that lets us run code without
provisioning or managing service Lambda
executes your code only when needed and
scales automatically from few requests
per day to thousands per second you pay
only for the compute time you consume
there is no charge when your code is not
running let's look at some storage
services that Amazon provides like
Amazon S3 Amazon Glacier Amazon abs and
Amazon elastic file system Amazon S3 is
an object storage that can store and
retrieve data from anywhere websites
mobile apps iot sensors and so on can
easily use Amazon S3 to store and
retrieve data it's an object storage
built to store and Destroy any amount of
data from anywhere with its features
like flexibility in managing data and
the durability it provides and the
security that it provides Amazon simple
storage service or S3 is a storage for
the internet and Glacier Glacier is a
cloud storage service that's used for
archiving data and long-term backups and
this Glacier is an secure durable and
extremely low cost cloud storage service
for data archiving and long-term backups
Amazon EVS Amazon elastic Block store
provides Block store volumes for the
instances of ec2 and this elastic Block
store is highly available and a reliable
storage volume that can be attached to
any running instance that is in the same
availability Zone ABS volumes that are
attached to the ec2 instances are
exposed as storage volumes that persist
an independently from the lifetime of
the instance and Amazon elastic file
system or EFS provides an elastic file
storage which can be used with AWS cloud
service and resources that are on
premises and Amazon elastic file system
it's an simple it's scalable it's an
elastic file storage for use with Amazon
cloud services and for on-premises
resources it's easy to use and offers a
simple interface that allows you to
create and configure file systems
quickly and easily Amazon file system is
built to elastically scale on-demand
without disturbing the application
growing and shrinking automatically as
you add and remove files to your
application have the storage they need
and when they need it now let's talk
about databases the two major database
flavors are Amazon RDS and Amazon
redshift Amazon RDS it really eases the
process involved in setting up operating
and scaling a rational database in the
cloud Amazon RDS provides cost efficient
and resizable capacity while automating
time-consuming administrative tasks such
as Hardware provisioning database setup
patching and backups it sort of frees us
from managing the hardware and sort of
helps us to focus on the application
it's also cost effective and resizable
and it's also optimized for memory
performance and input and output
operations not only that it also
automates most of the services like
taking backups you know monitoring stuff
like that it automates most of those
Services Amazon redshift Amazon redshift
is a data warehousing service that
enables users to analyze the data using
SQL and other business intelligent tools
Amazon redshift is an fast and fully
managed data warehouse that makes it
simple and cost effective analyze all
your data using standard SQL and your
existing business intelligent tools it
also allows you to run complex analytic
queries against petabyte of structured
data using sophisticated query
optimizations and most of the results
they generally come back in seconds
alright let's quickly talk about some
more services that AWS offers there are
a lot more services that AWS provides
but are we going to look at some more
services that are widely used AWS
application Discovery Services help
Enterprise customers plan migration
projects by gathering information about
their on-premises data centers in a
planning a data center migration can
involve thousands of workloads they are
often deeply interdependent server
utilization data and dependence see
mapping or important early first step in
migration process and this AWS
application Discovery service collects
and presents configuration usage and
behavior data from your servers to help
you better understand your workloads
Route 53 it's a network and content
delivery service it's an highly
available and scalable Cloud domain name
system or DNS service and Amazon Route
53 is fully compliant with IPv6 as well
elastic load balancing it's also a
network and content delivery service
elastic load balancing automatically
distributes incoming application traffic
across multiple targets such as Amazon
ec2 instance containers and IP addresses
it can handle the varying load of your
application traffic in a single
availability zones and also across
availability zones AWS Auto scaling it
monitors your application and
automatically adjusts the capacity to
maintain steady and predictable
performance at a lowest possible cost
using AWS Auto scaling it's easy to set
up application scaling for multiple
resources across multiple services in
minutes Auto scaling can be applied to
web services and also for DB Services
AWS identity and access management it
enables you to manage access to AWS
services and resources securely using IM
you can create and manage AWS users and
groups and use permissions to allow and
deny their access to AWS resources and
moreover it's a free service now let's
talk about the future of AWS well let me
tell you something cloud is here to stay
here's what in store for AWS in the
future as yours pass by we're gonna have
a variety of cloud applications born
like iot artificial intelligence
business intelligence serverless
Computing and so on cloud will also
expand into other markets like
healthcare banking space automated cars
and so on as I was mentioning some time
back lot or greater Focus will be given
to artificial intelligence and
eventually because of the flexibility
and advantage that cloud provides we're
going to see a lot of companies moving
into the cloud all right let's now talk
about how easy it is to deploy an web
application in the cloud so the scenario
here is that our users like a product
and we need to have a mechanism to
receive input from them about the likes
and dislikes and you know give them the
appropriate product as per their need
all right though the setup and the
environment it sort of looks complicated
we don't have to worry because AWS has
tools and Technologies which can help us
to achieve it now we're going to use
services like Route 53 so this is like
Cloud watch ec2 S3 and lot more and all
these put together are going to give an
application that's fully functionable
and an application that's going to
receive the information like using the
services like Route 53 Cloud watch ec2
and S3 we're going to create an
application and that's going to meet our
need so back to our original requirement
all I want is to deploy a web
application for a product that keeps our
users updated about the happenings and
the newcomings in the market and to
fulfill the requirement here is all the
services we would need ec2 here is used
for provisioning the computational power
needed for this application and ec2 has
a vast variety of family and types that
we can pick from for the types of
workloads and also for the intents of
the workloads we're also going to use S3
for storage and S3 provides any
additional storage requirement for the
resources or any additional storage
requirement for the web applications and
we're also going to use cloudwatch for
monitoring the environment and
cloudwatch monitors the application and
the environment and it provides trigger
for scaling in and scaling out the
infrastructure and we're also going to
use Route 53 for DNS and Route 53 helps
us to register the domain name for our
web application and with all the tools
and Technologies together all of them
put together we're going to make an
application a perfect application that
caters our need all right so I'm going
to use elastic Beanstalk for this
project and the name of the application
is going to be as you see GSG sign up
and the environment name is GSG signup
environment one let me also pick a name
right let me see if this name is
available yes that's available that's
the domain name so let me pick that and
the application that I have is going to
run on node.js so let me pick that
platform and launch now as you see
elastic Beanstalk this is going to
launch an instance it's going to launch
the monitoring setup or the monitoring
environment it's going to create a load
balancer as well and it's going to take
care of all the security features needed
for this application
all right look at that I was able to go
to that URL which is what we gave and
it's now having an default page shown up
meaning all the dependencies for the
software is installed and it's just
waiting for me to upload the code or in
specific the page required so let's do
that
foreign
let me upload the code I already have
the code saved here
that's my code
and that's going to take some time all
right it has done its thing and now if I
go to the same URL look at that I'm
being thrown an advertisement page all
right so if I sign up with my name email
and stuff like that you know it's going
to receive the information and it's
going to send an email to the owner
saying that somebody had subscribed to
your service that's the default feature
of this app look at that email to the
owner saying that somebody had
subscribed to your app and this is their
email address stuff like that not only
that it's also going to create an entry
in the database and dynamodb is the
service that this application uses to
store data there's my dynamodb and if I
go to tables right and go to items I'm
going to see that a user with name
Samuel and email address so and so has
said ok or has shown interest in the
preview of my site or product so this is
where this is how I collect those
information right and some more things
about the infrastructure itself is it is
running behind and load balancer look at
that it had created a load balancer it
had also created an auto scaling group
now that's the feature of elastic load
balancer that we have chosen it has
created an auto scaling group and now
let's put this URL you see this it's
it's not a fancy URL all right it's an
Amazon given URL a dynamic URL so let's
put this URL behind our DNS let's do
that
so go to Services go to Route 53
go to hosted Zone and there we can find
the DNS name right so that's a DNS name
all right
all right let's create an entry
and map that URL to our load balancer
right
and create now technically if I go to
this URL it should take me to that
application all right look at that I
went to my custom URL and now that's
pointed to my application previously my
application was having a random URL and
now it's having a custom URL let me help
you understand about AWS ec2 a compute
servers in the cloud through this video
somewhere far in the country a scientist
has a lab far in the woods and at one
day he stumbled on a calculation that he
had trouble solving and he was very
certain that his computer can handle it
and he asked his computer to do the math
or the calculation for him and the
computer thought about it for a while
then took couple of hours in trying to
process the data and eventually at one
point it gave up and died due to low
memory and this old scientist is now
clueless about how he was going to
finish the task and complete his
invention and let the whole world know
about about it and that's when he was
introduced to this new friend AWS as you
see on the screen AWS was very handy in
replacing his old machines and it was
able to give him the service that he
wanted at that moment AWS has been
around for a while helping people with
their computer needs and now this new
scientist friend in need is welcomed by
the new and trendy ID technology AWS and
sure enough his new AWS friend welcomed
and walked him through the new way of
computing and this new Happy faced AWS
friend talked to this scientist about
AWS ec2 in specific and walked him
through about all the new Innovations in
ID and in Cloud that he had been missing
all these days so his new friend AWS
started the conversation about
explaining how there is no need for any
hardware units no managing Hardware or
provisioning in AWS and secondly it
explained increasing and decreasing the
capacity as per the demand is just a
click away and the best part here is
that there is no upfront commitment and
we only pay for what we have used just
like we pay electricity and water bills
and all this comes with complete control
from our side other words the whole key
for this infrastructure is with us and
as if this was not enough all this comes
with Enterprise grade security that's
beyond imagination in on-premises and if
this tool does not excite you then this
definitely would you can work from
anywhere in the world now this really
made the scientist to get excited
especially when he thought about working
from home working from home there is
nothing like it isn't it now this person
the scientist is not tied up to a
particular environment he can work from
home work on the Fly work from anywhere
still the data and everything else in
his ID environment is secure and safe
now let's move to the next level of
discussion let's talk about what is ec2
and some some of the use cases of ec2
and this use case we're going to talk
about are this architecture we're going
to talk about it notifies a group of
users about a new letter and the
components are resources this
architecture would need be first ec2
instance then SNS a simple notification
service and coupling ec2 and S3 service
together that's all it would require to
get an architecture that notifies a
group of users about a new newsletter
and now I think it would be a good time
to talk about what ec2 is AWS offers
plenty of services offered under
different domains like you know compute
storage database migration Network
management tools Media Services security
business productivity application
integration a machine learning game
development and lot more coming up out
of which ec2 falls under the compute
capacity so what is ec2 ec2 is a web
service which aims to make life easier
for Developers for providing secure and
resizable compute capacity in the cloud
with ec2 it is very easy to scale up or
scale down our infrastructure based on
the demand and not only that this ec2
service can be integrated well with
almost all the services in Amazon and
out of all this the best part could be
we only pay for what we use all right
let's talk about this use case a use
case here is that a successful business
owner has a bunch of users and a
successful product that's running and
now he has developed few more products
that he thinks will be very successful
that he thinks his customers are going
to like now how can he advertise his
product to his new and prospective
customers or the solution for this
question can be addressed by AWS in AWS
we can use services like simple
notification service SNS and ec2 for
compute and S3 for storage which we can
in a way integrate them all and achieve
this business use case and that sort of
got this business owner very chewed up
and now he wants to use the service and
he wants to get benefited from the
service he wants to advertise or he
wants to notify his users every time the
company creates a newsletter all right
so let's talk about what it would take
to get this environment up and running
or what it would take to connect the
environment and put the applications on
top of it firstly we would require an
AWS account and then for compute
capacity we would require an ec2
instance and here's how we go about
doing it the first thing is to create an
Ami which is Amazon Mission image that's
really the softwares and the application
packages we would need to run our
application and the second is to choose
the hardware in here it's the instance
type depending on the workload we would
be choosing the hardware and depending
on the intents of the work load we will
be choosing the size of the hardware and
finally we would configure the instances
in a Harmony instance do I want you know
which subnet do I want them in and
what's going to be the in a stop or
terminate a behavior of the instance and
do I want to update any patches when the
instance starts running all those speeds
of information go in here when we
configure the instance and then the
first three steps is really about the OS
volume and the Basic Hardware now it's
time to add additional storage to the
ec2 instance that would be step four
here we add additional storage to the
ec2 instance and then tags we use tags
or we would configure tags to easily
identify an ec2 instance at a later
point you know we give it some
meaningful names so we can identify like
you know which team it belongs to which
billing department it belongs to what's
the purpose behind launching this
instance stuff like that in an
environment where we run 700 to 800 or
even more instances identifying an
instance and trying to understand you
know who owns the resource for what
purpose we created it could be an
full-time work so tagging comes to a
rescue at that time after tagging as
step 6 we would configure the firewall
which is also called Security Group for
the ec2 instant and this is where we
would allow or deny connection from
external world to this particular ec2
instance well it works both ways from
outside and from inside out this
firewall blocks the connection based on
port number and IP address and finally
as step 7 we review all the
configurations that you have done and we
make sure that the configurations is
what we wanted and finally click on
submit that's going to launch an ec2
instance alright this was just an
overview of how to create an ec2
instance now let's talk about each and
every step in detail so to begin with
let's talk about how to create an Ami
well the AI is just a template a
template that's used to create a new
instance or an a new computer or a new
VM or a new machine based on the user
requirement the things that go into an
Ami are the software the operating
system the additional applications that
get installed in it stuff like that the
Ami will also contain software
information you know information about
operating system information about
access permission information about
volumes they all compact in the Ami
again the Ami is of two types one is
predefined Amis are called Amazon
provided Amis the other one would be
custom Amis the Amis that we create and
if you're looking at a particular Ami
that you don't want to create but still
want to get it from Amazon there is a
place or a portal called Ami Marketplace
there we get like thousands of Amis in
there available for us to shop up and
use them on a pay as you go business
model and use them as pay as you go
billing so there you can search Ami that
you're looking for most probably you'll
be able to get it there now let's talk
about choosing the instance type the
instance type is basically the hardware
specification that's required for a
machine that we're trying to build and
the instant types is categorized into
five main families they are to begin
with it's compute optimized now compute
optimize gives us lots of compute power
a lot of processing power so if my
application is going to require a lot of
processing power I should be picking
compute optimized instance and the
second one is memory optimized now this
is very good for application that
require in memory caching you know there
are some application that performs well
with cash or through cash or the
application would create a lot of data
that it wants to keep in cash for
re-reading or for processing you know
for link empty processing stuff like
that for those type of application this
memory optimized instance that comes
within memory cache is a very good use
case and the third one is the instant
that comes with the GPU otherwise called
GPU optimized GPU stands for graphical
process unit and this is very good for
application that deals with gaming this
is very good for application that's
going to require large graphical
requirements and storage optimized is
the fourth option just like the name
says this is a very good use case for
storage servers and the fifth family
type is general purpose just like the
name says it's for general purpose if
you're not particular about the family
then you generally would end up picking
the general purpose because here the
services are sort of equally balanced
you know you'll find a balance between
the virtual CPU and the memory and the
storage and the network performance it's
sort of balanced all the components all
the features that needs to go in a
computer are sort of balanced in general
purpose now these instant types are
fixed and they cannot be altered because
it's Hardware based we buy Hardware we
do not have much control on the hardware
that's being used well we have options
but we do not have control on the
hardware and these instant types are
divided into five main families they are
computer optimized memory optimized GPU
enabled storage optimized and general
purpose then as third thing we have to
configure the instance now here is where
I have a lot of options about purchasing
you know what type of purchasing do I
want to do do I want to go for a spot
instance do I want to go for a reserved
instance do I want to go for an
on-demand instance these are different
billing options available and that's
available under configure instance not
only that here's where I'm going to put
the ec2 instance do I want an public IP
address assigned to it do I want an IAM
role attached to it IM role is
Authentication what kind of
authentication am I going to provide and
the shutout Behavior the Sharon
behaviors include do I want to stop the
instance when the user shuts down the
machine from the desktop or do I want to
Simply terminate this instance when the
user shuts down the instance from the
desktop so those things go in here just
like the name says configure instance
lot of instance configuration options
comes in here that's the third step and
not only that under the advanced details
or Advanced tab under configure instance
I can bootstrap the instance with some
scripts now bootstrap is nothing but the
scripts that you want to be run in the
instance before it actually comes online
let's say you're provisioning the
instance for somebody else you know
instead of you launching the instance
and then logging in and running some
commands and then handing it over to the
other person you can create bootstrap
shell scripts and you know paste it in a
console option available under configure
instance and Amazon is going to take
those commands run it on the instance
before it hands over to the user that
initially requested for that instance
now it could be a different user or just
you it sort of automates you know
software installation procedures in the
instance that we will be launching and
not only that there are multiple payment
options available under configure
instance the user can pick an instance
under normal price and that instance
would apply normal rates applied to it
and there are also options like reserved
instance where the user can pay for an
instance upfront before a year or before
months you know for a span of year or a
span of months and that way they can pay
less per hour for using that instance
not only that you can also go for spot
instance like bidding for those
instances whoever bids more they get the
instance for that particular time well
these instances are a lot cheaper than
on demand and instances and through
bidding and buying you can keep the
instance as long as your bid price
doesn't exceed the price that Amazon is
proposing and as the fourth step we will
have to add storage to the instance that
we are about to launch and here we have
bunch of storage options I can go for a
permanent storage which is free or I can
go for an external elastic block storage
also called EBS which is paid and it's a
permanent storage or else I can
integrate my ec2 instance with S3 for
its storage needs and the best part
about storage is a free subscription
users they get to use 30 gigabit of SSD
storage or magnetic storage for the
whole year in this page where we are
ready to add storage we will have to
mention or provide the size in gigabit
and the volume type is it going to be an
provisioned volume is it going to be an
general purpose volume is it going to be
a Mac magnetic volume stuff like that
they are volume types and we also need
to give inputs about where the disk will
be mounted and whether this volume needs
to be encrypted or not so all these
options are all these inputs are
received from us under the adding
storage section and then the fifth
option would be adding tags like we
discussed sometime back tags are very
helpful to identify a machine in an
environment where we have 700 or 1000
VMS running and security groups are the
actual firewall that sits in front of
ec2 instance and it protects that ec2
instance from unintended inbound and
outbound traffic now here is where I can
fine tune the access to my ec2 instance
based on port numbers and based on IP
address from which it can be accessed
and finally we get to review the whole
changes or the whole configurations that
we have made to find out whether they
are intact with the requirement and then
click on submit that's going to launch
an easy to use instance but hold on
we're not done yet when we're about to
launch or before the Amazon console
actually launches the ec2 instance it's
going to give us an option to create a
keypad remember I said it's key pair you
know key pair is two things one is
public and private the private key is
downloaded by the user and is kept with
the user and the public key is used by
Amazon to confirm the identity of the
user so just go ahead and download the
private key and keep it for yourself and
this private key gets downloaded as a
DOT pem file it's a format of the file
and it gets downloaded as dot pimp file
and our next step is to access the ec2
instance and because the instance that
we have launched in this example let's
assume it's Linux instance and that's
going to require a tool called putty to
be able to access it and this putty tool
is really needed when we are trying to
access a Linux instance from Windows
instance most of the time Windows
instance will have put the install in
them but in some rare cases they do not
come with putty in those cases we can go
ahead and download putty and putty
generator and we can start using it to
access the Linux instance now you might
ask well I understand putty what's putty
generator now the file that we have
downloaded is in dot pem format but
unfortunately putty does not accept dot
pem format as input you know it has to
be converted into a different format
called PPK and put it gen is a tool that
helps us to convert the dot pem file
into PPK file so as a quick way to do it
is download generator open it up click
on conversion and insert the dot pem key
that we have downloaded and save the
private key and this when we save the
private key it gets saved as a DOT PPK
type private key and when that's done
the next very step is to open putty and
try to log in and the way to login is to
open putty put that IP address here and
then click on auth you know this is
where we would input the file that we
have created so click on op and then
click on browse and find the dot pbk
file that we have converted and stored
browse it and upload it and then click
on open now that's going to open up a
login screen for us and the Amis comes
with a default username depending on the
Ami that we have picked the username
might differ in our case we have picked
an Ami for which the username is ec2
hyphen user and this is the default by
the way let's put the username ec2
hyphen user and hit enter and that's
going to open up the Linux instance
using CLI there are a few other things
that we can do with the terminal that
will explain it a little later alright
so we have successfully launched an ec2
instance and yeah give yourself a pat on
your back launching an instant sense was
just one part of the solution so let's
actually talk about how we can notify
our customers SNS or simple notification
service is a service or a product in
Amazon that helps us to notify customers
through email so navigate to SNS in your
account and create a topic and we're
going to use this topic for public
notification so let's make it public and
then add a subscribers to it now these
subscribers these subscribers are the
people who you want to be notified about
the newsletter so we already have the
email database in there add them to the
subscribers list and then they will
start getting new newsletters as and
when we post them to the topic and as
Next Step create a bucket in S3 where
you can store content and in that bucket
create an event that triggers a
notification to simple notification
service so this is how it will be set up
and notification education will be sent
to our subscribers anytime we put
something in our S3 bucket so S3 bucket
is going to create an event for the
notification and the notification is
going to make sure that it's delivered
to your end Customer because they're
already subscribed to the topic as
subscribers and finally let's connect
the S3 with ec2 so the bucket and the
AWS instance are in sync so we put some
content in the S3 bucket our email
system notifies our customers and the
customers can go online to a website
that's hosted in ec2 and because S3 and
ec2 are in sync the items that we put in
S3 will also show up in ec2 see how this
is all connected and it's working
together and once this is all connected
our subscribers will regularly be
informed anytime we put new content in
the S3 bucket and the same content will
be made available in ec2 instance
through the website let me help you
understand 10 about Lambda one day at
office in a growing company there was
this question going on between two IT
personnel it was about the new role that
his colleague Jessica has taken Benjamin
the guy standing here wants to know
about it and Jessica's job is new
different and dynamic and interesting
too she scale and manage servers and
operating systems and apply security
patches onto them and monitor all of
these at the same time to ensure the
best quality for application is given to
the users and Benjamin was awestruck
with the amount of work Jessica is doing
and with the time it would take to
complete all of them but Jessica being a
very Dynamic person very suitable for
the job said it was easy for her to
handle all of it and even more but that
easiness on the job did not last longer
as the Environ grew more and more it
being a startup company Jessica was
getting drained and was not really happy
about all her job as she used to be
Jessica's manual way of scaling and
environment did not last long and she
was also finding out that she missed to
scale down some of the resources and
it's costing her a lot she needs to pay
for the service that she was not at all
using she sort of felt that she was at
the end of the role and there was no way
out from this manual task she was very
desperate and that's when Benjamin
suggested something and that brought
back the peace and joy Jessica initially
had Benjamin suggested about a service
called Lambda that can ease the work
that Jessica is doing at the moment and
Lambda as happy as it looks like it's a
solution that solves the manual
repetitive work and lot more and Lambda
introduced itself as the problem solver
and started to explain the following
things the very same thing that we're
gonna learn about in this series so in
this section we're going to learn about
the features of AWS Lambda and we're
going to talk about what Lambda is and
then we're going to talk about where
where Lambda is being used in the it or
in the cloud environment as we speak and
then we're going to talk about how
Lambda works and some use cases of
Lambda and we're going to be
particularly discussing about the use
case about automatically backing up the
data that's put in the cloud storage
let's talk about Lambda in detail Lambda
automatically runs our code without
requiring us to provision or manage
servers just write the code and upload
it to Lambda and Lambda will take care
of it that means that we don't require
any server to run or to manage and all
you need to do is write the code and
upload it to Lambda and Lambda will take
care of it which also means that we can
stop worrying about provisioning and
managing service the only thing Lambda
expects from you is a code that's
working AWS Lambda also automatically
scales our application by running code
in response to each trigger our code
runs in parallel and processes each
triggers individually scaling precise
nicely with the size of the workload
scaling here is done automatically based
on the size of the workload Lambda can
scale the application running the code
in response to each and every trigger
that it receives billing in Lambda is
meter on the seconds we only pay for the
amount of time that our code is running
which means that we're not charged for
any of the servers the only payment
required is for the amount of time the
code is computed with AWS Lambda we are
charged for every 100 milliseconds we
are actually charged for 100
milliseconds our code executes and the
number of times our code is triggered
and we don't pay anything when the code
is not running let's talk about what is
AWS Lambda now Lambda is one of the
servers that falls under the compute
section or the compute domain of
services that AWS provides along with
ec2 EBS elastic load balancer Lambda is
also a service that comes under the
bigger umbrella of compute services in
AWS and Lambda allows us to execute code
or any type of application with AWS
Lambda we can run code for virtually any
type of application or backend Services
all we need to do is supply our code in
one of the languages that AWS Lambda
supports as we speak the languages that
are supported by AWS Lambda are node.js
Java c-sharp go and Python and Lambda
can be used to run code in response to
certain events from other services and
based on the event it can run functions
and those functions can be of node.js
java c-sharp Etc now let's talk about
where is Lambda used there are huge
number of use cases for Lambda and there
are many ways AWS Lambda is used
specifically in the business world let's
talk about some of them one use case is
AWS Lambda is used to process images
when it is uploaded in an S3 bucket
let's say the object gets uploaded in an
S3 bucket in a format that we don't
expect it to be which means the file
needs to be formatted so it gets
uploaded in a raw format and AWS Lambda
is triggered anytime a new object is
added to the bucket and the images are
processed and converted into thumbnails
based on the devices the other end
device that could be reading the data it
could be in PC it could be an apple
machine it could be an Android phone it
could be an Apple phone it could be a
tablet What Not So based on the devices
different formats Lambda can get
triggered and convert video or convert
the picture into the different format
that it requires another use case for
Lambda is to analyze the social media
data let's say let's say we're
collecting the hashtag trending data and
the data is received and it's added into
the Kinesis stream to feed into the
Amazon environment and Lambda action get
triggered and it will receives the data
and then the data is stored into the
database which can be used by businesses
for later analysis and some of the
companies that have gotten tremendous
benefit using Lambda or Thompson routers
bench links Nordstrom Coca-Cola robot
are some of the companies to name at the
moment that have received tremendous
amount of benefit by using Lambda let's
look at how Lambda Works in other words
let's look at how the complicated
function behind the scenes work in a
simple and in a seamless way so here
clients send data now clients send data
to Lambda and clients could be anyone
who's sending requests to AWS Lambda it
could be an application or other Amazon
web services that's sending data to the
Lambda and Lambda receives the request
and depending on the size of the data or
depending on the amount or volume of the
data it runs on the defined number of
containers if it is a single request or
if it is less request it runs on a
single container so the requests are
given to the container to handle and the
container which contains the code the
user has provided to satisfy the query
would run and if you're sort of new to
Containers then let me pause here for a
while and explain to you what container
is now container image is a lightweight
Standalone executable package of a piece
of software that includes everything
needs to run it like the codes the
runtimes the system tools the system
libraries and any of the settings needed
and it is at the moment available both
on Linux and windows based application
and containerized software will always
run the same regardless of the
environment it's running on and
containers isolate software from its
surrounding for example there could be
difference between a development and
staging environment so that's sort of
isolated and this helps in reducing the
conflict between the teams running
different software on the same
infrastructure all right now that we
know containers needed to understand
Lambda so if there are few requests it
sends to a single container but as and
when the request grows it actually
creates multiple containers shares the
multiple requests to the different
containers there and depending on the
volume depending on the size depending
on the number of sessions the more
number of containers are provisioned so
to handle those requests and when the
requests reduce the number of containers
reduce as well and that helps in Saving
costs we're not running any resources
and paying for it when we're not using
them and in fact we're not at all paying
for the resources we're only charge for
the amount of time a function is running
inside these containers now consider a
situation where you have to set up a
temporary storage and as a system to
backup the data as soon as the data is
uploaded which is a near real time
backup now a near real-time manual
backups are nearly impossible and
they're not that efficient too A near
real-time manual backups that's what the
business demands but that's not near
real-time backup that to a manual one
that's not at all efficient even if we
come up with a solution of manually
backing up close to near real Time
That's not going to be efficient looking
at the amount of data that will be put
in and looking at the random times the
data will be put into the source bucket
and there is no way we can do a manual
backup and they keep it as real as
possible but if that's still your
requirement we can use AWS Lambda and
set things up so AWS Lambda manually
handles the backup in other words for an
impossible or a difficult situation like
that AWS Lambda comes for the rescue and
this is what we do create a 2s3 bucket
one one would be the source bucket where
the data will be uploaded and the other
one is and destination bucket where the
data will be backed up from the source
bucket and for these buckets to talk to
themselves it's going to require an IM
role and then for the automatic copy
it's going to require an Lambda function
to copy the files from The Source bucket
to the destination bucket and what
triggers the Lambda function the Lambda
function is triggered every time there's
a change in the metadata for the bucket
and this data is then uploaded into the
destination bucket and after setting all
this up we can literally test it by
putting a data in the source bucket
that's going to automatically replicate
or that's going to automatically copy
the data from The Source bucket to the
destination bucket all right let's see
how we can replicate data between to
bucket well we have a feature to cross
region replicate in S3 that's a feature
that comes along with S3 what if you
want to replicate between two different
buckets in two different accounts in
those cases we can use Lambda to
replicate the data between the buckets
so you put one data or you put data in
the source bucket and that data gets
replicated to the destination bucket and
let's see how that's done the procedure
here would be to have two buckets to
begin with and then create an IM role
that lets you access to pull data from
The Source bucket and put data on the
destination bucket and then create
Lambda files or Lambda event or triggers
to actually look for event in the source
bucket and anytime a new data gets added
Lambda gets triggered copies the data
from The Source bucket and moves the
data to the destination bucket and it
uses the IAM role and policy for the
needed permissions and in just a couple
of clicks we have set up a temporary
backup system that can run seamlessly
without any manual intervention and that
can be as near real time as possible all
right that's the concept and let's see
how how it is done real time through
this lab so to begin with we need two
buckets so I have here a source bucket
and a destination bucket and the source
bucket as of now do not have any data in
it so as the destination bucket all
right so that's one down the second
would be to create an IM role right so
let me create an IM role and the role is
going to have this policy in it a policy
that's allowing get object on the source
bucket and a policy that's allowing put
object on the destination bucket and
here I'm going to use or I'm going to
paste my source and destination buckets
Arn all right go to Services go to S3
Source bucket
all right click on the source bucket and
copy the bucket Arn
so that would be the source bucket Arn
right on on the destination bucket copy
the destination bucket Arn
and this is going to be my destination
bucket Arn so with this I'm going to
create a policy
all right
go to IM
and create a policy
now I I have already created a policy
with the same information all right
destination bucket Arn and a policy is
available with the name S3 bucket copy
Lambda attach the policy to the role
right go to rules create a role Lambda
is the service that's going to use it in
here attach the policy that we have
created
right give it the name
and then create a role now I have a role
created as well
all right copy Lambda and that's having
the policy that we have created some
time back now create a Lambda function
let's go to Lambda
create a function give it a name like S3
bucket copy all right choose a role that
we want to use
all right that's the rule that we want
to use copy one two
create a function
all right
and then here we're going to use node.js
code right I have a sample code
this can be used as template in here
replace the source bucket with the name
of the source bucket and the destination
bucket with the name of the destination
bucket this is a node.js code that gets
run when an event get triggers now
what's an event anytime there is a new
object placed in the S3 bucket it
creates an event and the evil triggers
Lambda and Lambda checks this Source S3
bucket picks the data puts it in the
destination bucket all right paste it
here
paste it here and click on save all
right now before you click on Save just
ensure that you have the appropriate
rules defined that's all you got to do
click on save all right now I I already
have created
a Lambda function
all right
which is the same thing same code and
the rule is attached to it
now it's running it's active now let's
put this to test go to S3
pick the source bucket
put some data in it
all right and in theory those data
should be present in the destination
bucket as well
there you go it's all done by Lambda I'm
going to be touring you with different
S3 features and technical details in
this section so what are we going to
learn are we going to learn about what
is cloud storage in general and then the
types of storage available in general in
the cloud and how things were before
anybody adopted using S3 that's
something are we going to learn and then
we're going to immediately dive into
what is S3 and then the benefits of
using S3 over other storage and then
we're gonna do a couple of labs or
console walkthroughs about what is
object and how to add an object what is
bucket how to create a bucket stuff like
that and then we're going to talk about
how Amazon S3 generally works now it
comes with a lot of features it comes
with a lot of Promise um how does this
all work how does Amazon able to keep up
with the promise we're going to talk
about that and then we will talk about
some features add-on features that comes
along with with the Amazon S3 so what is
cloud storage in general cloud storage
is a service that provides web services
where we can store our data and not only
that that data can be easily accessed
and the data can be easily backed up
everything over the internet in chart if
you could store your data if you could
access the data if you could backup your
data everything you do through the
internet then that's a good definition
for cloud storage and the additional
definitions are in cloud storage we only
pay for what we use you know no
commitment no pre-proitioning is you
know pay as you go type subscription and
the best part is we pay on a monthly
basis you know we don't rent a hardware
for the year or we don't give commitment
for the whole year it's pay as you go
and pay on a monthly basis and these
Cloud storages are very reliable meaning
once you put the data in it it's never
going to get lost and these cloud
storage just are scalable assuming I
have a requirement to store 100 times of
what my actual data size is and I want
it now it's available in the cloud and
these storages are secure as well
because we're talking about data data
virginity they need to be secure and
Amazon provides tools and Technologies
through which we can secure our data and
these are generally not found in the
on-premises storage system so let's talk
about the different types of storage in
general so S3 is cloud storage in AWS
and then we have elastic Block store now
elastic Block store is actually the SSD
hard drives that gets attached to our
ec2 instance you know it's like the C
drive it's like the D drive it's like
the e Drive that gets attached to our
instances now EFS is elastic file system
the underlying technology is kind of the
same but it differs from EBS in a way
that EBS can be accessed only by the
system that's attached to it meaning the
volumes and the D volumes we spoke about
they can be accessed only if there is an
instance connected to it but these EFS
are actually shared file systems elastic
file system all right they are shared
systems they can be accessed by multiple
systems they can be accessed from inside
the Amazon environment it can be
accessed from on-premises equipment as
well a glacier is actually the archiving
solution in the cloud if you want to
dump a data and try to keep them in the
low cost as possible then Glacier is the
product we should be using and then we
have storage Gateway if I want to safely
move my data from my local environment
to the cloud environment and also want
to keep a copy of the data locally so
users locally can access them and in a
cloud users or Internet users can access
the data from the cloud if that's your
requirement then storage Gateway is the
one we would be choosing and then we
have snowball snowball is really an data
in Import and Export a system but it is
actually an Hardware that gets shipped
to our premises where we can copy a data
into it and then I ship it back to
Amazon and Amazon would copy the data
into whatever destination we give them
in our account and if the data is really
huge then I can call for a snowmobile
which is actually a data center on a
truck where Amazon would send me a truck
loaded with the data center as you see
that has compute capacity lots and lots
of storage capacity and electricity AC
and a lot more so they get compared near
our data center and cables run into our
data center we can copy data into it
send it back to Amazon and they would
copy it to our account in whatever
storage that we advise that so if the
data is really really huge then I would
be calling snowmobiles snowmobile is not
available in all the regions all right
let's take this example how things were
before S3 was introduced you know two
professionals are having a conversation
and one of them is finding it very
difficult to sort of manage all the data
in the organization well if the data is
small it can be easily managed but as
company grow and we are living in an era
where data is everything we want data to
backup every idea we want data to backup
every proof of concept that we provide
so data is everything so in this era
it's all about collecting data analyzing
them and saving you know not losing logs
you know saving them analyzing stuff
like that so coming back to our
discussion here one person finds it very
difficult to store and manage all the
data that they have so some of the datas
that this person is having problem
storing is datas that application used
to running and then datas that gets sent
to the customers and status that the
websites require the data that are
because of the email backups and a lot
more other storages that an Enterprise
can have and this person is having
problem backing up all those data and
even if we think of increasing the local
storage capacity and that's going to
cost the fortune and few things that
make it sometimes impossible to increase
the storage capacity in-house is you
know we will have to go and pay heavy to
buy hardware and software to run these
storages and we need to hire a team of
experts for maintaining them the
hardware and the software and anytime if
there is a dynamic increase in the
storage capacity the on-premises or
in-house Hardwares won't be able to
scale and data security data security is
very costly when it comes to building
our own storage environment in-house and
adding data security on top of it so the
other guy in the conversation was sort
of quietly listening everything the
manager was saying and then he slowly
introduced him to S3 because he knew
that all the problem that this manager
was worried about can be solved to S3 in
other words all the scalability all the
data security all the not being able to
provision hardware and software
components are all available with S3 so
that actually brings us to the
discussion about what S3 is S3 is simple
storage service it actually provides an
object storage service let me talk to
you about object and block storage
object storage is where you can store
things in the drive all right you can't
install anything in it and this object
storage can be accessed directly from
the internet whereas block storage is
something that needs to be attached to
an instance and we can't directly access
it but we can install software in it so
that's a high level difference between
object storage and block storage and S3
is an object storage what does that mean
we can store data from the internet we
can retrieve from the internet but we
can't install anything in S3 all right
so so S3 is an object based storage and
it's it's really built for storing and
recovering or retriving any amount of
data or information from anywhere in the
internet few other things you need to
know about S3 is that this S3 is
accessible through the web interface the
storage one type of accessing or one way
of accessing S3 is by dragging dropping
content into it and another way of
retrieving data from S3 is go to a
browser click on download that's going
to let you download any content and the
data can be five terabytes in size now
we're talking about one file you know
you can have hundreds or thousands of
files like that one file can be as big
as 5 terabytes in size and S3 is
basically designed for developers where
they can push logs into S3 or drive logs
anytime they want instead of storing
locally in the server they can use S3 as
code repositories you know where they
can save the code and have the
applications read the code from there
and lot more if they want to safely
share the code with another person with
a lot of encryption and security added
on top of it that's possible as well so
there are few things about S3 and on top
of all this S3 provides 11 9 durability
and four nine availability meaning
durability is if I store the data will
it get lost Amazon is like no it's not
going to get lost you're gonna have the
data because we provide 11 9 durability
for the data and availability is if you
want the data now will you be able to
show it Amazon is like yes we will be
able to show it we have 99.99
availability and when you request the
data we will be able to show the data to
you all right so let's talk about the
benefits of S3 S3 is durable as we saw
it provides 11 9 durability S3 is low
cost out of all the storage options in
Amazon S3 is the cheapest ns3 is very
scalable like we were saying there
there's no required to pre-provision a
storage capacity you know if you need
more go ahead and use more if you need
even more go ahead and use even more and
once you're done some data needs to be
removed just remove the data so that
particular month you will be paying less
so it's very scalable in nature and it's
very available as well S3 isn't regional
service you know it's not based on one
availability zone so one available it is
on going down within Amazon the whole
availability going down it's not going
to affect your ability to access S3
storage and S3 is secure a lot of
security features like bucket policy a
lot of security features like encryption
and then MFA authentication are possible
with S3 that actually adds a very good
security layer on top of the data that
we have stored in S3 and not only that
this S3 is very flexible in terms of
cost flexible in terms of of where I
want to store the data in terms of cost
there are a lot of pricing tiers within
S3 S3 itself is a cheap service now
within that we have a lot of pricing
tiers depending on the durability so I
can always choose to put data on a
different storage tier or storage option
in S3 we're going to talk about it as
you stick along and in terms of
flexibility in region I can always
choose any of the region available in
the console or in the S3 console to put
my data to there is no restrictions on
where I can or cannot put the data in
the cloud as long as there are regions
available for me to move the data to and
data transferring with S3 is very simple
all I have to do is browse to the bucket
upload the data and the data gets
uploaded and we can also upload data
using CLI commands are very similar to
Linux commands are very similar to what
we would use in the Run command prompt
in Windows and what we would use in the
Run command prompt in the Powershell all
right let's talk about a basic building
block of S3 which is bucket and objects
now what's a bucket what's an object
object is the actual data and bucket is
the folder where the objects get stored
let me give you a new definition for
object so object is the actual data plus
some information that reference the data
like is it an JPEG file the name of the
file and at what time it was added to so
they're called metadata right so object
is actually data plus metadata and
bucket is actually a container that
receives the data and safely stores in
it and when we add a data in a bucket
Amazon S3 creates an unique version ID
and allocates it to the object so we can
easily identify it at a later Point let
me show you a quick lab on S3
foreign
console if you're wondering how I
reached here go to Services Under
storage and S3 is right here
and let's create a bucket called simply
learn
now the bucket names will have to be
unique
so I really doubt if simply learn will
be available let's let's check it anyway
all right it doesn't seem to be
available so
um
let me pick another name or let's call
it simply learn that
samuel.com
and I'm going to put this in
Mumbai or I can choose Oregon
let me choose Oregon
yes let me choose Oregon
and let me create a bucket
sure enough a bucket got created let me
upload an object into the bucket
and you know these objects can be as big
as
five terabytes we talked about it right
all right let me upload an object
all right so that's my object so you get
the relation right here's a bucket
right here's my bucket and within that
is my object now object is the actual
file plus what type of file it is and
then
and then the size of the file the date
in which it got added and the storage
class it is in at the moment
so if I have to access it
I can simply access it through the
internet
so let's talk about how does this S3
bucket work anyway all right so how does
it work a user creates a bucket they
will specify the region in which the
bucket should be deployed we had an
option we could have chosen to deploy in
all the regions Amazon provides S3
service you know beat not Virginia beat
Mumbai beat Tokyo beat Sydney uh beat uh
Oregon and we chose Oregon to be the
destination region where we want to
create bucket and save our data there
and when we upload data into the bucket
we can specify three types of storage
classes in our case we pick the default
which was a S3 standard as we saw on the
object data it was on S3 standard so
that's the basic thing later once the
object gets added we can always add a
bucket policies you know policies to
Define who access it and who should not
access it what can they access are we
going to allow users only to read or to
read write as well stuff like that so
that's bucket policy we're defining the
life cycle or the lifespan of the data
in the S3 bucket now over the time do
you want the data
to automatically move to a different
storage tier and at any point do you
want to sort of expire the data you know
get the data flushed out of your account
automatically you know those things can
be configured in lifecycle policies and
Version Control is creating multiple
versions if you're going to use S3 for a
code repository creating multiple
versions let's say if you want to roll
back to whatever you had before a month
how are you going to do it if you kept
updating the file and never took a
version of it so Version Control helps
us to keep different versions and it
helps us to roll back to the older
version anytime that is a need so let's
talk about the different storage classes
in S3 the different storage classes in
S3 begins with S3 standard now this is
the default and it's very suitable for
use cases where you need less or low
latency for example if you want to
access the data of a student's
attendance you would retrieve them very
quickly as much as possible so that's a
good use case to store data in S3 let's
understand the different storage classes
in Amazon S3 now let's take a school for
example and the the different datas
present in a school and the features of
those data the validity of the data all
right so let's take this example and
there are different storage options in
S3 let's take S3 standard for example
and what would be the actual candidate
data that can be stored in S3 standard
let's talk about that so S3 standard in
general is suitable for use cases where
the latency should be very low and in
here the good example are the good
candidate file that can be stored in S3
is a data that needs to be frequently
accessed and that needs to be retrieved
quickly something like students
attendance report or students attendance
sheet would we access daily and then it
needs to be retrieved immediately as and
when we need it the other type of
storage tier in S3 is infrequent access
or in frequent data access just like the
name says the use case for that is less
frequently accessed data I mean the
candidate data that should go in in
frequent access data is a student's
academic record you know which we don't
need to access on a daily basis but if
there is a requirement we might want to
go and look at it then that's going to
be quick so it's not a data that we
would access on a daily basis but it's
data that needs to show up on your
screen real quick and the third option
is Amazon Glacier now Glacier is really
an archival solution in the cloud so for
archives high performance is not a
requirement so let's talk about some
candidate data that can go into archives
something like students admission fee
and it's not critical also now anytime
if you want to look at the data you can
always wait to retrieve the data so in
other words you know put it in the
archive and you're driving from the
archival takes time so a student's old
record are a good candidate to be put in
the archives the other options are one
zone IA storage class where the data is
infrequently accessed and the data is
stored in a single availability zone for
example you know by default Amazon
stores data in multiple availability
zones and there is a charge for that now
it's not an option but the charge
includes storing data in multiple
availability zones but if your data
requirement is you want to keep the
charges in a low even further you can
choose one's own IA storage class where
it stores data in one availability Zone
and the candidate data that can go in
one zone in frequent access is students
report card and the other option with
Amazon S3 is standard reduced redundancy
storage it is suitable for cases where
the data is not critical and the data
can be reproduced quickly for example
you know take a copy of the library book
take a copy of the PDF library book for
example now we would have a source PDF
and we would make copies of it and then
we make it available for the readers to
read the other option in S3 is reduced
redundancy storage here the use case is
data that's not critical and a data can
be reproduced quickly for example a
books in the library are not that
critical and we always have a copy of
the book we're talking about PDF so if
the customer facing or the student
facing book gets deleted I can always
copy the same PDF put it in the
destination folder and make it available
for the users to read that would be a
very good use case for reduced
redundancy storage all right let's
summarize everything that we learned
about different storage options in S3 so
S3 standard it's for frequently accessed
data it's the default storage if you
don't mention anything the data gets
stored in S3 standard it can be used for
cloud applications you know content
distribution gaming applications big
data analytic Dynamic websites they are
a very good use case for S3 standard
frequently accessed data the other one
on the contrary is S3 standard
infrequently accessed data just like the
name says the use case is this is good
for data that will be less frequently
accessed and and then the use case are
it's good for backups it's good for
disaster recovery and it's good for
lifelong storage of data Glacier on the
other hand is very suitable for
archiving data which is infrequently
accessed and the Vault lock feature is
the security feature of the glacier that
also provides a long-term data storage
in the cloud this is the lowest storage
tier within S3 the other options are one
zone in frequent access storage class
just like the name says it's
infrequently accessed and it is stored
in just one availability Zone and use
cases are any data that doesn't require
any high level of security can be stored
here in one zone the fifth storage tier
is reduced redundancy storage this is
good for data that's frequently accessed
it's good for data that is non-critical
and that can be reproduced if it gets
lost and reduce redundancy storage or
RRS is an highly available solution
designed for sharing or storing data
that can be reproduced quickly all right
let's compare and contrast couple of
other features that are available in S3
for example durability availability SSL
support first byte latency and life
cycle management so in standard the
durability is 11 9 durability it's the
same for standard standard IA one zone
IA Glacier except for reduced redundancy
the durability is 11 9 and availability
of all the storage classes is all the
same except for one zone IA where the
availability zone is
99.5 percentage all of these products
support SSL connection and the first
byte latency of these products are most
of them provide access with millisecond
latency except for Glacier it provides
retrieval time of couple of minutes to a
maximum of hours and all of them can be
used for a life cycle management you
know moving data from one storage tier
to another storage here that's possible
with all of these storage options all
right now that we've understood the
different types of storage options
available on S3 let's talk about some of
the features that are available on S3
lifecycle management now lifecycle
management is a service that helps us to
define a set of rules that can be
applied to an object or to the bucket
itself life cycle is actually moving the
data from one storage tier to another
storage tier and finally expiring it and
and completing the life cycle of the
object with lifecycle management we can
manage and store our objects in a very
cost effective way it has two features
basically transition actions and
expiration actions let's talk about
transition actions with transition
action we can choose to move the objects
or move the data from one storage class
to another storage class with lifecycle
management we can configure S3 to move
our data from one storage class to
another storage class at a defined time
interval or at a defined schedule let's
talk about transition actions in a mode
till let's say we have our data in S3 at
the moment and we haven't used the data
for quite some time and it's that's how
it's going to be for the rest of the
time so that data is a very good
candidate to move to the infrequent axis
because S3 standard is a bit costlier
and S3 infrequent access is a bit
cheaper than S3 standards so the kind of
usage sort of fits very well for moving
that data into infrequent access so
using lifecycle transition or lifecycle
management I can move the data to S3 in
frequent access after 30 days and let's
say that the data stayed in in frequent
access for 30 more days and then now I
realized that nobody is looking into the
data so I can find an appropriate
storage here for that particular data
again and I can move it to that
particular storage here which is Glacier
so in this case after 30 days or in a
total of 60 days from the time the data
got created the data can be moved to
Glacier and what is this really help us
with the life cycle management help us
to automatically migrate our data from
one storage cost to another storage cost
and by that it really helps us to save
the storage cost lifecycle management
can also help us with object expiration
meaning deleting the object or flushing
it out after a certain amount of time
let's say that our complex requirement
requires that we keep the data for seven
years and we have like thousands and
thousands of data like that it would be
humanly impossible to check all those or
keep track of all the dates and you know
when they need to be deleted stuff like
that but with lifecycle management it is
very much possible I can simply create a
data and set up lifecycle management for
the data to expire after seven years and
exactly after seven years the data is
going to expire meaning it's going to be
deleted automatically from the account
all right let me show you a lab on
lifecycle management and let me explain
to you how it's actually done so I'm
into the bucket that we have created and
here's a data into the bucket assume we
have thousands and thousands of data in
the bucket and that requires to be put
in a different storage tier over time
and that requires to be expired after
seven years let's say so the way I would
create a life cycle management is go to
management from inside the bucket and
click on life cycle and then add and
lifecycle rule just give it a name name
like expire so all the objects that's
present in this bucket meaning the
current version of it set a transition
for it so the transition is at the
moment they are in S3 so here I would
like to put them in infrequent access
after 30 days and then after it's been
an infrequent access for 30 days I would
like to move it to Glacier all right
plus 30 days so how do you read it so
for the first 30 days it's going to be
in Glacier so how do we actually read it
after I put the data in S3 the data is
going to get moved to standard IA and
then it's going to stay in standard IA
and after 60 days from the data creation
it's going to get moved to a glacier so
on the 31st day it's going to move to
standard IE on the 61st day it's going
to move to Glacier let's say if I want
to sort of delete the data if I want the
data to get deleted automatically after
seven years you know being in a glacier
how do I go about doing it let me open
up a quick calculator
365 into 7 that's
2555 days right after that the data is
gonna get deleted pretty much I have
created a life cycle so after on the
31st day it's going to get moved to
infrequent access and on the 61st day
Glacier and after seven years is over
any data that I put in the bucket it's
going to get deleted all right let's
talk about bucket policies bucket
policies are some permission files that
we can attach to an a bucket that allows
or denies access to the bucket based on
what's mentioned in the policy so bucket
policy is really an IM policy where you
can allow and deny permission to an S3
resource with bucket policy we can also
Define security rules that apply to more
than one file in a bucket now in this
case you know we can create an user or
let's say there's already a user called
simply learn or we can allow or deny
that user connection to the s 3 bucket
or connecting to the S3 bucket using
bucket policy and bucket policies are
written in Json script and let's see how
that's done all right there are tools
available for us to help us create
bucket policies what you're looking at
is a tool available online that helps us
to create a bucket policy so let's use
this tool to create a bucket policy I'm
going to create a deny statement I'm
going to deny all actions to the S3
bucket and what is the Arn to which we
want to attach the Arn of the resources
actually the name of the bucket but it
really expects us to give that key in a
different format so the Arn is available
right here copy bucket Arn so this is
actually going to deny everybody now we
wanted to deny a user just one user now
look at that now we have a policy that
has been created that's denying access
to the bucket and it's denying a user
called simply learn pretty much done so
I can use the policy and go over to
bucket policies so once I save it only
the user call Simply learn won't have
access to the bucket and the rest of
them will have access to it so once you
save it it gets added and only the user
simply learn will not have access to the
bucket because we're denying them
purposefully the other features of S3
include data protection we can protect
our data in S3 with the now one of which
is bucket policy I can also use
encryptions to protect my data I can
also use IM policy to protect my data so
Amazon S3 provides a durable storage not
only that it also gives us unprotected
and scalable infrastructure needed for
any of our object storage requirements
so here the data is protected by two
means one is data encryption and the
other one is data versioning data
encryption is encrypting the data so
others won't get access or even if they
get access to the file they won't be
able to access the data without the
encryption key and versioning is making
multiple copies of the data so let's
talk about them in detail what's data
encryption now data encryption refers to
protecting the the data while it is
being transmitted and protecting the
data while it is at rest now data
encryption can happen in two ways one is
client encryption encryption at rest and
server side encryption encryption that's
in motion client-side encryption refers
to when client sends the data they
encrypt the data and send it across to
Amazon and server side encryption is
when the data is being transferred they
get encrypted and stay encrypted
throughout the transfer versioning is
another security feature let I mean it
helps us so our unintentional edits are
not actually corrupting the data for
example let's say you edited the data
and now you realize that the data is
incorrect and you want it all back now
how do you roll back without versioning
it's not possible in other words only
with versioning it's possible so
versioning it can be utilized to observe
recovery and restore any early versions
of every object that we stored in our
Amazon S3 bucket unintentional erases or
overrides of the object can be easily
regained if we have versioning enabled
and it's possible only if we have one
file with the same name and anytime we
update the file it keeps the file name
but creates a different version ID take
this bucket and data for example in a
photo.pmg is a file that was initially
stored it attached a version ID to it
and then we edited it let's say we added
some watermarks we you know added some
graphic to it and that's now the new
version of it when we store it we store
it with the same file name it accepts
the same file name but creates a new
version ID and attaches it anytime we
want roll back we can always go to the
console look at the old versions pick
the version ID and roll back to the old
version ID all right let's take this
example now I'm in a bucket that we've
been using for a while and let me upload
an object now before we actually upload
an object this bucket needs to be
versioning enabled so let me watch
enable this Bucket from this point
onwards this bucket is going to accept
versioning so let me upload an object
photo.jpg let me upload it alright it
successfully got uploaded good enough
it's uploaded now let me upload another
object with the same file name now look
at that it was uploaded at 7 40 35 am
let me upload another object with the
same file name that I have it stored
right here that got up to uploaded but
with the same name
all right so that's the other photo now
what if if I want to switch back the way
I would switch back is simply switch
back to the older version Look at that
this is the latest version and this is
the old version that I have I can simply
switch back to the old version that was
created at such and such time and I can
open it
that's going to open the old file so in
short it creates different version of
the data that I create as long as it's
with the same name and at any point I
can go and roll back to the original
data this is a very good use case if you
want to use S3 for storing our codes
let's talk about other feature like
cross region replication now cross
region replication is an very cool
feature if you want to automatically
keep a copy of the data in a totally
different region for you know data
durability for any additional data
durability or if you want to serve data
to your customers who live in another
country or who are accessing your data
from another country if you want to
serve the data with low latency cross
region replication is a very cool
feature that you can use and get
benefited from and let's see how that's
done so before we actually do a lab on
Cross region replication let's put
together a proper definition for it
cross region application is a feature
that provides automatic copying of every
object uploaded to our bucket or your
bucket Source bucket and it
automatically copies the data to the
destination bucket which is in a
different AWS region as you see here in
the picture I put data only in region
one it's going to copy the data to
region 2. and for us to use cross region
replication versioning must be turned on
so it creates versions and copies the
versions as well if tomorrow the
original region goes down let's say the
other region will be active and it has
the complete data that was present in
the original region or at any point if
we want to Simply you know cut the
region replication and use the other
bucket as in Standalone bucket it can be
used as well because it already has all
the data that was present in the master
or all the data that was present in the
original replication bucket let's see
how all that's done so there are two
things needed one is versioning and
another one is role when we transfer
data from one bucket to another bucket
we need proper permissions to do so and
these roles they give us proper
permissions to transfer data from one
bucket to another bucket let's see how
that's done right so here's my bucket a
bucket in US Oregon let's create another
bucket
and
in Mumbai
call it dot Mumbai
.com name through the console that shows
up and then like I said it's going to
require permission to put data onto the
other bucket now I can create different
roles these are different roles uh that
are used for different other services I
can also choose to create a role that
specifically uh gives permission only to
move the data from one bucket to another
bucket three months it's done so if I go
over to my source bucket and if I add
some data to it let's say index.html
assuming I'm adding some files to it in
theory they should move to the other
region automatically there you go I'm in
the Mumbai region and the data is they
got moved to the other region
automatically let's talk about the other
feature called transfer acceleration now
it's a very handy and a helpful tool or
a service to use if we are transferring
data which is is very long distance from
us meaning from the client to the SC
bucket let's say from my local machine
which is in India if I transfer the data
over to Oregon let's say it's a long
distance if it is going to go to the
Internet it's going to go through high
latency connections and my transfer
might get delayed if it is in one
gigabit file it's okay but if we're
talking about anything that's uh you
know five terabyte size and if you're
talking about anything that's a five
terabyte in size then it's not going to
be a pleasant experience so in those
cases I can use transfer accelerator
with which in a secure way but in a fast
way or a fastest way transfers my data
from the laptop or from client to the S3
bucket and it makes use of a service
called cloudfront to transfer or to
enable the data acceleration so the way
it would do it is instead of copying the
data directly to the location instead of
copying the data directly to the
destination bucket it copies the data
locally into a cloudfront location which
is available very local to whatever
place we are in and from there it copies
the data directly to an S3 bucket not
going through the internet it helps
eliminate a lot of latency that could
get added when transferring the data so
let's see how that's done
right here I'm in the S3 bucket and
under properties I can find transfer
accelerator and if I enable transfer
accelerator so I'm in another bucket let
me go to properties and let me go to
transfer accelerator and enable transfer
accelerator so now if I put data into
this bucket they're gonna get copied to
the local Cloud run location and from
there they're gonna get copied to the S3
Bucket from the cloud front now if we
need to compare you know how the speed
is going to be compared to directly
putting the data to the internet and
using cloudfront there is a tool
available that actually runs for a while
and then comes with a report that tells
me how much will be the improved speed
if I use transfer accelerator and it
shows for all the regions available in
Amazon so from the source to the
destination if you want to put you know
what's the normal and what's the
accelerated speed when you transfer the
data those results we will get it in the
screen so at the moment this tool is
going through it testing like uploading
some file through the internet and
uploading some file using cloudfront and
it has come up with the calculation that
if I'm uploading file to San Francisco
compared to uploading through the
internet and through cloudfront it's 13
times faster so similar way it's going
to calculate for all the regions
available and it's going to give me a
result let me help you understand series
called im a service in AWS for security
here in this section we're going to talk
about what is Security in AWS and then
we're going to slowly or gradually move
on to the other topics like types of
security available in AWS out of all the
services y IM is the most preferred one
and then we're going to talk about what
is IM in general how it works the
building blocks or components in IM and
the features it the the attractive
features that it provides that makes IAM
stand out from the rest of the services
available we're going to talk about that
and then we're going to end today's
session with a demo about how IAM gets
well interacted with other services in
Amazon and help create a secure
environment in the cloud let's talk
about AWS security Now Cloud security is
the highest priority in AWS and when we
host our environment in the cloud we can
be rest assured that we are hosting our
environment in a data center or in a
network architecture that's really built
to meet the requirement of the most
security sensitive organization and this
high level of security is available to
us on a pay as you go type meaning there
is really no upfront cost at that we
need to pay and the cost for using the
service is a lot lot cheaper than what
it is in an on-premises environment so
AWS Cloud provides an secure what
virtual platform where we can deploy our
application now compared to the
on-premises with AWS the security level
is very high and the cost involved in
using or attaching that type of security
to our application is very low compared
to on-premises there's really no upfront
cost and the cost is very lower whatever
cost that we pay is very lower than what
it would be in on-premises and all this
contributes to the secure environment we
can get through IM in AWS Cloud there
are really many types of security
services available in AWS to name a few
or to name the familiar ones IM stands
first followed by a key management
system KMS and then we have Cognito
that's another service and web access
firewall WAFF is another security
service in AWS now let's start our
discussion by talking about IM and
that's what this whole series is about
now I am or identity and access
management it really enables us to
manage access to AWS services and AWS
resources in a very secure manner with
IM we can create groups we can actually
allow those users or groups to access
some service or we can sort of deny them
to access the service whichever we want
that's all possible through identity and
access management and this feature comes
with no additional charge now let's talk
about how things were before AWS before
AWS or before IM in general it was not
that safe in a corporate to share the
password over the phone or through the
email that was the practice that was
existed at that time now we all can
remember the days when we need to switch
to a different account or we had just
one admin password commonly stored in a
location or one person would reset it
and maintain it and anytime or we need
to log in we call the person ask for the
admin password over the phone own and
then we try logging in now that was not
secure at all back then no somebody
could walk by and sort of eavesdrop and
get the password now they walk away with
the password with them so they're all
possible when we share the password over
the phone and through the internet or
email now with AWS a lot of options are
available that I'm not sharing password
over the unsecured medium now a slack is
a third-party product available with AWS
it's not an AWS product but slack is a
third-party application that's hosted on
AWS and it's really a communication tool
that helps people to share a documents
so now we're not sharing the password
over the phone rather through the
applications and the no eavesdrop person
can really catch the password and you
know try it in their system to access
our environment that's not possible so
you see the difference now back then
sharing password was only through phone
and email and you would write it on a
paper and give it to somebody but now
technology is providing Provisions
enough for us to share the password in a
secure way we're still talking about I
am I am is an web service for securely
controlling access to the AWS resource
now it really helps us to authenticate
our sort of limit access to a certain
set of users accessing the AWS account
or certain set of users accessing a
certain set of resources in AWS account
now you see this picture we have an IM
administrator who's trying to allocate
permissions to different group of people
so we have group one on the top and
group two in the middle and group 3
towards the end the administrator using
im or IAM empowers the administrator
allow access to certain group to certain
resources that's what IAM is all about
now let's talk about the building blocks
or let's talk about the elements that
make and complete Im so the elements are
categorized into six different elements
we have the principle in IM the
authentication the request the actual
request coming in the authorization
allowing denying access actions what are
the scope of actions can be taken and on
what resource is it easy to visit RDS is
it S3 bucket so what resource these
actions are applied to so they are the
basic elements of an IM workflow let's
talk about principle for example an
action on AWS resource can only be
performed by a principal an individual
user they can be a principal a role in
AWS IM it can be a principle as well in
other words a principle is an entity
that can take an action on an AWS
resource you know a principle can be an
user a principle can be a role a
principle can be an application that's
trying to access the AWS environment
secondly authentication now
authentication is a process of
confirming the identity off the
principle trying to access the AWS
environment now how do we get
authenticated or how does a user get
authenticated by providing credentials
or the required keys to validate that
this is what he or she is as per what's
in the record so all principle must be
authenticated and we get authenticated
using the username and password to log
into the console if it is CLI or we get
authenticated using the axis key and the
secret access key the other component
that makes up IM is request when a
principal tries to use the AWS
Management console what the principle is
doing or what the user is doing is
sending a request to the AWS environment
and the request will have the principal
actually wants to perform is it an put
request or is it a get request or is it
a delete request stuff like that and
it's also going to carry information
about on which resource the action needs
to be done is it done ec21 is it on S3
bucket simplylearn.com stuff like that
so so it has a specific action that it
wants to perform and the resource on
which it wants to perform and also some
information about from where the request
is originating from is it within an AWS
environment or is it with another cloud
service provider or is it with
on-premises stuff like that so these
information will be present in the
request authorization now this IM uses
information from the request context to
check for matching policies and it
determines it takes a decision whether
to allow or to deny the request now here
it has a logic by default all the
resources are denied and the IM
authorizes your request only if every
part of the request is allowed by a
matching policy so there is an
evaluation logic and that says by
default all requests are denied and if
that is an explicit allow then it
overrides the default deny and if you
are explicitly denying a service then
all the allow state treatments get
overridden and all the other statements
gets over return and this explicit deny
stands by default only the AWS account
root user has access to all the
resources in that account so if you're
not signed in as a root user then we
must be specifically granted permission
through a policy in other words we need
to be authorized through the policy now
let's talk about action now after
authenticating and authorizing the
request AWS approves the action that we
are about to take Now using action we
can view the content we can create a
Content or create a bucket or create an
ec2 instance I can edit content or even
I can delete a resource that's all based
on the action that I'm allowed to do now
that was about actions now where is the
action performed the action is performed
on the resources a set of actions can be
performed on a resource and anything
that's not mentioned in the action or
anything that's not tagged with the
action and the resource they don't get
to complete for example let's say a few
attempt to delete an IM role and you
also request to access the ec2 instance
for that role then the request gets
denied now let's talk about some of the
other components of Im so the other
components are IM are the basic building
block is in user and then many users
together they form a group and then
policies are the engines that allows or
denies a connection you know based on
policy one gets to access or gets no
access to a resource and then roles
roles are another component roles are
temporary credentials I would say that
can get assumed to an instance as and
when needed right let's talk about this
component called user in an IM with IM
we can securely manage access to AWS
services and we can create an IM user
anytime there is a new employee joining
our corporate so it's it's a one-to-one
mapping you know one user or one
employee get a username directly
attached to them and a username or a
user is an account specific thing you
know it's very local to that AWS account
that we are using so for in detail and
IM user is an entity that we create in
an AWS environment to represent a person
or a service that interacts with AWS
environment and this user is going to
have some credentials attached to them
and by default they do not have a
password and they do not have any access
key or secret access key attached to
them in fact literally no credentials of
any kind now we must create a user and
we must create the type of credential
that gets attached to the user do they
want to access a CLI So based on that we
would be adding credentials to them a
user by default is not authorized to
perform any action in AWS and the
advantage of having one-to-one user is
that we can assign permissions
individually to that user for example we
might want to assign administrative
permissions to few users who can
administer our AWS environment and users
are entity within an AWS account users
don't have to pay separately you know
they start using the servers and that
get bills under the account they are
attached to so separate users doesn't
mean that separate payment for those
users they are just users in our account
and you know the whole account gets to
pay for the resources that they
provision again the IM user does not
always represent a person an IM user is
really just an identity with Associated
credential and permissions attached to
it it could be an actual person who is a
user and it could be an application also
a who's a user next we'll talk about
groups talking about groups or
understanding group is very easy a
collection of user forms an IM group and
we can use IM group to specify
permission for multiple users so that
any permission that's applied to the
group is also applied to the users who
are at add to that group now there are a
few things you might want to know about
group a group can have many users and a
user they can belong to many groups but
groups can't be nested meaning group can
only have users you know a group cannot
have a group inside a group that's not
possible and there's nothing called a
default group that sort of automatically
includes all users in the AWS account if
you want to have a group then we will
have to create a group now let's take
this diagram for example now this is a
diagram of a small company now the
company owner creates an admin group for
users to create and manage other users
as the company expands every day and the
admin group creates a developer group
and a test group each of these group
consists of users users who are people
users who are application that interact
with AWS environment so the different
types of users we have are Jim is a user
Brad is an user and Dev app one is a
user and and so on so each users have an
individual set of security credential
like I said it's one to one and the uh
10 users that we see on screen are
shared between or they belong to
multiple groups in the account and
managing group is quite easy we set
permission to the group and that
permission gets applied to all the users
automatically in the group and after we
applied the policy if I add another user
to the group the new user will
automatically inherit all the policies
all the permissions that's already
mentioned in that group so
administrative button is sort of taken
away administrative button about user a
privilege or user permission management
is sort of taken out with IM all right
the next thing we will want to discuss
is policy a policy sets permission and
controls the access to AWS resource and
the policies these permissions and
controls are stored in Json format a
policy is a very clear document it
defines who has access to a resource and
what are all the actions they can
perform so in other words policies and
entity in AWS that when a policy gets
attached to an identity or a resource
you know it really defines the
permission what they can and cannot do
and AWS it evaluates these policies when
a principal such as a user makes an
request and the permission statement and
the policy it really defines whether the
usage is allowed to access a service or
is he denied to access a service all
right let's take this example now we
have a task the task is to give Paul who
is a developer access to Amazon S3
environment and what you're looking at
is a snippet of what a policy would look
like so these are some questions we will
have to answer or these these are some
question the policy tries to answer and
once it found an answer then it becomes
a complete policy so who wants access to
the service it's Paul who wants access
to the service and what action do Paul
want now Paul wants to download or Paul
wants to upload objects in S3 in Json
language it's otherwise called Paul
wants to get information Paul wants to
put information otherwise Paul wants to
get object Paul wants to put object in
S3 and which resource does he want now
in this case every bucket the star
symbol represents all buckets in S3 so
which results its all bucket in S3 so we
can start reading already from the data
present here so who wants access Paul
wants access what action does he want he
wants to get he wants to put and what's
the resource that he's trying to access
or you want to give him access it's all
the bucket in AWS and when does he want
these are additional statement that goes
in a policy so since when does he want
that access he wants access till March
2nd 2019 so all this who all this action
all this resource you know till the time
all this gets allowed so this is the
statement that really defines now does
this all refer to an allow statement or
does this all refer to a deny statement
if we had deny here it's the direct
opposite of what we discussed but we
have allow that means Paul is allowed to
get and put access in an S3 bucket and
all the buckets in S3 till March 2nd
2019 he's allowed to access the
resources so if we put together put all
the information that we have gathered or
all the answers that we have so far if
we put together in Json format this is
how it's gonna look like so the effect
is allow or deny here it's allowing and
the principle is any now who can access
it it's any an action it's any bucket in
S3 any action in S3 put get request and
the resource is any bucket in S3 so
that's how a basic policy would look
like or that's how a basic policy is
formed by answering those basic
questions so let's talk about the types
of policies so we have two broad
categories manage policy and inline
policy now manage policy it's the
default policy that we attach to
multiple entries bid users beat groups
and beat roles in our AWS account on the
other hand inline policy are the
policies that we create and manage them
and these policies are embedded directly
into a single user group or a role so if
I need to brief it a little bit more
then a managed policies are Standalone
identity based policies that we can
attach to multiple users groups and
roles in our AWS account we can use two
types of managed policies in other words
manage policies they themselves have two
categories one is AWS managed policies
which is created and managed by AWS and
the other one is customer managed
policies just like the name says it's
managed by the customer now we can
create and edit an IM policy in visual
editor or simply create a Json policy
document directly and upload it in the
console and start using them so that's
manage policy on the other hand inline
policies are policies that we create and
manage and that are imported directly
into a single user group or role let's
talk about this next component called
role now this role is very similar to
everything that we discussed so far it's
a set of permission that defines what
actions are allowed and denied by an
entity in an AWS console the role is
very similar to end user I said very
similar I didn't say it's the same as
the user but I said it's very similar to
the user and the difference is that user
is hard-coded user permissions are
hard-coded but the role permissions are
accessed by any entity you know be it a
user or a beat an AWS service and
moreover the role permissions are
temporary on the other hand user
permissions are permanent and the role
permissions are temporary
so in detail a role is very similar to a
user in that it's an AWS entity with
permission policies that determines what
the identity can and cannot do in AWS
now instead of it being uniquely
associated with one person a role is
intended to be assumable by anyone who
needs it roles generally do not have a
long term credential you know password
or access Keys associated with it you
know it does not have long-term
credentials it only has temporary
credentials created dynamically and
provided to the user as in when the user
assumes a role and wants to access any
service roles can be assumed by users
roles can be assumed by applications
roles can be assumed by services that
normally they don't have access to AWS
resources for example you might want to
Grant a user in your AWS account access
to your resource that they do not
normally have or Grant users in one AWS
account access to resource in another
AWS account now this is something that
we don't have by default and this is
something we may not need all the time
or you might want to allow a mobile app
to use AWS resource but you do not want
to save the key or save the credential
or save the passwords in the mobile app
or sometimes you might want to give
access to resources who already have
identities defined outside of AWS like a
user who's already and Google or
Facebook authenticator if you want to
give them some service or if you want to
let them to access some of the resources
in your account we can use roles for
that purpose or you also might want to
Grant access to your account to a third
party a consultant or an auditor so they
can for some time get some temporary
access to audit our AWS resources
remember they're not permanent users
such as template users they want some
temporary access to our environmental
the audit is over so for those cases row
goals are a very good use case so let's
take this example let's see where roll
sits and let's see how roles give
permission to other services so here is
a scenario where where an easy to
instance wants access to an S3 bucket by
default though both of them were created
by the same username are the same admin
they do not have access by default so by
default they don't have access and I
also do not want to give permanent
access in a one-on-one hard-coded
permanent access instead I would like to
create and share access so that's
possible through road so coming back to
the discussion uh the scenario here is
that an ac2 instance wants to access
data in an S3 bucket so the first thing
is to create a role or a permission we
saw how that's done right using policies
roles use policies policy is the actual
working engine for any permission
related actions right so create a role
with an appropriate policy that that
gives access to S3's bucket and then
launch an ec2 instance with the role
attached to it we said rules are assumed
by any entity right it would be user it
could be an application it could be a
service it could be another resource in
AWS account so here it's another
resource in AWS account right so we
create a role and we attach it to an ec2
instance so now the ec2 instance can
assume the role now the same role can be
attached to another ec2 instance the
same role can be attached to another
user the same role can be attached to
another database service we get the idea
right roles can be assumed by anyone so
when the ec2 instance wants to
communicate with S3 it contacts the role
and then the role gives this ec2
instance some temporary username and
password that expires after one hour
let's say so it's a temporary username
and password now with that temporary
username and password the ec2 instance
can access the S3 bucket and access the
file with the credential that it already
has and that credential is a temporary
one and the credential will expire after
one hour or how much of a Time the admin
sets it to be and then the next time
when is when an ec2 instance wants to
contact S3 it will have to contact the
role and the role will propose a new
access key and secret access key in
other words a new credential with that
new credential the second time the ec2
instance will be able to contact the S3
bucket and get the information so the
password is not a permanent or a
one-time or a hard-coded password it
keeps rotating it's a token it's a
secure token that an ec2 instance or any
application that uses the role gets to
access the resources on the other end so
let's talk about the features of IM the
main feature of IM is that I can create
separate username and password for
individual users or resources and I can
delegate access now those days where we
had just one username and password for
admin and we need to call the other
person to get the username and password
over the phone uh if it gets compromised
you know the whole account gets
compromised stuff like that those issues
are gone I can create separate username
and password for all thousand users in
my account no more username and password
sharing I can manage access to all those
thousand accounts in a very simple and
an easy way so IM provides share access
for all the Thousand users in my account
it provides share access to the AWS
environment and the permissions that can
be given through IM are very granular
now we saw how restrictions can be put
on get request you know we can allow a
user to download information and not
update an information so that's possible
through the IM policies that we looked
at some time back and with the use of
roles you know we're authenticating an
ec2 instance answer of the application
running on top of it so if there are
like 10 or 20 application is running on
top of an ec2 instance instead of
creating a separate username and
password for all those 20 instances I
can create a role and assign that role
to the ec2 instance and all the
applications running on the ec2 instance
get a secure access to the other
resources use the role credential that's
provided to that ec2 instance now
besides username and password IM also
supports multi-factor authentication
where we provide a credential the
username and password plus and OTP from
our phone or an randomly generated
number that gets displayed in our phone
before Amazon console or before Amazon
CLI would authenticate and lets us
access some of the service in the
account so it's called multi-factor
authentication it's username and
password plus something else from what
you have I am also provides identity
Federation if a user is already
authenticated with account corporate ad
or Facebook or Google you know IM can be
made to trust that authentication method
and then allow access based on that
authentication now without Federation
what would happen is the users will have
to remember two passwords you know one
for on-premises and one for cloud
anytime they work on on premises they'll
have to use one set of password and
anytime they switch to the cloud which
is going to be very frequent in uh every
day so anytime they switch to the cloud
they will have to again type in the
cloud username and password now with
identity Federation we can sort of
Federate or we can connect both the
authentication systems both on-premises
and Im so users can just use one
username and password for both
on-premises and Cloud environments and
all that we saw so far it's free to use
there's no additional charge for IM
security there is no additional charge
for creating additional users groups or
policies it's a free service comes along
with any account IMS and PCI DSS
compliant product now IM comes with
password policy where we can reset the
password remotely or rotate the
passwords remotely and we can set rules
like and how a user should pick an
password it should not be the one that
was used in the past any of the past
three times stuff like that so you get
the idea right how the features of IM
help us to build and secure
authentication and authorization system
in or for our AWS account all right it's
time to do a quick slab let's let's put
all the knowledge that we have earned so
far together and apply it and try a lab
and solve the problem so here is a
problem statement we need to create an
S3 bucket for a company where users can
read or write the data only if they are
multi-factor authenticated so there
could be like 20 users in an account but
a user is allowed to read or write a
data in an S3 bucket only if the user is
multi-factor authenticated now this is a
very good use case if we have a
sensitive data in an S3 bucket and you
only want privileged or MFA
authenticated users to do changes to
those buckets and for those privileged
users you would enable multi-factor
authentication so let's see how that's
done before that let me talk to you a
bit more about multi-factor
authentication a multi-factor
authentication is an additional level of
security process it's provided by AWS
here the user's identity is confirmed
only after the user proposes or the user
passes two level of verification now one
being the username and password and
another being an OTP that gets generated
in this case it's the mobile phone it
could also be an RSA token key that
generates the one-time password that's
possible as well but in this case it's
the mobile phone now that's going to be
very similar to how we login to our
Gmail account sometimes when we log into
a Gmail account and I mean if you have
the proper setting enabled it's going to
send an one-time password to mobile
phone and only after we put that
information it's going to let us log in
let's see how all this is done in an AWS
account so the first thing is to log in
to the AWS account create a user and
attach the user to the virtual MFA
device now we're going to use Google
Authenticator here and we're going to
attach the user to Google Authenticator
and make the user use the Google
Authenticator one-time password every
time he logs in to the account now this
is an addition to the username and
password that he or she already has
right so the first thing is to log into
the account connect or sync the virtual
Appliance with the AWS username and
password now when we sync there will be
an one-time password that gets shown in
the phone type in the password in the
AWS console and then the phone and the
username comes to sync and from that
point onwards the user anytime they log
in they will have to propose their
username and password which is the first
step of security and then once they
typed in the username and password type
in the MFA code that gets generated on
the phone that would be the second step
of security or the last step of security
once that is done the account is going
to let them log in and access the AWS
resources all right so in order to test
IM MFA S3 together this is what we're
gonna do so we're gonna create a bucket
and we're gonna have two users and we're
gonna allow or deny access to the S3
bucket to those two users based on
whether they are MFA authenticated or
not and on purpose we're going to assign
MFA to one user and no MFA to the other
user like you might have guessed by now
the user with MFA will have access to
the bucket and the user with no MFA
attached will not have access to the
bucket both of them are going to have
full S3 services but MFA like I said is
one layer above the other permissions
MFA stands at all time so irrespective
of whether the underlying policy says
but they have full access to the S3
bucket they are not going to because MFA
stands on top of it let's see how that's
done to begin with firstly we need a
bucket so let's create a bucket
so I'm in my AWS console so let me go to
S3
and in here create a bucket call that
bucket as simply learn MFA bucket and
let me put it in North Virginia and
create
all right so that's done
now I'm going to put a separate folder
in here
I'm going to create another folder in
here and the name of the folder is tax
documents now this is where I'm planning
to keep my tax files
and I only want my privileged users to
be able to upload and download
information from the tax document so on
the bucket side it's partially done or
on the S3 side it's partially done so
let's go back to IM and here we're going
to create two users one a junior
employee and another one and a senior
employee the senior employee is the one
who's going to have MFA access and more
access to the S3 bucket and the junior
employee is the one who's not going to
have access to that particular bucket so
let's get started let's create an user
under IM
click on users and let's create a user
called as user
Junior
right so he's a junior user
and for the password
set a password
the user does not need to create a new
password at sign in because it's a test
environment and the user who creates the
username and the user are the same
person so let's keep it simple username
password Management console access
and this user is going to have full S3
bucket access all right this is really
the policy
we should be familiar with this Json
document by now it says effect is
allowed and what action any action in S3
and what resource anybody who's attached
to it review
and create a user
so this user is having S3 full access
now let's create another user call them
as a senior employee
all right attach
a policy to the user
you know from the surface level both of
them have the same permissions both of
them have S3 full access
all right so both of them have S3 full
access as we see
there's one thing different we're going
to do to this senior employee now we're
going to attach MFA to this employee so
the way we would do it is under the
summary section of that particular user
click on security credential and see
here is a place we can attach an MFA to
this user so let's attach MFA to this
user for MFA I can use both virtual MFA
or Hardware MFA this being in lab
environment we're going to use Virtual
MFA now that is an application there are
a lot of applications available but
there is one application that I'm using
at the moment called Google
Authenticator
so once we have installed the
application and once it is running
so I can go to Virtual MFA device and
once it is running I can scan the code
using the Google Authenticator in my
mobile phone once you turn on the
application and once you do scan the
barcode that is showing right here now
that's going to give us codes that we
can use and we will have to put in those
codes here twice we'll have to wait for
some time and it would generate a second
set of key that we can put so my first
set of key is
402351 right I'll have to wait for some
time and then it would throw me a second
set of key it's like validating twice
right here so let me put in my second
set of key
so this user is now MFA authenticated
user so anytime this user logs in it's
going to ask for MFA anytime this user
proposes something it's going to attach
the MFA key along with it all right so
we're done with the IM what have you
done with IM we have created two users
both of them have s34 access but one of
them have MFA access and the other one
does not have MFA access and based on
whether the user is having MFA or not
you know we're identifying privileged
users by this MFA right so based on
whether the user has MFA or not are we
going to allow deny access in the S3
bucket
so we already have a bucket we already
have a folder and this is a very
privileged folder path here I would like
to restrict access based on whether the
user is having MFA or not
so let me create a bucket policy here
now here's a policy that I have written
the policy says that you know under tax
document folder give access only if the
user is MFA authenticated right if the
user is not MFA authenticated simply
deny the access to that user so as you
might guess right now the user 1 will
not have access or the junior employee
will not have access because it's a
privilege and you know Junior employee
might tend to delete them unknowingly
and only privileged users get access to
the tax document because it's
confidential because it's privileged
because if it gets deleted we won't be
able to get it back for those reasons
right so apply the bucket policy
now try logging in as
the different users and see how the
permissions are applied on both the
users all right so let's make a note of
the IM URL
and then the two usernames and password
let's login
so let me log in as the privileged user
sure enough I'm being asked for an MFA
code let me put my MFA code
so let's directly navigate to the S3
bucket
right here's my privileged path let me
try uploading some content
claim forms
sure enough I'm able to upload content
into it will I be able to delete
yes I'm able to delete as well now let's
see what's the situation for the other
user
so let's login as the other user
navigate to the SC bucket
if you noticed when logging in it did
not ask for an MFA code because the user
is not set up for MFA
so navigate to the folder which we want
to test
now try adding some files
as you see it's failing to add content
to this bucket it shows error because
the bucket policy is requiring MFA and
this user is not MFA and we did that in
IEM or under iam
but still as you see you know they will
be able to view the content in the
bucket they can do all that we have
specifically restricted access to upload
and download content from the bucket and
that's exactly this user is now denied
with
in this section we're going to learn
about why we need a solution called
cloud formation or why we need a product
called cloud formation and we're going
to talk in detail about what is cloud
formation and then how cloud formation
works and the concepts involved in cloud
formation like I know templates and
stacks there are some Concepts involved
in cloud formation we're going to talk
about that and how do we maintain access
control over cloud formation we're going
to talk about that as well in this video
and then we're going to go through a
demo or a lab where we create an lamp
stack environment from a template
through cloud formation and then we're
going to talk about some use cases one
of which include being able to create
and redeployable template using cloud
formation that's a very good use case
we're going to talk about that in this
video so let's talk about why cloud
formation so when the number of products
and services grow more and managing them
and maintaining them becomes an tedious
work and cloud formation it's sort of
eases that environment now cloud
formation is really an infrastructure as
the code and it sort of solves all the
problem that we discussed some time back
and with cloud formation we can actually
create a perfect clone of the server
configuration at any point in time and
we can also manage the configuration
changes and configuration changes with
cloud formation we can manage the
configuration changes across the
environment and not only that we can
easily embed in the ad hoc changes to
our existing environment so one might
ask why use cloud formation let's look
at the current problem that we have
creating and managing multiple AWS
resource in the portal is a big task
especially when you need to replace some
Services it becomes an bigger task now
cloud formation eases that word let me
explain it in detail now at the moment
without the cloud formation or
environments that don't use cloud
formation have this problem that is a
lot of of time is being spent on
building the infrastructure and less
focus and less time at the moment is
being given on developing that
application that runs on that
environment that's because majority of
the time is consumed by building the
environment and if we need to redeploy
the same environment again and again the
same happens in a cycle again in a new
environment we start from the scratch
build environment and then put
application on top of it now that can be
avoided using cloud formation now
without cloud formation still is a
problem because the the resource or the
bandwidth that is needed for the
application development is not provided
because that's taken by developing the
infrastructure and to solve that problem
we can use cloud formation now that
leads to a discussion about what is
cloud formation so let's talk about or
let's try understanding what cloud
formation is cloud formation is a
service that provides users a simple way
to create and manage collection of AWS
Resources by provisioning and updating
them and then very orderly and in a
predictable way if I need to expand the
explanation of cloud formation cloud
formation is an server that really helps
us to model and set up our Amazon web
services or resources so we can spend
less time on managing the resources and
show more focus on the application that
runs on top of it we can simply create a
template for an easy to do instance or
for an RDS instance and upload it in the
cloud formation portal and cloud
formation will provision and configure
those resources based on the template
that we Define we really don't have to
sort out the complexities in dependency
between those applications once the
template is vetted and validated cloud
formation takes the responsibility of
handling the dependencies between the
application in an orderly and a
predictable way it creates those
services and makes it available for us
once the template is fully run so in
short the cloud formation it allows us
to create and model our infrastructure
and applications without we having to
perform the manual action for example
the well-known company called Expedia is
able to easily manage and run its entire
front and back-end resources they run on
AWS in cloudfront what does that mean
they are spending less time on managing
infrastructure and More Time On The Core
Business and application that runs on
top of it and we're still talking about
what cloud formation is with cloud
formation it enables us to manage our
complete infrastructure or AWS resource
in a text file now we're going to see
that in a moment you know it's either a
Json or an yaml file and that file is
called as the template to begin with the
resources the template provision is
called the stack all right so the
abstract of the code is called the
template and the resource that it
Provisions is called the stack and this
stack can be I mean it's going to run
resources obviously and those results
sources can be updated as well it's not
like one secret stack gets done if you
need a change you need to go create
another resource that's not needed this
stack is an updatable stack let's say if
I'm including two more servers if I'm
sort of extending my environment it's
branching out to another application now
I'm including another functionality in
my environment all those can be emboded
in the update and can be updated so like
I said the stack is an updatable one now
let's talk about what the template can
do or some features and functionality of
the template Now using a template we can
almost include all the application and
resources that a user might require
let's say you know after the ec2
instance is provision running an
application on top of it and you want to
templatize that and include that in the
template that's possible as well and
these templates are portable ones
meaning I can use the template in one
region and I can use the same template
in another region and that's going to
build a very similar envelope government
in another region I can also share that
with the customer and when they run it
it's going to run an environment from
the portable template in their account
in their environment of course all the
security is taken care I'm just saying
that if we need to build a resource if
you need to build an architecture if you
need to build an environment which looks
very similar to the other environment
that is possible and and these templates
are usable by the use of some sections
in the template like the parameter
section the mapping section the
condition section within the template is
what makes the templates reusable and we
will talk about parameters mapping and
conditions down the line we're still
talking about AWS how AWS cloud
formation works and we're going to talk
about how a template becomes an
infrastructure right so to begin with
one request template and the template
will be in Json or yml format so one
would develop a template based on the
requirement based on number of ec2
instances based on whether want a load
balancer based on what they want and a
Windows Server based on whether they
want an database server in that
environment and then based on the
applications that will be running on top
of it that can be templatized in the
code itself so one creates a code and
then the code is saved locally or they
can be put in an S3 Bucket from which
the cloud formation will call the
template and provision the resource
right so we use cloud formation to
create a stack or create the resource
defined in the template and cloud
formation analyzes the template first
validates template and then it
identifies the dependencies between them
and then it starts provisioning the
resource one after the other for example
if you need five servers in a new VPC
obviously it's going to create the VPC
first and servers second and stack all
right let's understand the two major
components in cloud formation by now you
might have guessed it the two major
component events are the template and
the stack together the aid or they
complement cloud formation and that's
how the resource of provision that's how
the resources are managed and that eases
the job of the administrator who's
managing the environment so let's talk
about template first a template in cloud
formation is an text file or a formatted
text file in Json or yaml language and
that the code or the template or the
text file that actually describes how
your infrastructure looks like or will
look like one's provision and for us to
create the template or for us to you
know modify an existing template we can
use a tool available called cloud
formation designer from the console or
any text editing tool that's available
but I would recommend the cloud
formation designer though that has a
rich Graphics in it and these templates
are built off or they consist of nine
main objects the first of which is the
format version and this really
identifies the capabilities of the
template based on the version number and
then the second object in a template
would be description and this helps us
to include any arbitrary comments about
the template for what reason are we
building this template what's the
purpose of it stuff like that and then
we have the object called metadata in a
template and that includes a details
about the template details of the
resources in the template and then we
have the optional parameters section
this really helps us to customize our
template now parameters enable us to
input custom values to our template each
time we create or update and stack and
the mapping object it helps us to match
a key to a corresponding set of named
values for example if you want to set a
value based on region then we get to
create a mapping that uses region name
as the key and then the value that we
want to specify for for each specific
regions and then we have conditions
object this is again an optional object
with this we can include statements that
Define when a resource is created or
when a property is defined for example
we can compare whether a value is equal
to another value and based on the result
of that condition we can conditionally
create additional resources and then the
object called transform it's it's an
optional object as well and this
transform section specifies one or more
transforms that we can use in our cloud
formation template for example errorless
cloud formation transforms helps
simplify template authoring by
condensing the expression of the AWS
infrastructure as a code or the cloud
formation template and it enables reuse
of template components for example we
can condense multiple line resources
declaring it into a single line in our
template it now we will talk about all
these examples in the upcoming slides
and then we have the required section
called resource that declares the AWS
resource that you want to include in the
stack for example if you want to include
an ec2 instance if you want to include
an S3 bucket we would be using the
resource object in our stack and then we
have object called output this output
object it's an optional object in the
template and it helps us to sort of
declare the outputs that we can import
into other Stacks or we can actually
show it on the cloud formation console
for example if you want the output of
the or the name of the S3 bucket that
got created in response to a cloud
formation template now we can have that
outputted into an output section in the
cloud formation console itself so it's
sort of easy for us to identify the
resources that the template provisioned
so with all of those objects put
together other this is how a full-blown
cloud formation template with all the
objects included is going to look like
now this includes optional and mandatory
object let's talk about those objects in
detail in the upcoming section all right
let's now discuss each and every object
of this template structure and let's
begin our discussion with the format
version The Format version it really
defines the capabilities of the template
the latest version format version as of
now is the one that was updated on 2010.
now the value of the template format
version it has to be an string and if we
really don't specify the format version
cloud formation automatically assumes
the latest version talking about
description descriptions are really any
comments that help ourselves that we
want to embed in the template itself
that can be a description and this
description in a template it has to be
an string the length of the string can
be between 0 to 124 bytes in length the
metadatars are really used in the
template to provide any additional
information using the Json and yaml
objects and metadata holds the
implementation details of a specific
resource and parameters are really a way
to customize the template each time we
create or update our stack these
parameters are the ones that helps us to
give some custom value to the template
during runtime in the example shown
below at the parameter named the
instance type parameter it lets us to
specify the ec2 instance type for the
stacks to use when creating or updating
the stack by default as we see it's
picking T2 micro and this is the value
that will get picked if we don't
provision another value to it and
mapping mapping really enables us to map
a key to a corresponding named value
that we specify in a conditional
parameter and also we can retrieve the
map or try the value values in the map
using the function find in map in strict
function let's take this example let's
say based on a region if you want to set
values in a template we can create a
mapping that uses a key and holds the
value that you want to specify for each
region and the object conditions can be
used when we want to reuse the templates
by creating resources in a totally
different context for example in a
template during stack creation all the
conditions that we mentioned in the
template are evaluated and any resources
that are associated and that come up to
be true are created and any condition
that fails or invalid are kind of
ignored automatically and the check
moves forward to the next condition and
conditional is an optional object and it
includes statement that Define when a
resource is created or when a property
is actually defined for example you can
create whether for example you can
compare with that a value is equal to
another value and based on the result of
that condition we can conditionally
create resources if you have multiple
conditions then they are generally
separated with commas sometimes
conditions are very helpful when we want
to create templates and we want to reuse
those templates which was created for
one environment to another environment
for example if you want to use a
template that was created in a test
environment in a Dev environment
conditions would be helpful for example
in a production environment we might
want to include instances with certain
capabilities and in a test environment
we might want to include instances with
some reduced capability in them for
saving money and condition helps us to
sort of create resources based on the
environment it will be used in we can
also use intrinsic functions to Define
conditions like equals we can also use
our conditions we can use not functions
intrinsic functions in a condition and
when put together the syntax is going to
look like the one that you see on the
screen now the optional object called
transform it specifies one or more
transforms that the cloud formation uses
to process our template now these
transform sections are built on a simple
declarative language of AWS cloud
formation with a powerful macro system
that helps us to reuse the templates or
the template components and they really
help us to condense or simplify our
codes by enabling reuse of the template
components for example condense a
multiple line resource declaration into
a single line in our template the
resource section it really declares the
AWS resource that you want to include in
this stack such as ec2 instance such as
S3 bucket and some of the resource
fields are The Logical ID the resource
type and the properties let's talk about
them in brief The Logical ID is unique
within the template and The Logical ID
name it actually reference the resource
in other parts of the template in this
case it's my bucket for example I know
if we want to map an elastic Block store
volume or if you want to map an uh name
of the bucket in another place in the
template not then we would use the
logical ID and again in this case it is
my bucket a logical name has the
physical ID with which we actually
assign the resource for example in this
case my S3 bucket was named as my bucket
to begin with and the resource type in
the template it identifies the type of
the resource is an S3 bucket and the
properties are the additional optional
information that we can specify to our
resource for example if it is an ec2
instance let's say we would like to know
which Ami it used then property section
really defines the Ami that was used or
Ami as the property of the instance so
this section describes the output value
that needs to be imported to other
Stacks or the output value that needs to
be shown in the console for the user to
easily navigate to the resource that are
being created for example for a S3
bucket name we can declare an output and
once the bucket is created we can
actually declare the output and sort of
import the name of the bucket in a
different place in the console so it's
it's easy to view instead of you know
the user getting confused and going to
S3 and searching for the bucket name
this can be made available in the cloud
formation console itself and the output
Fields it can include some of these
followings like The Logical ID it's
actually the identifier of the current
output and it's very unique within the
template and it can also include a
description description is really a
string type that describes the output
value and it can also include value and
value is the property that was returned
by the AWS cloud formation described
Stacks command all right let's talk
about the template resource attribute in
this section we're going to talk about
attributes that you can add to a
resource to control additional behavior
and relationships so let's talk there
are many resource attributes available
out of which we have I mean if we need
to name them we have a creation policy
and then we have deletion policy it
depends on metadata attribute update
policy attribute let's talk about each
of them separately when we associate the
create policy attribute with the
resource it actually delays the resource
configuration actions before proceeding
with the stack creation I mean the
attribute stack creation is delayed till
the time the cloud formation receives
some number of success signals back I
mean this is a very good use case when
we do auto scaling and this creation
policy can be used only with a limited
number of services like Auto scaling and
ec2 instances
some of the use cases would be if you
want to install and software application
on an ec2 instance you might want the
applications to be running before it
proceeds further so in this case we
would use the creation policy attribute
to the instance and then send the
success signal after the applications
are installed and configured then cloud
formation goes to the next step here in
the syntax that we're looking at the
auto scaling creation policy and the
minimum successful instance percentage
it's actually a number of signals that
it will have to reply back before it can
move forward using deletion policy it
preserves backing up of resources when
the stack is getting deleted and by
default if we don't have a delete policy
the data gets deleted just like that but
if we use an deletion policy we would be
able to preserve the data by taking a
snapshot of it or just letting the
resource and moving on with deleting the
other resources in the stack and we
specify the delete policy attribute for
each resource specifically that we want
to control and if there are no deletion
policy mentioned for a particular
resource the cloud formation simply
deletes the resources as that's its
default behavior and if you want to keep
the resource when the stack is deleted
we use we we mention V10 in the delete
policy and that simply retains the
resource from getting deleted so in this
example we're actually retaining an
dynamodb table rest of the resources in
the stack will get deleted and using the
depends on attribute we actually create
an order in which the resource gets
deleted for example if I map one
resource to another resource and say
that this resource depends on the other
resource the other resource gets created
first Then followed by this instance or
this resource so with the difference on
attribute we can specify that the
creation of specific resource is
actually followed by and another when we
add that depends on attribute towards
Source the resources created only after
the creation of the resource specified
by the depends on attribute let's take
this example in this example we're
saying that the resource X depends on
why we've said that X depends on y so in
this case when cloud formation is
executing it's going to deploy y first
because it has some resources that
depends on it so it's going to create y
first and then it's going to create the
resource called X on the same context
let's say in the template we say that an
ec2 is going to depend on S3 and when
the cloud formation is executing it's
going to create an S3 bucket first and
then the ec2 instant that's probably
because the codes needed for the ec2
instance are stored in the S3 bucket and
and what we're looking at is the syntax
of how that depends on template resource
attribute will look like this is how it
actually will look like when we put it
in the cloud formation the instance
depends on the markets the other
template research attribute is metadata
metadatars are the one that really helps
us to associate our Resources with the
the structured data and by including
this attribute in our template or by
including this attribute to a resource
we can specify the data in Json or in
yaml language for example in this
section of the template we're creating a
VPC and the metadata explains our
metadata defines that the VPC is part of
the region U.S east one and the update
policy template resource attribute and
cloud formation we can manage and
replace the updates of the instance in
an auto scaling room for example you're
looking at this sample where it says
that the update policy will it replace
the instance in an auto scaling group or
not so depending on what the value is
for the will replace section whether
it's true or false depending on that at
the update policy will replace the
instance or will replace the auto
scaling group itself when it's doing
enrolling deployment now that we've
discussed about templates let's talk
about AWS Stacks as well now we know
that AWS Stacks are the actual resources
that gets generated or that gets created
because we ran a template right so stack
is a collection of AWS results that we
can manage in a single unit in other
words you know we can create a stack
update a stack or delete a stack and
that would actually create update delete
the collection of resources within the
stack and all the resources in the stack
are really defined by the cloud
formation template and a stack for
instance can include all the resources
required to run a web application such
as a web server a database server and
some networking rules that come along
with it all that gets embedded in a
stack and let's say if we want to delete
all the resources that were created by
template that is in a separate stack we
can simply delete the stack and that
would sort of delete all the resources
that is in the stack so it sort of helps
us to manage all the resources in a
single unit or as a single unit so to
summarize stack is a collection of AWS
resource and it can be managed as a
single unit and the cloud formations
template defines a stack in which the
resource can be created deleted or
updated in a very predictable way and a
stack can have all the resources like
web server database server VPC the
network and the security configurations
in a VPC all that is required to run a
web or a database application now stack
could be nested as well with cloud
formation we can actually Nest a stack
with another stack and that's going to
create an hierarchy of the stacks for
example I mean this is a very good
picture that explains how the stacks are
nested and hierarchical way let's say
stack p is the root stack and that could
would be apparent stack for the stack
called R and the stack all Cube and the
same way the the stack call R is a
parent stack for the stack s and that
the stack s is the Varan stack for D and
Q you get that right so Stacks can
always be nested it's possible plot
formation allows us to create a
Microsoft Windows stack based on Amazon
ec2 Windows Amis and provide us with the
ability to install software and use a
remote desktop to access our stack and
update the configuration of our stack
and these Stacks can be run on Windows
Server instances there are a number of
pre-configured templates available and
it's directly available to use from the
AWS website itself to name a few we have
templates available for SharePoint
running on an Windows Server 2008 R2 we
also have templates that create a single
server installation of active directory
running on a Windows server and in fact
we have templates available for elastic
Beanstalk and some sample applications
that runs from an Windows Server 2008 R2
let's talk about stack sets Stacks sets
actually has taken the attack level
implementation to the next level using
AWS cloud formation template we can
define a stack set that lets us to
create stack in AWS account across the
globe by using just a single template
and after we create the stack or after
the stack set is defined creating
updating or deleting the stack in the
Target account and the regions can also
be specified by us so the stack said it
really extends the functionality of the
stacks by allowing us to create update
and delete stack across multiple
accounts regions in just a single
operation and using an administrator
account we can Define and manage an AWS
cloud formation template and use the
template as the basis for provisioning
Stacks into you know some selected
Target accounts across a specified
region let's talk about cloud formation
access control with IAM I can specify
the list of users or list of privileged
users who would have access to the cloud
formation template who can create update
and delete Stacks so that's how IIM
helps me with having or putting a layer
of control over the cloud formation
service and we can also use service
roles service roles are the one that
allows AWS cloud formation to make a
call to a resource in a stack on the
user's behalf and I can also have stack
policies and these stack policies are
applied to the users who already have
access to the cloud formation service
and these policies are the ones that
help the users who attempt to update the
stack all right let's do a quick lab on
creating and lamp stack on an ec2
instance with a local mySQL database for
storage now we can do the other way as
well I can pick an ec2 instance and
install the servers one top of the other
and that can be done as well but that's
going to take a lot of time now we're
talking about automating it we're
talking about you know provisioning and
infrastructure using a code and platform
machine helps us to do that so this is
what we're going to do we're going to
create or we have in cloud formation
template already and we're going to use
that template the provision web instance
and that is going to have look at that
that's going to have MySQL installed in
it that's going to have PHP that's going
to have httpd service installed in it
and running and it's also going to have
an a PHP website running from it so
that's going to receive information from
the website and that's going to store
that information in the database that's
very local to it
this is the template that defines that
environment
all right this is a very simple
provisioning so let's provision this
environment let's create a stack
we're going to give a stack name
and a database password
right and which region is it this is in
California is that
all right
now let me do one thing let me switch to
the Mumbai region or let me switch to
North Virginia region
Al from here actually let me switch to
Mumbai region
all right just to be sure it's the same
template that we're provisioning
right that's the same template that we
are provisioning
all right let's give this uh name so it
can be great this could be simply learn
simply learn lamb stack and what could
be the DB password
and DB root password
and what could be the DB user
I'm going to keep the rest as defaults
and I'm going to launch
all right so there's an issue with the
password
[Music]
password should only have Alpha numeric
characters okay that
so let's go back and create a new
password
right it also needs to have eight
characters
so what can be your password
well look at that the template is
actually creating the resources
and here in the screen we can see the
template that we used to deploy the
environment
if you remember we have we discussed
about instant types in parameters right
the default instance type is T2 small
but these are also allowed
to run
all right parameter section is the one
that was used to receive information
from us like the DB name
the DB password the DB root password DB
user instance type key name and the SSH
locations
all right now this resource section is
is showing us the resource that it
actually created
right looks like it's rolling back why
would that be give me a moment
[Music]
all right this is one live example
anytime it could not provision or any if
there is an interruption that it cannot
proceed it would simply roll back and
delete all the resources that it had
provision and that's what it did
now let me fix this
oh it adds a fix I have switched the
regen because I had some issue with the
VPC that's going to take time for me to
analyze and fix it so here we're going
to understand
about cloud formation so I thought I'll
run the cloud formation from another VPC
that I know is working fine that's not
Virginia
all right let's provision this lamp
server which is running out of Linux
which has Apache installed on it which
has PHP and MySQL already installed in
it so one server gonna act as web and DB
server
all right so I'm going to create a stack
and from here I'm going to pick a sample
stack now if we look at if you look at
it in the designer
it's going to provision one lamp server
and a security at that Security Group
attached to it there you go right so
let's go ahead and create a stack
all right
parameters are used to receive
input from us what could be the DB
password
and the DB user
and
let's select the key name
but I'm going to keep the rest as
defaults and I'm going to create
a stack
all right so our stack
that we run from the template
at the moment it's getting created it's
in progress
from here I can watch the events as to
what is getting created at the moment
like I said in a lot of these would have
already sorted out their dependencies
you know which one needs to get created
first which one needs to get created
second all that is sorted out by cloud
formation itself
and parameters are the values that we
have inputted and resource
tab is a section where we can find what
resources are being provisioned at the
moment so to begin with it created a
security group at the moment it's
creating an instance and output uh it's
empty as of now we're going to come back
and see it now output is where we can
get outputs of a finished job let's say
here I wanted an URL
of the server that got created so
instead of me uh you know going to a
couple of other places within the
console and find the output of the URL
or the the output of the resource that
was created I can simply get it from
here well this needs to be defined in
the templates First Once We Define it in
the template it's going to be made
available
like here
right so I can open it up
and there you go so it has it already
has
a database locally installed and it's
connected over if I launch an
application on top of it that will get
connected to the database which is very
local and my single
server with web and database in it is
ready for production
now while we're talking about a lamp
server a single lamp server let's talk
about
uh creating an environment like this
which has elastic load balancer a VPC uh
server running in an auto scaling group
and putting some restrictions that
nobody will be able to access the ECU
instance directly but they should be
able to access the ec2 instance or the
data only through the elastic load
balancer this is a bit complicated than
the environment that we've already
created let's see how this is done all
right in this lab we're going to create
elastic load balance to Auto scaling
Group which is going to create a load
balancer and an auto scaling group and
that auto scaling group receives traffic
only from the load balancer so here's
the template
and here's the architecture that we're
going to provision
let me call it all right and the key
pair it's going to use is uh simply loan
keypair
now this is where the problem was now we
were selecting few subnets
so now if I provision it
now this is going to take its short time
to provision the resources
so through parameters we can see the
values that we have inputted
and the events look good no roll back no
no delete and the resource section shows
the resource that it is creating so
previously created a Target group now
it's creating the application load
balancer itself
all right so it created and uh
load balancer and then it create a
security group it created a launch
configuration it at the moment it's
creating a web server group
and the events look good with all green
and yellow green ones are completed
yellow ones are in progress we don't
have any red delete or roll back errors
so it looks good all right it took a
while and
the resources have been created some of
them show that they are in progress but
the status of the stack is complete
all resources have been created and we
do have an output to access the URL
there you go
[Music]
and remember there was another feature
of the cloud formation that was it
should restrict access I mean direct
access to ec2 instance let's see if that
has been done
if I try to access using the load
balancer it lets me access but if I try
to access it using
the ec2 instance IP or the DNS name my
connection won't go through because it's
blocked through the security group but
direct access through the load balancer
is allowed and that's what we wanted to
achieve through that template here we're
going to talk about Amazon ECS a service
that's used to manage Docker containers
so without any further Ado let's get
started in this session we would like to
talk about some Basics about AWS and
then we're going to immediately dive
into why Amazon ECS and what is Amazon
ECS in general and then it uses a
service called Docker so we're going to
understand what Docker is and there are
competitive services available for ECS I
mean you could ECS is not the on and
only service to manage Docker containers
but why ECS advantage of ECS we will
talk about that and the architecture of
ECS so how it functions what are the
components present in it and what are
the function functions that it does I
mean each and every component what are
all the functions that it does all those
things will be discussed in the
architecture of Amazon ECS and how it
works how it all connects together
that's something we will discuss and
what are the companies that are using
ECS what were the challenge and how ECS
helped to fix the challenge that's
something we will discuss and finally we
have a wonderful lab that talks about
how to deploy Docker containers on an
Amazon ECS so let's talk about what is
AWS Amazon web service in short call as
AWS is an web service in the cloud that
provides a variety of services such as
compute power database storage content
delivery and a lot of other resources so
you can scale your business and grow not
focus more on your ID needs and the rest
of the ID demands rather you can focus
on your business and let Amazon scale
your it or let Amazon take care of your
it so what is that you can do with AWS
with AWS we can create deploy any
application in the cloud so it's not
just deploying you can also create your
application in the cloud it has all the
tools and services required the tools
and services that you would have
installed in your laptop or you would
have installed in your on-premises
desktop machine for your development
environment you know the same thing can
be installed and used from the cloud so
you can use cloud for creating and not
only that you can use the same Cloud for
deploying and making your application
available for your end user the end user
could be internal internal users the end
user could be the could be in the
internet the end user could be kind of
spread all around the world it doesn't
matter so it can be used to create and
deploy your applications in the cloud
and like you might have guessed now it
provides service over the Internet
that's how your users worldwide would be
able to use the service that you create
and deploy right so it provides service
over the Internet so that's for the End
customer and how will you access those
Services that's again through the
internet it's like the extension of your
data center in the internet so it
provides all the services in the
internet it provides compute service
through the internet so in other words
you access them through the internet it
provides database service through the
internet over the internet in other
words you can securely access your
database through the internet and lot
more and the best part is this is a pay
as you go or pay only for what you use
there is no long term or you know
beforehand commitment here most of the
services does not have any commitment so
there is no long term and beforehand
commitment you only pay exactly for what
you use there's no overage there's no
overpaying right there's no buying in
advance right you only pay for what you
use let's talk about what ECS is so
before ECS before containers right ECS
is a service that manages Docker
containers right it's not a product or
it's not a feature all by itself it's a
service that's dependent on Docker
container so before Docker containers
all the applications were running on VM
or on an host or on a physical machine
right and that's memory bound that's
latency bound the server might have
issues on and on right so let's say this
is Alice and she's trying to access her
application which is running somewhere
in her on-premises and the application
isn't working what could be the reason
some of the reasons could be Memory full
the server is currently down at the
moment we don't have another physical
server to launch the application a lot
of other reasons so a lot of reasons why
the application wouldn't be working in
on-premises some of them are Memory full
issue and server down issue very less a
high availability or in fact single
point of failure and no high
availability if I if I need to tell it
correctly with ECS the services can kind
of breathe free right the services can
run seamlessly now how how is that
possible now those thing we will discuss
in the upcoming sessions so because of
containers and easiest managing
containers the applications can run in a
high available mode they can run in a
high available mode meaning if something
goes wrong right there's another
container that gets spun up and your
application runs in that particular
container very less chances of your
application going down that's what I
mean this is not possible with a
physical Host this is very less possible
with an VM or at least it's going to
take some time for another VM to get
spun up so why ECS or what is ECS Amazon
ECS maintains the availability of the
application and allows every user to
scale containers when necessary so it
not only meets the availability of the
application meaning one container
running your application or one
container hosting your application
should be running all the time so to
meet that high availability availability
is making sure your service is running
24 7. so Container makes sure that your
services run 24 bar 7 not only that not
only that suddenly if there is an
increase in demand how do you meet that
Demand right let's say you have like
1000 users suddenly the next week there
are like 2000 users all right so how do
you meet that demand Container makes it
very easy for you to meet that demand in
case of VM or in case of physical host
you literally have to go buy another
physical host or you know add more RAM
add more memory add more CPU power to it
all right or kind of Club two three
hosts together clustering you would be
doing a lot of other things to meet that
high availability and also to meet that
demand but in case of ECS it
automatically scales the number of
containers it automatically scales the
number of containers needed and it meets
your demand for that particular R so
what is Amazon ECS the full form of ECS
is elastic container service right so
it's basically a container Management
Service which can quickly launch and
exit and manage Docker containers on a
cluster so what's the function of ECS it
helps us to quickly launch and quickly
exit and manage Docker container so it's
kind of a Management Service for the
docker containers you will be running in
Amazon or running in the AWS environment
so in addition to that it helps to
schedule the placement of container
across your cluster so it's like this
you have two physical hosts you know
joined together as a cluster and ECS
helps us to place your containers now
where should your container be placed
should it be placed in host one should
it be placed in host too so that logic
is defined in ECS we can Define it you
can also let ECS take control and Define
that logic most cases you will be
defining it so schedule the placement of
containers across your cluster let's say
two containers want to interact heavily
you really don't want to place them in
two different hosts all right you would
want to place them in one single host so
they can interact with each other so
that logic is defined by us and these
container services you can launch
containers using AWS Management console
and also so you can launch containers
using SDK kids available from Amazon you
can launch through a Java program you
can launch container using an.net
program you can launch container using
an node.js program as in when the
situation demands so there are multiple
ways you can launch containers through
Management console and also
programmatically and ECS also helps to
migrate application to the cloud without
changing the code so anytime you think
of migration the first thing that comes
to your mind is that how will that
environment be based on that I'll have
to alter my code what's what's the IP
what is the storage that's being used
what what are the different parameters
I'll have to include the environment
parameters of the new environment with
containers now that worry is already
taken away because we can create an
pretty exact environment the one that
you had in on-premises the same
environment gets created in the cloud so
no one worries about changing the
application parameter no worries about
changing the code in the application but
you can be like if it ran in my laptop a
container that I was running in my
laptop it's definitely going to run in
the cloud as well because I'm going to
use the same container in the laptop and
also in the cloud in fact you're going
to ship it you're going to move the
container from your laptop to Amazon ECS
and make it run there so it's like the
same the very same image the very same
container that was running in your
laptop will be running in the cloud or
production environment so what is Docker
we know that it ECS helps to quickly
launch exit and manage Docker containers
what is Docker let's let's answer that
question what is Docker now Docker is a
tool that helps to automate the
development of an application as a
lightweight container so that the
application can work efficiently in
different environments this is pretty
much what we discussed right before the
slide I can build an application in my
laptop or in on-premises in a container
environment Docker container environment
and anytime I want to migrate right I
don't have to kind of rewrite the code
and then rerun the code in that new
environment I can simply create an image
a Docker image and move that image to
that production or the new Cloud
environment and simply launch it there
right so no compiling again no
relaunching the application simply pack
all your code in a Docker container
image and ship it to the new environment
and launch the container there that's
all so Docker container is a light
weight package of software that contains
all the dependencies so because you know
when packing you'll be packing all the
dependencies you'll be packing the code
you'll be packing the framework you'll
be be packing the libraries that are
required to run the application so in
the new environment you can be pretty
sure you can be guaranteed that it's
going to run because it's the very same
code it's the very same framework it's
the very same libraries that you have
shipped right there's nothing new in
that new environment it's the very same
thing that's going to run in that
container so you can be rest assured
that they are going to run in that new
environment and these Docker containers
are highly scalable and they are very
efficient suddenly you wanted like 20
more Docker containers to run the
application think of adding 20 more
hosts 20 more VMS right how much time
would it take and compared to that time
the amount of time that Docker
containers would require to kind of
scale to that amount like 20 more
containers it's very less or it's
minimal or negligible so it's a highly
scalable and it's a very efficient
service you can suddenly scale number of
Docker containers to meet any additional
demand very short short boot up time
because it takes a it's not going to
load the whole operating system and
these Docker containers you know they
use the Linux kernel and features of the
kernel like c groups and namespaces to
kind of segregate the processor so they
can run independently any environment
and it takes very less time to boot up
and the data us that are stored in the
containers are kind of reusable so you
can have an external data volume and I
can map it to the container and whatever
the space that's occupied by the
container and the data that the
container puts in that volume they are
kind of reusable you can simply remap it
to another application you can kind of
remap it to the next successive
container you can kind of remap it to
the next version of the container next
version of the application you'll be
launching and you don't have to go
through building the data again from the
scratch whatever data the container was
using previously or the previous
container was using that data is
available for the next container as well
so the volumes that the containers users
are very reusable volumes and like I
said it's isolated application so it
kind of isolates by its nature it kind
of by the way it's designed by the way
it is created it isolates one container
from another container meaning anytime
you run applications on different
containers you can be rest assured that
they are very much isolated though they
are running on the same host though they
are running on the same laptop let's say
though they are running on the same
physical machine let's say running 10
containers 10 different applications you
can be sure that they are well
disconnected or well isolated
applications now let's talk about the
advantages of ECS the advantage of ECS
is improved security it's security is
inbuilt in ECS with ECS we have
something called as a container registry
you know that's where all your images
are stored and those images are accessed
only through https not only that those
images are actually encrypted and access
to those images are allowed and denied
through identity and access management
policies IAM and in other words let's
say two container running on the same
instance now one container can have
access to S3 and the others or the rest
of the others are denied access to S3 so
that kind of granular security can be
achieved through containers when we mix
and match the other security products
available in Amazon like IAM encryption
accessing it using https these
containers are very cost efficient like
I've already said these are lightweight
processors right we can schedule
multiple containers on the same node and
this actually allows us to achieve high
density D on an ec2 instance imagine an
ec2 instance that that's very less
utilized that's not possible with a
container because you can actually dance
or crowd an ec2 instance with more
container in it so to best use those
resources in ec2 straightforward you can
just launch one application but with
when we use containers you can launch
like 10 different applications on the
same ec2 server that means 10 different
applications can actually feed on those
resources available and can benefit the
application and ECS not only deploys the
container it also maintains the state of
the containers and it makes sure that
the minimum a set of containers are
always running based on the requirement
that's another cost efficient way of
using it right and anytime an
application fails and that has a direct
impact on the revenue of the company and
is just make sure that you're not losing
any Revenue because your application has
failed and ECS isn't pretty extensible
Services it's like this in many
organizations there are majority of
unplanned work because of environment
variation a lot of firefighting happens
when we kind of deploy the code from one
or kind of move the code or redeploy the
code in a new environment a lot of
firefighting happens there right this
Docker containers are pretty extensible
like we discussed already environment is
not a concern for containers because
it's going to kind of shut itself inside
a Docker container and anywhere the
docker container can run the application
will run exactly the way it performed in
the past so environment is not a concern
for the docker containers in addition to
that ECS is easily scalable we have
discussed this already and it improves
it has improved compatibility we have
discussed this already let's talk about
the architecture of ECS like you you
know now the architecture of ECS is the
ECS cluster itself that's group of
servers running the ECS service and it
integrates with Docker right so we have
a Docker registry Docker registry is a
repository where we store all the docker
images or the container images so it's
like three components ECS is of three
components one is the ECS cluster itself
right when I say easy as itself I'm
referring to easiest cluster cluster of
servers that will run the containers and
then the repository where the images
will be stored right the repository
where the images will be stored and the
image itself so container image is the
template of instructions which is used
to create a container right so it's like
what's the OS what is the version of
node that should be running and any
additional software do we need so those
question gets answered here so it's the
template template of instructions which
is used to create the containers and
then the registry is the service where
the docker images are stored and shared
so many people can store there and many
people can access or if there's another
group that wants to access they can
access the image from there or one
person can store the image and rest of
the team can access and the rest of the
team can store imagine this one person
can pick the image from there and kind
of ship it to the customer or ship it to
the production environment all that's
possible in this container registry and
Amazon's version of the container
registry is ECR and there's a third
party Docker itself has a container
registry that's Docker Hub ECS itself
which is the the group of servers that
runs those containers so these two the
container image and the container
registry they kind of handle Docker in
an image format just an image format and
in ECS is where the content gets live
and then it becomes an compute resource
and starts to handle requests now starts
to serve the page and starts to do the
batch job you know whatever your plan is
with that container so the cluster of
servers ECS integrates well with the
familiar services like VPC VPC is known
for securing VPC is known for isolating
the whole environment from rest of the
customers or isolating the whole
environment or the whole infrastructure
from the rest of the clients in your
account or from the rest of the
applications in your account on and on
so VPC is a service that provides or
gives you the network isolation ECS
integrates well with VPC and this VPC
enables us to launch AWS resources such
as Amazon ec2 instance in a virtual
private Network that we specified this
is basically what we just discussed now
let's take a closer look at the CCS how
does ECS work let's find answer for this
question how does ECS work ECS has got a
couple of components within itself so
these easier servers can run across
availability Zone as you can see there
are two availability zones here they can
actually run across availability zones
and ECS has got two modes fargate mode
and the ec2 mode right here we're seeing
fargate more and then here we're seeing
nothing that means it's an ec2 mode and
then it has got different network
interfaces attached to it because they
need to be running in an isolated
fashion right so anytime you want
Network isolation you need separate IP
and if you want separate IP you need
separate network interface card and
that's what you have elastic network
interface card separate elastic network
interface card for all those tasks and
services and this runs within an VPC
let's talk about the far gate service
tasks are launched using the far gate
service so we will discuss about tasks
what is forget now fargate is a compute
engine in ECS that allows users to
launch containers without having to
monitor the cluster ECS is a service
that manages the containers for you
right otherwise managing containers will
be an full-time job so ECS manages it
for you and if you and you get to manage
ECS that's the basic service but if you
want Amazon to manage ECS and the
containers for you we can go for fargate
so fargate is a compute engine in ECS
that allows users to launch containers
without having to monitor the ECS
cluster and the tasks the tasks that we
discussed the tasks has two components
you see task right here so they have two
components we have ECS container
instance and then the container agent so
like you might have guessed right now
easiest container instance is actually
an ec2 instance right capable of running
containers not all ec2 instances can run
containers so these are like specific
ec2 instances that can run containers
they are ECS container instances and
then we have container agent which is
the agent that actually binds those
clusters together and it does a lot of
other housekeeping work right kind of
connects clusters makes sure that the
version needed is present so it's all
part of that agent or it's all job of
that agent container instances container
instances is part of Amazon ec2 instance
which run Amazon ECS container agent
pretty straightforward definition and
then a container agent is responsible
for communication between ECS and the
instance and it also provides the status
of the running contain owners kind of
monitors the container monitors the
state of the container make sure that
the container is up and running and if
there's anything wrong it kind of
reports it to the appropriate service to
fix the container on and on it's a
container agent when we don't manage
container agent it it runs by itself and
you really don't have to do anything to
make the container agent better it's
already better you really won't be
configuring anything in the agent and
then elastic network interface car is in
Virtual interface Network that can be
connected to an instance in VPC so in
other words elastic network interface is
how the container interacts with another
container and that's how the container
interacts with the ec2 host and that's
how the container interacts with the
internet external world and a cluster a
cluster is a set of ECS container
instances it's not something that's very
difficult to understand it's simply a
group of ec2 instances that runs that e
CS agent and this cluster it cluster
handles the process of scheduling
monitoring and scaling the request we
know that ECS can scale the containers
can scale how does it scale that's all
Monitor and managed by this ECS cluster
let's talk about the companies that are
using Amazon ECS there are a variety of
companies that use ACS clusters to name
a few okta users easiest cluster and
OCTA is a product that use identity
information to Grant people access to
applications on multiple devices at any
given point of time they make sure that
they have a very strong security
protection so OCTA uses Amazon ECS to
run their OCTA application and serve
their customers and abima abima is an TV
channel and they chose to use
microservices and a Docker containers
they already had microservices and
Docker containers and when they thought
about a service that they can use in AWS
ECS was the only service that they can
immediately adapt to and because in
abima TV the engineers have already been
using Docker and Docker containers it
was kind of easy for them to adapt
themselves to ECS and start using it
along with the benefits that ECS
provides previously they had to do a lot
of work but now ECS does it for them all
right similarly remind and Ubisoft GoPro
or some of the famous companies that use
Amazon ECS and get benefited from its
scalability get benefited from its cost
gets benefited from its Amazon managed
Services get benefited from the
portability that ECS and the migration
option that ECS provides let's talk
about how to deploy a Docker container
on on Amazon ECS the way to deploy
Docker container on ECS is first we need
to have an AWS account and then set up
and run our first ECS cluster so in our
lab we're going to use the launch wizard
to run an ECS cluster and run containers
in them and then toss definition task
definition tells the size of the
container the number of the container
and when we talk about size it tells how
much of CPU do you need how much of
memory do you need and talking about
numbers you know it requires how many
numbers of container you're going to
launch you know is it 5 is it 10 or is
it just one running all the time now
those kind of information goes in the
task definition file and then we can do
some Advanced configuration on ECS like
load balancers and you know what port
number you want to allow when you don't
want to allow you know who gets access
who shouldn't get access and what's the
IP that you want to allow and deny
request from on and on and this is where
we would also mention the name of the
container so the differentiate one
container from the other and the name of
the service you know is it an a backup
job is it a web application is it an a
data container is it going to take care
of your data data backend and the
desired number of tasks that you want to
be running all the time those details go
in when we try to configure the ECS
service right and then you configure
cluster you put in all the security in
the configure your cluster step or
configure cluster stage and finally we
will have an instance and bunch of
containers running in that instance all
right let's do a demo so here I have
logged in to my Amazon portal and let me
switch to the appropriate region I'm
going to pick North Virginia North
Virginia look for ECS and it tells ECS
is a service that helps to run and
manage Docker containers well and good
click on it I'm a not Virginia I just
want to make sure that I'm in the right
region and go to clusters and here we
can create cluster this is our far gate
and this is our ec2 type launching for
Linux and windows environment but I'm
going to launch through this walkthrough
portal right this gives a lot of
information here so the different steps
involved here is creating a container
definition which is what we're going to
do right now and then a task definition
and then service and finally the cluster
it's a four-step process so in container
definition we Define the image the base
image we are going to use now here I'm
going to launch an httpd or a simple
HTTP web page right so a simple httpd
2.4 image is fair enough for me and it's
not an heavier application so 0.5
gigabit of memory is enough and again
it's not a heavy application so 0.25
virtual CPU is enough in our case right
you can edit it based on the requirement
you can always edit it and because I'm
using hdpd the port mapping is already
Port 80 that's how the container is
going to receive the request and there's
no health check as of now when we want
to design critical and complicated
environments we can include health check
right and this is the CPU that we have
chose we can edit it and I'm going to
use some bash commands to create an HTML
page right this page says that you know
Amazon ECS sample app right and then it
says Amazon ECS sample app your
application is running on a container in
Amazon ECS so that's the page the HTML
page that I'm going to create right
index.html so I'm going to create and
put it in an appropriate location
location so those pages can be served
from the container right if you replace
this with any of your own content then
it's going to be your own content ECS
comes with some basic logs and these are
the places where they get stored that's
not the focus as of now all right so I
was just saying that you can edit it and
customize it to your needs We're not
gonna do any customization now we're
just getting familiar with ECS now and
the task definition name of the task
definition is first run task definition
and then we are running it in a VPC and
then this is an fargate mode meaning the
servers are completely handled by Amazon
and the task memory is 0.5 gigabit and
the task CPU is 0.25 virtual CPU name of
the service is it a batch job is it an
you know a front end is it an back end
or is it a simple copy job what's the
service name of the service goes here
again this you can edit it and here's a
security group as of now I'm allowing
for 80 to the whole world if I want to
restrict to a certain IP I can do that
the default option for load balancing is
no load balancer but I can also choose
to have a load balancer and use port 80
to map that Port 80 to The Container
Port 80 right I can do that the default
is no load balancer all right let's do
one thing let's use load balancer let's
use load balancer and Port 80 that
receives information on Port 80 HTTP
what's going to be the cluster name
within the last step what is the cluster
name cluster name can be simply learn
ECS demo next we're done and we can
create so it's launching a cluster as
you can see and it's picking the task
definition file that we've created and
it's using that to launch and service
and then these are the log groups that
we discussed and it's creating your VPC
remember ECS clubs well with the VPC
it's creating a VPC and it's creating
two subnets here for high availability
it's creating that Security Group Port
80 allowed to the whole world and then
it's putting it behind and load balancer
right generally would take like five to
ten minutes so which is need to be
patient and let it complete its creation
and once this is complete we can simply
access these servers using the load
balancer URL and when this is running
let me actually take you to the other
products or the other services that are
integrated with ECS it's getting created
our service is getting created as of now
ECR repository this is where all our
images are stored now as of now I'm not
pulling my image from ECR I'm pulling it
directly from the internet Docker Docker
Hub but all custom images all custom
images they are stored in this
Repository so you can create a
repository call it app one create a
repository so here's my repository so
any image that I create locally or any
Docker image that I create locally I can
actually push them push those images
using these commands right here and they
get stored here and I can make my ECS
connect with ECR and pull images from
here so they would be my custom images
and as of now because I'm using a
default image it's directly pulling it
from the internet let's go to ec2 and
look for a load balancer because we
wanted to access the application from
behind a load balancer right so here is
a load balancer created for us and
anytime I put the URL so cluster is now
created you know you see there's one
service running all right let's click on
that cluster here is the name of our
application and here is the the tasks
the different containers that we are
running and if you click on it we have
an IP right IP of that container and it
says it's running it was created at such
and such time and started at such and
such time and this is the task
definition file that it this container
uses meaning the template the details to
all the version details they all come
from here and it belongs to the cluster
called simply learn ECS demo right and
you can also get some logs container
logs from here so let's go back and
there are no ECS instances here because
remember this is forget you're not
managing any ECS instance all right so
that's why you're not seeing any easiest
instance here so let's go back to tasks
and go back to the same page where we
found the IP pick that IP put it in the
browser and you have this sample HTML
page running from an container so let me
go back to load balancer ec2 and then
under ec2 I'll be able to find a load
balancer find that load balancer pick
that DNS name put it in the browser and
now it's accessible to the load balancer
URL right now this URL can be mapped to
other services like DNS this URL can be
embedded in any of your application if
you want to make that application
connect with this container Now using IP
is not all that advisable because these
containers can die and then a new
container gets created and when a new
container gets created it gets a new IP
right so a hard coding IP is not
hardcoding Dynamic IPS are not advisable
so you would be using load balancer and
putting that URL in that application
that you want to make it interact with
this container instance it was a
wonderful experience in Walking you
through this ECS topic and in here we
learn about what AWS is and why we're
using ECS and what is easiest in gen
handle what is Docker in specific and we
also learn about the advantages of ECS
the architecture the different
components of ECS and how ECS works when
they're all connected together and we
also looked at the companies that use
ECS and their use cases and finally a
lab how we can launch ECS fargate
through the portal in this section we
are going to talk about basics of AWS
and then we're going to immediately dive
into why why we need Amazon Route 53 and
then we're going to expand and talk
about the details of Amazon Route 53 the
benefits it provides over its
competitors and the different types of
routing policy it has and some of Amazon
route 53's key features and we're going
to talk about how to access Route 53 I
mean the different ways the different
methods you can access Route 53 in and
finally we're going to end with an a
wonderful demo in Route 53 so let's talk
about what is AWS Amazon web services or
AWS in short is a cloud provider that
offers a variety of services such as a
variety of IT services or infrastructure
services such as compute power database
a Content delivery and other resources
that helps us to scale and grow our
business and AWS is hard AWS is picking
up AWS is being adapted by a lot of
customers that's because AWS is easy to
use even for a beginner and talking
about safety the the AWS infrastructure
is designed to keep the data safe
irrespective of the size of the data
with small data be it very minimal data
the all the data that you have in
terabytes and in petabyte Amazon can
keep it safe in their environment and
the wonderful thing and the most
important reason why a lot of customers
move into the cloud is that the pay as
you go pricing there is no long-term
commitment and it's very cost effective
what this means is that you're not
paying for research that you're not
using in on-premises you do pay for
resources you're not using a lot meaning
you go and buy a server you do the
estimate for the next five years and
only after like three or four years
you'll be hitting the peak capacity but
still you would be buying that capacity
before four years right and then you
will gradually be you know utilizing it
from you know 40 percent date 60
percentage 70 80 and then 100. so what
you have done is that even though you're
not using the full capacity you still
have bought it and are and are paying
for it from day one but in the cloud
it's not like that you only pay for the
resources that you use anytime you want
more use scale up the results and you
you pay for the scaled up results and
anytime you want less you scale down the
resource and you pay less for that
scaled down resource let's talk about
why Amazon Route 53 let's take this
scenario where Rachel is trying to open
her web browser and the URL that she hit
isn't working a lot of reasons behind
why the URL isn't working it could be
the server utilization that went High it
could be it could be the memory usage
that went High a lot of reasons and she
starts to think is there an efficient
way to scale resources according to the
user requirements or is there an
efficient way to kind of mask all those
failures and kind of divert the traffic
to the appropriate active you know
active resource or active service that's
running our application you always want
to hide the failures right in it kind of
mask the failure and direct the customer
to another healthy service that's
running all right none of your customers
would want to see a server not available
or you know none of the customers your
customers would want to see your service
not working not impressive to them and
this is Tom Tom is an I.T guy and he
comes up with an idea and he's answering
Rachel yes we can scale resources
efficiently using Amazon a Route 53 in a
sense he's saying that yes we can mask
the failure and we can keep the services
up and running meaning we can provide
more High availability to our customers
with the use of Route 53 and then he
goes on and explains Amazon Route 53 is
a DNS service that gives developers an
efficient way to connect users to
internet applications without any
downtime now downtime is the key Amazon
Route 53 helps us to avoid any downtime
that customers would experience you
still will have downtime in your server
in your application but your customers
will not be made aware of it and then
Rachel is kind of interested and she's
like yeah that sounds interesting I want
to learn more about it and Tom goes on
and explains the important concepts of
Amazon Rock 53 that's everything that
I'm going to explain it to you as well
alright so what is Amazon Route 53
Amazon raw 53 is a highly scalable DNS
or domain name system web service this
service this Amazon raw 53 it functions
three main things or it has three main
functions so the first thing is if a
website needs a name Route 53 registers
the name for the website domain let's
say you want to buy google.com you want
to buy the domain name let's say you
want to buy that domain name you buy
that through route 53. secondly a Route
53 is the service that actually connects
your server which is running your
application or which is holding which is
serving your web page so that's this
service that actually Route 53 is the
service that connects the user to your
server when they hit google.com in the
browser or whatever domain name that you
have purchased so you bought a domain
name and the user types in your
domainname.com and then Roth 53 is a
service that helps the user to connect
their browser to the application that's
running in an easy to instance or any
other server that you are using to serve
that content now not only that Route 53
checks Health after resource by sending
automated requests over the internet to
a resource so that's how it identifies
if there is any resource that has failed
when I say resource I'm referring to any
infrastructure failure any application
Level failure so it kind of keeps
checking so it understands it first
before the customer notices it and then
it does the magic kind of shifts the
connection from one server to the other
server we call it routing we will talk
about that as we progress so the
benefits of using Raw 53 it's highly
scalable meaning suddenly let's say the
number of requests the number of people
trying to access your website through
that domain name that you have bought
let's say it has increased Route 53 is
highly scalable right it can handle even
millions and millions of requests
because it's highly scalable and it's
managed by Amazon uh the same thing it's
reliable it's a highly scalable it can
handle large queries without the users
Without You interacting without the user
who bought it interact with it you don't
have to scale up you know when you're
expecting more requests it automatically
scales and it is very reliable in a
sense that it's very consistent it has
the ability to Route the users to the
appropriate application through the
logic that it has it's very easy to use
when we do the lab you're going to see
that it's very easy easy to use you buy
the domain name and then you simply map
it to the application you simply map it
to the server by putting in the IP or if
you you can simply map it to another
load balancer by putting in the load
balancer URL you can simply map it to
another S3 Buckhead by simply putting
the S3 bucket name or the S3 bucket URL
it's pretty straightforward easy to set
up and it's very cost effective in a way
that we only pay for the service that we
have used so no wastage of money here so
the billing is set up in such a way that
you are paying only for the amount of
requests that you have received right
the amount of traffic the amount of
requests that you have received and
couple of other things the the number of
hosted zones that you have created right
and couple of other things it's very
cost effective in such a way that you
only pay for the service that you are
using and it's secure in a way that
access to Route 53 is integrated with
the identity and access management IAM
so you only have authorized users gain
access to Route 53 the trainee who just
joined yesterday won't get access and
the contractor or the consultant the
third party consultant you have given
access or who is using your environment
you can block access to that a
particular person because he's not the
admin or he's not a privileged user in
your account so only privileged users
and admin gain access to Route 53
through IAM now let's talk about the
routing policies so when you create a
record in in Route 53 record is nothing
but an entry so when you do that you
choose a routing policy all right
routing policy is nothing but it
determines how Route 53 responds to your
queries how the DNS queries are being
responded right that's that's a record
or that's a routing policy so the first
one is a simple routing policy so we use
Simple routing policy for a single
resource in other words simple routing
allows to configure DNA business with no
special Route 53 routing it's kind of
one to one you use an single resource
that performs a given function to your
domain for example if you want to Simply
map an URL to a web server that's pretty
straightforward simple routing so it
routes traffic to a single resource
example web server to a website and with
simple routing multiple records with the
same name cannot be created but multiple
values can be created in the same record
the second type of routing policy is
failover routing so we would be using
failover routing when we want to
configure active passive failover if
something failed right you want to fail
over to the next resource which was
previously the backup resource now the
active resource or which was previously
the backup server now it's an active
server so you would be failing over to
that particular resource or that
particular IP you if you want to do that
we use failover routing so failure
routing routes traffic to a resource
when the resource is healthy or to a
different resource when the previous
resource is unhealthy in other words
anytime a resource goes unhealthy I mean
it does all that's needed to shift the
traffic from the primary resource to the
secondary resource in other words from
the unhealthy resource to the healthy
resource and this records can Route
traffic to anything from an Amazon S3
bucket or you can also configure a
complex tree of Records you know when we
configure the records it will be more
clear to you so as of now just
understand that Route 53 can route or
this routing policy the failover routing
policy can Route traffic to Amazon S3
bucket or to a website that has complex
tree of Records geolocation routing
policy now geolocation routing just like
the name says it it takes that routing
decision based on the geographic
location of the user in other words you
know when you want to Route traffic
based on the location of the user so
that's your primary criteria for kind of
sending that request to the appropriate
server we will be using jio location
routing so it localizes the content and
presents a part or the entire website in
the language of the user for example a
user from us you would want to direct
them to an English website and a user
from German if you want to send them to
the German website and a user from
France you know you want to send those
requests or you want to show content
specific to a customer who lives in
France a French website so this is if
that's your condition this is the
routing policy we would be using and the
geographic locations are specified by
either continent or by country or by
state in the United state so only in the
United States you can actually split it
to state level and for the rest of the
countries you can do it on a country
level on a high level you can also do it
on a continent level the next type of
routing policy would be your proximity
routing geoproximity routing policy when
we want to Route traffic based on the
location of our resource and optimally
shift traffic from resources in one
location to resource in another location
we would be using geoproximity routing
so geoproximity routing routes traffic
to the resources based on the geographic
location of the user and the resources
they want to access and it also has an
option to Route more traffic or less to
a given resource by specifying a value
known as a biased kind of weight but we
also have weighted routing that's
different so we've chosen different name
buyers so you can send more traffic to a
project resource by having a bias on
that particular routing condition and a
bias expands or shrinks the size of the
geographic region from which traffic is
routed to a resource and then we have
latency based routing just like the name
says we use latency based routing if we
have resources in multiple AWS regions
and if you want to Route traffic to the
region that provides the best latency at
any given point of time so let's say if
one single website needs to be installed
and hosted on multiple AWS regions then
latency routing policy is what is being
used it improves the performance of the
users by serving the request from the
AWS region that provides the lowest
latency so at any given point if
performance is your criteria and at any
given point of time irrespective of what
happens in Amazon infrastructure
irrespective of what happens in the
internet if you want to route your your
users to the best performing website
best performing region then we would be
using latency based routing and for
using latency based routing we should
create latency records for the resources
in multiple AWS regions and then the
other type of routing policy is
multi-value routing policy where we can
make Route 53 to respond to DNS queries
with up to eight healthy records
selected at random so you're not kind of
loading one particular server we can
Define eight records and on a random
basis Route 53 will respond to queries
from these eight records so it's not one
server that gets all the requests but
eight servers gets the request in a
random fashion so it's multi-value
routing policy and what we get by this
is that we are Distributing the traffic
to many servers instead of just one
server so multi-value routing configures
Route 53 to return multiple values in
response to a single or multiple DNS
queries it also checks the health of
order sources and Returns the multiple
values only for the healthy resources
let's say out of the eight servers we
have defined one server is not doing
healthy it will not respond to the query
with the details of the unhealthy server
right so now it's going to treat it as
only seven servers in the list because
one server is unhealthy and it has the
ability to return multiple Health
checkable IP addresses to improve
availability and load balancing the
other type of routing policy is weighted
routing policy and in here we use to
Route traffic or this is used to Route
traffic to multiple resources in a
proportion that we specify so this is an
weighted routing and weighted routing
routes multiple resources to a single
domain name or a subdomain and control
the traffic that's routed to each
resources so this is very useful when
you are doing load balancing and testing
new versions of the software so when you
have a new version of this software you
really don't want to send 100 of the
traffic to it so you want to get
customers feedback about the new
software that you have launched new
version or new application that you've
launched so you would kind of send only
20 of the traffic to that application
get customer feedback and if all is good
then we would move the rest of the
traffic to that new application so any
software launches application launches
we'll be using weighted routing now
let's talk about the key benefits or key
features of Route 53 some of the key
features of Route 53 are traffic flow it
routes end users to the endpoint that
should provide the best user experience
that's what we discussed in the routing
policies right uses a routing policy a
latency based routing policy and Geo
based routing policy and then failover
routing policies so it kind of improves
the user experience and the key feature
the other key feature of Route 53 is we
can buy domain names using a Roth 53
using Route 53 console we can buy it
from here and use it in route 53.
previously it was not the case but now
we can buy it directly from Amazon
through Route 53 and we can assign it to
any resources that we want so anybody
browsing that URL the connection will be
directed to the server in AWS that runs
our website a health checks it monitors
health and performance of the
application so it comes with an health
check attached to it health check or
useful to make sure that the unhealthy
resources are retired right the
unhealthy resources are taken away or
your customers or not kind of hitting
the unhealthy resources and they see an
service down page or something like that
we can have weighted round robin load
balancing that's helpful and spreading
traffic between several services or
service we are round robin algorithm so
no one server is fully hit or no one
server kind of fully absorbs all the
traffic you know you can shift you can
split and shift the traffic to different
servers based on the weight that you
would be configuring and also weighted
routing also helps with a soft launch
soft launch of your new application or
the new version of your website there
are different ways we can access Amazon
Route 53 so you can access Amazon Route
53 through AWS console you can also
access Amazon Route 53 using AWS sdks
and we can access it using we can
configure it using the the apis and we
can also do it through the command line
interface that's Linux type Linux flavor
AWS command line interface we can also
do that using Windows command line
Windows Powershell flavored command line
interface as well now let's look at some
of the companies that are using route
53. so some of the famous companies that
use Route 53 are medium medium is an
online publishing platform and it's more
like a social journalism it's kind of
having hybrid collection of
professionals people and Publications or
exclusive blogs or Publishers on medium
it's kind of an blog website and that
uses Rod 53 for the DNS service a Reddit
is an social news aggregation or web
content rating and discussion website
that uses route 53s so these are some
websites that that are accessed
throughout the world and they are using
Roth 53 and it's highly scalable
suddenly there is a new news right their
website will be accessed a lot and they
need to keep their service up and
running all the time more availability
otherwise customers will end up in a
broken page and the number of customers
who will be using the website will come
down so it's very critical on these
sites these companies are very critical
you know they're being highly available
the page their site being highly
available and the internet is very
critical and crucial for them and they
rely and use Route 53 to meet that
particular demand and Airbnb is another
company
instacart khoza is another company
stripe is another company that uses
Route 53 to as their DNS provider for
the DNS service they use Route 53 so
their customers get best performance
they use Route 53 so their website is
highly available they use Route 53 to
kind of have shipped to the traffic
between the resources so the resources
are properly used with all the weighted
routing the resources are properly used
now let's quickly look at a demo I'm in
my AWS console and I'm in Route 53 so
let me click on Route 53. so in this lab
we're actually going to simulate buying
a domain name and then we're going to
create an S3 static website and we're
going to map that website to this DNS
name right so the procedure is the same
for mapping load balancer the procedure
is the same for mapping cloudfront the
procedure is the same for mapping ec2
instances as well we're picking S3 for
Simplicity right but our focus is
actually on Route 53. so let's go in
here and we'll see if we can we will buy
a domain name here so let's first check
the availability of a domain name called
simply learn hyphen demo hyphen Route 53
let's check its availability it is
available for twelve dollars so let me
add it to cart and then come back here
and then once you continue to ask for
personal information once you give the
personal information you finally check
out and then it gets added to your
shopping list once you pay for it Amazon
takes like 24 to 40 dollars to make that
a DNS name available so the next stage
would be contact details and then the
third stage would be a verify and
purchase so once we've bought the domain
name it will become available in our DNS
portal and I do have a domain name which
I bought some time back and it's now
available for me to use so I can go to
hosted Zone and simply start creating I
can go to hosted Zone and then here it's
going to list all the domain names for
me right click on the domain name and
then click on the record set and here I
can actually map elastic load balancer
S3 website VPC endpoint API Gateway and
cloudfront elastic bean stock domain
names right all that gets mapped through
this portal quite simple like four or
five step button clicks and then it'll
be done so I have an domain name bot and
then I'm going to go to S3 and now I'll
show you what I've done in S3 so I've
created a bucket name call as DNS name
let me clear the content in them so I've
created a bucket and then permissions
I've turned off Public Access blocking
and then I've created an a bucket policy
so this bucket is now publicly
accessible and then I went on to
properties and created the static
website hosting right and I've pointed
that this is the file that's my index
file that I'm going to put or name of
the file that's going to be my index
file that I'm going to put in this S3
bucket so put the index file.html saved
it and we're going to create a file now
we're going to create an index file so
this is a sample code it says amazon.53
getting started routing internet traffic
effect to S3 bucket for your website and
then couple of other information so save
it as an
index.html file in my desktop so let me
upload that from my desktop into this
bucket so that's index.html and it's in
capital I so let me go to properties and
go to static website hosting and make
sure that I spell it properly right it's
case sensitive and then save it so now
this means that my website should be
running through this URL and it does
it's running to the static website URL
we're halfway through so now let me go
back to Route 53 go back to Route 53 go
back to hosted zones go into the domain
name and then create a record set and
it's going to be an alias record and I I
see my S3 static website endpoint there
all right so click on it and create it
has now created an record that's
pointing my domain name to the S3
endpoint that I have created and my
static web site is running from it so
let me test it so let me go to the
browser put the domain name in there and
sure enough the domain name when we
browse the queried for the domain name
around 53 returned a response saying
this domain name is actually mapped to
the S3 bucket static website hosting
enable S3 bucket and this is the URL for
that static website hosting and then my
browser was able to connect to that S3
bucket and download the details and show
it in my browser all right so it's that
simple and pretty straightforward let me
help you understand AWS elastic
Beanstalk so what's in it for you we'll
be discussing about what is AWS why we
require AWS elastic bean stock what is
AWS elastic mean stock the advantages
disadvantages the components of mean
stock along with that the architecture
and the companies that are primarily
using the AWS bin stock so let's get
started and first understand what is AWS
AWS stands for Amazon web services it's
a cloud provider and that offers a
variety of services such as compute
power database storage content delivery
and many other resources so we know that
AWS is the largest cloud provider in the
market and so many services are
available in the AWS where you can apply
the business Logics and create the
solutions using the cloud platforms now
why AWS elastic bean stock now what
happened earlier and that whenever the
developer used to create the software or
the modules related to the softwares it
has to be joined together to create a
big application now one developer
creates a module that has to be shared
with another developer and if the
developers are geographically separated
then it has to be shared over a medium
probably an internet so that is going to
take some time it would be a difficult
process and in return it makes the
application or a software development
Earl NBA process the building of the
software development linear process so
there were challenges which the
developers were facing earlier and to
overcome that we have the mean stock as
a service available in the AWS so why
AWS elastic bean stock is required AWS
elastic being stock has made the life of
the developers quite easy uh in terms of
that they can share the applications
across different devices at a shorter
time duration now let's understand what
is AWS elastic bean stock AWS elastic
bean stock is a service which is used to
deploy and scale web applications by
developers not only web application any
application that is being developed by
the developers this is a simple
representation of the AWS plastic bean
stock NOW along with that the AWS
elastic bean stock supports the
programming language the runtime
environments that are java.net PHP
node.js Python rubigo and Docker and in
case if you're looking for any other
programming language or a runtime
environment then you can make a request
with AWS to arrange that for you now
what are the advantages associated with
the elastic bean stock First Advantage
is that it's a highly scalable service
now when we talk about a scalability it
means that whenever we require the
resources in demand we can scale up the
resources or we can scale down the
resources so that is kind of a
flexibility we get in terms of changing
the type of resources whenever we need
it and in that case the elastic bean
stock is a highly scalable service now
that is something which is very
difficult to achieve in case of an
on-prem environments because you have to
plan for the infrastructure and in case
if you're short of the resources within
that infrastructure then you have to
procure it again the second Advantage
associated with the Beanstalk is that
it's a fast and simple to begin now when
we say it's fast and simple that means
that you just have to focus on the
development of an application building
an application and then you can just
deploy the application directly using
the Beanstalk what the bean stock is
going to do that every networking aspect
is being taken care by the Beanstalk it
deploys your application in the back end
on the servers and then you can directly
access your application using the URL or
through the IP address the third
Advantage is that it offers the quick
deployment that is what we discussed in
the fast and simple to begin as well so
why it offers a quick deployment you
don't have to bother about the
networking Concepts you just have to
focus on the application development and
then you can just upload your
application deploy that and then you are
good to go the other Advantage is that
it supports multi-tenant architecture
when we talk about tenants or
multi-tenants that means we can have a
virtual environments for separate
organizations or the divisions within
the organizations that will be virtually
isolated so likewise you can have a
virtually isolated environments created
on the Beanstalk and they can be
separated used as a separate entities or
separate divisions within the
organization and we know that it's a
flexible service since it's a scalable
then which is a flexible also now coming
to the simplifies operations as an
advantage now once the application is
deployed using the Beanstalk then it
becomes very easy to maintain and
support that application using the
Beanstalk Services itself and the last
advantage that we can have from the
Beanstalk is that it's a cost efficient
service the cost efficient as we know
that many of the AWS services are cost
effective the cost optimization can be
better managed using the AWS mean stock
as compared to if you are developing or
if you are deploying any kind of an
application or a solution on the on-prem
servers now there are some components
that are associated with the AWS
Beanstalk and it has to be created in
the form of a sequence manner so AWS
elastic means law consists of few
important components which are required
while developing an application now what
are these components these are four
components one is application the second
is application version the third is
environment and the fourth one is the
environment tier and we have to progress
while deploying our applications or the
softwares using the same sequence now
let's understand what are the different
components of the Beanstalk are the
application it refers to a unique label
which is used as a Deployable code for a
web application so generally you deploy
your web application or you create your
application and that is something which
is basically used as a unique label then
the second component is application
versions so it resembles a folder which
stores a collection of components such
as environments versions and environment
configurations so all these components
are being stored using the application
version the third most important
component is the environment in the
environment only the current versions of
the applications runs now remember that
elastic mean stock supports multiple
versions as well and using the
environment you can only run the current
version of the application file if you
wanted to have another version of an
application to be running then you have
to create another environment for that
then comes the environment tier and in
the environment here it is basically it
designates the type of application that
the environment runs on now generally
there are two types of environment here
one is the web uh and the other one is
the worker node and that's something
which we'll be discussing later as well
now let's understand how does elastic
bean stock in AWS works so first we have
to create an application and this is a
task that would be done by the
developers and for that you can actually
select any runtime environment or a
programming language like Java Docker
Ruby gopal or python as well and once
you select that environment you can
develop your application using that
runtime environments now after that once
the application is created then you have
to upload the version of an application
on the AWS and after that once the
version is uploaded and then you have to
launch your environment so just have to
click on the buttons that's it nothing
more you have to do once the environment
is launched then you can actually view
that environment using a web URL or
using the IP address now what happens in
that case is when you launch an
environment in the back end the elastic
stock or else automatically runs any ec2
instance and using a metadata the mean
stock deploys our application within
that ec2 instance that is something
which you can look into the ec2
dashboard as well so you don't have to
take care of the security groups you
don't have to take care of the IP
addressing and even you don't have to
login into the instance and deploy your
application it would be done
automatically by the bin stock it's just
that you just have to monitor the
environment and the statistics will be
available there itself in the bin stock
dashboard otherwise you can view those
statistics in the cloudwatch logs as
well now in case if you wanted to update
any kind of a version then you just
upload a new version and then just
deploy that and then monitor your
environment so these are the essentials
to create a local applications for any
platform whether it's a node.js python
Etc these are the things that you have
to actually take care and this is the
sequence you have to follow while
creating an environment so you can say
that it's a four steps creation of a
deployment of your application that's it
now after users upload their versions
the configuration is automatically
deployed with a load balancer yes and
with the load balancer that means you
can access the applications using the
load balancer DNS also and apart from
load balancer if you wanted to put any
other feature that includes the auto
scaling for example if you wanted to
create your ec2 instances where the
application will be deployed within the
virtual private cloud or in a particular
subnet within the VPC all those features
that are available and you can select
them using the mean stock itself you
don't have to move out to the VPC you
don't have to actually go to the ec2
dashboard and select all those
separately everything would be available
within the Beanstalk dashboard so that's
what it says in the presentation that
after creating an application the deploy
service can be specifically accessed
using the URL so once the environment is
created there will be a URL defined now
you can put a URL name also that is
something which you wanted to put for
your application you can define that you
can check for the availability of that
URL and then you have to use that URL to
access your application or the browser
now once it is done then in the monitor
environment it says the environment is
Monitor provided capacity provisioning
load balancing Auto scaling and Hand
Motor features all those features are
available there itself in the mean stock
now let's understand the architecture of
AWS elastic Beanstalk now there are two
types of environments that you have to
select you can select one is the web
server environment and the other one is
the worker environment So based on the
client requirement Beanstalk gives you
two different types of environment that
you have to select generally the web
server environment is the front-end
facing that means the client should be
as accessing this environment directly
using a URL so mostly web applications
are deployed using that environment the
worker environment is the back end
applications or on the micro apps which
are basically required to support the
running of the web applications now it
depends on the client requirement what
kind of an environment you wanted to
select now in the web server environment
it only handles the http request from
the clients so that's why we use the web
server environment mostly for the web
applications or any application which
works on the HTTP https requests so it's
not only the HTTP you can use the https
as well the worker environment it
process background tasks and minimizes
the consumption of resources so again it
is just like a kind of a micro service
or an application services that are
running in the back end to support the
web server environment now coming to the
understanding of the AWS means talk so
this is how the architecture of the AWS
bean stock is designed and you can refer
to that image also now in the web server
environment let's say if we select a web
server environment and it says that if
the application receives client request
the Amazon Route 53 sends his request to
the elastic load balance now obviously
we discussed here that the web server
environment is primarily an environment
which receives the HTTP requests it's a
kind of a client-facing environment now
if the application receives a client
request Amazon from the Amazon Route 53
this Route 53 is a service which is
primarily used for new DNS mapping it's
a global Service and it may route you
can route the traffic from the Route 53
matching your domains towards the load
balancer and from the load balancer you
can point the traffic to the web server
environment obviously the web server
environment is nothing it's just the ec2
instances that would be running in the
back end now here in the diagram you can
see that there are two web server
environments and they are created in the
auto scaling group that means there is
some kind of scaling options that are
defined as well and these instances are
created in an availability zone or they
can be created in a different
availability Zone also for the
redundancy as well and these web
application servers are further
connected to your databases which
primarily will be in a different
security groups probably it can be an
RDS database also so all these
functionalities all these features are
basically available on the elastic mean
stock dashboard itself now what happens
in that case is if the application
receives client requests Amazon Route 53
send these requests to the load balancer
later the load balancer shares those
require West among the ec2 instances how
does that happen it happens using a
predefined algorithm the equal
distribution of a load is distributed to
both the ec2 instances or n number of
ac2 instances running in the
availability zone now in the
availability zones every ec2 instance
would have its own Security Group they
can have a common Security Group also
they can have their own Security Group
as well now after the security group the
load balancer is then connected to the
Amazon ec2 instance which are part of
the auto scaling group so that's
something which we have discussed
already now this Auto scaling group is
would be defined from the Beanstalk
itself and there will be some scaling
options that will be created it could be
a possibility that it might be the
minimum number of instances that would
be running as of now and based on the
threshold defined it may increase the
number of ec2 instance and the load
balancer will keep on Distributing the
load to as many instances that will be
created inside the availability Source
obviously there will be an internal
health check that the load balancer will
be first doing before Distributing via
real-time traffic to these instances
created by the mean stock now what does
Auto scaling group does it automatically
starts the additional ec2 instance to
accommodate increasing load on your
application that's something which we
know that and also it monitors and
scales instances based on the workload
as well so depends on what kind of a
scaling threshold you have defined in
the auto scaling groups and when the
load of an application decreases the ec2
instance will also be decreased so
whenever we talk about the auto scaling
generally it comes in our mind is that
we scale up the resources that means we
it increases the ec2 instances in the
auto scaling you might have the scale
down option also scale down policy also
created in which if the load minimizes
it can terminate the additional ec2
instances as well so that is something
which will be automatically managed all
these features can be achievable using
the elastic mean stock and with this
feature accommodated it gives you the
better cost optimization in terms of
managing your resources now it says that
elastic bean stock has a default Quality
Group and the security group acts as a
Firefall for the instances now here in
this diagram it says about the Security
Group auto scaling also you might create
it in a default VPC also you might
create it in your custom VPC also where
you can have the additional level of
security is also created you can have
the NaCl snackers also defined here
before the security groups so that would
give you the additional filtering option
or the firewall option now it says that
with these groups with these security
groups it allows establishing security
groups to the database server as well so
every database would also have its own
Security Group and the connection can be
created between the web servers
environment and that is created by the
Beanstalk to the database security
groups as well now let's discuss about
the worker environment now understanding
the worker environment what happens is
that the client the web server
environment is the client facing the
client sends a request for an access to
the web server and in this diagram the
web server further sends it to the sqs
which is a simple queue service and the
Q service send it to the worker
environment and then whatever the worker
environment is created for doing some
kind of a processing or some kind of an
application that is running in the back
end that environment initiates and then
send back uh the results to this sqs and
my servers so let's understand the
architecture of a AWS plastic bean stock
with the worker environment so when a
worker environment here is launched AWS
elastic bean stock install the server on
every ec2 instance so that is in the
case of a web server environment also
and later the server passes the request
to the simple queue service now this
service is an asynchronous service
instead of a simple queue service you
can have other services also it is not
necessary that you need to have the sqs
also this is an example that we are
discussing about and the sqs shares
those message via a post request to the
HTTP path over the broker environment
and there are many case studies also
with respect to this kind of an
environment that is being created that
is being done on many customers and you
can search for this kind of a case
studies available on the internet now
the worker environment executes the task
given by the sqs with the HTTP response
after the operation is completed now
here what happens is a quick recap the
client request for an access of an
application to a web server using an
HTTP request the web server passes that
request to the queue service the queue
service shares the message with the
worker probably a worker might be the
manual worker and generally it's an
automated worker so it would be shared
via the worker environment only and the
worker sends back the response with the
HTTP response back to the queue that
response can be viewed directly from the
queue service by the client using the
web server so this is one of the example
likewise as I said that there can be
many other examples also where you can
have the worker environments defined now
what are the companies that are using
the elastic bean stock these are few of
the companies that are primarily using
on a Zillow jelly button games uh then
you have League of Women Voters eBay
these are some of the few listed
companies and obviously you search on
the AWS site and you'll find many more
organizations that are using the elastic
bean stock primarily for deploying their
applications now the next thing is to go
with the practicals that how actually we
use the elastic Beanstalk so let's look
into the demo using the AWS elastic
Beanstalk now first you have to login
into the AWS console and I'm sure that
you might be having the accounts created
or you can use the IM credentials as
well and then you have to select the
region also now I am in the North
Virginia region likewise you can select
any of the regions that are listed here
now click on the services and you have
to search for the elastic bean stock you
can find the elastic bean stock under
the compute section so here itself
you'll find the elastic bean stock as a
service now open this service and there
it will give you an option to create an
environment you have to specifically
select an environment probably a worker
environment or a web service environment
so let's wait for the service to open so
we have the dashboard now available with
us this is how the elastic bean stock
looks and this is the symbol
representation of a beanstalk now what
you have to do is we have to click on
get started and that will load and you
have to create a web app so instead of
creating a web app what we'll do we'll
create a new application so just click
on create a new application put an
application name let's say we put
something like x y z you can put any
description to your application let's
say it's a demo app and click on create
now it says you have to select an
environment now the environment the
application name XYZ is created you just
have to select the nav environment so
click on create one now and it is going
to ask you that what kind of an
environment here you wanted to select so
as we discussed that there are two types
of environments one is the web server
and the other one is the worker in one
let's look into it what is defined by
the AWS it WC is that it has two types
of environment tiers to support
different types of web applications web
servers are standard applications that
listen for and then process HTTP
requests typically over port number 80.
workers are specialized applications
that have a background processing task
that listens for message on an Amazon
sqs queue workers application post those
messages to your application by using
the HTTP response so that's what we saw
in the case of the Beanstalk slides also
now the usability of a worker
environment can be anything now we'll do
a demo for creating a web server
environment so just click on select and
you we have the environment name created
now we can Define our own domain it ends
with the region dot elasticbeanstalk.com
let's say I look for a domain which is
XYZ only that's the environment name now
I'll check for the availability whether
that domain name is available with us or
not and it says we don't have that
domain name so probably I'll try to make
it with some other name and let's look
for the availability XYZ ABC and it says
yes it is available now once I deploy my
application I would be able to access
the application using this complete DNS
so you can put a description it's a demo
app that we are creating and then you
have to define a platform as well now
these are the platforms that are
supported by the AWS let's say I wanted
to run a node.js environment so I'll
just click on the node.js platform the
application codes is something which is
basically developed by the developers
and you can upload the App application
right now or you can do that later as
well once the environment is ready now
either you can select to create an
environment if you wanted to go with all
the default settings otherwise if you
wanted to customize it more you can
click on configure more options so let's
click on configure more options and here
you would be able to Define very various
different features like the type of an
instance for example what kind of an ec2
instance or a server that should be
running so that the Beanstalk can deploy
our applications over it if you wanted
to modify just click on a modify button
and here you can modify your instances
with respect to the storage as well now
apart from that if you wanted to do some
modification in the case of monitoring
in the case of databases in the case of
security or in the case of a capacity
let's look into the capacity so here you
can actually do the modification so in
the capacity you can select the instance
type also by default it is T2 dot micro
but in case if your application requires
a larger type of an instance then you
can actually go for the instance type as
well similarly you can Define your Emi
IDs also because obviously for the
application to run you would require the
operating system also so you can select
that particular Ami ID for your
operating system as well let's cancel
that likewise you have many other
features that you can actually Define
here from the dashboard and you don't
have to go to the ec2 dashboard to do
the modifications now let's go and
create an environment let's assume that
we are going with the default
configuration so this is going to create
our environment the environment is being
created and you can get the environment
and the logs defined in the dashboard
itself so you'll see that the Beanstalk
environment is being initiated the
environment is being started and in case
if there would be any errors or if it is
deployed correctly you will get all the
logs here itself now the environments
are basically color coded so there are
different color codings that are defined
if you get the environment in a green
color that means everything is good to
go so here you can see that it has
created an elastic IP it has checked the
health of the environment now it has
created the security groups and that
would be an auto security groups created
by the mean stock and the environment uh
creation has been started you can see
that uh elastic bean stock as Amazon S3
storage bucket for your environment data
as well this is the URL through which
you will be accessing the environment
but right now we cannot do that since
the environment is being created let's
click on the application name and here
you can see that it is in a gray color
that means right now the build is being
done it is being created once it will be
successfully created it should change to
the green color and then we will be able
to access our environment using the URL
now if I move to the ec2 instances and
see in the ec2 dashboard if I see
whether the instance is being created by
the mean stock or not so let's see and
let's see what are the differences in
terms of creating an instance manually
and getting it created from the
Beanstalk so click on the ec2 let's go
to the old ec2 experience that's what we
are familiar with and let's see what's
there in the dashboard so here you can
see one running instance let's open that
and the XYZ environment which was
created from the Beanstalk is being
initiated the instance is being
initiated and that is something which is
being done by the mean stock itself we
have not gone to the dashboard and
created it manually now in the security
groups if you see that here the AWS mean
stock security groups are defined it has
the elastic IPS also defined so
everything is being created by the mean
stock itself right now let's go back to
the Beanstalk and let's look into the
status of our environment whether the
color coding has been changed from Gray
to green or not and here you can see the
environment is successfully created and
we have that environment colored in
green we'll access the environment and
it says it's a web server environment
its platform is node.js running on
64-bit Amazon Linux Ami and it's a
Samplers app sample application health
status is okay now the other thing is
that if you do not want to use the web
console the Management console to access
the main stock then the Beanstalk offers
you the elastic Beanstalk CLI as well so
you can install the command line
interface and then you have the command
reference so CLI command references that
you can actually play with and get your
applications deployed using the
Beanstalk itself so this is one of the
sample CLI commands that you can
actually look into now let's look into
the environment let's click on the
environment and we be represented with
the URL it says health is okay these are
the logs that you have to follow in case
if there are any issues the platform is
node.js that is what we selected now the
next thing is you just have to upload
and deploy your applications so just
click on upload and deploy select the
version label or the name select file
and wherever your application is hosted
at just select that upload it and deploy
your application you'll see that the
like your environment is created
similarly your application will be
deployed automatically on the instance
and from this URL you will be able to
view the output it is as simple as just
like you have to follow these four steps
now let's see whether the node.js
environment is running on our instance
before deploying an application so we'll
just click on this URL since the
Beanstalk has already opened up the
security groups or HTTP Port 80 for all
we can actually view that output
directly from the URL so we have the
node.js running that's visible here and
after that you just have to upload and
deploy your application and then from
that URL you can get the output now this
URL you can map it with the root 53
service so using the Route 53 DNS
Services the domain names can be pointed
to the elastic Beanstalk URL and from
there it can be pointed to the
applications that are running on the ec2
instance whether you wanted to point it
to the URL directly using the mean stock
you can do that otherwise as we saw in
the slides you can use the root 53
pointer to the load balancer and then
point it to the instances directly also
once it is created by the mean stock so
that was the demo guys with respect to
the bean stock and how we can actually
run the environments apart from the that
the operational task like system
operations you can manage all these
things from the environment dashboard
itself so you have the configurations
you have the logs you can actually check
the health status of your environment
you can do the monitoring and you can
actually get the alarms and the events
here so let's say if I wanted to if I
wanted to see the logs I can request for
the logs here itself and I'll be
represented with the full log report and
I can now download that log file and I
can view the logs so it's in the so we
have this bundle locks in the zip file
all right so if you want to see some
kind of logs with respect to elastic
bean stock activity it's in the form of
a notepad and here you can see what all
configurations the Beanstalk has done on
your environment on your instance
similarly you can go for the health
monitoring alarms events and all those
things in this lesson you'll learn all
about virtual private clouds and
understand their concept
you'll know the difference between
public private and elastic IP addresses
you'll learn about what a public and
private sudden that is
and you'll understand what an internet
gateway is and how it's used
you'll learn what route tables are and
when they are used
you'll understand what a Nat Gateway is
we'll take a look at security groups and
their importance
and we'll take a look at Network ACLS
and how they're used in Amazon VPC
we'll also review the Amazon VPC best
practices
and also the costs associated with
running a VPC in the Amazon Cloud
welcome to the Amazon virtual private
cloud and subnet section
in this section we're going to have an
overview of what Amazon VPC is and how
you use it and we're also going to have
a demonstration of how to create your
own custom virtual private cloud
we're going to look at IP addresses and
the use of elastic IP addresses in AWS
and finally we'll take a look at subnets
and there'll be a demonstration about
how to create your own subnets in an
Amazon VPC
and here are some other terms that are
used in vpcs
the subnets root tables elastic IP
addresses internet gateways Nat gateways
Network ACLS and security groups and in
the next sections we're going to take a
look at each of these and build our own
custom VPC that we'll use throughout
this course
Amazon defines a VPC as a virtual
private Cloud that enables you to launch
AWS resources into a virtual Network
that you've defined this virtual Network
closely resembles a traditional Network
that you'd operate in your own data
center but with the benefits of using
the scalable infrastructure of AWS
now VPC is your own virtual Network in
the Amazon Cloud which is used as a
network layer for your ec2 resources and
this is a diagram of the default VPC now
there's a lot going on here so don't
worry about that what we're going to do
is break down each of the individual
items in this default VPC over the
coming lesson
but what you need to know is that a VPC
is a critical part of the exam and you
need to know all the concepts and how it
differs from your own Networks
throughout this lesson we're going to
create our own VPC from scratch which
you'll need to replicate at the end of
this so you can do well in the exam
each VPC that you create is logically
isolated from other virtual networks in
the AWS Cloud it's fully customizable
you can select the IP address range
create subnet configure root tables set
up Network gateways Define security
settings using security groups and
network access control lists
so each Amazon account comes with a
default VPC that's pre-configured for
you to start using straight away so you
can launch your ec2 instances without
having to think about anything we
mentioned in the opening section A VPC
can span multiple availability zones in
a region
and here's a very basic diagram of a VPC
it isn't this simple in reality
and as we saw in the first section
here's the default Amazon VPC which
looks kind of complicated
but what we need to know at this stage
is that cidr block for the default VPC
is always a 16 subnet mask so in this
example it's
172.31.0.0 16. what that means is this
VPC will provide up to 65
536 private IP addresses
so in the coming sections we'll take a
look at all of these different items
that you can see on this default VPC but
why wouldn't you just use the default
VPC
well the default VPC is great for
launching new instances when you're
testing AWS
but creating a custom VPC allows you to
make things more secure and you can
customize your virtual Network as you
can Define your owner IP address range
you can create your own subnets that are
both private and public and you can
tighten down your security settings
by default instances that you launch
into a VPC can't communicate with your
own network
so you can connect your vpcs to your
existing data center using something
called Hardware VPN access so that you
can effectively extend your data center
into the cloud and create a hybrid
environment
now to do this you need a virtual
private Gateway and this is the VPN
concentrator on the Amazon side of the
VPN connection then on your side in your
data center you need a customer Gateway
which is either a physical device or a
software application that sits on your
side of the VPN connection
so when you create a VPN connection a
VPN tunnel comes up when traffic is
generated from your side of the
connection
VPC peering is an important concept to
understand
a peering connection can be made between
your own vpcs or with a VPC in another
AWS account as long as it's in the same
region
so what that means is if you have
instances in vpca they wouldn't be able
to communicate with instances in vpcb or
C and thus you set up appearing
connection
pairing is a one-to-one relationship a
VPC can have multiple peering
connections to other vpcs but and this
is important transitive peering is not
supported in other words
vpca can connect to B and C in this
diagram but C wouldn't be able to
communicate with B unless they were
directly appeared
also vpcs with overlapping cidrs cannot
be paired so in this diagram you can see
they all have different IP ranges which
is fine but if they had the same IP of
ranges they wouldn't be able to be
paired
and finally for this section if you
delete the default VPC you have to
contact AWS support to get it back again
so be careful with it and only delete it
if you have good reason to do so and
know what you're doing
this is a demonstration of how to create
a custom VPC
so here we are back at the Amazon web
services Management console and this
time we're going to go down to the
bottom left where the networking section
is I'm going to click on VPC
and the VPC dashboard will load up now
there's a couple of ways you can create
a custom VPC there's something called
the VPC wizard
which will build vpcs on your behalf
from a selection of different
configurations for example a VPC with a
single public subnet or a VPC with
public and private subnets now this is
great because you click a button type in
a few details and it does the work for
you however you're not going to learn
much or pass the exam if this is how you
do it so we'll cancel that and we'll go
to your vpcs
and we'll click on create a VPC
and we're presented with the Creator VPC
window
so let's give our VPC a name
I'm going to call that simply learn
underscore VPC
and this is the kind of naming
convention I'll be using throughout this
course
next we need to give it the cidr block
or the classes into domain routing block
so we're going to give it a very simple
110.0.0.0 and then we need to give it
the subnet mask so you're not allowed to
go larger than 15. so if I try to put 15
in it says no not going to happen
for a reference subnet mask of 15 would
give you around 131 000 IP addresses and
subnet 16 will give you 65
536 which is probably more than enough
for what we're going to do
next you get to choose the tenancy and
there's two options default and
dedicated if you select dedicated then
your ec2 instances will reside on
Hardware that's dedicated to you so your
performance is going to be great but
your cost is going to be significantly
higher so I'm gonna stick with default
and we just click on yes create
it'll take a couple of seconds
and then in our VPC dashboard we can see
our simply learned VPC has been created
now if we go down to the bottom here to
see the information about our new VPC we
can see it has a root table associated
with it
which is our default root table
so there it is and we can see that it's
only allowing local traffic at the
moment
we go back to the VPC again we can see
it's been given a default Network ACL
and we'll click on that and have a look
and you can see this is very similar to
what we looked at in the lesson
so it's allowing all traffic from all
sources inbound and outbound
now if we go to the subnet section
and just widen the VPC area here
you can see there's no subnets
associated with the VPC we've just
created
so that means we won't be able to launch
any instances into our VPC
and to prove it I'll just show you we'll
go to the ec2 section
so this is a glimpse into your future
this is what we'll be looking at in the
next lesson and we'll just quickly try
and launch an instance we'll select any
instance it doesn't matter
any size not important so here the
network section if I try and select
simply learn VPC it's saying no subnets
found this is not going to work
so we basically need to create some
subnets in our VPC
and that is what we're going to look at
in the next lesson
now private IP addresses are IP
addresses that are not reachable over
the internet and they're used for
communication between instances in the
same network
when you launch a new instance it's
given a private IP address and an
internal DNS hostname that resolves to
the private IP address of the instance
but if you want to connect to this from
the Internet it's not going to work
so then you'd need a public IP address
which is reachable from the internet you
can use public IP addresses for
communication between your instances and
the internet
each instance that receives a public IP
address is also given an external DNS
hostname
public IP addresses are associated with
your instances from the Amazon Pool of
public IP addresses
when you stop or terminate your instance
the public IP address is released and a
new one is associated when the instance
starts
so if you want your instance to retain
this public IP address
you need to use something called an
elastic IP address
an elastic IP address is a static or
consistent public IP address that's
allocated to your account and can be
Associated to and from your instances as
required an elastic IP address remains
in your account until you choose to
release it there is a charge associated
with an elastic IP address if it's in
your account but not actually allocated
to an instance
this is a demonstration of how to create
an elastic IP address
so we're back at the Amazon web services
Management console we're going to head
back down to the networking VPC section
and we'll get to the VPC dashboard on
the left hand side we'll click on
elastic IPS
now you'll see a list of any elastic IPS
that you have associated in your account
and remember any of the elastic IP
address that you're using that isn't
allocated to something you'll be charged
for so I have one available and that is
allocated to an instance currently so we
want to allocate a new address
and it reminds you that there's a charge
if you're not using it I'm saying yes
allocate
and it takes a couple of seconds
and there's our new elastic IP address
now we'll be using this IP address to
associate with the NAT Gateway when we
build that
AWS defines a subnet as a range of IP
addresses in your VPC
you can launch AWS resources into a
subnet that you select you can use a
public subnet for resources that must be
connected to the internet and a private
subnet for resources that won't be
connected to the internet
the netmask for the default Subnet in
your VPC is always 20 which provides up
to 4096 addresses per subnet and a few
of them are reserved for AWS use
a VPC can span multiple availability
zones but the subnet is always mapped to
a single availability Zone this is
important to know so here's our basic
diagram which we're now going to start
adding to so we can see the virtual
private cloud and you can see the
availability zones and now inside each
availability Zone we've rated a subnet
now you won't be able to launch any
instances unless there are subnets in
your VPC so it's good to spread them
across availability zones for redundancy
and failover purposes
there's two different types of subnet
public and private
you use a public subnet for resources
that must be connected to the internet
for example web servers
a public subnet is made public because
the main route table sends to subnets
traffic that is destined for the
internet to the internet gateway and
we'll touch on internet gateways next
private subnets are for resources that
don't need an internet connection or
that you want to protect from the
internet for example database instances
so in this demonstration we're going to
create some subnets a public and a
private subnet and we're going to put
them in our custom VPC in different
availability zones
so we'll head to networking and VPC
wait for the VPC dashboard to load up
we'll click on subnets
we'll go to create subnet
and I'm going to give the subnet a name
so it's good to give them meaningful
names so I'm going to call this first
one for the public subnet
10.0.1.0 and I'm going to put this one
in
the US East
one
B availability Zone
and I'm going to call that simply learn
public
so it's quite a long name I understand
but at least it makes it clear for what
what's going on in this example so we
need to choose a VPC so we obviously
want to put it in our simply learned VPC
and I said I wanted to put it in Us East
1B I'm using the North Virginia region
by the way
so we click on that then we need to give
it the cidr block
now as I mentioned earlier when I typed
in the name
that's the range I want to use and then
we need to give it the subnet mask and
we're going to go with
24. which should give us 251 addresses
in this range which obviously is going
to be more than enough if I try and put
a different value in that's unacceptable
to Amazon it's going to say
again it's going to give me an error and
tell me not to do that
let's go back to 24. click on the cut
and paste this by the way just because I
need to type something very similar for
the next one
click create
and it takes a few seconds
okay so there's our new subnet and I
just widen this
you can see so that's
the IP range that's the availability
Zone it's for simpler than and it's
public
so now we want to create
the private
so we put the name in I'm going to give
the private the IP address block
that
I'm going to put this one in Us East 1C
and it's going to be the private
subnet
obviously I want it to be in the same
VPC
credibility design of U.S east 1C
and we're going to give it
10.0.2.0 Dash
24.
and we'll click yes create
and again it takes a few seconds
okay so let me sort by name
so there we go we can see now we've got
our private subnet and our public subnet
okay let me just type in simply that
there we are so now you can see them
both there
and you can see they're both in the same
VPC
simply learn VPC
now if we go down to the bottom you can
see the root table associated with these
vpcs
and you can see that they can
communicate with each other internally
but there's no internet access
so that's what we need to do next in the
next lesson you're going to learn about
internet gateways and how we can make
these subnets have internet access
welcome to the networking section
in this section we're going to take a
look at internet gateways route tables
and NAC devices and we'll have a
demonstration on how to create each of
these AWS VPC items
so to allow your VPC the ability to
connect to the internet you need to
attach an internet gateway
and you can only attach one internet
gateway per VPC
so attaching the internet gateway is the
first stage in permitting internet
access to instances in your VPC now
here's our diagram again and now we've
added the internet gateway which is
providing the connection to the internet
to your VPC but before you can configure
internet correctly there's a couple more
steps
for an ec2 instance to be internet
connected you have to adhere to the
following rules
firstly you have to attach an internet
gateway to your VPC which we just
discussed
then you need to ensure that your
instances have public IP addresses or
elastic IP addresses so they're able to
connect to the internet
then you need to ensure that your
subnet's root table points to the
internet gateway
and you need to ensure that your network
access control and Security Group rules
allow relevant traffic to flow to and
from your instance so you need to allow
the rules to let in the traffic you want
for example HTTP traffic after the
demonstration for this section we're
going to look at how root tables Access
Control lists and security groups are
used
in this demonstration we're going to
create an internet gateway and attach it
to our custom VPC
so let's go to networking VPC
bring up the VPC dashboard
and on the left hand side we click on
internet gateways
so here's a couple of Internet gateways
I have already
um but I need to create a new one so
create internet gateway
I'll give it a name which is going to be
simply learn
internet gateway igw and I'm going to
click create so this is an internet
gateway which will connect a VPC to the
internet because at the moment our
custom VPC has no internet access
so there it is created
simpler than igw
but this state is detached because it's
not attached to anything so let me try
and attach it to a VPC
and it gives me an option of all the
vpcs that have no internet gateway
attached to them currently
so I only have one which is simpler than
VPC
yes attach
now you can see our VPC has internet
attached and you can see that down here
so let's click on that and it will take
us to our VPC
but before any instances in our VPC can
access the internet we need to ensure
that our subnet root table points to the
internet gateway
and we don't want to change the main
route table we want to create a custom
root table and that's what you're going
to learn about next
a root table determines where Network
traffic is directed
it does this by defining a set of rules
every subnet has to be associated with a
root table and a subnet can only be
associated with one root table
however multiple subnets can be
associated with the same root table
every VPC has a default route table and
it's good practice to leave this in its
original state and create a new root
table to customize the network traffic
routes associated with your VPC
so here's our example and we've added
two root tables the main root table and
the custom root table
the new routable or the custom root
table will tell the internet gateway to
direct internet traffic to the public
subnet
but the private subnet is still
Associated to the default route table
the main root table which does not allow
internet traffic to it
all traffic inside the private subnet is
just remaining local
in this demonstration we're going to
create a custom route table associated
with our internet gateway and Associate
our public subnet with it
so let's go to networking and VPC
the dashboard will load and we're going
to go to Route tables
now our VPC only has its main route
table at the moment the default one it
was given at the end time it was created
so we want to create a new root table
and we want to give it a name so we're
going to call it simply learn
and we call it root table rtb for sure
and then we get to pick which VPC we
want to put it in so obviously we want
to use simply learn VPC
so we click create
it'll take a couple of seconds and here
you are here's our new root table
so what we need to do now is change its
root so that it points to the internet
gateway so if we go down here to root
at a minute you can see it's just like
our main root table it just has local
access so we want to click on edit
and we want to add another root
so the destination is
the internet
which is all the zeros
and our Target and we click on this it
gives us the option of our internet
gateway which we want to do so now we
have internet access to this subnet
sorry to this root table
I'm going to click on Save
save for successful so now we can see
that as well as local access we have
internet access
now at the moment if we click on subnet
associations
you do not have any subnet associations
so basically both both our subnets the
public and private subnets are
associated with the main root table
which doesn't have internet access so we
want to change this so we'll click on
edit
and we want our public subnet to be
associated with this root table
click on Save
so it's just saving that
so now we can see that our public subnet
is associated with this route table
and this route table is associated with
the internet gateway so now anything we
launch into the public subnet will have
internet access
but what if we wanted our instances in
the private subnet to have internet
access
well there's a way of doing that with a
nap device and that's what we're going
to look at in the next lecture
you can use a Nat device to enable
instances in a private subnet to connect
to the Internet or other AWS services
but prevent the internet from initiating
connections with the instances in the
private subnet
so we talked earlier about public and
private subnets to protect your assets
from being directly connected to the
internet
for example your web server would sit in
the public Subnet in your database in
the private subnet which has no internet
connectivity
however your private sudden that
database instance might still need
internet access or the ability to
connect to other AWS resources if so you
can use a network address translation
device or a Nat device to do this
and that device forwards traffic from
your private subnet to the internet or
other AWS services and then sends the
response back to the instances
when traffic goes to the internet The
Source IP address of your instance is
replaced with the NAT device address and
when the internet traffic comes back
again then that device translates the
address to your instance's private IP
address
so here's our diagram which is getting
ever more complicated and if you look in
the public subnet you can see we've now
added a Nat device and you have to put
Nat devices in the public subnet so that
they get internet connectivity
AWS provides two kinds of nat devices
and that Gateway and in that instance
AWS recommends in that Gateway that it's
a managed service that provides better
availability and bandwidth than that
instances each Nat Gateway is created in
a specific availability Zone and is
implemented with redundancy in that zone
and that instance is launched from a Nat
Ami an Amazon machine image and runs as
an instance in your VPC so it's
something else you have to look after
whereas in that Gateway being a fully
managed service means once it's
installed you can pretty much forget
about it
and that Gateway must be launched into a
public subnet because it needs internet
connectivity it also needs an elastic IP
address which you can select at the time
of launch
once created you need to update the root
table associated with your private
subnet the point internet bound traffic
to the NAT Gateway this way the
instances in your private subnets can
communicate with the internet
so if you remember back to the diagram
when we had the custom root table which
was pointed to the internet gateway
now we're pointing our main root table
to the NAT Gateway so that the private
subnet also gets internet access but in
a more secure manner
welcome to the create and that Gateway
demonstration where we're going to
create a Nat Gateway so that the
instances in our private subnet can get
internet access
so we'll start by going to networking
and VPC
and the first thing we're going to do is
take a look at our subnets and you'll
see why shortly so here are our simply
learned subnets so this is the private
subnet that we want to give internet
access but if you remember from the
section
that gateways need to be placed in
public subnets so I'm just going to copy
the name of this subnet ID
for the public subnet and you'll see why
in a moment
so then we go to Nat gateways on the
left hand side
and we want to create a new Nat Gateway
so we have to put a subnet in there so
we want to choose our public subnet as
you can see
it truncates a lot of the subnet names
on this option so it's a bit confusing
so we know that we want to put it in our
simply learned VPC
in the public subnet but you can see
it's truncated so it's actually this one
at the bottom but what I'm going to do
is just placed in
the subnet ID which I copied earlier
so there's no confusion
then we need to give it an elastic IP
address now if you remember from the
earlier demonstration we created one so
let's select that but if you had an
allocated one you could click on the
create new EIP button
so we'll do that
okay so it's telling me my Nat Gateway
has been created and in order to use you
on that Gateway ensure that you edit
your root table to include a route with
a target of and then on that Gateway ID
so it's given us the option to click on
our edit root tables so we'll go
straight there now here's our here's our
root tables
now
here's the custom root table that we
created earlier and this is the default
the main route over which was created
when we launched out when we created our
VPC so we should probably give this a
name so that we know what it is so let
me just call this simply learn rtb
nine
so now we know that's our main root
table
so if you take a look at the main root
table and the subnet associations
you can see that our private subnet is
associated with this table
so what we need to do is put a root in
here that points to the NAT Gateway so
if we click on roots and edit
and we want to add another root and we
want to say that all traffic
can
either go to that simply in an internet
gateway which we don't want to do we
want to point it to a nap instance which
is this Nat ID here
and we click save
so now any instances launched in our
private subnet we'll be able to get
internet access via around that Gateway
welcome to the using security groups and
network ACL section
in this section we're going to take a
look at security groups and network ACLS
and we're going to have a demonstration
on how you create both of these items in
the Amazon web services console
a security group acts as a virtual
firewall that controls the traffic for
one or more instances
you add rules to each security group
that allow traffic to or from its
Associated instances
basically a security group controls the
inbound and outbound traffic for one or
more ec2 instances
security groups can be found on both the
ec2 and VPC dashboards in the AWS web
Management console we're going to cover
them here in this section and you'll see
them crop up again in the ec2 lesson
and here is our diagram and you can see
we've now added security groups to it
and you can see that ec2 instances are
sitting inside the security groups and
the security groups will control what
traffic Flows In and Out
so let's take a look at some examples
and we'll start with a security group
for a web server now obviously a web
server needs HTTP and https traffic has
a minimum to be able to access it
so here is an example of the security
group table and you can see we're
allowing HTTP and https
the ports that are associated with those
two and the sources and we're allowing
it from the internet we're basically
allowing all traffic to those ports
and that means any other traffic that
comes in on different ports would be
unable to reach the security group and
the instances inside it
let's take a look at an example for a
database server Security Group
now imagine you have a SQL Server
database then you would need to open up
the SQL Server Port so that people can
access it and which is Port 1433 by
default so we've added that to the table
and we've allowed the source to come
from the internet now because it's a
Windows machine you might want RDP
access so you can log on and do some
Administration so we've also added RDP
access to the security group now you
could leave it open to the internet but
that would mean anyone could try and
hack their way into your box so in this
example we've added a source IP address
of
10.0.0.0 so only IP ranges from that
address can RDP to the instance
now there's a few rules associated with
security groups by default security
groups allow all outbound traffic so if
you want to tighten that down you can do
so in a similar way to you can Define
the inbound traffic
Security Group rules are always
permissive you can't create rules that
deny access so you're allowing access
rather than denying it
security groups are stateful so if you
send a request from your instance the
response traffic for that request is
allowed to flow in regardless of the
inbound Security Group rules
and you can modify the rules of a
security group at any time and the rules
are applied immediately
welcome to the create Security Group
demonstration where we're going to
create two security groups one to host
DB servers and one the host web servers
now if you remember from the best
practices section it said it was always
a good idea to tier your applications
into security groups and that's exactly
what we're going to do
so if we go to networking and VPC to
bring up the VPC dashboard
on the left hand side under security we
click on security groups now you can
also get to security groups from the ec2
dashboard as well
so here's a list of my existing security
groups but we want to create a new
security group and we're going to call
it
simply learn
web server
SG Security Group and we'll give the
group name as the same and our
description is going to be simply learn
web servers
security groups
okay and then we need to select our VPC
now it defaults to the default VPC but
obviously we want to put it in our
simply learned VPC so we click yes
create
takes a couple of seconds
and there it is there's our new Security
Group
now if we go down to the rules the
inbound rules
you can see there are none so by default
a new security group has no inbound
rules
but what about outbound rules
if you remember from the lesson
a new Security Group by default allows
all traffic to be outbound
and there you are all traffic
has destination of everywhere so all
traffic is allowed we're going to add
some rules so let's click on inbound
rules click on edit
now this is going to be a web server so
if we click on the drop down
we need to give it http
so you can either choose custom TCP Rule
and type in your own port ranges or you
can just use the ones they have for you
so http
this pre-populates the port range and
then here you can add the source
now if I click on it it's giving me the
option of saying allow
access from different security groups
so you could create a security group and
say I only accept traffic from a
different Security Group which is a nice
way of securing things down you could
also put in here just your IP address so
that only you could do HTTP requests to
the instance but because it's a web
server
we want people to be able to see our
website otherwise it's not going to be
much use so we're going to say all
traffic so all source
traffic can access our instance on Port
http 80.
I want to add another rule because we
also want to do https
which is
hiding from it
there we are and again we want to do
the same
and also because this is going to be a
Linux instance we want to be able to
connect to the Linux instance to do some
work and configuration so we need to
give it SSH access
and again it would be good practice to
tie it down to your specific IP or an IP
range but we're just going to do all for
now and then we click on Save
and there we go there we have our ranges
so now we want to create our security
group for our DB servers so let's click
create Security Group
and then we'll go through and give it a
similar name
simply learn
TB servers s key
and the description it's going to be
simpler than DB servers security grade
and our VPC is obviously going to be
simpler than VPC
just click yes create wait a few seconds
and here's our new security group as you
can see it has no inbound Rules by
default and outbound rules allow all
traffic
so this is going to be a SQL Server
database server and so we need to allow
SQL Server traffic into the instance
so we need to give
it Microsoft SQL Port access Now the
default port for Microsoft SQL Server is
now in reality I'd probably change the
port the SQL server was running on to
make it more secure but we'll go with
this for now and then the source so we
could choose the IPA ranges again but
what we want to do is place the DB
server in the private subnet and allow
the traffic to come from the web server
so the web server will accept traffic
and the web server will then go to the
database to get the information it needs
to display on its web on the website or
if people are entering information into
the website we want the information to
be stored in our DB server so basically
we want to say that this the DB servers
can only accept SQL Server traffic from
the web server Security Group
so we can select the simply then web
server Security Group as the source
traffic
but Microsoft SQL Server data
so we'll select that now our SQL Server
is obviously going to be a Windows
instance so from time to time we might
not we might need to log in and
configure it so we want to give RDP
access
now again you would probably put a
specific IP range in there we're just
going to do all traffic for now then we
click save
and there we are so now we have two
security groups
DB servers and web servers
a network ACL is a network access
control list
and it's an optional layer of security
for your VPC that acts as a firewall for
controlling traffic in and out of one or
more of your subnets
you might set up Network ACLS with rules
similar to your security groups in order
to add an additional layer of security
to your VPC
here is our Network diagram and we've
added Network ACLS to the mix now you
can see they sit somewhere between the
root tables and the subnets
this diagram makes it a little bit
clearer and you can see that a network
ACL sits in between a root table and a
subnet
and also you can see an example of the
default Network ACL
which is configured to allow all traffic
to flow in and out of the subnets to
which It's associated
each Network ACL includes a whose rule
number is an Asterix this rule ensures
that if a packet doesn't match any of
the other numbered rules it's denied you
can't modify or remove this rule
so if you take a look at this table you
can see on the inbound some traffic
would come in and it would look for the
first rule which is 100 and that's
saying I'm allowing all traffic from all
sources so that's fine the traffic comes
in if that rule 100 wasn't there it
would go to the Asterix Rule and the
Aztecs rule is saying traffic from all
sources is denied
let's take a look at the network ACL
rules
each Subnet in your VPC must be
associated with an ACL if you don't
assign it to a custom ACL it will
automatically be Associated to your
default ACL
a subnet can only be associated with one
ACL however an ACL can be associated
with multiple subnets
an ACL contains a list of numbered rules
which are evaluated in order starting
with the lowest as soon as a rule
matches traffic it's applied regardless
of any higher numbered rules that may
contradict it
AWS recommends incrementing your rules
by a factor of 100 so there's plenty of
room to implement new rules at a later
date
unlike security groups ACLS are
stateless responses to allowed inbound
traffic are subject to the rules for
outbound traffic
welcome to the network ACL demonstration
where we're just going to have an
overview of ACLS where they are in the
dashboard
now you don't need to know a huge amount
about them for the exam you just need to
know how they work and where they are so
let's go to networking and VPC
and on when the dashboard loads on the
left hand side under security there's
Network ACLS let's click on that now you
can see some ACLS that are in my my AWS
account so we want the one that's
associated with our simply learn VPC so
if we extend this VPC
column
that's our Network ACLS simply then VPC
now let's give it a name because it's
not very clear to see otherwise also I'm
kind of an obsessive tagger so let's
call it simply learn ACL and click on
the tick so there we go so now it's much
easier to see
so if we click on inbound rules so this
is exactly what we showed you in the
lesson
the rule is 100 so that's the first rule
that's going to get evaluated and it's
saying allow all traffic from all
sources
and the outbound rules are the same
so if you wanted to tighten down the new
rule you could say edit we would give it
a new rule number say which would be 200
so you should always increment them in
100 so that means if you had 99 more
rules you needed to put in place you'd
have space to put them in in between
these two
and then you could do whatever you
wanted you could say you know we are
allowing HTTP access from
all traffic
and we're allowing or you could say
actually you know what we're going to
deny it so this is the way of
blacklisting traffic into your VPC
now I'm not going to save that because
we don't need it
but this is where Network ACLS sit and
this is where you would make any changes
it's also worth having a look at the
subnet associations with your ACL
so we have two subnets in our simply
learn VPC so we would expect to see both
of them associated with this network ACL
because it's the default
and there they are there's both our
public and our private subnets are
associated and you can also see up here
on the
on the dashboard it says default so this
is telling us this is our default ACL
if you did want to create a new network
ACL you would click create network ACL
just give it a name it's just a new ACL
and then you would associate it with
your VPC so we would say simply learn
VPC
takes a few seconds
and there we are there we have our new
one now you can see this one says
default no because it obviously isn't
the default ACL for our simply learn VPC
and it has no subnets associated with it
so let's just delete that because we
don't need it but there you are there's
a very brief overview of network pcls
welcome to the Amazon VPC best practices
and costs where we're going to take a
look at the best practices and the costs
associated with the Amazon virtual
private cloud
always use public and private subnets
you should use private subnets to secure
resources that don't need to be
available to the internet such as
database services
to provide secure internet access to the
instances that reside in your private
subnets you should provide a Nat device
when using Nat devices you should use a
Nat Gateway over Nat instances because
there are managed service and require
less Administration effort
you should choose your cidr blocks
carefully Amazon VPC can contain from 16
to 65
536 IP addresses so you should choose
your cidr block according to how many
instances you think you'll need
you should also create separate Amazon
vpcs for development staging test and
production or create one Amazon VPC with
separate subnets with a subnet each for
production development staging and test
you should understand the Amazon VPC
limits there are various limitations on
the VPC components for example you're
allowed five vpcs per region
200 subnets per VPC
200 route tables per VPC
500 security groups per VPC
50 in and outbound rules per VPC
however some of these rules can be
increased by raising a ticket with AWS
support
you should use security groups and
network ACLS to secure the traffic
coming in and out of your VPC Amazon
advises to use security groups for
whitelisting traffic and network ACLS
for blacklisting traffic
Amazon recommends tiering your security
groups you should create different
security groups for different tiers of
your infrastructure architecture inside
VPC
if you have web tears and dbtiers you
should create different security groups
for each of them
creating tierwise security groups will
increase the infrastructure security
inside the Amazon VPC
so if you launch all your web servers in
the web server security group that means
it'll automatically all have HTTP and
https open conversely the database
Security Group will have SQL Server
ports already open
you should also standardize your
Security Group naming conventions
following a security group naming
convention allows Amazon VPC operation
and management for large-scale
deployments to become much easier
always span your Amazon VPC across
multiple subnets in multiple
availability zones inside a region this
helps in architecting high availability
inside your VPC
if you choose to create a hardware VPN
connection to your VPC using virtual
private Gateway you are charged for each
VPN connection hour that your VPN
connection is provisioned and available
each partial VPN connection hour
consumed is billed as a full hour
you'll also incur standard AWS data
transfer charges for all data
transferred via the VPN connection
if you choose to create a Nat Gateway in
your VPC you are charged for each Nat
Gateway hour that your NAT Gateway is
provisioned and available data
processing charges apply for each
gigabyte processed through in that
Gateway each partial Nat Gateway hour
consumed is billed as a full hour
this is the practice assignment for
designing a custom VPC where you'll
create a custom VPC using the concepts
learned in this lesson
using the concepts learned in this
lesson recreate the custom VPC as shown
in the demonstrations
the VPC name should be simply learned
VPC the cidr block should be
10.0.0.016 there should be two subnets
one public with a range of
10.0.1.0 and one private with a range of
10.0.2.0 and they should be placed in
separate availability zones
there should be one internet gateway and
one that Gateway and also one custom
route table for the public subnet
also create two security groups simply
learn web server Security Group and
simply learn DB server Security Group
so let's review the key takeaways from
this lesson
Amazon virtual private cloud or VPC
enables you to launch AWS resources into
a virtual Network that you've defined
this virtual Network closely resembles a
traditional Network that you'd operate
in your own data center but with the
benefits of using scalable
infrastructure of AWS
there are three types of IP address in
AWS
a private IP address this is an IP
address that's not reachable over the
internet and it's used for communication
between instances in the same network
a public IP address is reachable from
the internet which you can use for
communication between your instances and
the internet
and there's an elastic IP address this
is a static public persistent IP address
that persists after an instance restarts
whereas a public IP address is reassed
associated after each restart
Amazon defines a setner as a range of IP
addresses in your VPC you can launch AWS
resources into a subnet that you select
and a subnet is always mapped to a
single availability Zone use a public
subnet for resources that must be
connected to the internet and a private
subnet for resources that won't be
connected to the internet
to allow your VPC the ability to connect
to the internet you need to attach an
internet gateway to it and you can only
attach one internet gateway per VPC
a root table determines where Network
traffic is directed it does this by
defining a set of rules
every subnet has to be associated with a
root table and a subnet can only have an
association with one root table however
multiple subnets can be Associated to
the same root table
and you can use a Nat device to enable
instances in a private subnet to connect
to the Internet or other AWS services
but and that device will prevent the
internet from initiating connections
with instances inside your private
subnet
a security group acts as a virtual
firewall that controls the traffic for
one or more instances you add rules to
each security group that allow traffic
to or from its Associated instances
a network access control list or network
ACL is an optional layer of security for
your VPC that acts as a firewall for
controlling traffic in and out of one or
more of your subnets
let's look into what we have in audition
so what's in it for you we would be
covering what is AWS
why do we need AWS sagemaker what is AWS
sagemaker services
what are the benefits of using the AWS
sagemaker
machine learning with AWS sagemaker how
to train a model with AWS stagemaker how
to validate a model with AWS
and the companies that are using AWS
stagemaker along with that we will be
covering up one live demo on the AWS
platform
now let's understand what is AWS so what
is AWS it's an Amazon web services it's
a largest or most widely used public
Cloud platform
offered by Amazon it provides services
over the internet
AWS Services can be used to build
Monitor and deploy any type of
application in the cloud
AWS also uses the subscription pricing
model that means you only pay for
whatever the services you use for
now why do we need AWS stage maker let's
look into it so let's consider an
example of one of the company that is
proquest now before AWS sagemaker
the proquest is a Global Information
content and technology company
that provides valuable content such as
ebooks newspapers Etc to the users
before AWS sagemaker the proquest
requirement was to have a better user
experience maximum relevant search
results now after AWS stage maker they
were able to achieve those results so
they achieved more appealing media user
experience they achieved more relevant
search results for the users now what do
we mean by AWS sagemaker why this
service is primarily used so Amazon
sagemaker is a cloud machine learning
platform that helps users in building
training tuning and deploying machine
learning models in a production ready
hosted environment
so it's kind of a machine learning
service which is already hosted on the
AWS platform now what are the benefits
of using AWS sagemaker uh the key
benefits of using aw sagemaker are it
reduces machine learning data cost so
you can do the cost optimization
while running this particular service on
the AWS
all ml components are stored in a
particular place in a dashboard so they
can be managed together
highly scalable so it can be scalable on
you can scale this particular service on
the Fly
it trains the models quite faster
maintains the uptime so you can be
assured that your workloads will be
running all the time it will be
available all the time
High data security so security becomes a
major concern on the cloud platforms and
it ensures that you have the high data
security along with that you can do a
data transfer to different AWS services
like S3 bucket and all with this simple
data transfer techniques
now machine learning with AWS sagemaker
let's look into it
so machine learning with AWS sagemaker
is a three-step function
so one is to build second is to test and
tune the model and third is to deploy
the model now with the build it provides
more than 15 widely used ml algorithms
for training purpose now to build a
model you can collect and prepare
training data or you can select from the
Amazon S3 bucket also choose and
optimize the required algorithm so some
of the algorithms that you can select
are k-means linear regressions logistic
regression sagemaker helps developers to
customize ml instances with the Jupiter
notebook interface in the test and tune
you have to set up and manage the
environment for training so you would
need some sample data to train the model
so train and tune a model
with the Amazon sagemaker sagemaker
implements hyper parameter tuning by
adding a suitable combination of
algorithm parameters also it divides the
training data and stores that in the
Amazon S3 S3 is a simple storage service
which is primarily used for storing the
objects and the data hence it is used
for storing and recovering data over the
internet and Below you can see that AWS
stage maker uses Amazon S3 to store data
as it's safe and secure also it divides
the training data and stores in Amazon
S3 where the training algorithm code is
stored in the ECR ECR stands for elastic
container registry which is primarily
used for containers and Dockers ECR
helps users to save Monitor and deploy
Docker and the containers later
sagemaker sets up a cluster for the
input data train set and stores it in
the Amazon S3 itself so this is done by
the sagemaker itself after that you need
to deploy it so suppose you want to
predict limited data at a time you use
Amazon sagemaker hosting services for
that okay but if you want to get
prediction for an entire data set prefer
using Amazon sagemaker batch transform
now the last step that is to deploy the
model
so once tuning is done models can be
deployed to sagemaker endpoints
and in the end point real-time
prediction is performed so you would
have some data which you would reserve
and validate your model whether it is
working correctly or not now evaluate
your model and determine whether you
have achieved your business goals now
the other aspect is how we can train a
model with AWS stage maker
so this is basically a flow diagram
which shows you how to train a model
with the AWS stage maker and here we
have used couple of Services of an AWS
to get that done
so model training in AWS stage maker is
done on machine learning compute
instances and here we can see there are
two machine learning compute instances
used as helper code and the training
code
along with that we are using two S3
buckets and the ECR for the container
registry
now let's look into what are the ways to
train the model as per the slides
So Below are the following requirements
to train a model so here in the diagram
you can see these are the following
requirements to train a model
the URL of an Amazon S3 bucket where the
training data is stored that is
mentioned
the computer sources on machine learning
compute instances so these are all your
machine learning compute instances
then the URL of an Amazon S3 bucket
where the output will be stored
and the path of AWS elastic container
registry where the code data is safe the
inference code image lies in the elastic
container registry now what are these
calls these are called as the training
jobs
now when a user trains a model in Amazon
sagemaker he she creates a training job
so we need to First create a training
job and then the input data is fetched
from the specified Amazon S3 bucket once
the training job is built Amazon
sagemaker launches the ml compute
instances so these compute instances
will be launched once the training job
is built then it trains the model with
the training code and the data set and
it shows the output and model articrafts
in the AWS S3 bucket so this is done
automatically now here the helper code
performs a task when the training code
fails the interference code which is in
the elastic container registry consists
of multiple linear sequence containers
that process the request for inference
on data the ec2 container registry is a
container registry that helps users to
say Monitor and deploy container images
whereas container images are the ready
applications
once the data is trained the output is
stored in the specified Amazon S3 bucket
so here you can see the output will be
stored here to prevent your algorithm
being deleted save the data in Amazon's
sagemaker critical system
which can process your your ml compute
instances now how to validate a model
let's look into it so you can evaluate
your model
using offline or using the historical
data so first thing is that you can do
the offline testing to validate a model
you can do an online testing with the
live data so if you have a live data
coming or real-time streams coming you
can validate a model from there itself
you can validate using a holdout set and
also you can validate using the k-fold
validation now use historical data to
send requests to the model
through the jupyter notebook in Amazon
sagemaker for the evaluation online
testing with live data deploys multiple
models into the endpoints of Amazon
sagemaker and directs live traffic to
the model for validation validating
using a holdout set is part of the data
is set aside where which is called hold
out set so the part of the data is left
which is basically called as the holdout
set
this data is not used for the model
training so later when the model is
trained
with the remaining input data and
generalize the data based on what is
learned initially so whatever the data
which is left out will be used for
validating a model because we have not
used the data while training a model the
k-fold validation is the input data is
split into two parts one part is called
K which is the validation data for
testing the model and the other part is
K minus 1. which is used as a training
data now based on the input data the
machine learning model evaluates the
final output now the companies that are
using AWS stage maker one is the ADP so
you must be knowing about ADB zalando
Dow Jones which is the stock market
proquest
and the Intuit now let's look into the
demo that how we can actually run the
AWS stage maker so we'll use the r
algorithm and then package the algorithm
as a container for building training and
deploying a model
we are going to use the Jupiter notebook
for that for model building for model
training for model deployment and the
code for the demo is in the below link
so you can see here that from this link
you can get the code for the demo let's
try to
do a demo on the AWS
now I would be using a link which is
provided by Amazon to build train and
deploy the machine learning model on the
sagemaker as you can see on my screen
and in this tutorial you would have some
steps where you can put those steps and
the code python codes into your AWS
stagemaker Jupiter lab
so in this tutorial you will learn how
to use Amazon sagemaker to build train
and deploy a machine learning model and
for that we will use the popular XT
boost ml algorithm for this exercise
so first of all what you need to do is
you have to go to the AWS console and
there you have to create a notebook
instance so in this tutorial you will be
creating a notebook instance you will
prepare the data train the model to
learn from the data deploy the model
evaluate your ml models performance and
once all those activities are done then
we'll see how we can actually remove all
the resources in order to prevent the
extra costing
now the first step is we have to enter
to the Amazon sagemaker console so here
you can see I'm already logged in into
the sagemaker console you can click on
the services
search for the sagemaker here
and here you get the Amazon sagemaker
service
now the next step is
that we have to create a notebook
instance so we will select the notebook
instance from the sagemaker service and
then after the notebook instance is
selected we'll put a name to our
instance and we'll create a new IM role
for that
so let's wait for the sagemaker studio
to open
so here you can see the studio is open
and you just have to click on the
notebook instances
and here you have to create a notebook
instance so here you can see couple of
notebook instances have already been
created one of them is in service so
this is The Notebook instance that we
are going to use for uh creating the
demo model
I'll show you how you can create a
notebook instance you just have to click
on create notebook instance button and
put your notebook instance name so
sagemaker 987 or we can put it as model
we'll go with notebook instance type as
default which is mlt2.media
and in the permission and encryptions
under the IM role we'll click on create
a new IM role
now why we are creating a new IM rule so
that we can allow the sagemaker to
access any S3 bucket that has been
created on our account
just click on create a role and here you
would see that the new IM role will be
created with the set of permissions
then rest of the things we'll keep it as
default and then you just have to click
on create a notebook instance
The Notebook instance creation takes
some time so you just have to wait for a
couple of minutes to get that in service
we already have one of the notebook
instance that has been created so we
will be using uh that to create a demo
now going back to the steps so these are
the steps that we have already performed
now once the notebook instance is
created then we have to prepare the data
so in this step we will be using the
sagemaker notebook instance to
pre-process the data that would require
to train the machine learning model
and for that we would be opening up the
jupyter notebook and then we have to
select an environment a kernel
environment in the Jupiter notebook that
would be conda underscore python 3. so
let's follow these steps go back to the
sage maker click on the notebook
instances
select the running notebook instance and
here you would select the open Jupiter
lab
now here you would see that this
sagemaker would try to open up the
Jupiter Notepad
and we would be performing all our
inputs into that jupyter notebook
and executing the results there itself
so just wait for the notebook to open
now here you can see the Jupiter lab
notebook has been open so I would be
selecting one of the notebook that has
been created
so this one so likewise you can create
your own notebook also how you can do
that
first of all let me select the kernel
environment so I would be selecting
Corner underscore Python 3 and just
click on select so how you can create
your own notebook just have to click on
file click on new and here you can
select the notebook just name your
notebook select the environment contact
underscore Python 3 to run this demo
so I have my notebook open so in the
tabs I would be putting up the python
codes and I would be executing those
codes to get the output directly
so the next step is
to prepare the data train the ml model
and deploy it we will need to import
some libraries and Define a few
environment variables in the Jupiter
notebook environment so I would be
copying this code
which you can see that would try to
import numpy pandas these are all
required to run the python
syntax so just
copy this code
and paste it into your
notebook
right so once you do that execute your
code
and here you can see that you get the
output which is
that it has imported all the necessary
libraries that have been defined in the
code
now the next step is we would create an
S3 bucket
into the S3 service and for that you
have to copy this python code just that
you have to edit it so you have to
specify this bucket name that you want
to get created
so here I would
provide the bucket name which should be
unique
should not overlap
so something like CH maker
Dash demo
is the name that I have selected for the
bucket and now you have to execute that
code
it says that the S3 bucket has been
created successfully with the name
sagemaker Dash demo 9876 so this is
something which you can verify so you
can go to the S3 service and there you
can verify whether the bucket has been
created or not now the next task is that
we need to download the data
to the AWS sagemaker instance and load
it into the data frame and for that we
have to follow this URL so from this URL
which is buildtrain deploy machine
learning model would have a data in the
form of bank underscore clean.csv and
this will be deployed onto our sagemaker
instance we'll copy this code
and paste it here
and execute the code
so change that it has successfully
downloaded bank underscoreclean.csv
which is which has the data inside it
and that has to be loaded into the
sagemaker data frame successfully
now we have a data to build and train
our machine learning model
so what we are going to do we are going
to shuffle the data and we are going to
split it one into the training data set
and the other one into test data set
so for the training data set we are
going to use 70 of the customers that
are listed in the CSV file and 30 of the
customers in the CSV file data will be
using it as a test data to train the
model so we'll copy the following code
into a new code cell and then we are
going to run that code cell
so I'll just copy it
for training the data so that we can
segregate the data model 70 for building
the model and 30 for testing the data so
click on
run the execution and here you can see
that we got the output successfully
now
we have to train the model from the data
so how we are going to train that model
and for that we will use sagemaker
rebuilt XG boost model which is an
algorithm
so you will need to reformat the header
and First Column of the training data
and load the data from the S3 bucket so
what I'll do is I'll copy
this syntax
and paste it
in the node cell
so it has the train data it would train
the model
click on run execution
now it is changing the S3 input class
which will be renamed to training input
because now we are training the model
with the training data
so we just have to wait for some time
till it gets executed completely
now the next thing is that we need to
set up the amazon sagemaker session to
create an instance of the xgboost model
so here we are going to create this
sagemaker session say we are going to
create an instance of the XT boost model
which is an estimator
so just copy that copy that code
and paste it here
executed
and here you can see that it will start
it has basically changed the parameter
image name to the image underscore URI
in the sagemaker python SDK V2
now we'll follow the next step that is
with the data loaded in the XT boost
estimator we'll set up train the model
using gradient optimization
and
we'll copy the following code and that
would actually start the training of the
model
so copy this code
and this would actually
start training the model using our input
data that we have reserved 70 of that
data that we have reserved for training
the model so just copy that
again initiate the execution and it will
start the training job
now we'll deploy the model and for that
I would copy the deploy code put that in
the cell
and execute it
so
it says parameter image will be renamed
to image URI and using already existing
models so XD boost was deployed already
if you have not done that if you're
doing it the first time so it will
initiate another XT post instead so
where you can find your XT boost and
points created you just have to scroll
down and here under the inference click
on the endpoints and you should find the
XT boost endpoints defined here
so here you can see that today I have
created one XT boost
endpoint and that is uh now in process
of creating so just refresh it
so it is uh still created it is going to
take some time to get that in service
now our endpoint is in service state so
now we can use it so going forward with
the next steps we will try to predict
whether the customer in the test data
enroll for the bank product or not for
that we are going to copy this code put
that in the Jupiter cell function
and execute it
so here it gives you the output that it
has actually evaluated and the same
output we got in the screenshot of the
demo as well
now we are going to evaluate the model
performance so what we are going to do
we are going to get the prediction done
so based on the prediction we can
conclude that you predicted a customer
that will enroll for a certificate of
deposit accurately for 90 of the
customers in the test data with the
Precision of 65 percent for enrolled and
90 which are which haven't enrolled for
it so for that we are going to copy this
code
and executed here in the cell
so if it is predicted correctly that
means our model is working absolutely
fine so here you can say the overall
classification rate is 89.5 percent and
there is the accurate
prediction that has been made by the
model and that's what the output we can
see here
in the screenshot of a model so that
means our model is absolutely working
fine it has been built deployed and
trained correctly now the next thing is
that once you are done with that you
terminate your resources and for that
you just have to copy
uh this code and put that in the cell
function so that the additional
resources and the endpoints and the
buckets that have been created by the
Jupiter notepad should be uh
terminated so that you would not be
incurred with the extra costing so just
execute it and here you would see that
it is prior to it would try to terminate
all the additional resources that we
have created from the Jupiter notebook
let's look into what we have in the
cloud front
so what's in it for you we would be
covering up the concept of what is AWS
what was earlier uh before AWS
cloudfront after AWS cloudfront what
were the services that were introduced
how it benefited what do we mean by AWS
cloudfront benefits of the using AWS
cloudfront and how AWS cloudfront
actually is known as a Content delivery
service the name of the companies that
are using AWS cloudfront and we would be
covering up on live demo
now AWS is the Amazon web services it's
a cloud service provider that basically
offers a multiple Services variety of
services such as compute power database
storage networking and other resources
so that you can create your Solutions on
the cloud and help the business grow now
with AWS you only pay for whatever the
services you use so for example if you
are using a service for a couple of
hours then you pay for only that many
hours that you have use that service
before AWS Cloud front so there is an
example that we are going to talk and
that is you must be aware of an
application called Spotify so when you
used to access Spotify and when you
click on it it kept on loading and at
the end you used to get the error and
the error was that the connection failed
and why you received that error because
of a latency issue probably a network
error right so how you can solve these
kind of a latency issues and that is
also going to these kind of an issues
are also going to impact the performance
of an application
so with the introduction of AWS cloud
from this problem of loading the
application got result so after AWS
cloudfront with the help of adult based
cloudfront Spotify gives the facility of
updating new features taxes to million
songs that you can access instantly
so with the use of AWS cloudfront or the
latency issues were solved and
successfully you can basically access
your application now what we mean by AWS
cloudfront so AWS cloudfront is a
globally distributed Network that is
offered by AWS Amazon web services which
securely delivers content to the end
users across any geography with a higher
transfer speed and an improve or a low
latency now what are the benefits of AWS
cloudfront there are multiple benefits
one is the cost effective so it helps
you to do the cost optimization when you
use the cloud front it is time saving so
it is implemented easily and also lot of
issues with respect to accessing the
application with respect to latency and
all can be resolved
content privacy so the content is placed
to the end users and also to the
cloudfront servers in a secured manner
in a secured way it is highly
programmable and you can make the
changes amend the changes on the Fly
and you can Target any location any
geography across the globe along with
that it helps you to get the content
delivered quickly now how AWS cloudfront
delivers the content let's look into the
architecture
so this is a flow and the flow is with
respect to how the user is going to get
a content from the cloud front now the
client first access our website by
typing a URL on the browser and in the
step one it acts tries to access the
application then the client requests
when the website is open the client
request for an object to download such
as for example a particular file now at
that time the DNS routes user request to
download that file to AWS cloudfront
the AWS Cloud front connects to the
nearest Edge locations Edge locations
are basically the servers where it
caches
the files documents and the web codes
AWS cloudfront connects to its nearest
Edge location in order to serve the user
the request
at Edge location
AWS cloudfront looks for its requested
cache file once the file is found let's
say if the file is available in the case
of an edge location AWS cloudfront then
sends the file to the user otherwise if
the file is not found in the cache
memory of an edge location
AWS cloudfront compares the requirement
with the specification and share it with
a respected server that means a web
server or a server where the file is
actually available the server the web
server responds to the edge location by
sending the file back to the cloud front
edge location
and then as soon as the AWS cloudfront
receives the file it shares with the
client also adds the file to the cache
of an edge location for a future
reference this is how the flow of a
cloud front is now
the name of the companies that are using
the AWS cloudfront
so one of them is jio 7 app it is which
is a very popular app so it uses Amazon
cloudfront to deliver 15 petabytes of
audio and video to its subscribers
globally which is a huge data Sky News
uh it uses the service in order to unify
the content for faster distribution to
script subscribers
or the discovery Communications uh also
uses the cloudfront it uses the service
for delivering API static asset and also
the dynamic content
and then the TV1 EU streaming Europe is
basically also uses the cloudfront
service that helps in improving latency
and performance
that results in fastest delivery of
content
now let's look into the demo how to use
cloudfront to serve private S3 bucket as
a website
now I'm going to
run a cloudfront distribution demo on
the AWS console and uh we basically try
to deliver the content from a private S3
bucket and then map that with the domain
name using the root 53 service
so what we need for this demo we would
need a domain URL we would need
Route 53 service
we would need
Cloud front we have to create a
cloudfront distribution and that will be
linked with our S3 bucket the private S3
bucket right and in the S3 bucket we
would have one HTML file the index.html
file
so let's uh move into AWS console
so right now I have opened up the
cloudfront distribution
and here you can see that couple of
distributions have already been created
so what I'm going to do I'm going to
create a distribution
now there are two types of delivery
method for your content one is the web
distribution and the other one is rtmp
rtmp stands for Real Time audio or video
distribution it's basically used for
distribution of a media content or a
media file which are available in the S3
bucket
here we are going to select a web
distribution because primarily we will
be using files which uses protocols HTTP
or the https
so you have to click on get started and
in the origin domain name you have to
specify the bucket where your code is
available
so I have a bucket already created here
you can see and what you need to do is
you have to create a bucket with a URL
name or the domain name which you would
be mapping with the Route 53 service
so this is a bucket that has already
been created let me show you in a new
tab
so here you have to go to the storage
under the storage you have to select the
S3 bucket
let's open the link in the new tab and
let's look into how we can create the S3
buckets
now here are a couple of buckets already
created I have created one bucket with
the domain name that I'm going to use
and map it with the root 53 service
so that is basically mapped to a region
which is in Ohio
and if you open up this bucket
here you will find an HTML web page the
index.html has been already added
right so similarly you have to create a
bucket with a domain and an index.html
page needs to be uploaded there
now again we'll go to the cloud front we
will try to create a distribution
just have to click on create
distribution
select a web delivery method
select An Origin domain which is
sunshinelearning.in
and origin path you don't have to
specify origin ID is this one so
basically when you define An Origin
domain name automatically the origin ID
appears
you can customize this origin ID as per
your requirement also
so rest of the things primarily we keep
it as a default settings only until and
unless if we require some customized
settings to be done
so let's say if you have to change the
cache Behavior settings you can do that
otherwise we'll keep it as default
now in the distribution setting you can
either select use all Edge locations for
the best performance so what does AWS uh
basically do here it uses all the edge
locations which are associated with AWS
across the globe otherwise you can
specify based on the regions also right
apart from that if you want to enable
firewalls or the access controllers you
can specify here
and then
what you need to do is in the default
root object here you have to specify
your index.html
pitch which is in the S3 bucket
the distribution state has to be enabled
and if you want to use IPv6 as well you
need to enable it
click on create distribution
now you you can see here a distribution
has been created it's in progress and it
is enabled
and it takes around 15 to 20 minutes to
get that distribution completed the
reason is that the web codes the web
pages will be
distributed across all the edge
locations across the globe so hence it
takes time to get that done right anyway
let's move on to Route 53 service
and let's create the hosted zones
so we'll type Route 53 here scalable DNS
and domain name registration
and what we are going to do here is
we are going to map our URL the domains
pointed to
the name servers that will be provided
by the root 53 so we have to create a
hosted Zone
let's wait for it
so now the root 53 dashboard is open and
you can see one hosted zone is already
created so just click on the hosted
zones
and in order to point the traffic from
the external domains towards the AWS you
have to first point the domain's traffic
to the uh hosted Zone in the route 53.
so
I'll click on create hosted Zone but
before that I will first delete the
existing one
and then I'll create another record
Another hosted Zone
right
put your domain name which I put as
sunshinelearning.in
and it is acting as a public hosted Zone
rest of the things will be default click
on create hosted Zone
now it gives you phone name servers and
these phone name servers has to be
updated in the domain so you have to
update these name servers in a platform
from where you have purchased the domain
right so this is half of the work done
then what you need to do is you have to
go and create records
now in the records you can select a
routing policy so right now what we are
targeting we are targeting basically
that the traffic from the domain should
be pointed directly towards the cloud
front distribution hence we are going
with a simple routing right now
click on next
here you have to specify the record set
so we are going to create the records
just click on the file simple record
put here as worldwide web
and you have to select an endpoint so
endpoint we are selecting for the cloud
front distribution so we have to specify
Alias for the cloud front distribution
now here we are going to put the
cloudfront distribution URL and then we
are going to define the simple report
set
so what we need is we need a cloudfront
distribution URL which you can find it
uh from the cloudfront service itself
and you can find uh the domain name here
itself
you just have to copy that
and then
paste it here in the distribution
and then just click on Define simple
records again click on create records
and here you can see
the record set has been updated now this
domain is basically pointed towards
these name servers which are further
pointed towards the cloudfront
distribution
right now the only thing which is left
is that
within the domain from wherever you have
purchased the domain you should update
these phonem servers and then you can
see the live traffic coming on this
domain will have an output from the
cloudfront distribution
let's begin with our tutorial and let's
look into what we have in AWS Auto
scaling so I would be covering up why we
require AWS Auto scaling uh what is AWS
Auto scaling
what are the benefits of using the
scaling service
how this Auto scaling works
the different scaling plans we have
uh what is the difference between the
snapshot and the Ami
what is the load balancer and how many
types of load balancers we have and
along with that I would be covering up a
real life demo on the AWS let's begin
with why we require AWS order scaling
now before AWS Cloud scaling there was a
question in the mind of Enterprises that
they were spending a lot of money on the
purchase of the infrastructure if they
have to set up some kind of a solution
so they have to purchase an
infrastructure and a one-time cost was
required
so that was a burden for them in terms
of procuring a server Hardware software
and then having a team of experts to
manage all those infrastructure
so they used to think that no longer
they require these resources if there
was a cost efficient solution for their
project that was the project manager
used to think
now after the AWS Cloud scaling that was
introduced uh automatically the auto
scaling maintains the application
performance based on the user
requirements at the lowest possible
price
so what does the auto scaling does is
that whenever there is a scalability
required it manages it automatically
and hence the cost optimization became
possible
now what is AWS Auto scaling let's look
into deep so AWS Auto scaling is a
service that helps users to monitor
their applications and the servers and
automatically adjust the capacity of
their infrastructure to maintain the
steadiness so they can increase the
capacity they can even decrease the
capacity also for the cost optimization
and also predictable performance at the
lowest possible cost
now what are the benefits of Auto
scaling it gave the better fault
tolerance applications you can get the
servers created and you can have a clone
copy of the servers so that you don't
have to deploy the applications again
and again better cost management because
the scalability is decided by the AWS
automatically based on some threshold
parameters
it was a reliable service and whenever
the scaling is created or initiated you
can get the notifications onto your mail
IDs or to your cell phones
uh scalability as I mentioned is always
there in the auto scaling it can scale
up it can scale down as well
and it has the flexibility the
flexibility in terms of whenever you
want to schedule it if you want to stop
it if you want to keep the size of the
servers at a fixed number you can always
make the changes on the Fly
and the better availability
now
with the use of the auto scaling we come
around with the terminology called
snapshot and the Ami let's look into the
difference between the snapshots and the
Emi
uh snapshots versus Ami uh so in a
company there was one of the employee
that was facing an issue with launching
the virtual machines
so he asked his colleague a question is
it possible to launch multiple virtual
machines with a minimum amount of time
because it takes a lot of time in terms
of creating the virtual machines
the other colleague said that yes it is
possible to launch multiple ec2 instance
and that can be done at a lesser time
and with the same configuration
and this can be done either you use a
snapshot or the Ami on the AWS
then the colleague said that what are
the differences between the snapshot and
Emi
uh let's look into the difference now
the snapshots basically kind of a backup
of a single ABS volume which is just
like a virtual hard drive
that is attached to the ec2 instance
whereas the Ami it is basically used as
a backup of an ec2 instance only
the snapshots opts for this when the
instance contain multiple static EVS
when you opt for the snapshot whenever
the instance contains multiple Statics
EBS volumes
Ami this is widely used to replace the
failed ec2 instance
in the snapshots here you pay only for
the storage of the modified data
whereas with the A9 you pay only for the
storage that you use
the snapshots are non-bootable images on
ABS volume
whereas Ami are bootable images on the
ec2 instance
however creating an Emi image will also
create the EVS snapshots
now how does AWS Auto scaling work let's
look into it
so for the AWS Auto scaling to work you
have to configure single unified scaling
policy for application resource
and this scaling policy with that you
can explore the applications also
and then select the service you want to
scale also for the optimization select
do you want to optimize the cost or do
you want to optimize the performance
and then keep track of scaling by
monitoring or getting the notifications
now what are the different scaling plans
we have
so in the auto scaling a scaling plan
basically helps a user to configure a
set of instructions for scaling based on
the particular software requirement
the scaling strategy basically guides
the service of AWS Auto screening on how
to optimize resources in a particular
application so it's basically a kind of
other parameters that you set it up so
that how the resource optimization can
be achieved in the auto scaling
uh with the scaling strategies users can
create their own strategy based on their
required metrics and thresholds and this
can be changed on the fly as well
what are the two types of scaling
policies we have so there are basically
Dynamic scaling and the predictive
scaling
uh now what is dynamic scaling it
basically guides the service of AWS Auto
scaling on how to optimize the resources
and it is helpful in optimizing
resources for availability and
particular price
now with scaling strategies users can
create their plan based on the required
metrics and thresholds so a metric can
be like let's say a network in network
out or it can be a CPU utilization
memory utilization likewise
now in the predictive scaling its
objective is to predict future workload
based on daily and weekly Trends and
regular forecast future network traffic
so it is kind of a forecast that happens
based on the previous past experiences
it uses a machine learning technique for
analyzing that Network graphic and this
scaling is like how weather forecast
works right
it provides schedule scaling actions to
ensure the resource capacity is
available for application requirement
now with the auto scaling you would need
the load balancers also because if there
are multiple instances that are created
then you would need a load balancer to
distribute the load to those instances
so let's understand what do we mean by a
load balancer
a load balancer basically acts as a
reverse proxy and it is responsible for
Distributing the network or the
application traffic across multiple
servers
with the help of a load balancer you can
achieve a reliability you can achieve a
fault tolerance of an application that
is basically it increases the fault
tolerance and the reliability
so for example when there is a high
Network traffic that is coming to your
application and if that much traffic
comes to your application to the
instances your instances May crash
so how you can avoid that situation
so you need to manage the network
traffic that is coming to your instances
and that can be done with the load
balancer so thanks to the AWS load
balancers which helps in distributing
Network traffic across backend servers
in a way that it increases performance
of an application
here in the image you can see the
traffic coming from a different
resources Landing onto the ec2 instance
and the load balancer is actually
Distributing that traffic to all the
three instances hence managing the
network traffic quite properly
now what are the types of load balances
we have there are three types of load
balancers on the AWS one is the classic
load balancer second is the application
load balancer and the third one is the
network load balancer
let's look into what we have in the
classic load manager
so the classic load balancer is the most
basic form of load balancing and we call
it as a primitive load balancer also and
it is widely used for the ec2 instances
it is based on the IP address and the
TCP port and it routes Network traffic
between end users as well as in between
the backend servers
and it does not support host based
routing and it results in low efficiency
of resources
let's look into what we have in the
application load balancer
this is one of the advanced forms of
load balancing it performs a task on the
application Level in the OSI model
it is used when there are HTTP and https
traffic routing is required
and also it supports the host based and
Pathways routing and performs well with
the micro services or the backend
application
the network load balancer performs the
task at layer 4 of the connection level
in The OSI model
the prime role of the network load
balancer is to Route the TCP traffic
and it can manage a massive amount of
traffic and is also suitable to manage
the low latencies
let's look into the demo and see how
practically we can
create your order scale
hi guys let's look into the demo for how
we can create an auto Skilling on the
AWS console
so right now I'm logged into the AWS
console and I am in the Mumbai region uh
what you need to do is you have to go to
the compute section and under that click
on the easy to service
let's wait for the ec2 service to come
now just scroll down
and under the load balancing there is an
option called Auto scaling so there
first you have to create a launch
configuration and then after that you
have to create the auto scaling groups
so click on launch configuration
and then you have to click on create
launch configurations
so click on create launch configuration
now this launch configuration is
basically this set of parameters that
you define while launching and auto
scaling so that this uniformity is
maintained with all the instances
so that includes let's say if you select
a Windows Os or a Linux OS that
particular type of an operating system
will be implemented in all the instances
that will be part of an auto scaling so
there are certain set of parameters that
we have to specify during the launch
configuration so that we can have a
uniformity in terms of launching the
servers so here I would select an Amazon
Linux Ami
and then I would select the type of a
server which will be t2.micro
click on configure details put the name
to the launch configuration let's say we
put it as a demo
and the rest of the things we'll keep it
default
click on add storage since it's a Linux
Ami we can go with the 8GB storage that
should be fine click on configure
Security Group
uh let's create a new Security Group
which has the SSH Port open and that is
open for anywhere which is uh basically
source ipv4 and IPv6 IPS any IP would be
able to access that
click on review uh just review your
launch configuration if you want to make
changes you can do that otherwise click
on create a launch configuration
uh you would need the key pair and this
key pair will be a unique key pair which
will be used with all the instances that
are part of the auto scaling group so we
can select an existing key pair if you
have that otherwise you can create a new
key pair so I have an existing key here
I'll go with that acknowledge it and
click on create launch condition
now we have successfully launched the
configuration of an auto scaling the
next thing is to create an auto scaling
group so click on create an auto scaling
group using this launch configuration
put a group name let's say we put
something like test
and the group size to start with it says
one instance so that means at least a
single instance will always be running
and it will be initiated and running 24
cross 7 till the auto scaling is
available you can increase the size of
the minimum base instances Also let's
say you can change it to 2 also so you
would get at least two servers running
all the time
so we'll go with the one instance uh the
network would be the VPC default and uh
in the VPC that particular region we can
select the availability zones so let's
say if I select availability Zone 1A and
then availability is on 1B so how the
instances will be launched so one
instance will be launched in money the
other one in b1b the third one and the
one a fourth one and the one likewise it
will be equally spreaded among the
availability zones
next part is to configure the scaling
policies so click on it
if you want to keep this group at its
initial size let's say if you want to go
with only a single instance or two
instances and you don't want the scaling
to progress you can put it keep this
group at its initial size so this is
basically a way to Halt the scaling
but we'll use the scaling policies to
adjust the capacity of this group so
click on it and we would scale between
let's say minimum one instance that we
have and we'll scale it between one two
four instances
and uh what condition on what basis
these instances will be scaled up or
scaled down would be defined in the
scale group size
so the scaling policies you can
Implement uh based on a scale group size
or using the simple scaling policies
using the steps
steps so in the scale group size you
have a certain metrics you can use
average CPU utilization you can define a
metric related to average networking
average Network out or the load balancer
request counts per Target and if you
create the simple scaling policies using
steps then you need to create the alarms
and there you can get some more metrics
that you can add up as a parameter for
the auto scaling
let's go over the scaling group size
let's go with the metric type as average
CPU utilization and the target value
here you have to specify what would be
the threshold that when the instance CP
utilization is crossed then a new
instance should be initiated
so you can put a reasonable threshold
for that let's say we put something like
85 percent and whenever the instance CP
utilization is crossed 85 threshold you
will see that there will be a new
instance created
let's go to the next configure
notifications
and here you can add notifications so
let's say if there is a new instance
that is initiated and you want to
basically be notified so you can get
notifications over your email IDs or you
can get it on the cell phones so for
that for adding the notification you
would need the SNS service that is
called as a simple notification service
and you have to create a topic there you
have to subscribe for the topic using
your email ID and then you should get
the notifications
click on configure tags the tags are not
mandatory you can basically
put attack let's say if you want to
identify the instance for the purpose it
was created otherwise you can leave it
blank also click on review
and review your scaling policies
notification tags as well as the scaling
group details
click on create auto scaling group and
here you go your scaling has been
launched click on close
and you should get at least a single
instance initiated automatically by the
auto
let's wait for the details to appear so
here you can see
on launch configuration name demo Auto
scaling group name test
minimum instance we want one the maximum
instances we want four
we have selected two availability zones
AP South one AP South 1B
and uh
the instance one has been initiated and
if you want to verify where exactly this
instance has been initiated just click
on the instances here
and here you will see that our single
instance has been initiated that is in
service and that has been initiated in a
episode one week now once the threshold
of this instance crosses 85 percent that
is what we have defined in the scaling
policies
then you should see that another
instance will be initiated
so likewise this is basically I have
created steps to
initiate a scaling policy that needs to
increase the number of servers whenever
the threshold crosses likewise here
itself you can add another policy to
scale down
the resources in case if the CPU
utilization goes to a normal value so
let's begin with Amazon redshift and
let's see what we have for today's
session so what's in it for you today
we'll see what is AWS why we require
Amazon redshift what do we mean by
Amazon redshift the advantages of Amazon
redshift the architecture of Amazon
redshift some of the additional Concepts
associated with the redshift and the
companies that are using the Amazon
redshift and finally we'll cover up a
one demo which will show you the
Practical example that how you can
actually use the redshift service now
what is AWS as we know that AWS stands
for Amazon web service it's one of the
largest cloud providers in the market
and it's basically a secure cloud
service platform provided from the
Amazon also on the AWS you can create
and deploy the applications using the
AWS service along with that you can
access the services provided by the AWS
over the public network that is over the
Internet they are access possible plus
you pay only whatever the service you
use for now let's understand why we
require Amazon redshift so earlier
before Amazon red Chef what used to
happen that the people used to or the
developers used to fetch the data from
the data warehouse so data warehouse is
basically a terminology which is
basically represents the collection of
the data so a repository where the data
is stored is generally called as a data
warehouse now fetching data from the
data warehouse was a complicated task
because might be a possibility that the
developer is located at a different
geography and the data data warehouse is
at a different location and probably
there is not that much network
connectivity or some networking
challenges internet connectivity
challenges security challenges might be
and a lot of Maintenance was required to
manage the data warehouses so what are
the cons of the traditional data
warehouse Services it was time consuming
to download or get the data from the
data warehouse maintenance cost was high
and there was the possibility of loss of
information in between the downloading
of the data and the data rigidity was an
issue now how these problems could
overcome and this was basically solved
with the introduction of Amazon redshift
over the cloud platform now we say that
Amazon redshift has solved traditional
data warehouse problems that the
developers were facing but how what is
Amazon redshift actually is so what is
Amazon redshift it is one of the
services over the AWS Amazon web
services which is called as a data
warehouse service so Amazon redshift is
a cloud-based service or a data
warehouse service that is primarily used
for collecting and storing the large
chunk of data so it also helps you to
get or extract the data analyze the data
using some of the bi tools so business
intelligence tools you can use and get
the data from the redshift and process
that and hence it simplifies the process
of handling the large scale data assets
so this is the symbol for the Amazon
redshift over the AWS now let's discuss
about one of the use case so DNA is
basically a telecommunication company
and they were facing an issue with
managing their website and also the
Amazon S3 data which led down to slow
process of their applications now how
could they overcome this problem let's
see that so they overcome this issue by
using the Amazon redshift and all the
company noticed that there was a 52
increase in the application performance
now did you know that Amazon redshift is
basically cost less to operate than any
other cloud data warehouse service
available on the cloud computing
platforms and also the performance of an
Amazon redshift is the fastest data
warehouse we can say that that is
available as of now so in both cases one
is that it saves the cost as compared to
the traditional data warehouses and also
the performance of this redshift service
or a data warehouse service the fastest
available on the cloud platforms and
more than 15 000 customers primarily
presently they are using the Amazon
redshift service now let's understand
some of the advantages of Amazon
redshift first of all as we saw that it
is one of the fastest available data
warehouse service so it has the high
performance second is it is a low cost
service so you can have a large scale of
data warehouse or a databases combined
in a data warehouse at a very low cost
so whatever you use you pay for that
only scalability now in case if you
wanted to increase the nodes of the
databases in your redshift you can
actually increase that based on your
requirement and that is on the fly so
you don't have to wait for the
procurement of any kind of a hardware or
the infrastructure it is whenever you
require you can scale up or scale down
the resources so the scalability is
again one of the advantage of the Amazon
redshift availability since it's
available across multiple availability
zones so it makes this service as a
highly available service security so
whenever you create whenever you access
redshift you create a clusters in the
redshift and the Clusters are created in
the you can define a specific virtual
private Cloud for your cluster and you
can create your own security groups and
attach it to your cluster so you can
design the security parameters based on
your requirement and you can get your
data warehouse or the data items in a
secured Place flexibility and you can
remove the Clusters you can create under
clusters if you are deleting a cluster
you can take a snapshot of it and you
can move those snapshots to different
regions so that much flexibility is
available on the AWS for the service and
the other Advantage is that it is
basically a very simple way to do a
database migration so if you're planning
that you wanted to migrate your
databases from the traditional data
center over the cloud on the redshift it
is basically a very simple to do a
database migration you can have some of
the inbuilt tools available on the AWS
access you can connect them with your
traditional Data Center and get that
data migrated directly to the redshift
now let's understand the architecture of
the Amazon redshift so architecture of
an Amazon redshift is basically it
combines of a cluster and that we call
it as a data warehouse cluster in this
picture you can see that this is a data
warehouse cluster and this is a
representation of a Amazon redshift so
it has some of the compute nodes which
does the data processing and a leader
node which gives the instructions to
these compute nodes and also the leader
node basically manages the client
applications that require the data from
the redshift so let's understand about
the components of the redshift the
client application of Amazon redshift
basically interact with the leader node
using jdbc or the odbc now what is jdbc
it's a Java database connectivity and
the odbc stands for open database
connectivity the Amazon redshift service
using a jdbc connector can monitor the
connections from the other client
applications so the leader node can
actually have a check on the client
applications using the jdbc connections
whereas the odbc allows a leader node to
have a direct interaction or to have a
live interaction with the Amazon
redshift so odbc allows a user to
interact with live data of Amazon
redshift so it has a direct connectivity
direct access of the applications as
well as the leader node can get the
information from the compute nodes now
what are these compute nodes these are
basically kind of a databases which does
the processing so Amazon redshift has a
set of computing resources which we call
it as a nodes and the nodes when they
are combined together they are called it
as a clusters now a cluster a set of
computing resources which are called as
nodes and this gathers into a group
which we call it as a data warehouse
cluster so you can have a compute node
starting from one to n number of nodes
and that's why we call that the redshift
is a scalable service because we can
scale up the compute nodes whenever we
require now the data warehouse cluster
or the each cluster has one or more
databases in the form of a nodes now
what is the leader node this node
basically manages the interaction
between the client application and the
compute node so it acts as a bridge
compute nodes also it analyzes and
developed designs in order to carry out
any kind of a database operations so
leader node basically sends out the
instructions to the compute nodes
basically perform or execute that
instruction and give that output to the
leader node so that is what we are going
to see in the next slide that the leader
node runs the program and assign the
code to individual compute nodes and the
compute nodes execute the program and
share the result back to the leader node
for the final aggregation and then it is
delivered to the client application for
analytics or whatever the client
application is created for so compute
nodes are basically categorized into
slices and each node slice is allotted
with specific memory free space or you
can say a storage space where the data
is processed these node slices Works in
parallel in order to finish their work
and hence when we talk about a redshift
as a fast a faster processing capability
as compared to other data warehouses or
traditional data warehouses this is
because that these node slices work in a
parallel operation that makes it more
faster now the additional concept
associated with Amazon redshift is there
are two additional Concepts associated
with the red shirt one is called as the
column storage and the other one is
called as the compression let's see what
is the column storage as the name
suggests column storage is basically
kind of a data storage in the form of a
column so that whenever we run a query
it becomes easier to pull out the data
from The Columns so column storage is an
essential factor in optimizing query
performance and resulting in quicker
output so one of the examples are
mentioned here so below example show how
database tables store record into disk
block by row so here you can see that if
we wanted to pull out some kind of an
information based on the city address
age we can basically create a filter and
from there we can put out the details
that we require and that is going to
fetch out the details based on the
column storage so that makes data more
structured more streamlined and it
becomes very easier to run a query and
get that output now the compression is
basically to save the column storage we
can use a compression as an attribute so
compression is a column level operation
which decreases the storage requirement
and hence it improves the query
performance and this is one of the
Syntax for the column compression now
the companies that are using Amazon
redshift one is Lya the other one is
Equinox the third one is the Pfizer
which is one of the famous
Pharmaceuticals company McDonald's one
of the burger chains across the globe
and Philips it's an electronic company
so these are one of the biggest
companies that are basically relying and
they are putting their data on the
redshift data warehouse service now in
another video we'll see the demo for
using the Amazon redshift let's look
into the Amazon redshift demo so these
are the steps that we need to follow for
creating the Amazon redshift cluster and
in this demo what we will be doing is
that we'll be creating an IM role for
the redshift so that the redshift can
call the services and specifically we'll
be using the S3 service so the role that
we will be creating we will be giving
the permission to redshift to have an
access of an S3 in the read-only format
so in the step 1 what we require we'll
check the prerequisites and what you
need to have is the AWS credentials if
you don't have that you need to create
your own credentials and you can use
your credit and the debit card and then
in the Step 2 we'll proceed with the IM
role for the Amazon redshift once the
role is created we'll launch a sample
Amazon redshift cluster mentioned in the
step 3 and then we'll assign a VPC
security groups to our cluster now you
can create it in the default VPC also
you can create a default security groups
also otherwise you can customize the
security groups based on your
requirement now to connect to the sample
cluster you need to run the queries and
you can connect to your cluster and run
queries on the AWS Management console
query editor which you will find it in
the redshift only or if you use the
query editor you don't have to download
and set up a SQL client application
separately and in the step 6 what you
can do is you can copy the data from the
S3 and upload that in the redshift
because the redshift would have an
access a read-only access for the S3 as
that will be created in the IM role so
let's see how we can actually use the
redshift on the AWS so I am already
logged in into my account I am in North
Virginia region I'll search for redshift
service and here I find Amazon redshift
so just click on it
let's wait for the redshift to come now
this is a redshift dashboard and from
here itself you have to run the cluster
so to launch a cluster you just have to
click on this launch cluster and once
the cluster is created and if you wanted
to run queries you can open query editor
or you can basically create queries and
access the data from the redshift so
that's what it was mentioned in the
steps also that you don't require a
separate SQL client application to get
the queries run on the data warehouse
now before creating a cluster we need to
create the role so what we'll do is
we'll click on the services and we'll
move to IM role section so IM rule I can
find here under the security identity
and compliance so just click on the
identity access management and then
click on create roles so let's wait for
IM page to open so here in the IM
dashboard you just have to click on the
rules I already have the role created so
what I'll do is I'll delete this role
and I'll create it separately so just
click on a create role and under the AWS
Services you have to select for the
redshift because now the redshift will
be calling the other services and that's
why we are creating the role now which
other services that the redshift will be
having an access of S3 why because we'll
be putting up the data on the S3 and
that is something which needs to be
uploaded on the redshift so we'll just
search for the redshift service and we
can find it here so just click on it and
then click on redshift customizable in
the use case now click on next
permissions and here in the permissions
give the access to this role assign the
permissions to this role in the form of
an S3 read-only access so you can search
here for the S3 Also let's wait for the
policies to come in here it is let's
type S3 and here we can find Amazon S3
read-only access so just click on it and
assign the permissions to this role tags
you can leave them blank click on next
review put a name to your role let's put
my redshift role and click on a create
role now you can see that your role has
been created now the next step is that
we move to Redshirt service and we'll
create one cluster so click on the
services click on Amazon redshift you
can find that in the History Section
since we browsed it just now and from
here we are going to create a sample
cluster now to launch a cluster you just
have to click on launch this cluster
whatever the uncompressed data size you
want in the form of a gigabyte terabyte
or petabyte you can select that and
let's say if you select in the form of
GB how much GB memory you want you can
Define it here itself this also gives
you the information about the costing On
Demand is basically pay as you use so
they are going to charge you 0.5 dollars
per hour for using the two node slices
so let's click on launch this cluster
and this will be a dc2 DOT large kind of
an instance that will be given to you it
would be in the form of a solid state
drive ssds which is one of the fastest
way of storing the information and the
nodes two are mentioned by default that
means there will be two node slices and
that will be created in a cluster you
can in increase them also let's say if I
put three note slices so it is going to
give us 3 into 0.16 DB per node storage
now here you have to define the master
username password for your redshift
cluster and you have to follow the
password instructions so I would put a
password to this cluster and if it
accepts that means it does not give you
any kind of a warning otherwise it is
going to tell you about you have to use
the ASCII characters and all and here
you have to assign this cluster the role
that we created recently so in the
available IM rules you just have to
click on my redshift role and then you
have to launch the cluster if you wanted
to change something in with respect to
the default settings let's say if you
wanted to change the VPC from default
VPC to your custom VPC and you wanted to
change the default security groups to
your own Security Group so you can
switch to advanced settings and do that
modification now let's launch the
cluster and here you can see the
redshift cluster is being created now if
you wanted to run queries on this thread
shift cluster so you don't require a
separate SQL client you just have to
follow the simple steps to run a query
editor and the query editor you will
find it on the dashboard so let's click
on the cluster and here you would see
that the redshift cluster would be
created with the three nodes in the US
East 1B availability zone so we have
created the redshift cluster in the Ohio
region and now what we'll do is we'll
see how we can create the tables inside
the redshift and we'll see how we can
use the copy command so that we can
directly move the data uploaded on the
S3 bucket to the redshift database
tables and then we'll query the results
of a table as well so how we can do that
first of all after creating the redshift
cluster we have to install SQL workbench
slash J this is not a MySQL which is
managed by Oracle and you can find this
on the Google you can download it from
there and then you have to connect this
client with the direct shift database
how you can do click on file click on
connect window and after connecting a
window you have to paste the URL which
is a jdbc driver this driver link you
can find it onto the AWS console so if
you open up a redshift cluster there you
would find the jdbc driver link let's
wait for it so this is our cluster
created let's open it and here you can
find this jdbc URL and also make sure
that in the security groups of a
redshift you have the port 5439 open for
the traffic incoming traffic you also
need to have the Amazon redshift driver
and this is the link where you can
download the driver and specify the path
once you are done with that you provide
the username and the password that you
created while creating the redshift
cluster click on OK so this connects
with the database and now the database
connection is almost completed now what
we will be doing in the SQL workbench
will be first creating the sales table
and then in the sales table we'll be
adding up the entries copied from the S3
bucket and then move it to the redshift
database and after that we'll query the
results in the sales table now whatever
the values you are creating in the table
the same values needs to be in the data
file and I have taken up this sample
data file from this link which is
docs.aws.amazon.com redshift sample
database creation and here you can find
a download file ticketdb.zip file this
folder has basically multiple data files
sample data files which you can actually
use it to practice uploading the data on
the redshift cluster so I have extracted
one of the files from this folder and
then I have uploaded that file in the S3
bucket now we'll move into the S3 Market
let's look for the file that has been
uploaded on the S3 bucket so this is the
bucket sample and sales underscore tab
dot text is the file that I have
uploaded this has the entries data
entries that will be uploaded using a
copy command onto the redshift cluster
now after executing after putting up the
command for creating up the table then
we'll use a copy command and copy
command we have to define the table name
the table name is sales and we have to
define the path from where the data
would be copied over to the sales table
in the redshift now path is the S3
bucket and this is the redshift bucket
sample and it has to look for the data
inside the sales underscore tab dot text
file also we have to define the role Arn
that was created previously and once it
is done then the third step is to query
the results inside the sales table to
check whether our data has been uploaded
correctly on the table or not now what
we'll do is we'll execute all these
three syntax it gives us the error
because we have to connect it again to
the database let's wait for it execute
it it's again gives us the error let's
look into the name of the bucket it's
redshift bucket sample so we have two
T's mentioned here right let's connect
with the database again and now execute
it so table sales created and we got the
error the specified bucket does not
exist a redshift bucket sample let's
view the bucket name redshift bucket
sample let's copy that put it here
connect to the window connect back to
the database right and now execute it so
table sales created uh the data in the
table has been copied from the S3 bucket
to sales underscore tab dot text to the
redshift and then the query of the
results now the results from the table
has been Twitter in this section you'll
learn what elastic load balancing is
elastic load balancing automatically
distributes incoming application traffic
across multiple Amazon ec2 instances
it enables you to achieve increased
levels of fault tolerance for your
applications by seamlessly providing the
required amount of load balancing
capacity needed to distribute the
application traffic
you can distribute incoming traffic
across your ec2 instances in a single
availability zone or multiple
availability zones
elastic load balancing automatically
scales its request handling capacity in
response to incoming traffic
elastic load balancing can also detect
the health of your Amazon ec2 instances
when it detects an unhealthy instance
it'll spread the load across the
remaining instances and no longer Route
traffic to the unhealthy instance
when you're using VPC you can create and
manage security groups associated with
elastic load balancing to provide
additional networking and Security
Options
you can also create a load balancer
without a public IP address so it serves
as an internal I.E non-internet-facing
load balancer
elastic load balancing also supports the
ability to stick user sessions to
specific ec2 instances using cookies and
if you remember from lesson two when we
talked about session Affinity this is a
version of that
in this demonstration we're going to
create a load balancer for our simply
learn web servers
so to do that we'll go to the compute
ec2 section
and I want to show you that before we
can configure load balancing there's a
couple of things we need to do so if we
go to load balancers on the left hand
side
and then click on create load balancer
so we want to create a load balancer
inside simply learn VPC now I want to
show you this warning that comes up says
please select at least two subnets in
different availability zones to provide
High availability for your load balancer
and you could think well that's great we
have two subnets we have a public subnet
and a private subnet and they're both in
different availability zones so if we
add them both
we get another warning since this is an
internet-facing elastic load balancer
but there is no internet gateway
attached to the subnet you've just
selected so obviously our private
Gateway private subnet only has a Nat
gateway to provide its internet access
so it's not a public internet-facing
subnet so what that means is we need to
create a new public subnet and a
different availability zone for our load
balancer
so we already have this one public in Us
East 1B we're going to create a public
Subnet in U.S east 1C as well so to do
that let's go back
to the networking VPC section
and this is going to be a quick review
of the VPC lesson
so we'll go to subnet
we'll sort by VPC so here are our two
existing subnets
so we'll create a new subnet and we're
going to call it let me just paste what
I copied we're going to call it 10.0.3.0
U.S east 1C simply learn Pub and we're
going to put it in our simply learned
VPC
and we want to put it in the US East 1C
availability zone so it's different to
our existing public subnet
and we're going to put it in
that cidr block
so let's click create
so there we are now we have
three subnets in our simple and BBC two
of them are public now if you remember
when you create a new subnet it will get
attached to your default root table by
default so that's no good because our
default route table doesn't have
internet access so we need to go to root
tables
we click on our main default root table
and have a look at subnet associations
we can see that our new subnet
is in here so we need to move it
into our custom root table
so it will be the same as our existing
public subnet so if we click on edit
we just click the box next to our new
public subnet
and click save
so now our new public subnet is in
this root table so it has internet
access so now we're good to go so let's
go back to the ec2 section and we want
to launch a new web server into this new
public subnet
so we'll go to but we'll launch it from
our Ami because we've already configured
our web servers as an Ami so we'll click
launch
we'll choose T2 Nano or configure our
instance details
so we're going to place it in the simply
land VPC
we're going to place it in our new
public Subnet in the US East 1C
availability Zone
we're going to enable the public IP
we're going to give it the administrator
I am roll and we're going to protect
against accidental termination
the storage is fine
we're going to tag this one as
simply learn web server 3.
we'll configure the security group so
we'll put it in an existing Group which
will be
the
Web Service Group
and we'll launch it
using our existing simply learn key pair
which I have possession of
okay so that's launching
so we can
see our simply learn web servers
so there we are we've got three of them
we've got one two which are already up
and running and number three which is
coming online
so now we're ready to create our load
balancing so let's go to load balances
again
and create load balancer
we want to put it in our VPC and we'll
give it a name so this is the kind of
internal name we can tag it differently
later on
because you can't put any underscores or
hyphens in this section so we'll call it
simply learn lb simply learn VPC if we
wanted to create an internal load
balancer so it was balancing traffic
that was just internal to our AWS VPC we
could tick this box is the listener
configuration so what we can do here is
we're saying that any HTTP that comes in
on Port 80
to the load balancer is being pushed to
Port HTTP 80 on our instances so what we
could do is you could change this you
could have a different port for the load
balancer and it Maps it to your web
service you could protect your web
servers but we're just going to leave it
as it is now we want to add the subnet
so we're going to add
both of our public subnets and that
warning's now gone so now we're good we
have two subnets and two availability
zones
next we assign security groups so we
could just use our existing web server
Security Group because that has HTTP
Port 80 open it also has
httpps open and SSH so it's probably
good practice to create a new Security
Group just for our load balancer so
we'll call it simply then
load balancer
SG
and we're simply going to have
HTTP Port 80 open from anywhere and
nothing else
we should probably just give it a quick
description so we know what it is
Security Group for load balancing
okay so let's click next configure
security settings and it's just telling
us that our load balance security isn't
using a secure listener because we're
not using https or SSL which is fine for
this demonstration next we configure the
health check
so this is the check that the load
balancer is going to perform to see if
our instances are healthy so it's using
HTTP Port 80 and it's going to look for
existence of a file so we're going to
tell it to look for
our healthcheck.html file
and if that doesn't exist then the
instance isn't healthy
now we can configure some more details
so the response timeout is five seconds
we'll leave that the interval between
checks the default value is 30. so let's
bring that down because we want to want
things to happen quicker so that's 10
seconds unhealthy threshold is set to
two so if it has two checks or it
doesn't find the file it's going to
determine that the instance is unhealthy
and the health of threshold is 10. we're
also going to bring that down we'll
bring that down to three so after three
consecutive healthy checks it will say
the instance is healthy
okay so now we can add our ec2 instances
so we'll add our three web servers
we've enabled cross Zone load balancing
so it can push traffic across both
availability zones and the connection
draining setting will just leave as
default that's when it detects an
unhealthy instance that's how long
before it will start redirecting traffic
elsewhere
so next we'll click on ADD tags so we
can give
this a more meaningful name
simply learn
underscore load balancer and review and
create okay so we can review everything
we did
well if you should be okay so let's
click create
and our load balancer is now being
created
so let's have a look so here it is
if we click on instances you can see the
instances and it's saying they're all
out of service at the moment so that's
because it's just configuring itself and
it will take a while to come up so I'm
going to pause the demonstration and
we'll come back when everything's up and
running
okay so the load balancer has configured
and you can see that two of our three
web servers are in service but our third
web server is out of service
so why do you think this is
well I'll tell you why it's because our
new web server simply learn web server 3
has just come up and we haven't done
anything to it other than just launch
the Ami so let's go and check out what's
going on on the instance
so I've open sessions to our three web
servers here and this is the new one and
it's because the Apache service
isn't started by default so we need to
start the Apache service
okay so we get that weird error but the
it tells me it's okay so if we now go
back to the um the load balancer
and we wait a few seconds we should see
simply then web server number three come
online
there you are so now we're online so it
was as simple as just starting the
service
so that shows how load balancing works
today I'm joined by two giants of the
cloud computing industry they'll be
going head to head with each other to
decide who amongst them is better it's
going to be one hell of fight now let's
meet our candidates on my left we have
AWS who's voiced by a bake shop hi guys
and on my right we have Microsoft Azure
who's voice by Anjali hey there so today
we'll be deciding who's better on the
basis of their origin and the features
they provide their performance in the
present day and comparing them on the
basis of pricing market share and
options free tier and instance
configuration now let's listen to their
opening statements let's start with AWS
launched in 2006 AWS is one of the most
commonly used cloud computing platforms
across the world companies like Adobe
Netflix Airbnb HTC Pinterest and Spotify
have put their faith in AWS for their
proper functioning it also dominates the
cloud computing domain with almost 40
percent of the entire market share so
far nobody's even gotten close to
beating that number AWS also provides a
wide range of services that covers a
great number of domains domains like
compute networking storage migration and
so much more now let's see what Azure
has to say about that Azure was launched
in 2010 and is trusted by almost 80
percent of all Fortune 500 companies the
best of the best companies in the world
choose to work only with Azure Azure
also provides its services to more
regions than any other cloud service
provider in the world Azure covers 42
regions already and 12 more being
planned to be made Azure also provides
more than 100 Services spanning a
variety of domains now that the opening
statements are done let's have a look at
the current market status of each of our
competitors this is the performance
route here we have the stats for the
market share of AWS Azure and other
cloud service providers this is for the
early 2018 period Amazon web services
takes up a whopping 40 percent of the
market share closely followed by sgr at
30 and other cloud services adding 30
percent this 40 indicates most
organizations clear interest in using
AWS VR number one because of our years
of experience and Trust we've created
among our users sure you're the market
leader but we are not very far behind
let me remind you more than 80 percent
of the Fortune 500 companies trust Azure
with their cloud computing needs so it's
only a match of time before Azure takes
the lead the rest of the 30 person that
is in AWS or is your accounts so the
other cloud service providers like
Google Cloud platform Rackspace IBM
software and so on now for our next
round the comparison round first we'll
be comparing pricing we'll be looking at
the cost of a very basic instance which
is a virtual machine of two virtual CPUs
and 8 GBS of RAM for AWS this will cost
you approximately
0.0928 US dollars per hour and for the
same instance in Azure it will cost you
approximately 0.096 US dollars per hour
next up let's compare market share and
options as I mentioned before AWS is the
Undisputed market leader when it comes
to the cloud computing domain taking up
40 of the market share by 2020 AWS is
also expected to produce twice its
current Revenue which comes close to 44
billion dollars not to mention AWS is
constantly expanding its already strong
roaster of more than 100 services to
fulfill the shifting business
requirements of organizations all that
is great it really good for you but the
research company Gartner has released a
magic quadrant that you have to see you
see the competition is now neck to neck
between Azure and AWS it's only a match
of time before Azure can increase from
its 30 market share and surpass AWS this
becomes more likely considering how all
companies are migrating from AWS to
Azure to help satisfy their business
needs Azure is not far behind AWS when
this comes to Services as well azure's
service offerings are constantly updated
and improved on to help users satisfy
their cloud computing requirement now
let's compare AWS and azure's free
offerings AWS provides a significant
number of services for free helping
users get hands-on experience with the
platform products and services the free
tier Services fall under two categories
services that will remain free forever
and the others that are valid only for
one year the always free category offers
more than 20 services for example Amazon
SNS sqs cloudwatch Etc and the valid for
your category offers approximately 20
services for example Amazon S3 ec2
elastic cache Etc both types of services
have limits on the usage for example
storage number of requests compute time
Etc but users are only charged for using
services that fall under the valid for a
year category after a year of their
usage a shop provides a free tier as
well it also provides services that
belong to the categories of free for a
year and always free there are about 25
plus always free services provided by
Azure these include app service
functions container service active
directory and lots more and as of the
valid for a year there are eight
services offered there's Linux or
Windows Virtual machines blob storage
SQL database and few more Azure also
provides the users with credit bits of
200 US dollars to access all their
services for 30 days now this is a
unique feature that Azure provides which
users can use their credits to utilize
any service of a choice for the entire
month now let's compare instance
configuration I just instance that AWS
offers is that over whopping 256 GBS of
RAM and 16 virtual CPUs the largest that
Azure offers isn't very far behind
either 224 GBS of RAM and 16 virtual
CPUs and now for the final round each of
our contestants will be shown facts and
they have to give explanations for these
facts we call it the rapid fire round
first we have features in which AWS is
good and Azure is better AWS does not
cut down on the features it offers its
users however it requires slightly more
Management on the user's part Azure goes
slightly deeper with the services that
fall under certain categories like
platform as a service and infrastructure
as a pelvis next we have hybrid Cloud
where AWS is good and Azure is better OK
although AWS did not emphasize on hybrid
Cloud earlier they are focusing more on
technology now Azure has always
emphasized on hybrid cloud and has
features supporting it since the days of
its inception for developers AWS is
better and Azure is good of course it's
better because AWS supports integration
with third-party applications well Azure
provides access to data centers that
provide a scalable architecture for
pricing both AWS and Azure are at the
same level it's good for AWS because it
provides a competitive and constantly
decreasing pricing model and in the case
of azure it provides offers that are
constantly experimented upon to provide
its users with the best experience and
that's it our contestants have finished
giving their statements now let's see
who won surprisingly nobody each cloud
computing platform has its own pros and
cons runs choosing the right one is
based entirely on your organization's
requirements we're going to talk about
the best cloud computing platform
available Amazon web services uh Rahul I
think you said something wrong here the
best cloud computing platform is
obviously Google Cloud platform no it
isn't AWS is more than 100 services that
span a variety of domains all right but
Google Cloud platform has cheaper
instances what do you have to say about
that well I guess there's only one place
we can actually discuss this a boxing
ring so guys I'm apeksha and I will be
Google Cloud platform and I'm Rahul I'll
be AWS so welcome to fight night this is
AWS versus gcp the winner will be chosen
on the basis of their origin and the
features they provide their performance
in the present day and comparing them on
the basis of pricing market share and
options the things they give you for
free and instance configuration now
first let's talk about AWS AWS was
launched in 2004 and is a cloud service
platform that helps businesses grow and
scale by providing them Services the
number of different domains these
domains include compute database storage
migration networking and so on a very
important aspect about AWS is its years
of experience now AWS has been on the
market a lot longer than any other cloud
service platform which means they know
how businesses work and how they can
contribute to the business growing also
AWS has over 5.1 billion dollars of
Revenue in the last quarter this is a
clear indication of how much faith and
trust people have in AWS they occupy
more than 40 percent of the market which
is a significant chunk of the cloud
computing Market they have at least 100
services that are available at the
moment which means just about every
issue that you have can be solved within
AWS service now that was great but now
can we talk about gcp I hope you know
that gcp was launched very recently in
2011 and it is already helping
businesses significantly with a suite of
intelligent secure and flexible Cloud
Computing Services it lets you build
deploy and scale applications websites
services on the same infrastructure as
the intuitive user experience that DCP
provides with dashboards Wizards is way
better in all the aspects gcp has just
stepped in the market and it is already
offering a modest number of services and
the number is rapidly increasing and the
cost for a CPU instance or Regional
storage that JCP provides is a whole lot
cheaper and you also get a
multi-regional cloud storage now what do
you have to say on that I'm so glad you
asked let's look at present day in fact
let's look at the cloud market share of
the fourth quarter of 2017. this will
tell you once and for all that AWS is
the leader when it comes to cloud
computing Amazon web services
contributes 47 of the market share
others like Rackspace or Verizon cloud
contribute 36 Microsoft Azure
contributes 10 the Google Cloud platform
contributes four percent and IBM
software contributes three percent 47 of
the market share is contributed by AWS
you need me to convince you any more
wait wait wait all that is fine but we
only started a few years back and have
already grown so much in such a less
span of time haven't you heard the
latest news our revenue is already a
billion dollars per quarter wait for a
few more years and the world shall see
and AWS makes 5.3 billion dollars per
quarter it's going to take a good long
time before you can even get close to us
yes yes we'll see now let's compare a
few things for starters let's compare
price for AWS a compute instance of two
CPUs and 8GB ram costs approximately 68
US Dollars now a computer instance is a
virtual machine in which you can specify
what operating system Ram or storage you
want to have for cloud storage it costs
2.3 cents per GB per month with AWS you
really want to do that because gcp wins
this hands down let's take the same
compute instance of two CPUs with 8GB
Ram it will cost approximately 50
dollars per month with gcp and as per my
calculations that's a 25 annual cost
reduction when compared to AWS talking
about cloud storage costs it is only 2
cents per GB per month with g CP what
else do you want me to say let's talk
about market share and options now AWS
is the current market leader when it
comes to cloud computing now as you
remember we contribute at least 47 of
the entire market share AWS also has at
least 100 services available at the
moment which is a clear indication of
how well AWS understands businesses and
helps them grow yeah that's true but you
should also know that gcp is steadily
growing we have over 60 services that
are up and running as you can see here
and a lot more to come it's only a
matter of time when we will have as many
services as you do many companies have
already started adopting gcp as their
cloud service provider now let's talk
about things you get for free with AWS
you get access to almost all the
services for an entire year with usage
limits now these limits include an
hourly or by the minute basis for
example with Amazon ec2 you get 750
hours per month you also have limits on
the number of requests to services for
example with AWS Lambda Quest per month
now after this limits across you get
charged standard rates with gcp you get
access to all Cloud platform products
like Firebase the Google Maps API and so
on you also get 300 in credit to spend
over a 12 month period on all the cloud
platform products and interestingly
after the free trial ends you won't be
charged unless you manually upgrade to a
paid account now there is also the
always free version for which you will
need an upgraded billing account here
you get to use a small instance for free
and 5 GB of cloud storage any usage
above this always free usage limits will
be automatically billed as standard
rates now let's talk about how you can
configure instances with AWS the largest
instances offers of 128 CPUs and 4
degrees of ram now other than the
on-demand method like I mentioned before
you can also use Spartan sensors now
these are for situations where your
application is more fault tolerant and
can handle an interruption now you pay
for the spot price which is effective at
a particular hour so these part prices
do fluctuate but are adjusted over a
period of time the largest instance
offered with Google cloud is 160 CPUs
and 3.75 TVs Ram like spot instances of
AWS Google Cloud offers short-lived
compute instances suitable for back jobs
and fault tolerant workloads they are
called as preemptable instances so these
instances are available at 80 percent
off on on-demand price hence they reduce
your compute engine costs significantly
and unlike AWS these come at a fixed
price Google Cloud platform is a lot
more flexible when it comes to instance
configuration you simply choose your CPU
and RAM combination of course you can
even create your own instance types this
way before we wrap it up let's compare
on some other things as well Telemetry
it's a process of automatically
collecting periodic measurements from
remote devices for example GPS gcp is
obviously better because they have
Superior Telemetry tools which help in
analyzing services and providing more
opportunities different tube light when
it comes to application support AWS is
obviously better since they have years
of experience under their belt AWS
provides the best support that can be
given to the customers containers are
better with gcp a container is a virtual
process running in user space as
kubernetes was originally developed by
Google gcp has full native support for
the tools other cloud services are just
fine-tuning a way to provide kubernetes
as a service also the containers help
with abstracting application we run it
the applications can be deployed easily
regardless of their environment when it
comes to geographies AWS is better since
they have a head start of a few years
AWS in this fan of time has been able to
cover a larger market share and
geographical locations now it's time for
the big decision so who's going to be
yeah who is it going to be TCP or AWS I
think I'm going to go for choosing the
right cloud computing platform is a
decision that's made on the basis of the
user or the organization's requirement
on that note I believe it's time for us
to wrap this video up we hope you guys
enjoyed this video and learned something
new that AWS is better right no that
choosing a platform entirely depends on
you and your organization's requirement
AWS Azure and gcp are three of the
world's largest cloud service providers
but how are they different from each
other let's find out hey guys I'm Rahul
and I'll be representing Amazon web
services I'm chinmayi and I'll be
representing Microsoft Azure and I am
Shruti and I'll be representing Google
Cloud platform talking about market
share Amazon web services leads with
around 32 percent of the worldwide
public cloud share Azure owns up to 16
of the worldwide market share and gcp
owns around nine percent of the world's
market share let's talk about each of
these service providers in detail AWS
provides services that enable users to
create and deploy applications over the
cloud these services are accessible via
the Internet AWS being the oldest of the
lot was launched in the year 2006. Azure
launched in 2010 is a Computing platform
that offers a wide range of services is
to build manage and deploy applications
on the network using tools and
Frameworks launched in the year 2008 gcp
offers application development and
integration services for its end users
in addition to Cloud management it also
offers services for Big Data machine
learning and iot now let's talk about
availability zones these are isolated
locations within data center regions
from which public cloud services
originate and operate talking about AWS
they have 69 availability zones within
22 geographical regions this includes
regions in the United States South
America Europe and Asia Pacific they are
also predicted to have 12 more editions
in the future Azure available in 140
countries has over 54 regions worldwide
grouped into six geographies these
geographical locations have more than
100 data centers gcp is available in 200
plus countries across the world as of
today gcp is present in 61 zones and 20
regions with Osaka and Zurich being the
newly added regions now let's talk about
pricing these Services follow the pay as
you go approach you pay only For The
Individual Services you need for as long
as you use them without requiring
long-term contracts or complex licensing
now on screen you can see the pricing
for each of these cloud service
providers with respect to various
instances like general purpose compute
optimized memory optimized and GPU now
let's talk about the compute services
offered first off we have virtual
servers for AWS we have ec2 it is a web
service which eliminates the need to
invest in Hardware so that you can
develop and deploy applications in a
faster manner it provides virtual
machines in which you can run your
applications azure's virtual machines is
one of the several types of computing
resources that Azure offers Azure gives
the user the flexibility to deploy and
manage a virtual environment inside a
virtual Network gcp's VM service enables
users to build deploy and manage virtual
machines to run workloads on the cloud
now let's talk about the pricing of each
of these services awcc free to try it is
packaged as part of aws's free tier that
lasts for 12 months and provides 750
hours per month of both Linux and
Windows Virtual machines Azure virtual
machine service is a part of the free
tier that offers this service for about
750 hours per month for a year the user
gets access to Windows and Linux virtual
machines gcp's VM service is a part of a
free tier that includes micro instance
per month for up to 12 months now let's
talk about platform as a service or past
services for AWS elastic Beanstalk is an
easy to use service for deploying and
scaling web applications and services
developed with java.net node.js python
and much more it is used for maintaining
capacity provisioning load balancing
Auto scaling and application Health
monitoring the past backbone utilizes
virtualization techniques where the
virtual machine is independent of the
actual Hardware that hosts it hence the
user can write application code without
worrying about the underlying Hardware
Google app engine is a cloud computing
platform as a service which is used by
Developers for hosting and building apps
in Google data centers the app engine
requires the apps to be written in Java
or Python and store data in Google
bigtable and use the Google query
language for this next let's talk about
virtual private server Services AWS
provides light sale it provides
everything you need to build an
application or website along with the
cost effective monthly plan and minimum
number of configurations in simple words
VM image is a more comprehensive image
for Microsoft Azure virtual machines it
helps the user create many identical
virtual machines in a matter of minutes
unfortunately gcp does not offer any
similar service next up we have
serverless Computing Services AWS has
Lambda it is a serverless compute
service that lets you run your code
without facilitating and managing
servers you only pay for the compute
time you use it is used to execute
backend code and scales automatically
when required Azure functions is a
serverless compute service that lets you
run even triggered code without having
to explicitly Vision or manage
infrastructure this allows the users to
build applications using serverless
simple functions with the programming
language of their choice gcp Cloud
functions make it easy for developers to
run and scale code in the cloud and
build image driven serverless
applications it is highly available and
fault tolerant now let's talk about
storage services offered by each of
these service providers First off we
have object storage AWS provides S3 it
is an object storage that provides
industry standard scalability data
availability and performance it is
extremely durable and can be used for
storing as well as recovering
information or data from anywhere over
the Internet blob storage is an Azure
feature that lets developers store
unstructured data in Microsoft's Cloud
platform along with storage it also
offers scalability it stores the data in
the form of tiers depending on how often
data is being accessed Google Cloud
Storage is an online storage web service
for storing and accessing data on Google
Cloud platform infrastructure unlike the
Google Drive Google Cloud Storage is
more suitable for Enterprises it also
stores objects that are organized into
buckets Amazon provides EBS or elastic
Block store it provides high performance
block storage and is used along with ec2
instances for workloads that are
transaction or throughput intensive
Azure managed disk is a virtual hard
disk you can think of it like a physical
disk in an on-premises server but
virtualized these managed disks allow
the users to create up to 10 000 VM
disks in a single subscription
persistent storage is a data storage
device that retains data after power to
the devices shut off Google persistent
disk is durable and high performance
block storage for gcp persistent disk
provides storage which can be attached
to instances running in either Google
compute engine or kubernetes engine next
up we have Disaster Recovery Services
AWS provides a cloud-based recovery
service that ensures that your it
infrastructure and data are recovered
while minimizing the amount of down time
that could be experienced site recovery
helps ensure business continuity by
keeping business apps and workloads
running during outages it allows
recovery by orchestrating and automating
the replication process of azure virtual
machines between regions unfortunately
gcp has no disaster recovery service
next let's talk about database Services
first off for AWS we have RDS or
relational database service it is a web
service that's cost effective and
automates administration tasks basically
it simplifies the setup operation and
scaling of a relational database
Microsoft Azure SQL database is a
software as a service platform that
includes built-in intelligence that
learns app patterns and adapts to
maximize performance reliability and
data protection it also eases the
migration of SQL Server databases
without changing the user's applications
Cloud SQL is a fully managed database
service which is easy to set up maintain
and administer relational postgresql
MySQL and SQL dual server databases in
the cloud hosted on gcp cloud SQL
provides a database infrastructure for
applications running anywhere next we
have nosql database Services AWS
provides dynamodb which is a managed
durable database that provides security
backup and restore and in-memory caching
for applications it is well known for
its low latency and scalable performance
Azure Cosmos DB is Microsoft's globally
distributed multi-model database service
it natively supports nosql it natively
supports nosql created for low latency
and scalable applications gcp cloud
datastore is a nosql database service
offered by Google on the gcp it handles
replication and scales automatically to
your applications load with cloud data
stores interface data can easily be
accessed by any deployment Target now
let's talk about the key Cloud tools for
each of these service providers for AWS
in networking and content delivery we
have AWS Route 53 and AWS cloudfront for
management we have AWS cloudwatch and
AWS cloud formation for development we
have AWS code star and AWS code build
for security we have IAM and Key
Management Service for Microsoft Azure
networking and content delivery we have
content delivery Network and express
route for management tools we have Azure
advisor and network Watcher for
development tools for management we have
Azure advisor and network Watcher for
development we have Visual Studio IDE
and Azure blob studio for security we
have Azure security Center and Azure
active directory for gcp we have the
following tools for networking and
content delivery we have Cloud CDN and
Cloud DNS for management we have
stackdriver and gcp monitoring for
development we have Cloud build and
Cloud SDK and finally for security we
have Google cloud IM and Google and
Cloud security scanner now let's talk
about the companies using these Cloud
providers for AWS we have Netflix
Unilever Kellogg's NASA Nokia and Adobe
Pixar Samsung eBay Fujitsu EMC and BMW
among others use Microsoft Azure so as
seen on your screens the companies that
use gcp are Spotify HSBC Snapchat
Twitter PayPal and 20th Century Fox
let's talk about the advantages of each
of these Services Amazon provides
Enterprise friendly Services you can
leverage Amazon's 15 years of experience
delivering large-scale Global
infrastructure and it still continues to
hone and innovate its infrastructure
management skills and capabilities
secondly it provides instant access to
resources AWS is designed to allow
application providers isvs and vendors
to quickly and securely host your
applications whether an existing
application or a new SAS based
application Speed and Agility AWS
provides you access to its services
within minutes all you need to select is
what you require and you can proceed you
can access each of these applications
anytime you need them and finally it's
secure and reliable Amazon enables you
to innovate and scale your application
in a secure environment it secures and
hardens your infrastructure more
importantly it provides security at a
cheaper cost than compromise
environments now talking about some of
the advantages of azure Microsoft Azure
offers better development operations it
also provides strong security profile
Azure has a strong focus on security
following the Standard Security model of
detect assess diagnose stabilize and
close Azure also provides a
cost-effective solution the cloud
environment allows businesses to launch
both customer applications and internal
apps in the cloud which saves an ID
infrastructure costs hence it's Opex
friendly let's now look at the
advantages of gcp Google bills in minute
level increments so you only pay for the
compute time you use they also provide
discounted prices for long-running
workloads for example you use the VM for
a month and get a discount gcp also
provides live migration of virtual
machines live migration is the process
of moving or running VM from one
physical server to another without
disrupting its availability to the users
this is a very important differentiator
for Google Cloud compared to other Cloud
providers gcp provides automatic
scalability this allows a size container
scale to as many CPUs as needed Google
Cloud Storage is designed for 99.9
durability it creates server backup and
stores them in an user configured
location let's talk about the
disadvantages of each of these services
for AWS there's a limitation of the ec2
service AWS provides limitations on
resources that vary from region to
region there may be a limit to the
number of instances that can be created
however you can request for these limits
to be increased secondly they have a
technical support fee AWS charges you
for immediate support and you can opt
for any of these packages developer
which costs 29 per month business which
costs more than 100 an Enterprise that
costs more than fifteen thousand dollars
it has certain network connectivity
issues it also has General issues when
you move to the cloud like downtime
limited control backup protection and so
on however most of these are temporary
issues and can be handled over time
talking about some of the disadvantages
of Microsoft Azure code base is
different when working offline and it
requires modification when working on
the cloud pass ecosystem is not as
efficient as iaas Azure Management
console is frustrating to work with it
is slow to respond and update and
requires far too many clicks to achieve
simple tasks Azure backup is intended
for backing up and restoring data
located on your on-premises servers to
the cloud that's a great feature but
it's not really useful for doing bare
metal industry stores of servers in a
remote data center let's now look into
the disadvantages of gcp so when it
comes to Cloud providers the support fee
is very minimal but in the case of gcp
it is quite costly it is around 150
dollars per month for the most basic
service similar to AWS S3 gcp has a
complex pricing schema also it is not
very budget friendly when it comes to
downloading data from Google Cloud
Storage kubernetes specific to AWS Cloud
platform so what's a part of this
tutorial and demo what's in store for
you at your offset I would like to cover
the basics of orchestration tools as
most of you would know kubernetes is one
of the most popular orchestration tools
in recent times specifically for
applications which are Cloud native and
deployed on some or the other types of
containers but what are these
orchestration tools why would one need
to use orchestration tools what are the
facilities or features provided by these
orchestration tools that's the first
thing that I'm going to cover after that
I will pick two orchestration tools
specific to container management Docker
swarm vs kubuntis I am going to compare
them with regard to the features that
they provide the use cases that they
cover what facilities that they provide
and when to use what after that I will
get into little bit details of the
kubernetes architecture what exactly is
required for setting up our kubernetes
cluster what runs in a control plane or
a master node what runs as a part of the
worker node after that I will end the
tutorial by running you through a demo
by setting up a three node kubernetes
cluster on AWS platform I will use
something called as cops which is one of
the admin tools for setting the
production grade kubernetes cluster so I
will use this to set up a three node
cluster on AWS all right now that we set
the context right let me get started so
what are orchestration tools the
application development and the
lifecycle management from the time the
application is developed connecting the
source code to your continuous
integration to testing them all along
your development process and eventually
moving it down to production managing
your production servers the dependencies
that your software has the requirement
that it has in terms of the hardware the
features of fault all runs self-healing
capabilities Auto scaling all this as
complicated over the last few years as a
part of devops one thing that everyone
is interested in is managing all these
application dependency or lifecycle
management using some or the other kind
of a tool so that's where these
orchestration tools have become very
very popular so what kind of features
that they provide is you'll have to just
let them know what are the kinds of tool
sets that is required what are the fault
tolerance mechanisms that it has to be
adopted to what kind of a self-healing
capabilities that application will have
to need and if at all there is any auto
scaling features that is required if at
all you can bake in all these specific
parameters into your tool your
orchestration tool becomes a One-Stop
shop for all your deployment and
configuration management needs that's
where these orchestration tools have
become a very very popular and relevant
specifically these days when people are
more and more interested in adopting
devops practices all right so having
said that about orchestration tools
let's concentrate on two of these
orchestration tools specifically for
container management Docker swarm and
kubuntus many of the applications that
are written for these kind of containers
are called or kind of fall into a
category of cloud native where the
application need not know much about the
underlying infrastructure or the
platform where these applications are
running so these two along with Apache
me Source there are many other container
management systems but I'm going to
Docker swarm and kubernetes for
comparing the features that is provided
by these two Frameworks for the sake of
comparison I picked up Docker swarm and
kubuntase just because of the reason
that both of them operate in the space
of container management they do
something very very similar to
Containers that's the similarity that
exists between these two orchestration
tools however there's a big difference
that exists when it comes to the types
of containers that both of them cater to
and also the capacity of workloads they
can be used for Docker swarm is a
cluster management solution that is
provided by Docker container Docker is
one of the very very popular containers
of recent times and in case you have
your applications that is totally
powered by only Docker containers if you
have a need where you want to run a
cluster of servers which are running
only Docker containers Docker swarm
should be your choice for your
orchestration tool kubernetes on the
other hand can cater to any other types
of containers other than Docker and
including Docker as well so in case you
have your applications which have got
Docker in them which I've got rkt in
them which they have got LX in them or
any other type of container kubernetes
should be your choice of orchestration
too a Docker swarm can manage up to 40
50 or 60 Max nodes so in case your
application is totally written in Docker
containers and the load or the expected
cluster size is about 50 60 nodes docus
swarm should be your choice of
orchestration tool on the other hand
kubernetes is something that was open
sourced by Google and the kind of the
scale of operations that kubernetes can
cater to is Google scale so if in case
your applications are more than a
thousand nodes that is where kubernetes
comes into play that's the big
difference that exists between Docker
swarm and kubernetes putting those
differences aside let me compare docus
warm and kubernetes based upon other
features which are similar in nature the
first and important feature that
kubernetes provides is something called
as Auto scaling if at all the load on
your cluster is too high and your
application is experiencing more load so
kubernetes can add new nodes to your
cluster of course you'll have to
configure kubernetes in order to have
those capabilities where it can spin up
new VMS or new nodes if at all you do
that configuration correctly kubernetes
has got the capacity or it has got the
feature where it can bring up a new node
and add it to the cluster on the Fly
based upon the load that exists at that
moment on similar lines if at all the
load is not too high it can identify a
few of those nodes which have got less
number of replicas or less number of
application containers running on it it
can move them to some other node and
also scale down by deleting few nodes
from your cluster so that is the of less
of Auto scaling which is provided by
kubernetes and this unfortunately does
not exist in Docker swarm the other
feature of load balancing specifically
application node balancing so Docker
swarm gives you an application Level
Auto load balancing however kubernetes
gives you the flexibility of manually
configuring any other type of load
balancer of your choice for application
load balancing installation as I
mentioned earlier Docker swarm is a
loose cluster of containers which are
running on nodes it is very easy to spin
up a new node and then connect them to a
swarm and this can be done in a very
very loose coupled way where you can
create swarms of your choice notes are
allowed to connect to swarms and quit or
leave the Swarms on the fly so in and
all the installation is pretty easy and
fast kubernetes on the other hand the
configuration of kubernetes is the way
to spin up a big cluster specifying the
size of the node how many Master known
so many config planes that you want how
many nodes that you want it's a pretty
tough thing to bring up a kubernetes
scalability kubernetes strength is very
very strong they are very tightly
coupled and even they have the
capability where on the cluster size
things or the nodes can be increased on
the Fly based upon the requirement on a
Docker swarm the cluster strength is
weak as compared to kubernetes worker
nodes can be added to a swarm worker
notes can be asked to leave us form or
can be taken out of a swarm based upon
the requirement so this is kind of a
Loosely coupled architecture for Docker
swarm while kubernetes the cluster is
very tightly coupled since docus warm
runs only Docker containers containers
find it very easy to share data and a
lot of other things with each other
because they all have the same signature
they are all from the same family so
it's very easy for them to share not
just volumes but lot of other things
however for kubernetes since it manages
containers of different types if
application has to share some data
across different containers there's a
little bit of a complexity in how you
would want your containers to share data
also when it comes to kubernetes
kubernetes groups containers in
something called as pods while a pod can
have either one container that's a
preferred choice or multiple containers
and the idea of pod is like each pod can
run in any other node it's not
guaranteed that you would want to have
two or three parts to be running on the
same node that makes data sharing a
little bit of a different thing compared
to Dockers form GUI so there's not a
good enough UI tool in Dockers form at
least the CE edition of it which will
allow you to get to know what is running
on your containers what is the size of
the containers what is the volume of the
containers and all that stuff there are
some free and open source tools like
portaner which gives you a good
visibility into your running Docker
containers however there's nothing at a
swarm level that is provided by docker
it is gives you an out of the box
dashboard which is easy to configure and
set up you can also Club it with some
metrics services and you can also get
information about the size of the
cluster that is running what is the load
on the nodes and stuff like that all
this across your cluster in a very
beautiful dashboard perspective so that
way this is little bit of a good UI for
kubernetes file for Dockers form there
isn't anything that is provided out of
the box let me spend some in explaining
a little bit about the kubernetes
architecture what comprises of the
kubernetes cluster what resides in a
master or a control plane and what
resides in a worker node this is a very
high level depiction of a kubernetes
cluster so this is the master node which
has got something called as a cluster
store a controller a scheduler component
and an EPA server and these are the
bunch of nodes that are connected or
administered by the master node the
master node can be 1 3 5 y typically an
odd number this is as per the typical
cluster management thing where you would
need the master nodes to be in odd
numbers so that whenever there's any
contention in terms of what needs to be
deployed where or where to give the job
to home and stuff like that all the
Masters would cast their vote and they
would decide on the outcome so that's
the master node and there are a bunch of
nodes which can be connected and
administered by the master node cubic
CTL or the command from using which
anybody can assign some workloads to the
cluster can also be run either on the
same node or on a separate node so Cube
CTL is the command line tool that we
would be installing and using in order
to fire up our commands to our cluster
so if at all I have to put up a job on
our cluster if I have to give out any
specific commands to my cluster all this
is done using cubic CTL there's a bunch
of rest apis which is used by QVC still
and Cube CTL will talk to the API server
and fire up the commands specific to my
cluster what runs in the master node
Master node without saying it's the most
important component of any of the
cluster if at all you're running
um Thruster with only one must node if
you master node goes down there's no
other way that you know you can or any
user can talk to the different nodes in
the cluster so masternode is the most
vital component responsible for the
complete kubernetes cluster there's
always one node that should be running
as a master node that's the bare minimum
requirement for your cluster so what are
the other components in the master node
the most important one is called etcd so
this is nothing but a data store a value
of key value pair which is stored which
contains all information about your
cluster so all the configuration details
which node is up which worker node is
down all this information is stored in
the cluster store so all the managers
would access this cluster store before 4
they go ahead and decide any other work
item or anything else that has to be
done specific to your cluster what's in
the controller as the name says
controller is something it's like a
Daemon server that is running in a
continuous loop all the time it is
responsible for controlling the set of
replicas the kind of the workload that
is running based upon the configuration
that the user has set in so if at all if
you are aware of something called as
replication controllers endpoint
controllers namespace controllers all
these controllers are managed by the
controller component if any user asked
for some three replicas of a particular
pod or a service to be running and if at
all any of the nodes goes down or the
Pod goes down for whatever reason the
controller is the one who wakes up and
assigns this particular job or the Pod
to some other available node by looking
up for the details using in the cluster
store that's the importance of the
control manager or the controller the
scheduler the scheduler assigns the
tasks based upon whoever is asked for
any job to be scheduled based upon a
time frame or based upon some criteria
it also tracks the working load as to
what what exactly is the load who is
running what in the cluster and places
the workload on whoever is the available
resource at that time all right APA
server this is one other important
component in in our kubernetes cluster
where how would the end user deploy or
give out any sort of a workload onto
your cluster all the requests come to
the API server so this is an entry point
for all your requests that come into
your cluster anybody who wants to deploy
something anybody want to scale up a
controller anybody who wants to bring
down few Services anybody wants to put
in a service all this will have to come
in as a part of a rest API endpoint and
API server is the entry point in case
you don't want uh you know somebody to
access your cluster in case you want
only specific people or specific users
to be running some specific workloads
you can set all those role-based access
control for this API server so this is
the entry point for anyone who wants to
submit any job to your cluster so that's
a quick overview about the master node
what what are the important components
of a master node now let's go over to
what runs in a worker or a slave node as
I mentioned earlier slave nodes are
something where the job that is
submitted to your cluster is eventually
run as a pod as a service as a container
so in kubernetes World there is
something called as a pod a pod is
nothing but a combination of a container
it is a wrapper around your running
containers so slave nodes are the worker
nodes typically run these parts so that
is where the whole workload typically
gets run but there are a bunch of other
components in the in the node which also
May manages what runs in the Pod who has
to have access to the Pod what is the
state of the Pod is it in a running
state is it going down for some reason
and all the stuff so let's quickly go
over those components that is there in
the slave node the most important
component in my opinion that should be
on the on the Node should be the
container runtime as I mentioned earlier
kubernetes can run any different types
of containers not just Docker so in case
you want to have a node which wants to
have Docker running on it rkd running or
at LKC running on it or any other
container environment that is running on
it you have to ensure that the specific
container runtime environment is
available on that specific node so that
whenever a job is submitted description
of what needs to be run as a part of the
Pod what should be the image with it
should be powered and what kind of a
container to spin up so that's what you
know when the job is finally assigned to
this particular node it would definitely
need a container runtime to be up and
running so that exist only if at all the
container runtime is installed and
running on your kubernetes worker node
okay now that we know what our
kubernetes node can run how would
somebody assign a job to our node that
is using something called as a cubelet
as the name says cubelet or cube alert
is a small subset which talks to the
cube API server so any node which has to
run any kind of a pod all these
instructions are passed around by the
qvpa server to the tubelight and cubelet
is capable of processing whatever job
that is assigned to it and ensuring that
so many parts and so many services are
spun up based upon the requirement the
last component that exists in the worker
node is the cube proxy or kubernetes
proxy this plays a very very important
role acting as a load balancer and a
network proxy so what typically happens
is whenever the pods are running in
nodes the parts can be typically running
in any node there is no um Affinity
towards any node on which these parts
are running because pods or containers
are something called as ephemeral they
can run anywhere so how would somebody
reach out to these applications that is
running in some pod which is running in
one container now and running in
probably another container another node
all together tomorrow so that is where
your kubernetes proxy contains a picture
and this component will ensure that any
container that is spun up or any pod
that is spun up it keeps track of all
these spots and kind of connects the end
points or acts like a DNS server so that
it knows when somebody is trying to
reach out to this particular service
which is the pod on which the service is
typically running so that plays a very
very important role by acting as a load
balancer and a network proxy now that at
a very high level we know what are all
the components that make up of our
kubernetes cluster let's go ahead and
create a small cluster we'll spin up
this cluster on AWS platform finally we
get to the demo section of my tutorial
now that you guys are aware as to what
is kubernetes what is the use of
kubernetes you also know at a very very
high level what are the components of a
cluster what is a master node or a
control plane what are the components of
a master node and what should be
existing in a worker node probably
you're thinking that it's going to be
pretty hard to kind of set this up so
let me demystify that by running you
with a quick demo of how to set up a
simple three node kubernetes cluster
using a tool called cops and I will be
doing this whole setup on my AWS Cloud
okay so what is cops cops is nothing but
a simple tool is an admin tool that
allows you to bring up production grade
kubernetes environments as I said
setting up a kubernetes cluster on a
bare metal is little challenging so that
is why I would use something called as a
cops and I will use this on my cluster
which I'll spin up on my AWS instance so
I have an AWS account and what I'll do
first is I will first spin up an ec2
server I will power this with one of the
Linux Amis and I will install cops on it
now this will be my starting point from
where I'm going to trigger running up a
big cluster in our case I'll try to keep
it little small I don't want too many
nodes in my cluster I'm going to have
one master node and two worker nodes
this whole operation would be done
programmatically by installing this cops
admin tool so as you may know AWS is
little hard for me to programmatically
run other components or rather bring up
servers it's not pretty simple so what I
would do is I will create an IAM role
which will attach to my S2 server so
that my ec2 server gets powered with all
the required role so that it can go
ahead and spin up cluster based upon my
configuration that I'm going to specify
all right so once I have my cluster set
up I will also install cubic CTL which
you'd probably know by now is nothing
but a command line utility using which I
can kind of connect to my cluster give
out some jobs put some parts and stuff
like that so I will use Cuba CTL I will
also have a pair of SSH keys so that
from this machine I would be able to
successfully get onto the master node
and submit jobs on my behalf so let me
Begin by first logging into my AWS
account all the steps that I will be
following to bring up my AWS cluster
kubernetes cluster will be documented
and I'll be sharing you this document in
a GitHub repository so that in case
anybody wants to try you'll be more than
happy to find all the required
instructions in one place okay now the
first thing that I would need is to
launch an AWS ec2 instance now this is
an instance where I am going to install
cops and I will use it as a base server
from where I'm going to find some
commands which will bring up my
kubernetes cluster so let me log into my
AWS account and let me stick to one
particular region and let me bring up
some a one ec2 instance all right so let
me launch my instance let me choose
um it doesn't matter in the ways but in
case you want to try it on your free
tire I would recommend choose free tire
only and choose an Ami of your choice
let me choose this instance I will make
it T2 micro that is good for me
configuration instance details all right
I don't want to change anything here
that looks good maybe I will change this
30 gig that's good for me let me add a
tag to my instance I'll name this as my
cups server all right I would need a
bunch of ports to be opened up so what I
will do is I'll create a new security
group called open to the word I would
not recommend that you do this since I
don't want to it will take a long time
for me to specifically uh pick and
choose the ports that has to be open for
running my cluster I don't want to do
that I will open up all all the HTTP and
https ports so that it's quicker so I
will say all TCP I would say from
anywhere just to be on the safer side
also open HTTP and https and I will make
this anywhere and anywhere this is good
for me I will say review on launch all
right so I chose a T2 micro instance
just for the sake of easiness I've
opened up all the ports and the instant
details are you've seen what is that
I've chosen all right now important part
is like I would need a keypad I need to
create a new keypad I will call this as
simply learn keys I will download this
key pair and then I will launch the
instance it will take some time for my
ec2 instance to come up in the meanwhile
what I'll do is I will convert I have
this pem file which is the pair of keys
the SSH keys with which I need to log
into my ec2 instance so I'll need to
convert this because I'm trying to
connect from my Windows box I would need
to convert this into a PPK file so I
have putition I am going to load my set
of keys here and convert that key into
application all right open all right I
would say save and save Private key yes
I would say simply learn or simply learn
private private key and save this here
and that that's all so this is my public
key which is the pem file and this is my
PPK or my private key Now using the
private key I will log into my ec2
instance okay now my ec2 instance is up
and running it is running in this Ohio
region and this is the IP address of my
public IP address of my machine so let
me connect to it so I use Mobile X term
which is nothing but an SSH emulator you
can use putty or any of these sessions
which allow you to do on SSH this is my
ipe address of my machine and since I've
spun up an Amazon Ami the user this is
the default user I wouldn't specify the
private keys for my session and this is
the private key for my session say okay
I am in my Amazon ec2 instance so let me
look at what are the other things that I
need to do all right so as I said I just
brought up my ec2 instance but I would
need my ec2 instance to run few things
on my behalf so that it can spin up easy
to other ec2 instances it can also talk
to an S3 bucket where I'm going to store
the instant state of my kubernetes
cluster also some sort of an auto
scaling group because I want to spin up
more and more instances I also want to
have a private hosted Zone using my
Route 53 so I would need my ec2 instance
to have all these sort of permissions
for my server so what I would do is I'll
go and create a permission a role in the
ec2 or rather in the AWS IM role and I
will attach this I am role to my ec2
instance all right so let me go to my
IAM which is nothing but the iron entity
and access management I'll create a role
called as possibly cops role I will
create a role this role will be used by
my ec2 so I'm going to click on ec2 and
say next permissions they would need a
lot of permissions uh specific
permissions to be very honest and the
permissions are all listed out here S3
ec2 and all this stuff just to keep it
pretty simple what I would do is I'll
create a role with the administrative
access all right so I don't want any
tags I'm going to review I'll create a
role name I will say cops fold for ec2
all right so I'm going to create a rule
which has got administrative access
roles I'm going to create a role so this
would ensure that my ec2 instance from
which I am going to run a my cluster
would have all the prerequisite
permission so that it can go and spin up
instances talk to S3 buckets and all
that stuff all right now let us have our
running instance get powered by this
role so I will connect this role to my
running instance alright so this is my
easy to instant that is running I will
say action attached attach attach attach
replace IM rules so there is no rule as
of now I would want my cops roll for e0
that I created so I want this new room
to be assigned to my ec2 all right great
now my ec2 instance which is my cop
server has got all the required
permissions so that he can create a
cluster on my behalf great now before
this let me do a sudo gem update hyphen
y so that any of the because this is a
newly provisioned VM I just want to
ensure that all my library system
libraries are all updated so that when I
do install cop and Cube CTL and all
those things none of them will fail
because of some dependency or package
issues so I'm just running a sudo update
iPhone y so that all the libraries are
updated okay looks like it is done so
let me go ahead and install cops cops is
a pretty simple installation it is
available in a particular location I
have to just copy this and ensure that I
do a and I install this particular stuff
all right so it is fetching the cops
tool it's installing for me once it is
copied down let me change the mode so
that I can execute it and then also let
me move it to my user local bin so that
it is available for me in my path okay
that's pretty much the cops installation
let me also do one other thing let me
install something called as cubic CTL so
this is what would be you know a tool
using which I'm going to be firing my
commands to my kubernetes cluster once
it comes up right this is a pretty
smaller executable so keep sitting here
all right so I have Cube CTL as well as
cops installed on my ec2 server now okay
now what I'll do next is I'm going to
create an S3 bucket in AWS so that the
equivalent is a cluster state is
persisted in this bucket so let me
create a simple bucket with this name S3
bucket with this name so let me go to S3
and let me create a simple bucket with
this name I will just say create a
bucket okay so this is simply run dot
kubernetes is the bucket that I created
so this bucket will store all
information about my cluster let me now
uh go and create a DNS entry or a DNS
zone or AWS Route 53 hosted zone for my
cluster so this is required so that you
know I can give a cluster name for my
kubernetes cluster that I'm coming up so
I will create a private hosted Zone and
possibility possibly I will call this as
simply learn.in so this will be my name
of my private hosted Zone in case you
already have any other public hosted
zones in your name you can always put a
Route 53 hosted Zone specific for your
domain name since I don't have anyone
I'm just going to create a simple
private hosted zone so let me head down
to Route 53 click on any of these and
you will get these hosted zones out here
so I'm going to create a hosted Zone
here I'm going to create a hosted Zone
click on create hosted Zone um this
would be simply learn.in I want to
create a public no I don't want public I
want a private hosted Zone and I'm going
to associate my VPC ID for this hosted
Zone since I'm going to try out all my
exercises in the Ohio region I will
associate the VPC of the Ohio region for
this all right so this is the one that
is specific to the Ohio region so I will
say this one I'll say create a hosted so
great now let me come back to my ec2 box
my ec2 is all powered with whatever it
needs in order to go out with the
installation of my cluster only few
things that I need to take care of is
that you know now that I put a name for
my cluster I also have an S3 bucket that
I've configured for my cluster I will
have to ensure that I need to put in
these two configurations as a part of my
cluster building activity so I will open
my bash RC file and I'm going to export
these two variables if at all you
remember well these two variables are
nothing but the cluster name which is
nothing but the public or sorry the
private hosted Zone that I created and
the S3 bucket where I'm going to create
or rather I'm going to store my cluster
state so let me copy these two and open
up my bash RC file all right so I will
just add these two and copy these and
Export them out as my variable I'm going
to save this here now let me ensure that
this gets picked up all right I've got
these two that have configured and I've
also ensure that this environment
variables are set now let me create a
pair of SSH keys this is to ensure that
I can log into the box that I'm going to
be provisioning as a part of my cluster
SSH iPhone Keygen I don't want to give
any parameters let it go to the home
directory with the default name and
without any passphrase all right so I
created a bunch of my key pair now I'm
all set to go ahead and run my cops now
cops will ensure that this will take
some time for the cluster to come up but
this is exactly how I would Define my
cups command I I've copied here so cops
create cluster the state of the cluster
will be stored in this particular
variable which is what I have exported
out the number of node count is two node
count is the worker node count if at all
I don't specif there's a configuration
for specifying the master or the control
pane as well if I don't specify that the
default one is one so I'm going to
create one primary or the master node
and to worker nodes uh size of my master
Note size of the worker nodes or what
are the zones where I want this to be
created and where do I store the cluster
information and okay I've already added
this must account this is actually not
required but this is the command that
I'm going to fire off so that I bring up
my cluster all right that went off very
fast but this actually did not create a
cluster it is just the definition of a
cluster and that's why this came out
very fast now that everything looks good
with whatever configuration that is
specified now let me go ahead and create
the cluster base in cops update cluster
hyphen iPhone 8 yes now this will take
some time a good 5-10 minutes for it too
because this will actually start
provisioning the servers and as I
mentioned earlier based upon my
configuration I'm going to come up with
one master server and uh two nodes or
the worker nodes all right so this is
the command for me to validate the
cluster and I'm going to try it out
first I'm pretty sure that will fail
because all my servers are not up yet it
is taking some time the validation
everything failed but let me try to look
at my ec2 instances and see how many
servers do I have running as of now if
you see I had only one server that had
started which was my cop server and
automatically the other three instances
one is called notes dot simply not in
this these two are the nodes and this is
the master node so these three got
automatically provisioned by the cops
command that I ran all right so this may
take a while for it to get validated and
good 5-10 minutes so what I'll do is
I'll pause the video now and I'll come
back once the server the cluster is up
and running it's been a good uh eight to
nine minutes since I started my cluster
so let me validate now okay seems good
so this is a master node uh minimum One
Max one some nodes which are nothing but
the slave nodes or the worker nodes
there are two of them due to micro uh
subnet so my clusters seem to be up and
running and my cluster name is Milan dot
in so what I would want to do is now let
me just log into the master and see if I
can run some parts so let me get back to
my installation steps here the variation
is done so let me log into my since my
cluster name is simply learn.n this is
the way to log into my box so let me get
into my box so if you see here this is
the host name of the machine that I'm
currently in if you see this this is
nothing but our this cop server this is
a server now from here I'm trying to get
into this Master box all right so if you
see the IP address has changed I was in
a different box I'm in a different box
now if I see host name you'll find our
different host name so this is 153 which
is nothing but the master note yep
that's 153 this is the particular host
so I'm getting into this machine now so
I started the cluster from my cop server
here it ran and brought up three nodes
so I'm actually getting into my master
node and see if I can run some parts on
it all right so let me try cubic CTL get
cluster info right Cube CTL get nodes
all right so there are three nodes here
Master node and one master node and two
worker nodes so let me see if I have
some pods here give the CTL get pods so
there's no pod as of now so what I'll
try to do is let me just spin up a very
very simple Pawn just to check if my
connections is everything is correct or
not correct I have a simple node.js
application that I've built and I've got
a container for that this is already
pushed to the docker up registered is
called simply run Docker Hub and the
image name that I have here is called my
node app and I will use this image to
power one of my parts that I will run so
this is the way in which I am going to
launch my pod let me show you this
commands qctl run the name for my
deployment that I'm going to run hyphen
iPhone image and this is the image that
is going to be powering my container so
this is simply learn Docker Hub forward
slash my node app hyphen F1 replica is
equal to I want two replicas to be
running and the port that I want to
expose this particular part is on 8080.
so let me run this as soon as this is
run it creates something called as a
deployment all right now let me just say
I'm not really interested in the
deployment I am interested in checking
if at all the parts are up and running
so I will say Cube CTL get what all
right so that was pretty fast so I have
two parts that are running here these
are two replicas because I asked for two
replicas these parts are running so I
can run Cube CTL describe font pickup
all right I can pick up any of the name
and see what is the Pod what is the
information does it contain from what is
the image that is pulling what is the
image image Name ID this is actually
running my thought which is actually
spinning up a container great so for
some good so in kubernetes the pods can
are ephemeral so they can be there at
any time cannot be runtime if I need to
expose my pot outside I will have to
create a service for my pod so what I'll
do is I'll create a very very simple
service by exposing this particular
deployment before that you check Cube
CDL get deployment so there's a
deployment that is created the
deployment name is simply an app so I
will expose my deployment simply learn
app as
um yeah I'll just expose this let me see
all right I'm not specifying what type
and all I don't want to get into the
complications of what are the different
types of exposing this service and all
that stuff so if I don't specify
anything it gives me something closer
cluster ID so this is where my pod is
actually exposed so let me just check if
at all this spot is up and running I'll
just try a simple curl command curl HTTP
colon this is my cluster IP and the port
is 880. if at all I hit this it's
actually hitting my application and
giving me uh whatever I put a simple uh
sys dot out kind of a thing where I'm
just printing
um the container ID of whatever pod is
serving uh mix out of so I'm actually
heating my container and I'm getting
this output from the content so
everything looks good my content is up
and running so let me just go and clean
it up I will say Cube CTL delete
deployment simply learn app this should
get rid of all the parts that I created
Cube CTL get pod all right these parts
are interminating things let me just
check Cube CTL get Services there's one
service I don't want this service let me
delete that keep CTL delete service on
this all right this sounds good so let
me come back to my host my cop server
from where I'm running so I managed to
successfully verify this part see if
everything is is up and running so what
I'll do is I'll just go ahead and
complete this demo by going and getting
rid of my cluster so cops delete cluster
hyphen iPhone yes all right so this will
ensure that it will clean up my complete
cluster that I created so I had three or
four running instances if you see that
all the three are shutting down because
you know the cop server which had cops
installed on it uh has now got a mandate
to go ahead and shut down and clean up
the whole instances and all those things
that are created as a part of my
deployment in this video you will get to
know some interesting facts about AWS
get a brief overview about the course
and understand how the certification can
help your career Amazon web services
provides a highly reliable scalable
low-cost infrastructure platform in the
cloud that powers hundreds of thousands
of businesses in 190 countries around
the world
the worldwide cloud computing Market
grew 28 in revenues in 2015 which is 110
billion US Dollars and the public Cloud
revenue is expected to grow to 167
billion dollars by 2020. in a recent
survey conducted by Cloud management
company right scale to assess the
challenges regarding cloud computing 32
percent of the respondents cited lack of
resources or expertise as the number one
challenge against 29 citing security as
the biggest challenge
the AWS certification holder takes home
an average salary of 125
871 dollars which is an increase from
one hundred and fourteen thousand nine
hundred thirty five dollars last year
AWS developer associate is the perfect
certification that proves your technical
expertise in identifying appropriate AWS
architecture and in designing developing
and deploying Optimum AWS Cloud
Solutions you'll enhance your existing
knowledge of AWS so you can identify and
deploy secure procedures for optimal
Cloud deployment and maintenance you
will learn how to develop and maintain
applications written for S3 dynamodb sqs
SNS SWS AWS elastic Beanstalk and AWS
cloud formation
you will be able to identify and
Implement Cloud security best practices
with the certification you will be an
asset to any organization helping it to
leverage the benefits of best practices
around Advanced cloud-based Solutions
and identify and implement the
appropriate architecture for development
testing and staging environments
simply learns AWS developer associate
level course will help you understand
the key Concepts required to prepare for
the certification exam before diving
into the course details let us get a
glimpse of all the interesting ways you
get to learn about AWS
delve into the various AWS services
work with AWS Management console
learn the CLI commands
validate your knowledge
the practice assignments in the three
live projects are included for you to
gain hands-on experience with AWS
Management console and the CLI to become
a domain expert in building deploying
and managing systems in AWS
this course comprises 24 hours of
instructor-led training 15 hours of
e-learning and three hours of
demonstrations to understand technical
details associated with data management
networking security and more
you will also be provided with three
question sets totaling 180 questions to
validate the depth of your knowledge
what are the prerequisites for this
course you should have attended AWS
Essentials course or should have
equivalent experience
you should have knowledge developing
applications with API interfaces
you should have a basic understanding of
relational and non-relational databases
and be familiar with messaging and
queuing services
in this video you will get to know some
of the interesting facts about AWS get a
brief overview about the course and know
how the certification can help your
career Amazon web services provides a
highly reliable scalable low-cost
infrastructure platform in the cloud
that powers hundreds of thousands of
businesses in 190 countries around the
world the worldwide cloud computing
Market grew 28 to 110 billion dollars in
revenues in 2015.
in the first quarter of 2016 Amazon web
services or AWS Revenue was up by 58
percent
the certification holder takes home an
average salary of 125
871 up from 114 935 last year according
to Forbes there are over 18 million jobs
in the field of cloud computing globally
AWS sysops administrator associate is
the perfect certification to prove your
technical expertise in deploying
managing and operating scalable highly
available and fault tolerant systems on
AWS platform
you'll enhance your existing knowledge
of AWS so you can select the appropriate
products and tools to leverage AWS in
the most efficient and cost-effective
way
you'll learn how to implement and
control the flow of data to and from AWS
and also be able to estimate AWS usage
costs and identify operational cost
control mechanisms
with the certification you will be an
asset to any organization helping it to
leverage the benefits of best practices
around Advanced cloud-based Solutions
and migrate on-premises applications to
AWS simply learns AWS sysops
administrator associate level course
will help you understand the key
Concepts required to prepare for the
certification exam
before diving into the course details
let us get a glimpse of all the
interesting ways you get to learn about
AWS
delve into the various AWS services
work with AWS Management console
learn the CLI commands
validate your knowledge
the practice assignments and the three
live projects are included especially
for you to gain hands-on experience with
AWS Management console and the CLI to
become a domain expert in building
deploying and managing systems in AWS
this course comprises 24 hours of
instructor-led training 15 hours of
e-learning and three hours of
demonstrations to understand technical
details associated with data management
networking security and more you will
also be provided with three question
sets totaling 180 questions to validate
the depth of your knowledge
learning path
this certification also serves as a
prerequisite for the AWS devops engineer
professional Examiner whether you are
looking to Future proof your career or
enhance your know-how about the leading
cloud provider in the global market
becoming an AWS sysops administrator
associate will put you well on your way
to achieving your career goals
you should ideally be an I.T
professional with experience in both
traditional I.T infrastructure and the
AWS platform
you should have experience in everyday
operations of a system administrator
which include deployment of the it
systems backups OS management and have
some experience with the AWS platform in
in today's era many organizations run
their software environments in the
Amazon web services AWS
and a lot of other companies are also
migrating to AWS every day
considering that if you're looking for
an AWS job or planning to move to an AWS
position in your current company earning
an AWS certification can be a brilliant
investment
AWS Amazon web service is one of the
leading Platforms in cloud computing
Amazon web services was found in the
year 2006 and apparently it holds a
market share of 31.7 percent
AWS provides approximately
175 fully featured services
it consists of significant benefits like
compute storage databases networking
analytics robotics machine learning and
artificial intelligence
in case you're wondering where do you
begin which AWS certification is the
right choice for you AWS provides 12
individual certifications spread across
four different levels
identifying where to start and which AWS
certificate is the best choice for your
job profile can be a little confusing at
first
but once you find out what's the right
choice the path usually becomes pretty
clear
as I already said AWS provides to all
certifications
AWS certified Cloud practitioner AWS
certified developer associate AWS
certified sys Ops administrator
associate AWS certified Solutions
architect associate
s8co2
AWS certified devops engineer
professional
AWS certified Solutions architect
AWS certified Advanced networking
specialty
AWS certified security specialty
AWS certified machine learning specialty
AWS certified database specialty DBS c01
AWS certified data analytics specialty
Das c01
AWS certified Alexa skill Builder
specialty
you can get a complete understanding of
all learning paths to prepare for the
certifications on the simply learn AWS
certifications page
now let us have a closer look at each
certification
let's start with the AWS certified
Solutions architect it is an associate
exam designed for individuals who are
willing to gain knowledge in designing
applications
the associate certification focuses on
the core AWS services like identity and
access management virtual private Cloud
S3 and ec2 with the certification a
candidate will be able to design and
deploy a cost-effective application on
the AWS platform
move an existing on-premises application
on the AWS platform
submit and retrieve data from the AWS
platform
identify and Define best practices for
the implementation of AWS architecture
estimate AWS costs and identify cost
control mechanisms the fee for
completing this certification
is 150 US Dollars and the average salary
and AWS professionals earn after
completing the certification is 1 lakh
thirty thousand eight hundred and eighty
three dollars
now now let's move ahead and know the
eligibility criteria for this
certification
next you should be able to identify and
Define requirements for an AWS based
application AWS requires at least one
year of deploying distributed systems at
scale
knowledge of at least one programming
language is required
Proficiency in hybrid system deployment
using AWS components is necessary
provide best AWS service for
architecture requirements
next comes AWS certified Solutions
architect for professional
it was designed for experts who are
willing to enhance their knowledge in
designing distributed systems and
applications on the AWS platform
with this certification a candidate will
be able to learn the process of
Designing and deploying a reliable and
cost-effective application on the AWS
platform
he will be able to provide appropriate
AWS services to develop and deploy an
application based on client requirements
migrating an existing multi-tire and
complex application on the AWS platform
he can design and deploy Enterprise
level operations on AWS platform
estimating AWS costs and identified cost
control mechanisms will become easier
the fee for completing this
certification is 300 US Dollars and the
average salary and AWS professionals
earn after completing the certification
is 1 lakh forty eight thousand four
hundred and fifty six dollars
now let's look at the prerequisites for
completing the certification first is
minimum three years of hands-on
experience in designing and deployment
of AWS Cloud architecture
earlier this AWS certification required
completion of the AWS certified
Solutions architect associate
certification exam but since last year
this Criterion is not required however
if an individual doesn't have any
experience in AWS we recommend you to
prepare for Solutions architect
associate certification first
next the capability of identifying and
assessing Cloud requirements for
designing an AWS application is required
now let's discuss AWS certified
developer certificate for associate
level
it was designed for beginners to enhance
their skill in creating and maintaining
AWS applications
with this certification a candidate will
be able to learn the development process
of reliable and cost-effective Cloud
solution using AWS
choosing inappropriate AWS service for
the application
gain knowledge of creating IAM
credentials
I and rules Etc in AWS services
developing code that optimizes the
performance of AWS Services used by your
application
the fee for completing the certification
is 150 US dollars
and the average salary in AWS
professional earn after completing the
certification is 1 lakh thirty thousand
two hundred and seventy two dollars you
should have a basic knowledge of AWS
Services their uses and best practices
for the AWS architecture
to earn the salary as mentioned earlier
you must have at least one year of
hands-on experience in the design and
maintenance of AWS Cloud applications
knowledge of popular programming
language is required
experience with the development and
maintenance of applications built for
Amazon S3 dynamodb sqs SNS SWS elastic
Beanstalk and cloud formation is
important you should be proficient in
the design development and deployment of
cloud-based applications using the AWS
platform moving further let's discuss
AWS certified devops engineer
certification for professionals
this certification is designed for
enhancing knowledge and provisioning
management security and operations of
AWS Solutions with the certification a
candidate will be able to understand
Implement and automate the security
controls and compliance validations
implementation and management of
methodologies on AWS and continuous
Delivery Systems
determine and deploy metrics also will
be able to Monitor and lock systems on
AWS
implementation of Highly available and
robust systems on AWS platform
automate the operational process with
designing management and maintenance
tools
the fee for completing this
certification is 300 US Dollars and the
average salary and AWS professional earn
after completing the certification is 1
lakh 37
724 dollars
the eligibility criteria required to
complete the certification are minimum
two years of practical knowledge in
operating provisioning and managing
applications in an AWS environment
achievement of AWS certified developer
associate or AWS certified sus Ops
administrator associate certification
knowledge of other development
methodologies and processes such as
agile
experience in testing and automation via
programming and scripting languages
hands-on experience in code development
for at least one high level programming
language
next comes AWS certified sys Ops
administrator certification for the
associate level
the certification is suitable for it
professionals interested in deploying
scaling migrating and managing AWS
systems
this AWS exam tests your ability to
deploy manage and operate for tolerance
systems on AWS migration of an existing
application on AWS
recognizing and selecting the
appropriate AWS service based on compute
data or security requirements
identifying and estimating the AWS usage
costs and cost control mechanisms
the fee for completing the certification
is 150 US Dollars and the average salary
and AWS professionals earn after
completing the certification is 1 lakh
thirty thousand six hundred and ten
dollars
the eligibility criteria required to
complete the certification are at least
one year of hands-on experience in
operating AWS based applications
understanding of provisioning operating
and maintaining aws-based systems
identifying the challenges and
implementing AWS best practices over the
complete life cycle of a project
ability to identify and Define a
solution for AWS based applications
moving forward let's discuss AWS
certified Big Data
this certification validates skills of
technical expertise in designing and
managing AWS solutions that can help
organizations extract valuable insights
from their data
this exam will teach you how to perform
implementation of core AWS big data
services with best architectural
practices simple techniques to design
and maintain big data services leverage
tools to automate data analysis
getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
the fee for completing this
certification is 300 US Dollars and the
average salary and AWS professionals
earn after completing the certification
is one lakh thirty thousand six hundred
and ten dollars
the eligibility criteria required to
complete the certification are first you
must have an AWS account to follow along
with Hands-On activities next AWS
recommends associate level certification
before attempting the AWS Big Data exam
it is an advanced and challenging exam
a minimum of five years of hands-on
experience in data analytics experience
in designing and developing a scalable
and cost-effective architecture to
process data
defining an architecting AWS big data
services and their existence in the data
life cycle of collection ingestion
storage processing and visualization
finally the last Criterion is you should
have a basic understanding of AWS
services and a fair understanding of big
data and Hadoop Concepts
next comes the AWS certified security
certification
this certification is intended for cloud
Security Professionals it allows experts
to improve their knowledge on how to
secure the AWS platform
with the certification a candidate will
gain understanding of AWS Security
Services
implementation of AWS mechanisms secure
internet protocols and data encryption
methods implementation of AWS data
protection and specialized data
classifications
ability to make trade-off decisions
about cost and Security based on the
requirement
understanding of security operations and
risk the fee for completing this
certification is U.S dollars 300.
and the average salary and AWS
professionals earn after completing the
certification is 1 lakh
3195 dollars
the eligibility criteria required to
complete the certification are
achievement in any one AWS associate
certification or Cloud practitioner
certificate more than two years of
hands-on experience in securing AWS
workloads
at least five years of I.T security
experience in designing and implementing
Security Solutions
next comes the AWS certified Advanced
networking certification
this certification validates the skills
of it Professionals in designing and
implementing AWS as part of a hybrid it
Network architecture
the objective of this certification is
to help an individual to develop and
deploy cloud-based Solutions using AWS
design and maintain Network architecture
for all AWS services
implementing core AWS Services according
to basic architecture best practices
leverage tools to automate AWS
networking tasks
the fee for completing the certification
is 300 US Dollars and the average salary
and AWS professionals earn after
completing the certificate is 1 lakh 13
065 US dollars
the eligibility criteria required to
complete this certification are basic
knowledge of AWS networking Technologies
and Concepts
minimum experience of five years in data
analytics accomplishing at least one AWS
certification which is solution
architect for associate level sysops
administrator associate level AWS
certified developer associate level or
Cloud practitioner certification
speaking of cloud practitioner
certification it was intended for
individuals who have basic knowledge in
cloud computing and would like to
enhance their technical skills this exam
tests will teach you the fundamental
security aspects of the AWS platform
along with the shared security model
knowledge of AWS services and the common
use cases ability to explain AWS cloud
and its Global infrastructure
capability to Define principles of AWS
Cloud architecture
ability to Define pricing models billing
and account management
the fee for completing the certification
is 100 US dollars and the average salary
and AWS professionals earn after
completing the certification is 90
512 dollars
the eligibility criteria required to
complete the certification are basic
knowledge of IT solutions and services
and their uses in the AWS platform
more than six months of experience in
any role of AWS cloud
moving further let's understand what AWS
certified Alexa skill Builder
certification is
this certification is designed for
professionals who are currently in the
role of Alexa skill Builder it validates
an individual's ability to build test
and publish Amazon Alexa skills this
certification will help you gain basic
knowledge such as how to design the
architecture and user experience
elaborates on the best practices of AWS
and Alexa security it helps in
understanding the process of developing
testing and troubleshooting helps in
understanding the skill publishing
process and along with the Alexa
developer console
it consists of skill operations and life
cycles
the fee for completing the certification
is 300 US dollars
the recommended knowledge and experience
required to have before attempting the
certification are more than six months
of practical knowledge on building Alexa
skills using the Alexa skills kit
Advanced programming knowledge
next comes machine learning this
certification will help you learn how to
implement a suitable machine learning
algorithm for your business by unlocking
new insights
this certification will help you gain
basic knowledge such as choosing an
appropriate ml algorithm for a given
business problem
finding out appropriate AWS service to
implement ml Solutions
designing and applying scalable cost
efficient and secure ml Solutions
the fee for completing the certification
is 300 US dollars
the recommended knowledge and experience
required to have before attempting this
certification are understanding of basic
ml algorithms experience in implementing
hyper parameter optimization
familiar with machine learning and deep
learning Frameworks knowledge of ml
model training best practices knowledge
of ml deployment and operational best
practices
finally we will be discussing the AWS
database certification
this certification helps an individual
to learn the process of planning
designing and monitoring AWS database
Solutions
it validates an individual's ability to
differentiate the essential features of
AWS database services
analyze client requirements to create
and suggest suitable database Solutions
using AWS services
the fee for completing the certification
is 300 US dollars the eligibility
criteria required to complete the
certification are at least five years of
experience with basic database
Technologies minimum two years of
hands-on experience on AWS services
knowledge of AWS cloud-based relational
and nosql databases
a lot of people might be wondering about
the validity of the certification the
certification is valid for only two
years an individual has to take up the
exam every two years the reason behind
the logic of recertification is Amazon
keeps frequently adding new features and
services to their website in that case
staying up to date is essential
AWS re-certification consists of either
taking a step ahead that is advancing to
the next level of your certification
which is from associate level to the
professional level or taking a
re-certification test at a reduced cost
let's see the steps to create in AWS
account
the first step is to open the AWS web
page
then click create a free account to
display the sign in or create an AWS
account page
in this page click I am a new user
enter your email ID or mobile number in
the email or mobile number box and then
click sign in using secure server the
AWS servers verify if an account already
exists with the entered email ID if yes
it displays an error message else
displays the login credentials page
in the login credentials page enter the
name
re-enter the previously entered email ID
and the password for your account
then click create account to display the
contact information page
this page gives you the option to create
a company account or a personal AWS
account
for this demonstration we will create
personal AWS account
then enter your full name
and address in the displayed fields
next enter the captcha characters from
the displayed security image
an important step is to open the AWS
agreement and read it thoroughly then
select the AWS customer agreement
checkbox
selecting the check box indicates that
you have read the AWS agreement and you
agree to it then click create account
and continue to display payment
information page
in this page enter the credit card
details and then click verify card and
continue to display the identity
verification page
before displaying the identity
verification page the AWS servers verify
the entered credit or debit card details
by performing a reversible transaction
of a small amount
this page displays your entered mobile
number and is used to verify and confirm
your identity
as you click call me now the AWS system
calls you on the displayed number and
your computer screen displays a four
digit verification pin
enter the displayed four-digit pin in
your phone using the keypad
once the verification is successful the
page displays a message
identity verification complete
simply click continue to select your
support plan to display the support plan
page
page displays and explains about the
three support plans basic developer and
business
for this demonstration we will select
the free or basic plan and then click
continue to display the welcome page of
the AWS services
congratulations you have successfully
created an AWS account let's talk about
databases in AWS there are a host of
options to store your data by using
multiple database services in AWS so
quickly speaking you have RDS the
relational database service that
supports many engines then there's an
offering from AWS that is known as
Aurora it is a fully managed MySQL
compatible relational database service
then you have a nosql service offered
from AWS that is a fully managed Service
as well it is called
dynamodb we are going to take a look at
that then you have redshift that is a
petabyte level data warehousing service
again it is a fully managed service then
you have elastic cache that supports in
memory cache two very popular engines
such as memcached and redis then you
have a very cool service called database
migration service that basically allows
you to migrate your database from Oracle
to Aurora you can use the service and
then there is no downtime at all when
you use this service
so let's take a look at RDS
dynamodb elastic cache and redshift so
once you're in AWS console you can see
that this is the RDS and it is a
Management Service
which essentially means that batch
upgrade operating systems installation
are all taken care of by AWS then what
we are responsible for is when we store
our data we have to provide permissions
to set up the firewall settings and to
allow access for everything then of
course we are responsible for setting up
the databases but the engine is provided
by AWS
then if I click on this thing let's say
for example I want to fire my SQL
instance and if I click on this thing
I'll just show you how the high
availability as well as the backup is
taken care of by AWS
so I'll select my server my Hardware
that's based on my workload and then I
can do something called multi-az
deployment when I do this it basically
asks if you want to have a master save
configuration a high availability
configuration and when I do that then
yes I do get copies of my database in
the multiple availability zones within
the region and these are synchronized
replicated copies so in the event of
failure I will automatically be switched
onto the other availability Zone that
has the same copy of my database so
let's quickly add the dbe identifier and
the username and password so I'll just
call it MySQL for the sake of Simplicity
let me just copy and paste all these
okay it doesn't like that okay so it
doesn't like my SQL database and let us
copy it all
over
and then let's go to the next step
now when we go to advanced settings I'll
show you that they have something called
backup and then this backup is
automatically provisioned by AWS and you
can see here that there is a maintenance
window as well if I want I can give a
window then this is where you should
take my backup and the same thing for
the maintenance now these are all the
things that are taken care of by AWS and
in a traditional environment we have to
do all these things ourselves so this is
the beauty of using AWS that we don't
have to worry about the patches we don't
have to worry about the backup we don't
have to worry about the high
availability it's just configured and
all we have to do is set some security
rules some firewall rules and some
accessibility rules for the users coming
back to the nosql offering of AWS so
this is Amazon dynamodb again it is a
very fast and flexible no SQL database
so for all of your iot platforms for
your mobile for your gaming this is the
AWS service that you are going to use
because it is a schema-less database
essentially where you can have a keypad
value and you don't have to worry about
whether I'm going to store one value or
do I have to store values in all columns
as well it deals in something called
read capacity unit and write capacity
unit for your read requirement and For
Your Right requirement and that's how it
works you don't have to worry about the
provisioning of resources it scales
automatically
redshift is a petabyte scale data
warehousing solution and again it is a
managed service so you don't have to
worry about you know the OS level or the
patches the same thing goes with elastic
cache as well it supports the very
popular memcache and redis engines and
it is a fully managed service so you
don't have to worry about management or
scaling of all of the memory in these
engines
now let's look at storage services that
AWS offers
now storage makes up a very big part of
the services that AWS offers in the
cloud they are heavily used by multiple
organizations
individuals consumers around the world
so let's go and look at a few things so
EBS is essentially your block storage
your hard drives they are low latency
and all of your web servers and your
database servers your analytics engines
they all use EBS elastic block storage
let's say you have a requirement to have
shared file storage that is where you
are going to use elastic file storage
and again it provides High fault
tolerance with consistent latencies and
you pay only for what you use so you do
not have to pre-provision it just in the
case of EBS you need to pre-provision it
then you have S3 a simple storage
service and one of the most popular
Services of AWS launched way back in
2006 it is secure it has 11 9's
durability and it scales past tens of
trillions of objects and it has many
many use cases most importantly for
storage backup and Recovery tiered
archiver we're going to look at a demo
of that thing and it also acts like a
data link for big data analytics now if
we have something called cold data that
we want to keep for our audit records or
some archival record records AWS has
something called Glacier that is very
very economical archival service the
rates start as low as like four cents a
gigabyte which is very very cheap you
also have something called storage
Gateway where you apply this virtual
device to your data center and then you
can store all data through the storage
Gateway in the cloud this is one of the
very popular services in the hybrid
environment where you want to keep some
data in the cloud and some data in your
data center
there are a host of data transfer
services which help you move your data
to cloud and it can go from a small
amount of data that you can transfer
over the internet to exabytes of data
that you can transfer through truck to a
truck to AWS storage services so you
have something called data connect where
you connect directly to AWS Regional
data transfer you bypass the internet
and then your network is connected then
you have something called snowball which
is like a box where you migrate
petabytes of data in batches to the
cloud then you have something called
snowmobile where you migrate exabytes of
data in batches to the cloud and they
will simply send a truck to your data
center you plug it in the truck will
roll into AWS Data Center and then they
will put data anywhere you want
so let's also take a look at Kinesis
fire hose as well
so you have these Kinesis streams and
you have ingestion process streaming
data your iot data your mobile data your
Twitter feed the click stream data these
are the things you can use Kinesis to
store and process all of that data
this is where you would come in AWS
Services AWS console to request snowball
these are all the things that AWS gives
you to transfer your data again your
data is secure it's encrypted uh it's
addressed in transit and you can access
it anywhere using the internet let's
look at S3 in AWS Management console
S3 is a place which is used for data
leaks for any sort of data that you
would want to upload in Cloud I can very
easily go and I can create a bucket so
let's create a bucket
bucket is where you are going to store
your data all right so I have created
Albert simply learn labbucket and if I
click on it I can do so many things over
here I can upload any data that I want
over here I can send the permissions of
who all can access this data by default
in AWS it's a shared responsibility
model so I can upload the data and I can
choose who can access this data in S3
there are so many things that I can do
with this bucket that is my folder in
the cloud S3 that is simple storage
service I can enable versioning so I can
keep all the versions of my objects over
here I can set up logging I can set up a
static website hosting we will have a
demo for this static website hosting as
well but we don't have to worry about
this killing the load balancing Etc it
just scales automatically
I did mention that it's a great tool for
disaster recovery and what you can do is
you can set up your backups your
snapshots in S3 you can put all your
data in S3 you can simply enable the
cross region replication so what happens
is that let's say you are in Us East 1
or Northern Virginia region and you want
to set the cross region replication to
Oregon or maybe somewhere in Europe you
can just come over here and you can
enable the cross region replications so
what happens is AWS will automatically
replicate your data from one region to
another of your choice you decide where
you want your data to be replicated AWS
will not do so on its own
there are so many types of things that
you can do you can tag everything you
can give permissions to all your people
there are so many types of permissions
that you can give there is an access
control list you can set up a bucket
policy it's also tightly integrated with
identity and access management so you
can very easily command who is able to
access your bucket apart from that there
are some really interesting things there
is something called life cycle now this
is a tiered storage so normally whenever
you get data typically that data is
going to be very hot so you would Define
the data or classify the data as a hot
data warm data or cold depending on how
frequently it is accessed then you would
normally have a tiered storage so S3 has
four classes that's a standard storage
and infrequent access storage reduced
redundancy store storage where you would
put normally reproducible data and
archival storage that is Glacier so what
you normally do whenever you get some
data you would keep it in a standard and
you would know over a period of time you
would want to move that into an
infrequent storage like over here so I
will say that move this data into
infrequent storage which offers the same
security same durability but it's a lot
cheaper okay and then after that I can
also add a data that I want to move into
archive which is Glacier after some time
so we can add it to Glacier after 60
days and if I just click on next this is
where I will see it and then I can also
delete that object after whatever the
amount of time that I would want and I
click on it you see here that I have set
up a transition rule that says that for
the current version of the object
anything that I add to this S3 bucket I
want to transition all those objects
automatically to standard infrequent
access class
and then I will be charged lesser than
what I've been charged now and then I
also want to transition to Amazon
Glacier that is my archival service
after 60 days I do not want to delete
them ever so these are the things that
you can do with the S3 you also have a
lot of analytics tools which allow you
to see who is accessing your data what
data you have who is adding a lot of
data and these are all available to you
at a very economical rate
all these services are tightly
integrated with each other so you can
plug them in with an ec2 instance or IM
and you can get all the information at
your fingertips
so let's talk about static website
hosting on S3 and this is one of the
very very powerful features of S3 where
we can actually host a website and it's
static and some part dynamic as well so
you do not need a web server to host
your website I have this Bucket over
here AWS agile.n I click on it and you
can see that I have a couple of HTML
pages
error.html and
index.html and then my code my HTML CSS
files my image my video files are inside
the folder so I come over here I click
on the properties and you can see that
the bucket hosting is enabled so if I
click on it all I need is two documents
then whatever I want inside my website
if I simply click on this thing this is
what I get now these are the things that
I have inside my website my folder and
the beauty of it is that you do not need
any web servers you do not need any load
balancer you don't need any firewalls
you can simply give this URL and then
you can map it to your DNS the domain
name service and then anybody will type
your website name or your blog name and
then they are going to land on this page
and it's scalable it is load balanced
and you can scale it to any number of
people you can have millions of hits
coming in and this is one of the very
very very popular Services of S3
according to nist cloud computing is a
model for enabling ubiquitous convenient
on-demand network access
to a shared pool of configurable
computing resources
for example networks servers storage
applications and services
that can be rapidly provisioned and
released with minimal management effort
or service provider interaction
let us understand this definition by
focusing on a few key words
ubiquitous means irrespective of any
type of web enabled device or any type
of network
such as ethernet PPP FOC
Etc
we can access the services subscribed
from the service provider
cloud computing takes the technology
services and applications that are
similar to those on the internet and
turns them into a self-service utility
the latest version of nist definition
states that cloud computing networks
must use virtualization and
multi-tenancy
it also states that the customer must be
able to provision his or her Resources
with minimal management effort
and service providers interaction
this means customer can access the
resource subscribed from anywhere and
anytime
in the next slide we will discuss
essential characteristics of cloud
computing
nist states that there are five
essential characteristics which are
achieved by the service providers
so that they can call their service as
cloud service
the five essential characteristics are
on-demand self-service rapid elasticity
measured service
resource pooling
and Broad network access
let's understand each characteristic one
by one in the coming slides
the next slide will introduce us to the
concept of on-demand self-service
on-demand self-service means that a
client can provision Computer Resources
without the need for interaction with
the cloud service provider personnel
the customer gets the complete privilege
to select the resources and decide its
quantity based on their business process
without any formal consultation with the
service provider
the customer can access their dedicated
portal anytime and from anywhere
however he needs to comply with the
limitation of regulatory concern to
perform changes in configuration of the
current setup
the customer can upgrade or downgrade
Services anytime
also the upgrade or downgrade of
resources is committed in let's talk
about the economics of cloud
how much does it cost to be on cloud
what happens if I move some of my
resources from my data center to Cloud
how long is it going to take and if I
have to pay monthly what will my monthly
bill be how do I know that
AWS gives you a lot of tools to manage
your cost before you hop onto AWS cloud
or after you have made the move to Cloud
then once you have been on Cloud for a
while and we'll take a look at all of
these things so at the very beginning at
a very basic level it is the pay as you
go model
it is not a capex model that is capital
expenditure model it is an Opex model
so you pay only for what you use you do
not have to pay a fee or anything and
you can get a volume discount as well
so if you are a large organization and
you have multiple teams and multiple
accounts for AWS you can have a billing
option where you will have one person
one account that is going to pay the
bill for all of the accounts in the
organization and the benefit you get
from doing this is a volume discount
there are three tools that we are going
to look at now one is known as the AWS
cost calculator and what the AWS cost
calculator does for you is it tells you
how much you'll be charged for each
service for all the resources that you
are going to use
it will calculate and tell you your
monthly bill so in this scenario we are
looking at a very simple implementation
where we have a Dev environment a QA
environment and a broad environment
in Dev and QA we have one server each
that we are choosing as G2 dot medium
and in Broad we have two servers we know
that broad is going to run for a very
long time so we are using the billing
option of a one-year partial payment and
then we get a lot of discounts
if we know that this workload is going
to be required for up to three years
then we can select this option and we'll
get up to a 75 percent discount now
this is only for servers down below we
have used EBS volumes which are just
hard drives and then I also selected
three volumes one each for Dev QA and
production and then I also added how
much snapshot data I'm going to have
every month
if you see on the top of here that I get
the monthly bill now this is something
only for ec2 I could use the same thing
for my database as well so I will have
some databases as well and I can add all
the databases I need
apart from this if I scroll down here
there are so many services on your left
that you can see that if you want to use
all these services and it will just let
me know what the monthly charges for all
of these things
so this is something you can do before
you hop on to AWS there are servers I
have at my disposal in my data center
and then I'm going to transfer my
workload my application all my data to
the cloud how much am I going to pay and
this is a tool that is used day in and
day out by pre-sales persons by
Solutions Architects by Executives who
want to know beforehand how much they're
going to pay on the same line we have
something called TCO calculator that is
the total cost of ownership calculator
now here we can also add the manual
labor that we have the Personnel that we
have the power that we have and it goes
into more granular details of the
resources that we have it just gives you
a total cost of ownership and this is
why these two things are very very
beautiful things if you want to know
beforehand what will happen if you move
some of your workload to cloud and you
get a very very very good idea of the
cost that you are going to spend in
Cloud on a monthly basis coming back to
AWS console within the console there's a
tool called AWS trusted advisor that
essentially checks your implementations
so once you are on the cloud once you
have added all the sources on the cloud
from your databases your servers your
storage your cache everything then the
AWS trusted advisor checks all that you
have done and then it gives you
recommendations on four different things
among those four things are the cost
optimization which will tell you that if
you are using these workloads for
production you might want to convert
them into a reserve pricing option so
there are on-demand pricing options
there is a reserve pricing option and
then there's a spot pricing option
Reserve is the one that you use if you
know you are going to run this workload
for a period of one year two years or
three years then you can buy that
capacity in advance from AWS
and you don't have to necessarily pay
all the money up front you can do a
partial payment for one year and you
still get up to forty percent of the
discount which is really beautiful
apart from your cost AWS trusted advisor
also gives you recommendation on
performance on security and fault
tolerance so if you know some of your
firewall routes are not as stringent as
they should be it is going to scream at
you please don't do this
if you can see here I have some of my
security groups that have instance level
firewalls or they have unrestricted
access so I have kept it open for the
entire world and I really shouldn't be
doing that
so these are the things that AWS
provides for cost optimization and for
cost Management in Cloud so even before
you are into the cloud or when you have
been in the cloud for a while you can
use these tools to optimize your costs
on a regular basis let's look into what
we have in the AWS interview questions
which we find are important and our hope
is that you would use this material in
your interview preparation and be able
to crack that cloud interview and step
into your dream Cloud job so as you
progress in watching you're going to see
that these questions are practically
scenario based questions that tests the
depth of the knowledge of a person in a
particular AWS product or in a
particular AWS architecture so why wait
let's move on all right so in an
interview you would find yourself with a
question that might ask you define and
explain the three basic types of cloud
services and the AWS products that are
built based on them see here it's very
straightforward question just explain
three basic types of cloud service and
when we talk about basic type of cloud
service it's compute obviously that's a
very basic service storage obviously
because you need to store your data
somewhere and networking that actually
connects a couple of other services to
your application this basic will not
include monitoring these basic will not
include analytics because they are
considered as optional they are
considered as Advanced Services you
could choose a non-cloud service or a
product for monitoring of and for
analytics so they're not considered as
basic so when we talk about Basics they
are compute storage and networking and
the second part of the question says
explain some of the AWS products that
are built based on them of course
compute ec2 is a major one that's that's
the major share of the compute resource
and then we have platform as a service
which is elastic bean stock and then
function as a service which is Lambda
Auto scaling and light cell are also
part of compute services so the compute
domain it really helps us to run any
application and the compute service
helps us in managing the scaling and
deployment of an application again
Lambda is a compute service so the
compute service also helps in running
event initiated stateless applications
the next one was storage a lot of
emphasis is on storage these days
because if there's one thing that grows
in a network on a daily basis that
storage every new day we have new data
to store process manage so the storage
is again a basic and an important cloud
service and the products that are built
based on the storage services are S3
object storage Glacier for archiving EBS
elastic block storage as a drive
attachment for the ec2 instances and the
EFS file share for the ec2 instances so
the storage domain helps in the
following aspects it holds all the
information that the application uses so
it's the application data and we can
also archive old data using storage
which would be Glacier and any object
files and any requirement for Block
storage can be met through elastic Block
store and S3 which is again an object
storage talking about networks it's just
not important to answer the question
with the name of the services and the
name of the product it'll also be good
if you could go in depth and explain how
they can be used right so that actually
proves you to be a person knowledgeable
enough in that particular service or
product so talking about networking
domain VPC networking can't imagine
working without VPC in in the cloud
environment especially in AWS Cloud
environment and then we have Route 53
for domain resolution or for DNS and
then we have cloudfront which is an edge
caching service that helps customers get
our customers to read their application
with low latency so networking domain
helps with some of the following use
cases it controls and manages the
connectivity of the AWS services within
our account and we can also pick an IP
address range if you're a network
engineer or if you are somebody who
works in networks or planning to work a
network you will soon realize the
importance of choosing your own IP
address for easy remembering so having
an option to have your own IP address in
the cloud owned Range of IP address in
the cloud it really helps really really
helps in Cloud networking the other
question that get asked would be the
difference between the availability Zone
and the region actually the question
generally gets asked so to test how well
you can actually differentiate and also
correlate the availability Zone and the
region relationship right so a region is
a separate geographic area like the
us2s1 I mean which represents not
California or the AP South which
represents Mumbai so regions are a
separate geographic area on the contrary
availability Zone resides inside the
region you shouldn't stop there you
should go further and explain about
availability zones and availability
zones are isolated from each other and
some of the services will replicate
themselves within the available LED zone
so availability Zone does replication
within them but regions they don't
generally do replication between them
the other question you could be asked is
what is auto scaling what do we achieved
by Auto scaling so in short Auto scaling
it helps us to automatically provision
and launch new instances Whenever there
is an demand it not only helps us
meeting the increasing demand it also
helps in reducing the resource usage
when there is low demand so Auto scaling
also allows us to decrease the resources
or resource capacity as per the need of
that particular R now this helps
business in not worrying about putting
more effort in managing or continuously
monitoring the server to see if they
have the needed resource or not because
Auto scaling is gonna handle it for us
so business does not need to worry about
it and auto scaling is one big reason
reason why people would want to go and
pick a cloud service especially in AWS
service the ability to increase and
Shrink based on the need of that art
that's how powerful is auto scaling the
other question you could get asked is
what's your targeting in Cloud front now
we know that cloudfront is caching and
it caches content globally in the Amazon
caching service Global wide the whole
point is to provide users worldwide
access to the data from a very nearest
server possible that's the whole point
in using or going for cloudfront then
what do you mean by Geo targeting
geotargeting is showing customer and
specific content based on language we
can customize the content based on
what's popular in that place we can
actually customize the content the URL
is the same but we could actually change
the content a little bit not the whole
content otherwise it would be dynamic
but we can change the content a little
bit a specific a file or a picture or a
particular Link in a website and show
customized content to users who will be
in different parts of the globe so how
does it happen cloudfront will detect
the country where the viewers are
located and it will forward the country
code to the origin server and once the
origin server gets the specialized or a
specific country code it will change the
content and it will send to the caching
server and it get cached there forever
and the user gets to view a Content
which is personalized for them for the
country they are in the other question
you could get asked is the steps
involved in using cloud formation or
creating a cloud formation or a backing
up an environment within cloud formation
template we all know that if there is a
template we can simply run it and it
Provisions the environment but there is
a lot more going into it so the first
step in moving towards infrastructure as
a code is to create the cloud formation
template which as of now supports Json
and yaml file format so first create the
cloud formation template and then save
the code in an X3 bucket S3 bucket
serves as the repository for our code
and then from the cloud formation call
the file in the S3 bucket and create a
stack and now cloud formation uses the
file reads the file understands services
that are being called understands the
order understands how they are connected
with each other cloud formation is
actually an intelligent service it
understands the relation based on the
code it would understand the
relationship between the different
services and it would set an order for
itself and then would provision the
services one after the other let's say a
service has a dependency and the
dependent service the other service
which This Server service let's say it
serves A and B service B is dependent on
service a let's say cloud formation is
an intelligent service it would
provision the resource a first and then
would provision resource B so what
happens if we inverse the order if we
inverse the order resource B first gets
provision and because it does not have
dependency chances that the cloud
formation's default behavior is that if
something is not provisioned properly if
something is not healthy it would roll
back chances that the environment
provisioning will roll back so to avoid
that cloud formation first Provisions
all the services that has or that's
dependent on that's depended by another
service so it Provisions those service
first and then Provisions the services
that has dependencies and if you are
being hired for a devops or you know if
the interviewer wanted to test your
skill on systems aside this definitely
would be a question in his list how do
you upgrade or downgrade a system with
near zero downtime now everybody's
moving towards zero downtime or near
zero downtime all of them want their
application to be highly available so
the question would be how do you
actually upgrade or downgrade a system
with near zero downtime now we all know
that I can upgrade an ec2 instance to a
better ec2 instance by changing the
instance type stopping and starting but
stopping and starting is gonna cause a
downtime right so that's you should be
answering or you shouldn't be thinking
in those terms because that's the wrong
answer specifically the interviewer
wants to know how do you upgrade a
system with zero downtime so upgrading
system with zero downtime it includes
launching another system parallelly with
the bigger ec2 instance type over the
bigger capacity and install all that's
needed if you are going to use an Ami of
the old machine well and good you don't
have to go through installing all the
updates and installing all the
application from the Ami once you have
launched it in a bigger instance locally
test the application to see if it is
working don't put it on production yet
working and if the application works we
can actually swap if your server is
behind and behind a Route 53 let's say
all that you could do is go to Route 53
update the information with the new IP
address new IP address of the new server
and that's going to send traffic to the
new server now so the cutover is handled
or if you're using static IP you can
actually remove the static IP from the
old machine and assign it to the new
machine that's one way of doing it or if
you are using elastic Nik card you can
actually remove the new card from the
old machine and attach the new cards to
the new machine so that way we would get
near zero downtime if you're hired for
an architect level you should be
worrying about cost as well along with
the technology and this question would
test how well you manage cost so what
are the tools and techniques we can use
in AWS to identify and correct identify
and know that we are paying the correct
amount for the resources that we are
using or how do you get a visibility of
your AWS resources running one way is to
check the billing there's a place where
you can check the top services that were
utilized it could be free and it could
be paid Service as well top services
that can be utilized it's actually in
the dashboard of the cost Management
console so that table here shows the top
five most used services so looking at it
you can get it all right so I'm using a
lot of storage I'm using a lot of ec2
why is storage high you can go and try
to justify that and you will find if you
are storing things that should be
storing and then click clean it up why
is compute capacity so high why is data
transfer so high so if you start
thinking in those levels you'll be able
to dig in and clean up unnecessary and
be able to save your bill and there are
cost Explorer services available which
will help you to view your usage pattern
or view your spending for the past 13
months or so and it will also forecast
for the next three months now how much
will you be using if your pattern is
like this so that will actually help and
will give you a visibility on how much
you have spent how much you will be
spending if the trend continues budgets
are another excellent a way to control
cost you can actually set up budget all
that this is how much I am willing to
spend for this application for this team
or for this month for this particular
resource so you can actually put a
budget Mark and anytime it exceeds
anytime it's nearing you would get an
alarm saying that well we're about to
reach the allocate rated budget amount
stuff like that that way you can go back
and know and you know that how much the
bill is going to be for that month or
you can take steps to control bill
amount for that particular month so AWS
budget is another very good tool that
you could use cost allocation tags helps
in identifying which team or which
resource has spent more in that
particular month instead of looking at
the bill as one list with no
specifications into it and looking at it
as an expenditure list you can actually
break it down and tag the expenditure to
the teams with cost allocation tags the
dev team has spent so much the
production team has spent so much the
training team has spent more than the
dev and the production team why is that
you'll be able to you know think in
those levels only if you have cost
allocation tags now cost allocation tags
are nothing but the tags that you would
put when you create a resource so for
Production Services you would put as a
production you would create a production
tag and you would associate that
resources to it and at a later point
when you actually pull up your bill
that's going to show a detailed a list
of this is the owner this is the group
and this is how much they have used in
the last month and you can move forward
with your investigation and encourage or
stop users using more services with the
cost allocation tax the other famous
question is are there any other tools or
is there any other way of accessing AWS
results other than the console console
is GUI right so in other words other
than GUI how would you use the AWS
resource and how familiar are you with
those tools and Technologies the other
tools that are available that we can
leverage and access the AWS resource are
of course footy you can configure Puri
to access the AWS resources like log
into an ec2 instance an ec2 instance
does not always have to be logged in
through the console you could use putty
to log into an ec2 instance and like the
jump box like the proxy machine and like
the Gateway machine and from there you
can actually access the rest of the
resources so this is an alternative to
the console and of course we have the
AWS CLI in any of the Linux machines or
Windows machines we can install so
that's 0.23 and 4 we can install AWS CLI
for Linux Windows also for Mac so we can
install them and from there from your
local machine we can access run AWS
commands and access provision monitor
the AWS resources the other ones are we
can access the AWS resource
programmatically using AWS SDK and
Eclipse so these are a bunch of options
we have to use the AWS resource other
than the console if you are interviewed
in a company or buy a company that
focuses more on security and want to use
AWS native services for their security
then you will come across this question
what services can be used to create a
centralized logging solution the basic
Services we could use are cloudwatch
logs store them in S3 and then use
elasticsearch to visualize them and use
Kinesis to move the data from S3 to
elasticsearch right so log management it
actually helps organizations to track
the relationship between operational and
security changes and the events that got
triggered based on those logs i instead
of logging into an instance or instead
of logging into the environment and
checking the resources physically I can
come to a fair conclusion by just
looking at the logs every time there's a
change the system would scream and it
gets tracked in the cloud watch and then
Cloud watch pushes it to S3 Kinesis
pushes the data from S3 to elasticsearch
and I can do a Time based filter and I
would get an a fair understanding of
what was going on in the environment for
the past one hour or whatever the time
window that I wanted to look at so it
helps in getting a good understanding of
the infrastructure as a whole all the
logs are getting saved in one place so
all the infrastructure logs are getting
saved in one place so it's easy for me
to look at it in an infrastructure
perspective so we know the services that
can be used and here are some of the
services and how they actually connect
to each other it could be logs that
belongs to One account it could be logs
that belongs to multiple accounts it
doesn't matter you know those three
services are going to work fairly good
and they're gonna inject or they're
gonna like suck logs from the other
accounts put it in one place and help us
to monitor so as you see you have Cloud
watch here that actually tracks the
metrics you can also use cloud trail if
you want to log API calls as well push
them in an S3 bucket so there are
different types of logs flow logs are
getting captured in an instance
application logs are getting captured
from the same VPC from a different VPC
from the same account from a different
account and all of them are analyzed
using elasticsearch using the kibana
client so step one is to deploy the ECS
cluster step two is to restrict access
to the ECS cluster because it's valid
data you don't want anybody to put their
hands and access their data so resting
access to the ECS dashboard and we could
use Lambda also to push the data from
cloud watch to The elasticsearch Domain
and then kibana is actually the
graphical tool that helps us to
visualize the logs instead of looking at
log as just statements or a bunch of
characters a bunch of files kibana helps
us to analyze the logs in a graphical or
a chart or a bar diagram format again in
an interview the interview is more
concerned about testing your knowledge
on AWS security products especially on
the logging monitoring even management
or Incident Management then you could
have a question like this what are the
native AWS security logging capabilities
now most of the services have their own
logging in them like have their own
logging like S3 S3 has its own login and
cloudfront has its own logging DS has
its own logging VPC has its own logging
in additional there are account level
logins like a cloudtrail and AWS config
services so there are a variety of
logging options available in the AWS
like Cloud soil config cloudfront
redshift logging RDS logging VPC flow
logs S3 object logging S3 access logging
stuff like that so we're going to look
at two servers in specific cloudtrail
now this cloud trail the very first
product in that picture we just are the
cloudtrail provides an very high level
history of the API calls for all the
account and with that we can actually
perform a very good security analysis a
security analysis of our account and
these logs are actually delivered to you
can configure it they can be delivered
to S3 for long time archivals and based
on a particular event it can also send
an email notification to us saying hey
just got this error thought I'll let you
know stuff like that the other one is
config service now config service helps
us to understand the configuration
changes that happened in our environment
and we can also set up notifications
based on the configuration changes so it
records the cumulative changes that are
made in a short period of time so if you
want to go through the lifetime of a
particular resource what are the things
that happen what are the things it went
through they can be looked at using aw
nucleus config all right the other
question you could get asked is if you
know your role includes taking care of
cloud security as well then the other
question you could get asked is the
native services that Amazon provides
automaticate DDOS which is denial of
service now not all companies would go
with Amazon native services but there
are some companies which want to stick
with Amazon native Services just to save
them from the headache of managing the
other softwares or bringing in another
tool a third-party tool into managing
DDOS they simply want to stick with
Amazon proprietary Amazon native
services and a lot of companies are
using Amazon service to prevent DDOS
denial of service now denial of service
is if you already know what denial of
service is well and good if you do not
know then let's know it now denial of
service is a user trying to or
maliciously making attempt to access a
website or an application the user would
actually create multiple sessions and he
would occupy all the sessions and he
would not let legimate users access the
servers so he's in turn denying the
service for the user a quick picture
review of what denial of services now
look at it these users instead of making
one connection they are making multiple
connections and there are cheap software
programs available that would actually
trigger connections from different
computers in the internet with different
Mac addresses so everything kind of
looks legimate for the server and it
would accept those connections and it
would keep the sessions open the actual
users won't be able to use them so
that's denying the service for the
actual users denial of service all right
and distributed denial of service is
generating attacks from multiple places
you know from a distributed environment
so that's distributed denial of service
so the tools the native tools that helps
us to provide event the denial of
service attacks in AWS is cloud shield
and web access firewall AWS web now they
are the major ones they are designed to
mitigate a denial of service if your
website is often bothered by denial of
service then we should be using AWS
Shield or AWS Waf and there are a couple
of other tools that all showed us when I
say that also does denial of service is
not their primary job but you could use
them for denial of service route 53's
purpose is to provide DNS cloudfront is
to provide caching elastic load balancer
elb's work is to provide load balancing
VPC is to create and secure a virtual
private environment but they also
support mitigating denial of service but
not to the extent you would get in AWS
shield and AWS web so AWS shield and Waf
are the primary ones but the rest can
also be used to mitigate distributed
denial of service the other tricky
question is this actually will test your
familiarity with the region and the
services available in the region so when
you're trying to provision a service in
a particular region you're not seeing
the service in that region how do we go
about fixing it or how do we go about
using the service in the cloud it's a
tricky question and if you have not gone
through such situation you can totally
blow it away you really need to have a
good understanding on regions the
services available in those regions and
what a particular service is not
available how to go about doing it the
answer is not all services are available
in all regions anytime Amazon announces
a new service they don't immediately
publish them on all regions they start
small and as in when the traffic
increases as and when it becomes more
likeable to the customers they actually
move the service to different regions so
as you see in this picture within
America North Virginia has is more
services compared to Ohio or Compared to
North California So within not America
itself North Virginia is the preferred
one so similarly there are preferred
regions within Europe Middle East and
Africa and prefer regions within Asia
Pacific so anytime we don't see a
service in a particular region chances
that the service is not available in
that region yet we got to check the
documentation and find the nearest
region that offers that service and
start using the service from that region
now you might think well if I'm looking
for a service in Asia let's say in
Mumbai and if it is not available why
not simply switch to North Virginia and
start using it you could but you know
that's going to add more latency to your
application so that's why we need to
check for application which is check for
region which is very near to the place
where you want to serve your customers
and find nearest region instead of
always going back to North Virginia and
deploying an application in North
Virginia again let's as you place
there's a link in aws.com that you can
go and look for services available in
different region and that's exactly what
you're seeing here and if your service
is not available in a particular region
switch to the other region that provides
your service the nearest other region
that provides that service and start
using service from there with the coming
up of cloud a lot of companies have
turned down their monitoring team
instead they want to go with the
monitorings that cloud provides you know
nobody wants to or at least many people
don't want to go through the hassle of
at least new startups and new companies
that are thinking of having a monitoring
environment that they don't want to go
with traditional knock monitoring
instead they would like to leverage AWS
monitorings available because it
monitors a lot of stuff not just the
availability but it monitors a lot of
stuff like failures errors it also
triggers emails stuff like that so how
do you actually set up a monitor the
website how to set up a Monitor to
Monitor the website metrics in real time
in AWS the simple way anytime you have a
question about monitoring cloudwatch
should strike your mind because
cloudwatch is meant for monitoring is
meant for collecting metrics is is meant
for providing graphical representation
of what's going on in a particular
Network at a particular point of time so
Cloud watch cloudwatch helps us to
monitor applications and using
cloudwatch we can monitor the state
changes not only the state changes the
auto scaling life cycle events anytime
there are more services added there is a
reduction in the number of servers
because of less usage a very informative
messages can be received through
cloudwatch any cloudwatch can now
support scheduled events if you want to
schedule anything cloudwatch has an
event that would schedule an action
right schedule a Trigger Time based not
incident based you know anything
happening and then you get an action
happening that's incident based on the
other hand you can simply schedule few
things on time based so that's possible
with Cloud watch So This Cloud watch
integrates very well with a lot of other
services like notifications for
notifying the user or for notifying the
administrator about it and it can
integrate well with Lambda so to trigger
an action anytime you're designing an
auto healing environment This Cloud
watch can actually monitor and send an
email if we are integrating it with SNS
simple notification service or this
Cloud watch can monitor and based on
what's Happening it can trigger an event
in Lambda and that would in turn run a
function till the environment comes back
to normal so cloudwatch integrates well
with a lot of other AWS Services all
right so cloudwatch has three statuses
green when everything is going good
hello when the service is degraded and
red when the service is not available
green is good so we don't have to do
anything about it but anytime there is
an Lo the picture that we're looking at
it's actually calling an Lambda function
to debug the application and to fix it
and anytime there's a red alert it
immediately notifies the owner of the
application about well this service is
down and here is the report that I have
here is the metrics that I've collected
about the service stuff like that if the
job role requires you to manage the
servers as well there are certain job
roles which are on the system side there
are certain job roles which is
development plus system side now you're
responsible for the application and the
server as well so if that's the case you
might be tested with some basic
questions like the different types of
virtualization in AWS and what are the
difference between them all right the
three major types of virtualization are
hvm which is Hardware virtual machine
the other one is PV para virtualization
and the third one is PV on hvm para
virtualization on Hardware virtual
module all right the difference between
them are actually describing them is
actually the difference between them hvm
it's actually a fully virtualized
Hardware you know the whole Hardware is
virtualized and all virtual machines act
separate from each other and these VMS
are booted by executing Master boot
record in the root block and when we
talk about para virtualization paragraph
is actually the special boot loader
which boots the PV Amis and when we talk
about PV on hvm it's it's actually the
marriage between hvm and PV and this
para virtualization on hvm in other
words PV on hvm it actually helps
operating system take advantage in
storage and the network input output
available through the host another good
question is name some of the services
that are not region specific now you've
been thought that all services are
within a region and some services are
within an availability zone for example
ec2 is within an availability Zone EBS
is within an availability Zone S3 is
region specific dynamodb is region
specific stuff like that VPC is both
availability and region specific meaning
you know subnets are availability Zone
specific and vpc's region specific stuff
like that so you might have thought you
might have learned in that combination
but that could be some tricky questions
that tests you how well you have
understood the region non-region and
availability non-availability Services I
should say there are services that are
not region specific that would be IAM so
we can't have IM for every availability
Zone and for every region which means
you know users will have to use one
username and password for one region and
anytime they switch to another region
they will have to use another username
and password that that's more work then
that's not a good design as well
authentication has to be Global so IM is
a global Service and which means it's
not region specific on the other hand
Route 53 is again a regional Pacific so
we can't have a Route 53 for every
region Route 53 is not a region specific
service it's a global Service and it's
one application users access from
everywhere or from every part of the
world so we can't have one URL or one
DNS name for each region if your
application is a global application and
then web application firewall works well
with cloudfront then cloudfront is a
region based service so the web
application firewall it's not region
specific service it's a global Service
and cloudfront is again a global Service
though you can you know cache content on
a continent and country basis it's still
considered a global Service all right
it's not bound to any region so when you
activate cloudfront you're activating it
away from region or availability zone so
when you're activating a web application
firewall because it's not a region
specific service you're activating it
away from availability Zone and regions
so a quick recap I am users groups roles
and accounts they are Global Services
they can be used globally around 53
services are offered at Edge locations
and they are Global as well web
application firewall a service that
protects our web application from common
web exploits they are Global Services
well Cloud front Cloud front is global
content delivery Network CDN and they
are offered at Edge locations which are
a global Service in other words
non-region specific service or Beyond
region service all right this is another
good question as well in the project
that you are being interviewed if they
really want to secure their environment
using Nat or if they are already
securing their environment using Nat by
any of these two methods like Nat
Gateway or Nat instances you can expect
this question what are the difference
between a Nat Gateway and Nat instances
now they both saw the same thing right
so they're not two different Services
trying to achieve two different things
they both serve the same thing but still
they do have differences in them all
right on a high level they both achieve
providing nothing for the service behind
it but the difference comes when we talk
about the availability of it Nat Gateway
is a managed service by Amazon whereas
Nat instance is managed by us now I'm
talking about the third Point
maintenance here not Gateway is managed
by Amazon that instance is managed by us
and availability of nat Gateway is very
high and availability of nat instance is
less compared to the NAT Gateway because
it's managed by us you know it's on an
ec2 instance which could actually fail
and if it fails we'll have to relaunch
it but if it is not Gateway if something
happens to that service Amazon would
take care of reprovisioning it and
talking about bandwidth it can burst up
to 75 gigabits now traffic through the
nag Gateway can burst up to 75 gigabits
but for that instance it actually
depends on the server that we launched
and if we are launching a T2 micro it
barely gets any bandwidth so there's a
difference there and the performance
because it's highly available because of
the bigger pipe 75 gigabits now the
performance of the NAT Gateway is very
high but the performance of the NAD
instance is going to be average again it
depends on the size of the NAT instance
that we pick and billing a billing for
Nat Gateway is the number of gateways
that will be provision and the duration
for which we use the NAT Gateway but
billing for Nat instance is number of
instance and the type of instance that
we use of course number of instance
duration and the type of instance that
we use Security in that Gateway cannot
be assigned meaning it already comes
with full backed security but but in
that instance security is a bit
customizable I can go and change the
security because it's a server managed
by me or managed by us I can always
change the security well allow this
allow don't allow this stuff like that
size and load of the NAT Gateway is
uniform but the size and the load of the
NAT instance changes as per around
Gateway is a Fix-It product but not
instance can be small instance can be a
big instance so the size and the load
through it varies
right the other question you could get
asked is what are the difference between
stopping and terminating an ec2 instance
now you will be able to answer only if
you have worked on environments where
you have your instance stopped and where
you have your instance terminated if you
have only used lab and are attending the
interview chances are that you might you
always lost when answering this question
it might look like both are the same
well stopping and terminating both are
the same but there is a difference in it
so when you stop an instance it actually
performs a normal shutdown on the
instance and it simply moves the
instance to the stop state but when you
actually terminate the instance the
instance is moved to this stop State the
EBS volumes that are attached to it are
deleted and removed and will never be
able to recover them again so that's a
big difference between stopping and
terminating an instance if you're
thinking of using the instance again
along with the data in it you should
only be thinking of stopping the
instance but you should be terminating
the instance only if you want to get rid
of that instance forever
if you are being interviewed for an
architect level position or a junior
architect level position or even an
Cloud consultant level position or even
in an engineering position this is a
very common question that get asked what
are the different types of ec2 instances
based on their cost or based on how we
pay them right they're all compute
capacity for example the different types
are on-demand instances fought instances
and reserved instances it kind of looks
the same they all provide the compute
capacity they all provide the same type
of Hardwares for us but if you are
looking at Cost saving or optimizing
cost in our environment we're going to
be very careful about which one are we
picking now we might think that well
I'll go with on-demand instance because
I pay on a per hour basis which is cheap
you know I can use them anytime I want
and anytime I don't want I can simply
get rid of it by terminating it you're
right but if the requirement is to use
the service for one year the requirement
is to use the service for three years
then you'll be wasting a lot of money
buying on-demand instances you'll be
wasting a lot of money paying on an
hourly basis instead we should be going
for reserved instance where we can
reserve the capacity for the complete
one year or complete three years and
save huge amount in buying reserved
instances alright so on-demand is cheap
to start with if you are only planning
to use it for a short while but if
you're planning to run it for a long
while then we should be going for
reserved instance that is what is cost
efficient so spot instance is cheaper
than on-demand instance and there are
different use cases for spot instance as
well so let's look at one after the
other the on-demand instance the
on-demand instance is purchased at a
fixed rate per hour this is very short
term and irregular workloads and for
testing for development on demand
instance is a very good use case we
should be using on-demand for production
Spartan instance spot instance allows
users to purchase ec2 at a reduced price
and anytime we have more instances we
can always go and sell it in spot
instances I'm referring to anytime we
have more reserved instances we can
always sell them in spot instance
catalog and the way we buy Spot instance
is we actually put a budget this is how
much I'm willing to pay all right would
you be able to give service within this
cost so anytime the price comes down and
meets the cost that we have put in will
be assigned an instance and anytime the
price shoots up the instance will be
taken away from us but in case of
on-demand instances we have bought that
instance for that particular R and it
stays with us but with spot instances it
varies based on the price if you meet
the price you get the instance if you
don't meet the price it goes away to
somebody else and the spot instance
availability is actually based on supply
and demand in the market there's no
guarantee that you will get support
instance at all time all right so that's
that's a caveat there you should be
familiar with that's a caveat there you
should be aware when you are proposing
somebody that we can go for spot
instance and save money it's not always
going to be available if you want your
spot instance to be available to you
then we need to carefully watch the
history of the price of the spot
instance now how much was it last month
and how much was it how much is it this
month so how can I code or how much can
I code stuff like that so you got to
look at those history before you propose
somebody that well we're going to save
money using spot instance on the other
hand reserved instance provide cost
savings for the company or we can opt
for reserved instances for you know one
year or three years there are actually
three types of reserved instances light
medium and heavy reserved instances they
are based on the amount that we would be
paying and cost benefit also depends
with reserved instance the cost benefit
also depends based on are we doing all
up Trend or no upfront or partial
payment then split the rest as monthly
payments so there are many purchase
options available but overall if you're
looking at using an application for the
next one year and three years you should
not be going for on-demand instance you
should be going for reserved instance
and that's what gives you the cost
benefit
and in an AWS interview sometimes you
might be asked you know how you interact
with the AWS environment are you using
CLI are you using console and depending
on your answer whether console or a CLI
the panelist put a score okay this
person is CLI specific this person is
console specific or this person has used
AWS environment through the SDK stuff
like that so this question tests whether
you are a CLI person or an a console
person and the question goes like this
how do you set up SSH agent forwarding
so that you do not have to copy the key
every time you log in if you have used
Puri anytime if you want to log into an
ec2 instance you will have to put the IP
and the port number along with that you
will have to map or we will have to map
the key in the Puri and this has to be
done every time that's what we would
have done in our lab environments right
but in production environment using the
same key or mapping the same key again
and again every time it's actually a
hassle it's considered as a blocker so
you might want to Cache it you might
want to permanently add it in your putty
session so you can immediately log in
and start using it so here in the place
where you would actually map the private
key there's a quick button that actually
fixes or that actually binds your SSH to
your pretty instance so we can enable
SSH agent forwarding and that will
actually bind our key to the SSH and
next time when we try to log in we don't
have to always go through mapping the
key and trying to log in all right this
question what are Solaris and ax
operating systems are they available
with AWS that question generally gets
asked to test how familiar are you with
the Amis available how familiar are you
with ec2 how familiar are you with the
ec2 Hardwares available that basically
tests that now the first question or the
first thought that comes to your mind is
well everything is available with AWS
I've seen Windows I've seen Ubuntu I've
seen Red Hat I've seen Amazon Amis and
if I don't see my operating system there
I can always go to Marketplace and try
them if I don't final Marketplace I can
always go to community and try them so a
lot of Amis available there are a lot of
operating systems available I will be
able to find Solaris and ax but that's
not the case Solaris and ax are not
available with AWS that's because
Solaris uses a different I mean Solaris
does not support the architecture does
not support public Cloud currently the
same goes for ax as well and they run on
power CPU and not on Intel and as of now
Amazon does not provide Power machines
this should not be confused with HPC
which is a high performance Computing
should not be confused with that now
these are different Hardwares different
CPU itself that the cloud providers did
do not provide yet another question you
could get asked in organizations that
would want to automate the their
infrastructure using Amazon native
Services would be how do you actually
recover an ec2 instance or Auto recover
an ec2 instance when it fails oh well we
know that ec2 instances are considered
as immutable meaning irreparable we
don't spend time fixing bugs in an OS
stuff like that you know once an ec2
instance crashes like it goes on a over
spanic or there are various reasons why
it would fail so we don't have to really
worry about fixing it we can always
relaunch that instance and that would
fix it but what if it happens at two
o'clock in the night what if it happens
that during a weekend when nobody is in
office now looking or monitoring those
instances so you would want to automate
that not only on a weekend or during
midnights but it's general practice good
to automate it so you could face this
question how do you actually automate an
ec2 instance once it fails and the
answer to that question is using Cloud
watch we can recover the instance so as
you see there is an alarm threshold a
set in Cloud watch and once the
threshold is met meaning if there is an
error if there is a failure if the ec2
instance is not responding for a certain
while we can set an alarm and once the
alarm is met let's say the CPU
utilization stayed high for 5 minutes
all right it's not taking any new
connections or the instance is not
pinging for five minutes or in this case
it's two minutes it's not pinging so
it's not going to respond connection so
in those cases you would want to
automatically recover that ec2 instance
by rebooting the instance all right now
look at this the take this action
section under the action so there we
have a bunch of options like recover
this instance meaning reboot the
instance so that's how we would recover
the other two options are beyond the
scope of the question but still you can
go ahead and apply just like I'm gonna
do it so the other option to stop the
instance that's very useful when you
want to stop instances that are having
low utilizations nobody is using the
system as of now you don't want them to
be running and wasting the cloud
expenditure so you can actually set an
alarm that stops the ec2 instance that's
having low utilization so somebody was
working in an instance and they left it
without or they forgot to shut down that
instance and it gets I mean they will
only use it again the next day morning
so in between there could be like 12
hours that the system is running idle
nobody is using it and you're paying for
it so you can identify such instances
and actually stop them when the CPU
utilization is low meaning nobody is
using it the other one is to terminate
let's say you want to give system to
somebody temporarily and you don't want
them to hand the system back to you all
right this is actually an idea in other
words this is actually the scenario so
you hand over a system to somebody and
when they're done they're done we can
actually terminate the system so you
could instruct the other person to
terminate the system when they're done
and they could forget and the instance
could be running forever or you can
monitor the system after the specified
time is over and you can terminate the
system or best part you can automate the
system termination so you assign a
system to somebody and then turn on this
cloudwatch action to terminate the
instance when the CPU is low for like
two hours meaning they've already left
or CPU is low for 30 minutes meaning
they've already left stuff like that so
that's possible and if you're getting
hired for an system side architect or
even on the sysop site you could face
this question what are the common and
different types of Ami designs there are
a lot of AMR designs the question is the
common ones and the difference between
them so the common ones are the full
back Amis and the other one is just
enough OS Ami je OS Ami and the other
one is hybrid type Amis so let's look at
the difference between them the full
backed Ami just like the name says it's
fully baked it's ready to use Ami and
this is the simplest Ami to deploy can
be a bit expensive it can be a bit a
cumbersome because you'll have to do a
lot of work beforehand you could use the
Amis a lot of planning a lot of thought
process will go into it and the Ami is
ready to use right you hand over the Ami
to somebody and it's ready to use or if
you want to reuse the Ami it's already
ready for you to use so that's full
baked Ami the other one is just enough
operating system Ami just like the name
says it has I mean as you can also see
in the diagram or in the picture it
covers a part of the OS all bootstraps
are already packed properly and the
security monitoring logging and the
other stuff are configured at the time
of deployment or at the time you would
be using it so not much thought process
will go in here the only focus is on
choosing the operating system and what
goes the operating system specific
agents or bootstraps that goes into the
operating system that's all we worry
about the advantage of this is it's
flexible meaning you can choose to
install additional softwares at the time
of deploying but that's going to require
an additional expertise on the person
who will be using the Ami so that's
another overhead there but the advantage
is that it's kind of flexible I can
change the configurations during the
time of deployment the other one is the
hybrid Ami now the hybrid Ami actually
falls in between the fully baked Ami and
just enough operating system options so
these Amis have some features of the big
type and some features of the just
enough OS type so as you see the
security monitoring logging are packed
in that Ami and the runtime environments
are installed stalled during the time of
a deployment so this is where the strict
company policies would go into the Ami
company policies like you got to lock
this you got to monitor this these are
the ports that generally gets open in
all the systems stuff like that so they
strictly go into the Ami and sits in an
AMF format and during deployment you
have the flexibility of choosing the
different runtime and the application
that sits in an ec2 instance another
very famous question you would face in
an interview is how can you recover
login to an ec2 instance to which you
lost the key well we know that if the
key is lost we can't recover it there
are some organizations that integrate
their ec2 instances with an ad that's
different all right so you can go and
reset the password in the ad and you
will be able to log in with the new
password but here the specific tricky
question is you are using a key to log
in and how do you recover if you have
lost the key generally companies would
have made a backup of the key so we can
pick from the backup but here the
specific question is we have lost the
key literally no backups on the key at
all so how can we log in and we know
that we can't log into the instance
without the key present with us so the
steps to recover is that make the
instance use another key and use that
key to log in once the key is lost it's
lost forever we won't be able to recover
it you can't raise a ticket with Amazon
not possible they're not going to help
it's beyond the scope so make the
instance use another key it's only the
key that's the problem you still have
valid data in it you got to recover the
data it's just the key that's having the
problem so we can actually focus on the
key part alone and change the key and
that will allow us to log in so how do
we do it step by step procedure so first
verify the ec2 config service is running
in that instance if you want you can
actually beforehand install the ec2
config in that service or you can
actually make the easy to config run
through the console just couple of
button clicks and that will make the
easy to configure one in that easy to do
instance and then it detach the root
volume for that instance of course it's
going to require a stop and start to
detach the root volume from the instance
attach the root volume to another
instance as a temporary volume or it
could be a temporary instance that
you've launched only to fix this issue
and then login to that instance and to
that particular volume and modify the
configuration file configuration file
modify it to use the new key and then
move the root volume back to its
original position and restart the
instance and now the instance is going
to have the new key and you also have
the new key with which you can log in so
that's how we go ahead and fix it now
let's move on to some product specific
or S3 product specific questions a
general perception is S3 and EBS can be
used interchangeably and the interviewer
would want to test your knowledge on S3
and EVS well EBS uses S3 that's true but
they can't be interchangeably used so
you might face this question what are
some key differences between AWS S3 and
EBS well the differences are S3 is an
object store meaning you can't install
anything and you can store drive files
but you can't actually install in it
it's not a file system but ABS is a file
system you can install Services I mean
install applications in it and that's
going to run stuff like that and talking
about performance S3 is much faster and
abs is super faster when accessing from
the instance because from the instance
if you need to access S3 you'll actually
have to go out through the internet and
access the S3 or S3 is an external
service very external service you'll
have to go through or you'll have to go
outside of your VPC to access S3 S3 does
not come under a VPC but EBS comes under
a VPC it's on the same VPC so you would
be able to use it kind of locally
compared to S3 EBS is very local so that
way it's going to be faster and
redundancy talking about redundancy of
S3 and abs S3 is replicated the data in
S3 is replicated across the data centers
but EBS is replicated within the data
center meaning S3 is replicated across
availability zones EBS is within an
availability zone so that way redundancy
is a bit less in EVS in other words
durundancy is higher in S3 than EPs and
talking about security of S3 is3 can be
made private as well as public meaning
anybody can access S3 from anywhere in
the internet that's possible with S3 but
EBS can only only be accessed when
attached to an ec2 instance right just
one instance can access it whereas S3 is
publicly directly accessible the other
question related to S3 security is how
do you allow access to a user to a
certain a user to a certain bucket which
means this user is not having access to
S3 at all but this user needs to be
given access to a certain bucket how do
we do it the same case applies to
servers as well in few cases there could
be an instance where a person is new to
the team and you actually don't want
them to access the production service
now he is in the production group and by
default he or she is granted access to
that server but you specifically want to
deny access to that production server
till the time he or she is matured
enough to access or understand the
process understand the do's and don'ts
before they can put their hands on the
production server so how do we go about
doing it so first we would categorize
our instances well these are critical
instances these are normal instances and
we were actually put a tag on them
that's how we categorize right so you
put a tag on them put attack saying well
they are highly critical they are medium
critical and they are not critical at
all still there in production stuff like
that and then you would pick the users
who wants to or who should be or should
not be given access to a certain server
and you would actually allow the user to
access or not access servers based on a
specific tag in other words you can use
actually tags in in the previous step we
put tags on the critical server right so
you would Define that this user is not
going to use this tag all right this
user is not allowed to use the resources
for this stack so that's how you would
make your step forward so you would
allow or deny based on the tags that you
have put so in this case he or she will
not be allowed to servers which are TAG
critical servers so that's how you allow
deny access to them the same goes for
bucket as well or if an organization is
excessively using S3 for their data
storage because of the benefit that it
provides the cost and the durability you
might get asked this question which is
organizations would replicate the data
from one region to another region for
additional data durability and for
having data redundancy not only for that
they would also do that for Dr purposes
for Disaster Recovery if the whole
region is down you still have the data
available somewhere else and you can
pick and use it some organizations would
store data in different regions for
compliance reasons to provide low
latency access to their users who are
local to that region stuff like that so
when companies do replication how do you
make sure that there is consistency in
the replication how do you make sure
that a replication is not failing and
the data gets transferred for sure and
there are logs for that replication this
is something that the companies would
use where they are excessively using S3
and they are fully relying on the
replication in running their business
and the way we could do it is we can set
up a replication monitor it's actually
set of tools that we could use together
to make sure that the cloud replication
a region level replication is happening
properly so this is how it happens now
on this side on the left hand side we
have the region one and on the right
hand side we have Region 2 and region
one is the source bucket and region two
is the destination bucket all right so
object is put in the source bucket and
it has to go directly to the region to
bucket or made a copy in the region two
bucket and the problem is sometimes it
fails and there is no consistency
between them so the way you would do it
is connect these Services together and
create an cross replication or cross
region replication monitor that actually
monitors that actually monitors your
environment so there are cloudwatch that
make sure that the data is moved no data
is failing again there's Cloud watch on
the other end make sure that the data is
moving and then we have the logs
generated through cloudtrail and that's
actually written in dynamodb and if
there is an error if something is
failing you get notified through an SMS
or you get notified through an email
using the SNS service so that's how we
could leverage these tools and set up
and cross region replication monitor
that actually monitors your data
replication some common issues that
company companies face in VPC is that we
all know that I can use Route 53 to
resolve an IP address externally from
the internet but by default the servers
won't connect to the other servers using
our custom DNS name that does not do
that by default so it's actually a
problem there are some additional things
that as an administrator or as an
architect or as a person who uses it you
will have to do and that's what we're
going to discuss so the question could
be a VPC is not resolving the server
through the DNS you can access it
through the IP but not through the DNS
name and what could be the issue and how
do you go about fixing it and you will
be able to answer this question only if
you have done it already it's a quick
and simple step by default VPC does not
allow that's the default feature and we
will have to enable the DNS hostname
resolution before now this is for the
custom DNS not for the default DNS that
comes along this is for the custom DNS
so we will have to enable the DNS
hostname resolution so our will have to
enable DNS hostname resolution so they
actually resolve let's say I want to
connect to a server one dot
simplylearn.com by default it's not
allowed but if I enable this option then
I will be able to connect to server one
simplylearn.com if a company has vpcs in
different regions and they have a head
office in a central place and the rest
of them are Branch offices and they are
connecting to the head office for Access
or you know for saving data or for
accessing certain files or certain data
or touring data all right so they would
actually mimic The Hub and spoke
topology where you have the VPC which is
centrally in an accessible region a
centrally accessible region and then you
would have a local vpcs or Branch
offices in different other regions and
they get connected to the VPC in the
central location and the question is how
do you actually connect the multiple
sites to a VPC and make communication
happen between them by default it does
not do that we know that vpcs they need
to be paired between them in order to
access the resources let's look at this
picture right so I have like a customer
Network or Branch offices in different
parts and they get connected to a VPC
that's fine so what we have achieved is
those different offices the remote
offices they are connecting to the VPC
and they're talking but they can't
connect or they can't talk to each other
that's what we have built but the
requirement is the traffic needs to or
they should be able to talk to each
other but they should not have direct
connection between them which means that
they will have to come and hit the VPC
and then reach the other customer
Network which is in Los Angeles or which
is in New York right that's the
requirement so that's possible with some
architecting in the cloud so that's
using VPN Cloud Hub you look at this
dotted lines which actually allows
customers or which actually allows the
corporate networks to talk to each other
through the VPC Again by default it
doesn't happen cloudhub is an
architecture that we should be using to
make this happen and what's the
advantage of it as a central office or
as the headquarters office which is in
the VPC or headquarters data center
which is in the VPC you have control or
the VPC has control on who talks to who
and what traffic can talk to I mean what
traffic can be routed to the other head
office stuff like that that centralized
control is on the VPC the other question
person you could get asked is name and
explain some security products and
features available in VPC well VPC
itself is a security service it provides
a security service to the application
but how do you actually secure the VPC
itself that's the question and yes there
are products that can actually secure
the VPC or the VPC delivers those
products to secure the application
access to the vpcs restricted through a
network access control list all right so
that's a security product in VPC and a
VPC has security groups that protects
the instances from unwanted inbound and
outbound traffic and network access
control list protects the subnets from
unwanted inbound and outbound access and
there are flow logs we can capture in VP
scene that captures incoming and
outgoing traffic through a VPC which
will be used for later analysis as in
what's the traffic pattern what's the
behavior of the traffic pattern stuff
like that so there are some security
products and features available in VPC
now how do you monitor VPC VPC is a very
important concept very important Service
as well everything sits in a VPC most of
the service sits in a VPC except for
Lambda and S3 and dynamodb and couple of
other services most of them sit in a VPC
for security reasons so how do you
monitor your VPC how do you gain some
visibility on your VPC well we can gain
visibility on our VPC using VPC flow log
that's the basic Service as you see it
actually captures what's allowed what's
not allowed stuff like that which IPS
allowed which IP is not allowed stuff
like that so we can gather it and we can
use that for analysis and the other one
is cloud watch and Cloud watch logs the
data transfers that happen so this is
you know who gets allowed and who does
not get allowed I mean the flow logs is
who is allowed and who's not allowed
that kind of detail and Cloud watch
gives information about the data
transfer how much data is getting
transferred we can actually pick unusual
data transfers if there is a sudden hike
in the graph there's a sudden hike and
something happens at 12 on a regular
basis and you weren't expecting it
there's something suspicious it could be
valid backups it could be a malicious
activity as well so that's how you know
by looking at Cloud watch logs and
cloudwatch dashboard now let's talk
about multiple choice questions when
going for an interview you might
sometimes find yourself that the company
is conducting an online test based on
the score they can put you to a panelist
and then they would take it forward so
we thought it will also include multiple
choice questions to help you better
handle such situation if you come across
all right when you find yourself in such
situation the key to clear them is to
understand the question properly read
between the lines that's what they say
you know there can be like a big
paragraph with three lines or ten lines
you really got to understand what the
question is about and then try to find
answer for that question so that's a
thumb rule number one and then the
second rule is try to compare and
contrast the services mentioned or try
to compare and contrast the answers you
can easily read out one or two answers
and then you will be left with only two
answers to decide from you know so that
also helps you with time and that's how
that also helps you with some Precision
in your answer so number one read
between the lines number two compare and
contrast the services and you'll be able
to easily read out the wrong ones so
let's try answering this question
suppose you are a game designer and you
want to develop a game with a single
digit millisecond latency which of the
following database Services would you
choose so we know that the following are
database services are good enough all
right and it talks about the millisecond
latency that's the key point and the
third thing is it's a game it could be a
mobile game it's a game that you are
trying to design and you need a
millisecond latency and it has to be a
database all right so let's talk about
the options available RDS RDS is a
database for sure is it good for game
design we'll come back to that Neptune
Neptune is a graph a database service in
Amazon so that's kind of out of the
equation and snowball is actually a
storage all right it's it's a transport
medium I would say so that's again out
of the equation so the tie is between
RDS and dynamodb so if we need to talk
about RDS RDS is an a platform as a
service it provides cost efficient
resizable capacity but it's an SQL
database meaning the tables are kind of
strict you know it's good for Banking
and other type of applications but not
really good for or anything that has to
do with the gaming so the only option
left is dynamodb again it's the right
answer dynamodb is actually an fast and
flexible nosql database service and it
provides a single digit millisecond
latency at any scale and it's a database
at the same time it's a key Value Store
model database so the right answer is
dynamodb all right let's look at the
next question if you need to perform
real-time monitoring of AWS services and
get actionable insights which service
would you use all right let's list the
services so it talks about real-time
monitoring a firewall manager what does
it provide now firewall manager is not
really a monitor just like the name says
it's a manager it manages multiple
firewalls and AWS guard duty is and
thread detection service it does
monitoring it dust continuously monitor
our environment but it monitors for
threats all right only threats now let's
talk about Cloud watch a cloud watch is
a service that helps to track metrics
it's a service that is used to
monitor the environment and give us a
system-wide visibility and also it helps
us to store logs so at the moment it
kind of looks like that could be the
right answer we don't know that yet but
I mean we have one more option left
that's EBS so what's EBS EBS is a block
storage elastic Block store if we
abbreviate EBS it's elastic Block store
so all three of them are easily out of
the question the first one is to manage
second one is to find threats of course
it does monitoring so there's I mean if
there is one relation between Cloud
watch and guard Duty that's monitoring
so easily we can actually find ourselves
slipped towards picking guard duty but
know that God did is only for gaining
security inside but not about gaining
AWS service inside so cloudwatch is a
service that helps us to get a
system-wide or an AWS wide or an account
wide and it has number of metrics we can
monitor and get a very good Insight of
how a service is performing be it CPU be
it Ram beat Network utilization beat the
connection failures Cloud watch is a
service that helps us perform a
real-time monitoring and get some
actionable insights on the services all
right let's talk about this 33rd
question as a web developer you are
developing an app especially for the
mobile platform all right there is a
mention that this is especially for the
mobile platform so a lot of services
gets filtered out mobile platform right
which of the following lets you add user
sign up sign in and access control to
your web and mobile app quickly and
easily alright so this is all about
signing in to your mobile app so if we
need to read between the lines that's
how we can read sign up or sign in into
a mobile platform all right so we have
like four options here Shield AWS Massey
AWS inspector Amazon Cognito so let's
try to weed out Services which are not
relevant to it so what's AWS Shield AWS
Shield is actually a service that
provides a DDOS mitigation or DDOS
protection denial of service protection
it's a security feature let's talk about
the second option AWS Maxi is again a
security service that uses machine
learning to automatically discover and
classify the data it again talks about
security and this security is all about
encrypting or saving the data does not
come close with signing up an mobile
platform all right let's talk about the
other one AWS inspector now AWS
inspector has something to do with apps
it definitely has something to do with
apps so kind of looks like that's
relevant as of now so it actually helps
with improving the security and
compliance of the apps that we deploy in
the cloud so kind of looks like it could
be because it has to do with apps the
last one Cognito now Cognito is a
service that actually lets the
administrator to have control access
over web and mobile apps and it's a
service that helps us to sign up and
assign in to an mobile and web app so
that very much looks like we found the
answer so cognitos reserves that helps
web app and mobile app for sign up and
signing in and also gives the
administrator to have control over who
has I mean access control over the web
and the mobile app pretty much we found
it so it's cognitive Cognito is a
service that helps us to set up sign up
sign in and have access control over the
users who would be using our mobile and
web app all right how about this
question you are an ml engineer or a
machine learning engineer who is on the
lookout for a solution that will
discover sensitive information that your
Enterprise stores in AWS and then uses
NLP to classify that data and provide
business related insights which among
the following Services would you choose
so we have a bunch of services that's
going to help us achieve or one of it is
going to help us achieve the above
requirement so it's a service that deals
with machine learning you're a machine
learning engineer who's looking for a
service that will help you to discover
information at your Enterprise store so
we're talking about storage discover
information in store and then classify
the data depending on severity the
sensitivity classify the data so which
service is that so firewall manager just
like the name says it's a manager and
the AWS IAM if we abbreviate it it's a
identity and access manage months its
identity and access management nothing
to do with identifying sensitive data
and managing it so the first two is
already out of the equation then the AWS
is Massey we already had a quick
definition description for AWS Massey
that it's actually a security service
that uses machine learning kind of looks
like it could be it it's a security
service that uses machine learning and
it discovers and classifies the
sensitive information not only that it
does not stop there it goes beyond and
protects the sensitive data AWS massive
kind of looks like but we still have one
more option to look at which is cloud
HMS Cloud HMS is also a security service
kind of looks like that could be the
answer as well and it enables us to
generate encryption keys and save the
data so kind of 50 of it it's a security
service it encrypts helps us protect our
data but AWS Maxi is right on spot it's
a machine learning service it helps us
to classify the data and also to protect
the data so the answer for this question
will be AWS Massey so hope you kind of
get it how this is going so first we
apply the thumb rule identify the
question that's being asked read between
the lines and then try to find the
service that meets your requirement then
finding the service is by worth reading
out the wrong ones recollect everything
that you've learned about the service
and see how well that matches with those
hints that you have picked up and if
that doesn't match weed that out then
you'll end up with two just two to
decide from at some point and then it
becomes easy for you to decide click on
the question submit it and then move on
to the other question in your interview
alright so how about this one you are a
system administrator on your company
which is running most of its
infrastructure on AWS you are required
to track your users and keep a look on
how your users are being authenticated
all right so this is where the problem
statement starts right you need to keep
track of how your users are being
authenticated and you wish to create and
manage AWS users and use permissions to
allow and deny their access to the AWS
resources right you are to give them
permission number one and then I mean if
we put them in the right order first
giving them permissions and then
tracking their usage let's see which of
the service will help us achieve it IAM
is a service that helps us to looking at
the permissions we can actually predict
whether the user or the group will have
servers or not so that helps us to get a
track of who's able to use who's not
able to use certain servers and all that
stuff so it kind of looks like but we
have other three options left let's look
at AWS firewall manager just like the
name says it's actually a firewall
manager it helps us to manage multiple
firewalls simple as that and shield is a
service it's a service that's used to
protect denial of service or distributed
denial of service an API Gateway is a
service that may makes it easy for
developers to create publish maintain
and monitor and secure API so I mean
it's completely on the API side very
Less on user and how you authenticate
your user we can get that by looking at
the name itself right if we abbreviate
it or if we if you try to find a
definition for the name API Gateway you
would get it it has to do with API but
if you upgrade AWS IEM it's identity and
access management pretty much meets the
requirement but for the problem
statement about it's AWS identity and
access management that's the right
answer all right let's look at this one
if you want to allocate various private
and public IP address in order to make
them communicate with the internet and
other instances you will use this
service which of the following is this
service so it talks about using public
and private IP address so this service
uses IP address and then this service
helps us to allow and deny connections
to the internet and to the other
instances so you get the question is it
let's pick the service that helps us
achieve it Route 53 Route 53 is actually
a DNS service right so it's not a
service that's used to allow or deny no
it does not do that VPC VPC uses public
and private IP address yes so kind of
looks like a VPC helps us do allow I
mean the security in VPC the security
group the network access control list in
a VPC that routing table in a VPC that
actually helps us to allow or deny a
connection to a particular IP address or
to a particular service within the VPC
or outside of the VPC so as of now it
kind of looks like it could be but let's
look at the other services what if if we
find a service that closely matches to
the above requirement than the Amazon
VPC Gateway API Gateway we know that
it's a managed service that makes it
easy for developers to create publish
maintain and monitor apis and secure API
so that has completely do with API not
with IP Cloud front we know about
cloudfront that it's a Content delivery
Network and it provides global
distribution of servers where our
content can be cached it could be video
or or bulk Media or anything else they
can be cached locally so users can
easily access them and download them
easily alright so that's cloudfront now
at this point after looking at all four
it looks like VPC is the right answer
and in fact VPC is the right answer VPC
has public IP address VPC can help us
with the private IP address VPC can be
used to allow deny connection based on
the security group Access Control list
and routing table it has so that's right
answer is VPC all right how about this
one this platform as a service or
platform as a DB service provides us
with the cost of efficient and resizable
capacity while automating time-consuming
administrative tasks so this question is
very clear it's a DB service we gotta
look for and it's a service that can
provide automating some of the
time-consuming tasks it has to be
resizable at the same time so let's talk
about Amazon rational database it's a
database kind of matches the requirement
we can resize it as and when needed
all right looks like it's a fit as of
now it actually automates some of the
time consuming work looks like it's a
fit as of now let's move on to elastic
cache and then try to see if that
matches the definition that we've
figured out about elastic cache it's
actually a caching service it's again an
in-memory data store which helps in
achieving high throughput and low
latency in memory data store so it's not
a full-blown database and it does not
come with any Amazon provisioned
Automation in it for automating any of
the administration tasks now it does not
come up with anything like that yeah we
can resize the capacity as and when
needed but automation it's not there yet
and moreover it's not a database so
that's out of the equation VPC is not a
resizable one you know once we have
designed VPC it's fixed it can be
resized so that's out of the equation
and Amazon Glacier Glacier is a storage
but not a database all right so that's
again of the equation so the Thai is
kind of between Amazon rational database
service and Amazon elastic cache because
they both Aid the database service but
the elastic cache is not a full-blown
database it actually helps the database
but it's not a full-blown database so
it's Amazon relational database so
that's the one which is a platform as a
service it's the one which can be
resized it's the one which can be used
to automate the time consuming
administrative tasks all right let's
talk about this one which of the
following is a means for accessing human
researchers or Consultants to help solve
a problem on a contractual or a
temporary basis all right let's read the
question again which of the following is
a means for accessing human researchers
or consultant to help solve problems on
a contractual or a temporary basis it's
like assigning task or hiring AWS
exports for a temporary job so let's try
to find that kind of service in the four
services that are listed Amazon elastic
map reduce map reduce is actually an
framework service that makes it easy and
cost effective to analyze large amount
of data but that has nothing to do with
accessing human researchers all right
let's talk about mechanical terms it's a
web service that provides a human
Workforce that's the definition for it
for example automation is good but not
everything can be automated for
something to qualify for automation it
has to be a repeated task one-time task
can't be automated or the time and money
that you would be spending in automation
is not worth it instead you could have
done it manually so that does not
qualify for Automation and anything that
requires intelligence or anything that's
a special case all right automation can
do reperative tasks automation can do
precise work but it has to be repeated
tasks scenario you know it should have
been there already only then that can be
executed but if it's a new scenario and
it requires appropriate addressing then
it requires human thoughts so we could
hire researchers and Consultants who can
help solve a problem using Amazon
Mechanical Turk the other two are
already out of the equation now Dev pay
is actually a payment system through
Amazon and multi-factor authentication
as it says it's an authentication system
so the right answer is Amazon Mechanical
Turk all right this sounds interesting
let's look at this one this service is
used to make it easy to deploy manage
and scale containerized applications
using kubernetes on AWS which of the
following is this AWS service so it's a
service to deploy manage and scale
containerized applications so it deals
with containers so it also should have
the ability to use kubernetes which is a
container orchestration service all
right the first one an Amazon elastic
container service kind of looks like
it's the one the name itself has the
word and the relation we're looking for
elastic
container service so this container
service is an highly scalable high
performance container orchestration
service let's look at the other one AWS
batch it's a service that enables it
professionals to schedule and execute
batch processing I mean the name itself
says that that's meant for batch
processing elastic Beanstalk that's
another service that helps us to deploy
manage and scale but it helps us with
easy two instances not with
containerized instances so that's again
out of the equation would light still be
a good tie for elastic container service
what's slide sale now light sale is a
service it's called as virtual private
server without a VPC it's called as a
virtual private server it comes with a
predefined in the compute storage
networking capacity it's actually a
server not a container right so at this
point that also becomes out of the
equation so it's Amazon elastic
container service that's the one that
helps us to easily deploy manage scale
container services and it helps us
orchestrate the containers using
kubernetes all right how about this one
all right this service lets us to run
code without provisioning or managing
servers so no servers run code select
the correct service from the below
option all right so no servers but we
should be able to run code Amazon ec2
Auto scaling easy to order scaling ec2
is elastic compute Cloud which is a
server and auto scaling is a service
that helps us to achieve scaling the
server so that's the definition for it
could be that's out of the equation AWS
Lambda now Lambda is a service It's
actually an event driven serverless
Computing platform and Lambda runs code
in response to the event that it
receives and it automatically manages
the compute resource that's required for
that code as long as we have uploaded a
code that's correct and setup events
correctly to map to that code it's going
to run seamlessly so that's about Lambda
it kind of looks like it could be the
answer because Lambda runs code we don't
have to manage servers it manages
service by itself but we can't conclude
as of now we have other two service to
talk about AWS batch all right batch is
service that enables ID professionals to
run batch job we know that and about the
inspector Amazon inspector it's actually
a service that helps us to increase and
identify any security issues and align
our application with compliance well
that's not the requirement of the
question the requirement and the
question was a run code without
provisioning a server and without any
more space for confusion AWS Lambda is a
service or is the service that runs code
without provisioning and managing
Services right the right one would be
AWS Lambda let's get started so in an
environment where there is a lot of
automation infrastructure automation
you'll be posted with this question how
can you add an existing instance to a
new auto scaling group now this is when
you are taking an instance away from the
auto scaling group to troubleshoot to
fix a problem you know to look at logs
or if you have suspended the auto
scaling you know you might need to
re-add that instance to the auto scaling
group only then it's going to take part
in it right only then the auto scaling
is going to count it has part of it it's
not a straight procedure you know when
you remove them you know it doesn't get
automatically re-added I've had worked
with some clients when their developers
were managing their own environment they
had problems adding the instance back to
the auto scaling group you know
irrespective of what they tried the
instance was not getting added to the
order scaling group and whatever they
fixed that they were provided or
whatever fix that they have provided
were not you know getting encountered in
the auto scaling group so like I said
it's not a straight you know a click
button procedure there are ways we'll
have to do it so how can you add an
existing instance uh to the auto scaling
group there are a few steps that we need
to follow so the first one would be to
under the ec2 instance console right
under the instance under actions in
specific you know there's an option
called attach to Auto scaling group
right if you have multiple Auto scaling
groups in your account or in the region
that you're working in then you're going
to be posted with the different Auto
scaling groups that you have in your
account let's say you have five Auto
scaling groups for five different
application you know you're going to be
posted with five different or scaling
groups and then you would select the
auto scaling the appropriate Auto
scaling group and attach the instance to
that particular or a scaling group while
adding to the auto scaling group if you
want to change the instance type you
know that's possible as well sometimes
when you want to add the instance back
to the auto scaling group there would be
requirement that you change the instance
type to a better one to a better family
to the better instance type you could do
that at that time and after that you are
or you have completely added the
instance back to the auto scaling group
so it's actually a seven step up process
adding an instance back to the auto
scaling group in an environment where
they're dealing with migrating the
instance or migrating an application or
migrating an instance migrating and VM
into the cloud you know if the project
that you're going to work with deals
with a lot of migrations you could be
posted this question what are the
factors you will consider while
migrating to Amazon web services the
first one is cost is it worth moving the
instance to the cloud given the
additional bills and whistles features
available in the cloud is this apple
application going to use all of them is
moving into the cloud beneficial to the
application in the first place you know
beneficial to the users who will be
using the application in the first place
so that's a factor to think of so this
actually includes you know cost of the
infrastructure and the ability to match
the demand and Supply transparency is
this application in high demand you know
is it going to be a big loss if the
application becomes unavailable for some
time so there are few things that needs
to be considered before we move the
application to the cloud and then if the
application does the application needs
to be provisioned immediately is there
an urge is there an urge to provision
the application immediately that's
something that needs to be considered if
the application requires to go online if
the application needs to hit the market
immediately then we would need to move
it to the cloud because in on-premises
procuring or buying an infrastructure
buying the bandwidth buying this
switchboard you know buying an instance
you know buying their software so buying
the license related to it it's going to
take time at least like two weeks or so
before you can bring up an server and
launch an application in it right so if
the application cannot wait you know
waiting means uh you know Workforce
productivity loss is it so we would want
to immediately launch instances and put
application on top of it in those case
if your application is of that type if
that is the urge in making the
application go online as soon as
possible then that's a candidate for
moving to the cloud and if the
application or if the the software or if
the product that you're launching it
requires Hardware it requires an updated
Hardware all the time that's not going
to be possible in on premises we try to
deal with Legacy infrastructure all the
time in on-premises but in the cloud
they're constantly upgrading their hard
ways only then they can keep themselves
up going in the market so they
constantly the cloud providers are
constantly updating their hard ways and
if you want to be benefited of your
application wants to be benefited by the
constant upgrading of the Hardwares
making sure the hardware is as latest as
possible the software version the
licensing is as latest as possible then
that's a candidate to be moved to the
cloud and if the application does not
want to go through any risk if the
application is very sensitive to
failures if the application is very much
stacked to the revenue of the company
and you don't want to take a chance in
you know seeing the application fail and
you know seeing the revenue drop then
that's a candidate for moving to the
cloud and business agility you know
moving to the cloud at least half of the
responsibility is now taken care by the
provider in this case it's Amazon at
least half of the responsibility is
taken care by them like if the hardware
fails Amazon make sure that they're
fixing the hardware immediately and
notifications you know if something
happens you know there are immediate
notifications available that we can set
it up and make ourselves aware that
something has broken and we can
immediately jump in and fix it so you
see there are the responsibility is now
being shared between Amazon and us so if
you want to get that benefit for your
application for your organization for
the product that you're launching then
it needs to be moved to the cloud so you
can get that benefit from the cloud the
other question you could get asked is
what is RTO and RPO in AWS they are
essentially Disaster Recovery terms when
you're planning for Disaster Recovery
you cannot avoid planning disaster
recovery without talking about RTO and
RPO now what's the RTO what's the RPO in
your environment or how do you define
RTO how do you define RPO or some
general questions that get asked RTO is
recovery time objective RTO stands for
the maximum time the company is willing
to wait for the recovery to happen or or
for the recovery to finish when an
disaster strikes so RTO is in the future
right how much time is it going to take
to fix and bring everything to normal so
that's rtu on the other hand RPO is
recovery Point objective which is the
maximum amount of data laws your company
is willing to accept as measured in time
RPO always refers to the backups the
number of backups the the frequency of
the backups right because when an outage
happens you can always go back to the
latest backup right and if the latest
backup was before 12 hours you have lost
the in between 12 hours of data data
storage right so RPO is the acceptable
amount if the company wants less RPO RPO
is 1R then you should be planning on
taking backups everyone up if RPO is 12
hours then you should be planning on
taking backups every 12 hours so that's
how RPO and RTO you know helps Disaster
Recovery the fourth question you could
get asked is if you would like to
transfer huge amount of data which is
the best option among a snowball
snowball Edge and snowmobile again this
is a question that get asked if the
company is dealing with a lot of data
transfer into the cloud or if the
company is dealing with migrating data
into the cloud I'm talking about a huge
amount of data data in petabytes
snowball and all of the snowball series
deals with the petabyte sized data
migrations so there are three options
available as if now AWS snowball is an
data transport solution for moving high
volume of data into and out of a
specified AWS region on the other hand
AWS snowball Edge adds additional
Computing functions snowball is simple
storage and movement of data and
snowball Edge has a compute function
attached to it a snowmobile on the other
hand hand is an exabyte scale migration
service that allows us to transfer data
up to 100 petabytes that's like 100 000
terabytes so depending on the size of
data that we want to transfer from our
data center to the cloud we can hire we
can rent any of these three services
let's talk about some cloud formation
questions this is a classic question how
is AWS cloud formation different from
AWS elastic bean stock you know from the
surface they both look like the same you
know you don't go through the console
provisioning resources you don't you
know you don't go through CLI and
provision resources both of them
provision resources through click button
right but underneath they are actually
different Services they support they aid
different services so knowing that is
going to help you understand this
question a lot better let's talk about
the difference between them and this is
what you will be planning to the
interviewer or the panelist so the cloud
formation the cloud formation service
helps you describe and provision all the
infrastructure resources in the cloud
environment on the other hand elastic
bean stock provides an simple
environment to which we can deploy and
run application cloud formation gives us
an infrastructure and the elastic bean
stock gives us a small contained
environment in which we can run our
application and cloud formation supports
the infrastructure needs of many
different types of application like the
Enterprise application the Legacy
applications and any new modern
application that you want to have in the
cloud on the other hand the elastic bean
stock It's a combination of developer
tools they are tools that helps manage
the life cycle of a single application
so cloud formation in short is managing
the infrastructure as a whole and
elastic bin stock in short is managing
and running an application in the cloud
and if the company that you're getting
hired is using cloud formation to manage
their infrastructure using or if they're
using infrastructure or any of the
infrastructure as a code Services then
you would definitely face this question
what are the elements of an AWS cloud
formation template so it has a four or
five basic elements right and the
template is in the form of Json or in
yaml format right so it has parameters
it has outputs it has data it has
resources and then the format or the
format version or the file format
version for the cloud formation template
so parameter is nothing but it actually
lets you to specify the type of easy to
instance that you want the type of RDS
that you want all right so ec2 is an
umbrella RDS is an umbrella and
parameters within that ec2 and
parameters within that rdas are the
specific details of the ec2 or the
specific details of the RDS service so
that's what parameters in a cloud
formation template and then the element
of the cloud formation template is
outputs for example if you want to
Output the name of an S3 bucket that was
created if you want to Output the name
of the ec2 instance if you want to
Output the name of some resources that
have been created instead of looking
into the template instead of you know
navigating through in the console and
finding the name of the resource we can
actually have them outputted in the
result section so we can simply go and
look at all the resources created
through the template in the output
section and that's what output values or
output does in the cloud formation
template and then we have resources
resources are nothing but what defines
what are the cloud components or cloud
resources that will be created through
this cloud formation template now ec2 is
a resource RDS is a resource and S3
bucket is a resource elastic load
balancer is a resource and the NAT
Gateway is a resource VPC is a resource
so you see all these components are the
resources and the resource section in
the cloud formation defines what are the
AWS Cloud resources that will be created
through this cloud formation template
and then we have version a version
actually identifies the capabilities of
the template you know we just need to
make sure that it is of the latest
version type and the latest version is
0909 2010 that's the latest version
number you'll be able to find that on
the top of the cloud formation template
and that version number defines the
capabilities of the cloud formation
template so just need to make sure that
it's the latest all the time still
talking about cloud formation this is
another classic question what happens
when one of those Source in a stack
cannot be created successfully well if
the resource in a stack cannot be
created the cloud formation
automatically rolls back and terminates
all the resources that was created using
the cloud formation template so whatever
resources that were created through the
cloud formation template from the
beginning let's say we have created like
10 resources and the 11th resource is
now failing cloud formation will roll
back and delete all the 10 resources
that were created previously and this is
very useful when the cloud formation
cannot you know go forward cloud
formation cannot create additional
resources because we have reached the
elastic IP limits elastic IP limit per
region is five right and if you have
already used five IPS and a cloud
formation is trying to buy three more
IPS you know we've hit the soft limit
till we fix that with Amazon cloud
formation will not be able to you know
launch additional you know resources and
additional IPS so it's going to cancel
and roll back everything that's true
with a missing ec2 Ami as well if an Ami
is included in the template and but the
Ami is not actually present then cloud
formation is going to search for the Mi
and because it's not present it's going
to roll back and delete all the
resources that it created so that's what
cloud formation does it simply rolls
back all the resources that it created I
mean if it sees a failure it would
simply roll back all the resources that
it created and this feature actually
simplifies the system administration and
layered Solutions built on top of AWS
cloud formation so at any point we know
that there are no orphan resources in
the in in our environment you know
because something did not work or
because there was an you know cloud
formation executed some there are no
orphan resources in our account at any
point we can be sure that if cloud
formation is launching a resource and if
it's going to fail and it's going to
come back and delete all the resources
it's created so there are no orphan
resources in our account now let's talk
about some questions in elastic Block
store again if the environment deals
with a lot of automation you could be
thrown this question how can you
automate easy to backup using EBS it's
actually a six step process to automate
the ec2 backups we'll need to write a
script to automate the below steps using
AWS API and these are the steps that
should be found in the scripts first get
the list of instances and then and then
the script that we are writing should be
able to connect to AWS using the API and
list the Amazon ABS volumes that are
attached locally to the instance and
then it needs to list the snapshots of
each volume make sure the snapshots are
present and it needs to assign a
retention period for the snapshot
because over time the snapshots are
going to be invalid right once you have
some 10 latest snapshots any snapshot
that you have taken before that then
becomes invalid because you have
captured the latest and 10 snapshot
coverage is enough for you and then the
fifth point is to create a snapshot of
each volume create a new snapshot of
each volume and then delete the old
snapshot anytime a new snapshot gets
created the oldest snapshot of the list
needs to go away so we need to include
options we need to include scripts in
our script lines in our script that make
sure that it's deleting the older
snapshots which are older than the
retention period that we are mentioning
another question that you could see in
the interview be it written interview
beat online interview or beat and
telephonic or face to face interview is
what's the difference between EBS and
instance store let's talk about EBS
first EBS is kind of permanent storage
the data in it can be restored at a
later point when we save data in ABS the
data lives even after the lifetime of
the ec2 instance for example we can stop
the instance and the data is still going
to be present in EBS we can move the EBS
from one instance to another instance
and the data is simply going to be
present there so ABS is kind of
permanent storage when compared to
instance on the other hand the instance
store is a temporary storage and that
storage is actually physically attached
to the host of the machine abs is an
external storage an instant store is
locally attached to the instance or
locally attached to the host of The
Machine we cannot detach an instant
store from one instance and attach it to
another but we can do that with EBS so
that's a big difference one is permanent
data and another one is EBS permanent
instant store is a volatile data and
instant store with instant store we
won't be able to detach the storage and
attach it to another instance and
another feature of instant store is data
in an instant store is lost if the disk
fails or the instance is stopped or
terminated so instant store is only good
for storing cache data if you want to
store permanent data then we should
think of using EBS and not instant store
while talking about storage on the same
lines this is another classic question
how can you take backups of EFS like EBS
and if you can take backup how do you
take that backup the answer is yes we
can take EFS to EFS backup solution EFS
does not support snapshot like EBS EFS
does not support snapshot snapshot is
not an option for EFS elastic file
system right we can only take backup
from one EFS to another EFS and this
backup solution is to recover from
unintended changes or deletions of the
EFS and this can be automated right any
data that we store in EFS can be
automatically replicated to another EFS
and once this EFS goes down or gets
deleted or data gets deleted or you know
the whole EFS is for some reason
interrupted or deleted we can recover
the data from we can use the other EFS
and bring the application to consistency
and to achieve this it's not an One Step
configuration it's a cycle there are
series of steps that's involved before
we can achieve EFS to EFS backup the
first thing is to sign in to the AWS
Management console and under EFS or
click on EFS to EFS restore button from
the services list and from there we can
use the region selector in the console
navigation bar to select the actual
region in which we want to work on and
from there ensure that we have selected
the right template you know some of the
templates would be you know EFS to EFS
backup granular backups incremental
backups right so there are some
templates the kind of backups that you
want to take do you want to take
granular do you want to take increment
backups stuff like that and then create
a name to that solution the kind of
backup that we have created and finally
review all the configurations that you
have done and click on Save and from
that point onwards the data is going to
be copied and from that point onwards
any additional data that you put is
going to copy it and replicate it now
you have an EFS to EFS backup this is
another classic question in companies
which deals with a data management there
are easy options to create snapshots but
deleting snapshots is not always and you
know click button or a single step
configuration so you might be facing a
question like how do you Auto delete old
snapshots and the procedure is like this
now as best practice we will take
snapshots of EBS volume to S3 all
snapshots gets stored in S3 we know that
now and we can use AWS Ops automator to
automatically handle all snapshots the
Ops automator service it allows us to
create copy delete EBS snapshots so
there are cloud formation templates
available for AWS Ops automator and this
automator template will scan the
environment and it would take snapshots
it would you know copy the snapshot from
one region to another region if you want
I know if you're setting up a Dr
environment and not only that based on
the retention period that we create it's
going to delete the snapshots which are
older than the retention period so life
or managing snapshot is made a lot
easier because of this Ops automator
cloud formation template moving into
questions in elastic load balancer this
again could be an a question in the
interview what are the different types
of load balance says in AWS and what's
their use case what's the difference
between them and as of now as we speak
there are three types of load balances
which are available in AWS the first one
being application load balancer just
like the name says the application load
balancer works on the application layer
and deals with HTTP and https requests
and it it also supports part based
routing for example simplylearn.com
some web page simplylearn.com another
website so it's going to direct the path
based on the slash value that you give
in the URL so that's path based routing
so it supports that and not only that it
can support a port based a colon 8080
colon 8081 or colon 8090 you know based
on that Port also it can take a routing
decision and that's what application
load balancer does on the other hand we
have Network load balancer and the
network load balancer makes route
decisions at the transport level it's
faster because it has very less thing to
work on it works on Lower OSI layer it
works on a lower layer so it has very
less information to work with than
compared with application layers so
comparatively it's a lot faster and it
handles millions of requests per second
and after the load balancer receives a
connection it selects a Target group for
the default rule using the flow hash
routing algorithm it does simple routing
right it does not do path based or Port
based routing it does simple routing and
because of it it's faster and then we
have classic load balancer which is kind
of expiring as we speak Amazon is
discouraging people using classic load
balancer but there are companies which
are still using classic load balancer
they are the ones who are the first one
to step into Amazon when classic load
balancer was the first load balancer or
the only load balancer available at that
point so it supports HTTP https TCP SSL
protocol and it has a fixed relationship
between a load balance report and the
container Port so initially we only have
classic load balancer and then after
some point Amazon said instead of having
one load balancer address all type of
traffic we're gonna have a two load
balances called as the child from the
classic to load balancer and one is
going to specifically address the
application requirement and one is going
to specifically address the network
requirement and let's call it as
application load balancer and network
load balancer so that's how now we have
two different load balances talking
about load balancer another classic
question could be what are the different
uses of the various load balancer in AWS
elastic or load balancing there are
three types of load balancer we just
spoke about it application load balancer
is used if we need a flexible
application management and TLS
termination and network load balancer if
we require Extreme Performance and the
load balancing should happen on based on
static IPS for the application and
classic load balancer is an old load
balancer which is for people who are
still running their environment from
easy to Classic Network now this is an
older version of VPC or this is what was
present before VPC was created easy to
Classic network is what was present
before ec2 was created so they are the
three types and they are the use cases
of it let's talk about some of this
security related questions you would
face in the interview when talking about
security and firewall and AWS we cannot
avoid discussion talking about web
application firewall and you would
definitely see yourself in this
situation where you've been asked how
can you use AWS Waf in monitoring your
AWS applications Waf or web application
firewall protects our web application
from common web exploits and Waf helps
us control which traffic Source your
application should be allowed or a Blog
which traffic from a certain Source you
know which source or which traffic from
a certain should be allowed or blocked
your application with Waf we can also
create custom rules that blocks common
attack patterns you know if it is a
banking application it has a certain
type of attacks and if it is simple data
management data storage application it
has I mean content management
application it has a separate type of
attack So based on the application type
we can identify a pattern and create
rules that would actually block that
attack based on the rule that we create
and Waf can be used for three cases you
know the first one is allow all requests
and then block all requests and count
all requests for a new policy so it's
also an monitoring and Management
Service which actually counts all the
policies or counts all the requests that
matches a particular policy that we
create and some of the characteristics
we can mention in AWS web are the origin
IPS and the strings that appear in the
request we can allow block based on
Origin IP allow block based on strings
that appear in the request we can allow
block or count based on the origin
country length of the request yeah we
can block and count the presence of
malicious scripts in an connection you
know we can count the request headers or
we can allow block a certain request
header and we can count the presence of
malicious SQL code in a connection that
we get and that want to reach our
application still talking about security
what are the different AWS IM categories
we can control using AWS IAM we can do
the following one is create and manage
IM users and once the user database gets
bigger and bigger we can create and
manage them in groups and in IM we can
use it to manage the security
credentials kind of setting the
complexity of the password you know
setting additional authentications you
know like MFA and you know rotating the
passwords now resetting the power
password there are few things we could
do with the IAM and finally we can
create policies that actually grants
access to AWS services and resources
another question you will see is what
are the policies that you can set for
your users password so some of the
policies that we can set for the user
password is the minimum length or you
know the complexity of the password by
at least having one number or one
special characters in the password so
that's one and then the requirement of a
specific character types including you
know uppercase lowercase number and
non-alphabetic characters so it becomes
very hard for somebody else to guess
what the password would be and and try
to hack them so we can set the length of
the password we can set the complexity
in the password and then we can set an
automatic expiration of the password so
after a certain time the user is forced
to create a new password so the password
word is not stale old and easy to guess
in the environment and we can also set
settings like the user should contact
the admin I mean when the password is
about to expire so you know you can get
a hold of how the user is setting their
password is it having good complexity in
it is it meeting company standards or
there are few things that we can control
and set for the users when the users are
setting or recreating the password
another question that could be posted in
an interview so to understand your
understanding of IEM is what's the
difference between an IM role and an IM
user let's talk about IM user let's
start small and then go big or let's
start simple and then talk about the
complex one the IM user has a permanent
long term credential and it's used to
interact directly with AWS services and
on the other hand IEM role is an IM
entity that defines a set of permissions
for making AWS server a quest so IM user
is an permanent credential and role are
temporary credentials and IM user has
full access to all AWS IEM
functionalities and with role trusted
entities such as IEM users application
or AWS Services assume are the role so
when an IM user is given an a permission
you know it sticks within the IM user
but with roles we can give permissions
to Applications we can give permissions
to users in the same account in a
different account a corporate ID we can
give permissions to ec2 S3 RDS VPC and
lot more role is wide and IM user is is
not so wide you know it's very
constrained only for that IM user let's
talk about manage policies in AWS manage
policies there are two types you know
customer managed and Amazon managed so
manage policies are IM resources that
Express permissions using the IAM policy
language and we can create policies edit
them manage them manage them separately
from the IM user group and roles which
they are attached to so they are
something that we can do to managed
policies if it is customer managed and
we can now update policy in one place
and the permissions automatically extend
to all the attached entries so I can
have like three services four Services
point to a particular policy and if I
edit that particular policy it's going
to reflect on those three or four
services so anything that I allow is
going to be allowed for those four
Services anything that I denied is going
to be denied for the four Services
imagine what would be without the IM
managed policy we'll have to go and
specifically allow deny on those
different instances four or five times
depending on the number of instances
that we have so like I said there are
two types of managed policies one is
managed by us which is customer managed
policy is and then the other is managed
by AWS which is AWS managed policy this
question can you give an example of an
IM policy and a policy summary this is
actually to test how well-versed are you
with the AWS console the answer to that
question is look at the following policy
this policy is used to Grant access to
add update and delete objects from a
specific folder now in this case name of
the folder is example folder and it's
present in a bucket called example
bucket so this is an IAM policy on the
other hand the policy summary is a list
of access level resource and conditions
for each service defined in a policy so
IM policy is all about one particular
resource and the policy summary is all
about multiple resources with IM policy
it was only talking about S3 bucket and
one particular S3 bucket here it talks
about cloud formation template Cloud
watch logs ec2 elastic bean stock
Services summary summary of resources
and the permissions and policies
attached to them that's what policy
summary is all about another question
could be like this what's the use case
of IAM and how does IM help your
business and two important or primary
work of IM is to help us manage IAM
users and their access it provides a
secure access to multiple users to their
appropriate AWS resources so that's one
it does and the second thing it does is
manage access for Federated users
Federated users or non-iam users and
through IM we can actually allow and
provide a secured access to resources in
our AWS account to our employees without
the IM user no they could be
authenticated using the active directory
they could be authenticated using the
Facebook credential Google credential
Amazon credential and a couple of other
credentials third party identity
management right so we go should
actually trust them and we could give
them access to our account based on the
trust relationship that we have built
with the other identity systems right so
two things one is manage users and their
access for manage IAM user and their
access in our AWS environment and second
is manage access for Federated users who
are non-iim users and more importantly
IM is a free service and with that will
only be charged for the use of the
resources not for the IM username and
password that we create all right let's
now talk about some of the questions in
Route 53 one classic question that could
be asked in an interview is what is the
difference between latency based routing
and Geo DNS or Geo based DNS routing now
the Geo based DNS routing takes routing
decisions on the basis of the a
geographic location of the request and
on the other hand the latency based
routing utilizes latency measurements
between networks and data centers now
latency based routing is used where you
want to give your customers the lowest
latency as possible so that's when we
would use latency based routing and on
the other hand a geo-based routing is
when we want to direct customers to
different websites based on the country
they are browsing from you know you
could have you know two different or
three different websites for the same
URL you know take Amazon the shopping
website for example when we go to
amazon.com from in the US it directs us
to the US web page where the products
are different the currency is different
right and the flag and and couple of
other advertisements that shows up are
different and when we go to amazon.com
from India it gets directed to the
amazon.com Indian site where again the
currency the product and the
advertisements they're all different
right so depending on the country
they're trying to browse if you want to
direct customers to two or three
different websites we would use a
geo-based routing another use case of
geobase routing is if you have a
compliance that you should handle all
the DNS requests sorry if you should
handle all the requests you know from a
country within the country then you
would do geo based routing now you
wouldn't direct the customer to a server
which is in another country right you
would direct the customer to a server
which is very local to them that's
another use case of geo-based routing
and like I said for latency based
routing the whole goal or aim is to
achieve minimum end user latency if you
are hired for the architect role and if
that requires working a lot on the DNS
then you could be posted with this
question what is the difference between
domain and a hosted Zone a domain is
actually a collection of data describing
a self-contained administrative and
Technical unit on the internet right so
for example you know simplylearn.com is
actually a domain on the other hand
hosted zone is actually an container
that holds information about how you
want to Route traffic on the internet to
a specific domain for example
lms.simplyleon.com is an hosted Zone
whereas simplylearn.com is an a domain
so in other words in hosted Zone you
would see the domain name plus and a
prefix to it LMS is a prefix here FTP is
a prefix mail.simplieron.com is a prefix
so that's how you would see a prefix in
hosted zones another question from
another classic question from Route 53
would be how does Amazon Route 53
provide High availability and low
latency the way Amazon 53 provides High
availability and low latency is by
globally distributed DNS service Amazon
is a global Service and they have DNA
Services globally any customer doing a
query from different parts of the world
they get to reach an DNS server which is
very local to them and that's how it
provides low latency now this is not
true with all the DNS providers there
are DNS providers who are very local to
a country who are very local to a
continent so they don't they generally
don't provide low latency service right
it's always high latency it's low
latency for local users but anybody
browsing from a different country or a
different continent it's going to be
high latency for them but that's not
again true with Amazon Amazon is a
globally distributed DNS provider it has
DNS servers Global wide and like I said
it has optimal locations it has got
global Service or in other words it has
got servers around the globe different
parts in the globe and that's how they
are able to provide High availability
and because it's not running on just one
server but on many servers they provide
High availability and low latency if the
environment that you're going to work on
is going to take a lot of configuration
backups environmental backups then you
can expect questions in AWS config a
classic question would be how does AWS
config work along with AWS cloudtrail
AWS cloudtrail actually records user API
activity on the account and you know any
HTTP https access or any any sort of
access I know that's made to the cloud
environment that's recorded in the cloud
trail in other words any APA calls the
time is recorded the type of call is
recorded and what was the response given
was it a failure was it successful they
also get recorded in cloudtrail it's
actually a log it actually records the
activity in your Cloud environment on
the other hand config is an a point in
time configuration details of your
resources for example at a given point
what are all the resources that were
present in my environment what are all
the resources or what are the
configuration in those resources at a
given point they get captured in AWS
config all right so with that
information you can always answer the
question what did my AWS resource look
like at a given point in time that
question gets answered when we use AWS
config on the other hand with cloudtrail
you can answer the question I mean by
looking at the cloud trail or with the
help of cloudtrail you can easily answer
the question who made an APA call to
modify this resource that's answered by
cloudtrail and with cloud trail we can
detect if security group was incorrectly
configured and who did that
configuration let's say there happened
to be a downtime and you want to
identify let's say there happened to be
a downtime and you want to identify who
made the that change in the environment
you can simply look at cloudtrail and
find out who made the change and if you
want to look at how the environment
looks like before the change you can
always look at AWS config can AWS
configure or AWS config aggregate data
across different AWS accounts yes it can
now this question is actually to test
whether you have used AWS config or not
I know some of the services are very
local is it some of these services are
availability Zone specific some of them
are Regional specific and some of them
are Global Services in Amazon and though
some of the services are region Services
you still can do some changes you know
add some configuration to it and collect
Regional data in it for example S3 is a
regional service but still you can
collect logs from all other regions into
an S3 bucket in one particular region
that's possible and cloud trail is and
Cloud watch is an regional service but
still you can with some changes to it
with some adding permissions to it you
can always monitor the cloud watch that
belongs to Cloud watch logs that belongs
to other regions you know they're not
Global by default but you can do some
changes and make it Global similarly AWS
config is a service that's a
region-based service but still you can
make it act globally we can aggregate
data across a different region and
different accounts in an AWS config and
deliver the updates from different
accounts to one S3 bucket and can access
it from there AWS config also works or
integrates seamlessly with SNS topic so
you know anytime there is a change
anytime a new data gets collected you
can always notify yourself or notify a
group of people about the new log or the
new config or new edit that happened in
the environment let's look at some of
the database questions you know database
should be running on reserved instances
all right so whether you know that fact
or not the interviewer wants to
understand how well you know that fact
by asking this question how are reserved
instances different from on-demand DB
instances reserved instances and
on-demand instances are exactly the same
when it comes to their function but they
only differ based on how they are built
reserved instances are purchased for one
year or three year reservation and in
return we get a very low per hour
pricing because we're paying up front
it's generally said that reserved
incidence is 75 percentage cheaper than
on-demand instance and Amazon gives you
that benefit because you know you're
committing for one year and sometimes
you're paying in advance for the whole
year on the other hand on-demand
instances are built on an hourly hourly
price talking about Auto scaling how
will you understand the different types
of Auto scaling the interviewer might
ask this question which type of scaling
would you recommend for RDS and why the
two types of scaling as you would know
now vertical and horizontal and in
vertical scaling we can vertically scale
up the master database with a couple of
clicks all right so that's vertical
scaling vertical scaling is keeping the
same node and making it bigger and
bigger if previously it was running on
T2 micro now we would like to run it on
M3 two times large instance previously
it had one virtual CPU one gigabit now
it's gonna have eight virtual CPU and 30
gigabit of ram so that's vertical
scaling on the other hand the horizontal
scaling is adding more nodes to it
previously it was running on one VM now
it's going to run on 2 3 10 VMS right
that's horizontal scaling so a database
can only be scaled vertically and there
are 18 different types of instances we
can resize our rds2 right so this is
true for RDS MySQL postgres SQL mariadb
Oracle micro Microsoft SQL servers there
are 18 type of instances we can
vertically scale up to on the other hand
horizontal scaling are good for replicas
so they are read-only replicas we're not
going to touch the master database we're
not going to touch the primary database
but I can do horizontal scaling only
with Amazon Aurora and I can add
additional read replicas I can add up to
15 Read replicas for Amazon Aurora and
up to five a read replicas for RDS MySQL
postgres SQL and Maria DB RDS instances
and when we add replica we are
horizontally scaling adding more nodes
right I read only nodes so that's
horizontal scaling so how do you really
decide between vertical and horizontal
scaling if you're looking into increase
the storage and the processing capacity
we'll have to do a vertical scaling if
you are looking at increasing the
performance or of the read heavy
database we need to be be looking for
horizontal scaling or we need to be
implementing horizontal scaling in our
environment still talking about database
this is another good question you can
expect in the interview what is a
maintenance window and Amazon RDS will
your DB instance be available during the
maintenance event all right so this is
really to test how well you have
understood the SLA how well you have
understood the Amazon rdas the failover
mechanism of Amazon rdas stuff like that
so RDS maintenance window it lets you
decide when ADB instance modification a
database engine upgrades or software
patching has to occur and you you
actually get to decide should it happen
at 12 in the night or should it happen
at afternoon should it happen early in
the morning should it happen in the
evening you actually get to decide an
automatic scheduling by Amazon is done
only for patches that are security and
durability related sometimes Amazon
takes down and does automatic automatic
scheduling if you know if there is a
need for a patch update that deals with
security and durability and by default
the maintenance window is is for 30
minutes and the important point is the
DB instance will be available during
that event because you're going to have
primary and secondary right so when that
upgrade happens Amazon would shift the
connection to the secondary do the
upgrade and then switch back to the
primary another classic question would
be what are the consistency models in
dynamodb in dynamodb there is eventual
consistency read this eventual
consistency model it actually maximizes
your read throughput and the best part
with eventual consistency is all copies
of data reach consistency within a
second and sometimes when you write and
when you're you know trying to read
immediately chances that you you would
still be reading the old data that's
eventual consistency on the other hand
there is another consistency model
called the strong consistency or
strongly consistent read where there is
going to be a delay in writing the data
you know making sure the data is written
in all places but it guarantees one
thing that is once you have done a write
and then you're trying to do a read it's
going to make sure that it's going to
show you the updated data not the old
data now you can be guaranteed of it
that it is going to show the updated
data and not the old data that's
strongly consistent still talking about
database talking about nosql dynamodb or
nosql database which is dynamodb and
Amazon you could be asked this question
what kind of query functionality does
dynamodb support dynamodb supports get
and put operation dynamodb supports or
dynamodb provides flexible querying by
letting you query on non-primary key
attributes using Global secondary index
and local secondary indexes our primary
key can be either a single attribute
partition key or a composite partition
sort key in other words a dynamodb
indexes a composite partition sort key
as a partition key element and a sort
key element and by holding the partition
key you know when doing a search or when
doing a query by holding the partition
key element constant we can search
across the sort key element to retrieve
the other items in that table and at the
composite partition sort key should be a
combination of user ID partition and a
timestamp so that's what the composite
partition sort key is made of let's look
at some of the multiple choice questions
you know sometimes some companies would
have an written test or an McQ type
online test before they call you for the
first level or before they call you for
the second level so these are some
classical questions that companies asked
or companies ask in their multiple
choice online Quest let's look at this
question as a developer using this
pay-per-use service you can send store
and receive messages between software
components which of the following is
being referred here let's look at it
right we have AWS step functions Amazon
mq Amazon simple Q service Amazon simple
notification service let's read the
question again as a developer using this
pay-per-view service so the service that
we are looking for is a paper you
service you can send store and retrieve
messages between two software components
kind of like a queue there so what would
be the right answer it would be Amazon
simple Q service now Amazon simple queue
service is the one that's used to
decouple the environment it breaks the
tight coupling and then it introduces
decoupling in that environment by
providing a queue or by inserting a
queue between two software components
let's look at this other question if you
would like to host a real-time audio and
video conferencing application on AWS
right it's an audio and video
conferencing application on AWS this
service provides you with a secure and
easy to use application what is this
service let's look at the options they
are Amazon chime Amazon workspace Amazon
mq Amazon appstream all right you might
tend to look at Amazon appstream because
it's real time and video conference but
it's actually for a different purpose
it's actually Amazon chime that lets you
create chat and create a chat board and
then collaborate with the security of
the AWS services so it lets you do the
audio it's let lets you do the video
conference all supported by AWS security
features it's actually Amazon China
let's look at this question as your
company's AWS solution architect you are
in charge of Designing thousands of
individual jobs which are similar which
of the following service best serves
your requirement AWS ec2 Auto scaling
AWS snowball AWS foggy get AWS batch
let's read the question again as your
company's AWS solution architect you are
in charge of Designing thousands of
individual jobs which are similar it
looks like it's batch service let's look
at the other options as well AWS
snowball is actually an storage
Transport service ec2 auto scaling is
you know in introducing scalability and
elasticity in the environment and AWS
far gate is container services AWS batch
is the one is being referred here that
actually runs thousands of individual
jobs which are similar AWS batch it's
the right answer let's look at the other
one you are a machine learning engineer
and you're looking for a service that
helps you build and train machine
learning models in AWS which among the
following are we referring to so we have
Amazon sagemaker and AWS deep lens
Amazon comprehend AWS device form let's
read the question again you are a
machine learning engineer and you are
looking for a service that helps you
build and train machine learning models
in AWS which among the following are
referred here the answer is Sage maker
it provides every developer and data
scientist with the ability to build
train and deploy machine learning models
quickly that's what sagemaker does now
for you to be familiar with you know the
products I would recommend you to you
know simply go through the product
description you know there's one page
available on Amazon that explains all
the products a quick neat and simple and
that really helps you to be very
familiar with you know what the product
is all about and what it is capable of
you know is it the DB service is it a
machine learning service or is it a
monitoring service is it a developer
service stuff like that so get that
information get that details before you
attend an interview and that should
really help to answer or face such
questions with a great confidence so the
answer is Amazon Sage maker because
that's the one that provides developers
and a data scientist the ability to
build the train and deploy machine
learning models quickly as possible all
right let's look at this one let's say
that you are working for your company's
ID team and you are designated to adjust
the capacity of the AWS resource based
on the incoming application and network
traffic how do you do it so what's the
service that's actually helps us to
adjust the capacity of the AWS resource
based on the incoming application let's
look at it Amazon VPC Amazon IAM Amazon
inspector Amazon elastic load balancing
Amazon VPC is a networking service
Amazon IAM is an username password
authentication Amazon inspector is a
service that actually does a security
audit in our environment and Amazon
elastic load balancer is a service that
helps in scalability that's in one way
you know indirectly that helps in
increasing the availability of the
application right and monitoring it
monitoring in a Harmony quests are
coming in through the elastic load
balancer we can actually adjust the
environment that's running behind it so
the answer is going to be Amazon elastic
load balancer all right let's look at
this question this cross-platform video
game development engine that supports PC
Xbox PlayStation IOS and Android
platforms allows developers to build and
host their games on Amazon's servers so
we have Amazon game lift Amazon green
grass Amazon Lumberyard Amazon Sumerian
let's read the question again this
cross-platform video game development
engine that supports PC Xbox PlayStation
IOS and Android platforms allows
developers to build and host their games
on Amazon servers the answer is Amazon
lumber yard this lumber yard is an free
AAA gaming engine deeply integrated with
AWS and twitch with full source this
lumba yard provides a growing set of
tools that helps you create an highest
game quality applications and they
connect to a lot of games and vast
compute and storage in the cloud so it's
that service they are referring to let's
look at this question you are the
project manager of your company's Cloud
architect team you are required to
visualize understand and manage your AWS
cost and usage over time which of the
following service will be the best fit
for this we have AWS budgets we have AWS
cost Explorer we have Amazon workmail we
have Amazon connect and the answer is
going to be cost Explorer now cost
Explorer is an option any of the Amazon
console that helps you to visualize and
understand and even manage the AWS cost
over time who's spending more who's
spending less and what is the trend what
is the projected cost for the coming
month all these can be visualized in AWS
cost Explorer let's look at this
question you are a chief Cloud architect
at your company and how can you
automatically Monitor and adjust
Computer Resources to ensure maximum
performance and efficiency of all
scalable resources so we have a cloud
formation as a service we have AWS
Aurora as a solution we have AWS Auto
scaling and Amazon API Gateway let's
read the question again you're the chief
Cloud architect at your company how can
you automatically Monitor and adjust
Computer Resources how can you
automatically Monitor and adjust
Computer Resources to ensure maximum
performance and efficiency of all
scalable resources this is an easy
question to answer the answer is auto
scaling all right that's a basic service
and solution architect course is it auto
scaling is the service that helps us to
easily adjust Monitor and ensure the
maximum performance and efficiency of
all scalable resources it does that by
automatically scaling the environment to
handle the inputs let's look at this
question as a database administrator you
will use a service that is used to set
up and manage databases such as MySQL
mayodb and postgres SQL which service
are we referring to Amazon Aurora Amazon
elastic cache AWS RDS AWS database
migration service Amazon Aurora is
Amazon's flavor of the RDS service and
elastic cache is is the caching service
provided by Amazon they are not
full-fledged database and database
migration service just like the name
says it helps to migrate the database
from on-premises to the cloud and from
one a database flavor to another
database flavor Amazon RDS is the
service is the console is the service is
the umbrella service that helps us to
set up manage our databases like MySQL
maridb and postgres SQL it's Amazon RTS
let's look at this last question a part
of your marketing work requires you to
push messages to onto Google Facebook
Windows and Apple through apis or AWS
Management console you will use the
following service so the options are AWS
cloudtrail AWS config Amazon chime AWS
simple notification service all right it
says a part of your marketing work
requires you to push messages it's
dealing with pushing messages to Google
Facebook Windows and Apple through apis
or AWS Management console you will use
the following service it's simple
notification service simple notification
service is a message pushing service and
sqs is pulling similarly SNS is pushing
right here it talks about a pushing
system that pushes messages to Google
Facebook Windows and Apple through API
and it's going to be a simple
notification system or a simple
notification service and with that we
have come to an end of this AWS filcos I
hope it was informative and interesting
if you have any questions about the
topics covered in this video please ask
away in the comment section below our
team will be happy to solve all your
queries thank you for watching